LIKE TO CALL THIS MEETING TO
ORDER WELCOME [inaudible]
TO ARE.
THIRD THAT'S RIGHT THIRD HEARING
THIS YEAR ON THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE.
OFFICES --
OR SIXTH HEARING ON REQUEST THIS
SESSION.
I LIKE TO ENCOURAGE ALL OF THE
REST OF THE COMMITTEE.
TO PLEASE REPORT TO ROOM FOUR
FOUR SEVEN SO THAT WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND TAKE CARE
TODAY'S BUSINESS.
OF SAYING THAT WE DID NOT HAVE
QUORUM WE WILL OPERATE AS A SUB
COMMITTEE UNTIL A QUORUM IS
PRESENT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM AUDITOR
MORNING MISTER CHAIR --
IF YOU'D BE SO KIND TO PROVIDE
US A WHAT THE YOUR STATUS REPORT
AND WORK IN PROGRESS.
CERTAINLY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OFFER THE RECORD ELAINE
HOW CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR --
AT CURRENTLY AS OF AS OF TODAY
WE HAVE NINETEEN NOT IT'S
UNDERWAY SIXTEEN OF THOSE OUR
AUDITS THAT WERE APPROVED BY THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE.
ABOUT TWELVE OF THOSE ARE WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO COMPLETE
BEFORE THE END OF THIS YEAR I
WILL HAVE A COUPLE THAT WILL.
BE ISSUED IN EARLY AT TWENTY
NINETEEN WE ALSO HAVE A COUPLE
OF THAT WE'RE CONDUCTING UNDER
pONE RELATED TO MEDI CAL PAYMENTS.
WITHOUT OUR AND I OUR IT STAFF
WORKING ON SOME ANALYSES RELATE
TO THAT AND WE'RE DOING SOME
WORK.
OUR INNATE PART OF OUR EDUCATION
AREA.
IN OUR LOCAL HIGH RISK PROGRAM
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING TODAY WE
HAVE FOURTEEN REQUESTS TO BE
CONSIDERED I THINK THERE WAS --
ONE THAT WAS --
PULLED -- BY
MISTER LACKEY SO THERE WILL BE
FOURTEEN REQUESTS CONSIDERED BY
THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
AS I ALWAYS INDICATE TO THE
COMMITTEE THE STATUS OF MY
RESOURCES WE HAVE STAFF
AVAILABLE TO START TWELVE AUDIT
A MANY OF THOSE AUDITS WOULD BE
ABLE TO START THIS MONTH AND
NEXT MONTH I THINK I HAVE ABOUT
SIXTEENS APPROXIMATELY SIX TEAMS
AVAILABLE. TO COMMENCE AUDITS.
ESSENTIALLY IMMEDIATELY IN
AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER AND THEN
THE REMAINING AUDITS WOULD START
LATER THIS FALL PROBABLY
SOMETIME IN NOVEMBER --
IN AND DEPENDING UPON HOW LONG
DOES NOT AT STAKE IT WOULD NOW
WE DO REALLY SOME IN THE SPRING
AND SOME CLOSER TO BUDGET.
I MAY REVISE IT CETERA.
LA THIS YEAR WE HAVE ISSUED
CURRENTLY AT THIS POINT TWENTY
FIVE AUDITS WE HAVE AS I SAID
ABOUT TWELVE OR FOURTEEN THAT
WILL BE ISSUING.
BY THE END OF THIS YEAR THAT'LL
GET US UP TO ABOUT THIRTY NINE
OUT ITS LAST YEAR WE ISSUED
FORTY ONE REPORTS.
SO PRETTY CONSISTENT AS FAR AS
TIMING JUST TWO OTHER ITEMS THAT
I'D LIKE TO MENTION TO THE
COMMITTEE JUST AS A FOR YOUR
INFORMATION.
WE ALWAYS CONSIDER OUR STATUTORY
WERE THAT COMES FIRST WE HAVE A
AN ANNUAL REQUIREMENT TO EITHER
AUDIT THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL IN
THEIR PROCUREMENT PRACTICES AT
HEADQUARTERS OR TO GO OUT TO
FIVE JUDICIAL ENTITIES AND
POTENTIALLY COURTS.
AND AUDIT THEIR PROCUREMENT
PRACTICES THIS YEAR WILL BE THE
FIVE JUDICIAL ENTITIES WE'VE
NOTIFIED THE COMMITTEE OF THE
SELECTION OF THOSE FIVE AND WILL
BE COMMENCING THAT AUDIT IN THE
NEXT MONTH OR SO.
THE OTHER IS THE STATE BAR WE
TYPICALLY ARE AT THE STATE BAR
EVERY COUPLE OF YEARS SO WILL BE
COMMENCING STATE BAR AUDIT IN
THE NEXT MONTH OR SO.
THE LAST ITEM [inaudible]
IS REDISTRICTING.
I AS YOU KNOW THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR CREATING ARE BASICALLY THE
PROCESS --
FOR ESTABLISHING THE
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION EVEN
THOUGH IT SEEMS LIKE YESTERDAY
IT'S IT'S COMING UP AGAIN.
ALSO WE ARE AND THAT PRELIMINARY
PLANNING PHASES RIGHT NOW
INTERNALLY WE HAVE TO MAKE SOME
MODIFICATIONS TO THE REGULATIONS.
ARE AND CERTAINLY --
GAIN THE VALUE FROM LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THE LAST PROCESS WE
WENT THROUGH BUT WE WILL BE
REALLY RAMPING UP OUR ACTIVITIES
IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND WILL
CERTAINLY KEEP THE COMMITTEE
APPRISED.
OF THE PROCESS AS WE GO ALONG
BECAUSE THE APPLICATION PROCESS
WILL HAVE TO BE A COMMAND
SOMETIME NEXT YEAR BUT WE ARE IN
THE EARLY PLANNING PHASES FOR
THAT.
WITHOUT MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M
READY.
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR MOVE
ON WITH THE AGENDA ITEMS ALRIGHT
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE AT THIS TIME.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
UPDATES --
LIKE -- TO
BEFORE GOING FURTHER --
ANNOUNCE THAT --
AS THE OUR AUDITOR HAS INDICATED
WE HAVE FOURTEEN ITEMS.
IT IS SAID --
SEVEN ON CONSENT --
SEVEN EIGHT ON THE REGULAR
CALENDAR AND SIX ON THE CONSENT --
WE HAVE [inaudible]
PULLED --
THE GOLD COAST HEALTH PLAN FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR TO THE
REGULAR CALENDAR [inaudible]
AND WE HAD.
ONE EARLIER REQUESTS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY --
ITEM TWENTY EIGHTEEN DASH ONE
TWENTY THREE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS DIVISION OF
WORKERS COMPENSATION --
REQUESTS FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
TODAY'S AGENDA.
ALSO LIKE TO QUICKLY --
I MENTIONED THAT WE HAD A A
JOINT HEARING WITH THE ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEE ON HATE CRIMES
YESTERDAY --
TO FOLLOW UP ON ANOTHER
EXCELLENT AUDIT FROM OUR STATE
AUDITOR.
ON THE STATUS OF HATE CRIMES AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND DOWN THE WHAT WE CAN DO TO
IMPROVE.
STATE WHY LEADERSHIP ON
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE.
OF WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KANSEN CHU --
FOR ARE REQUESTING THAT AUDIT
AND FOR WORKING WITH THE AUDIT
COMMITTEE YESTERDAY ON THAT
IMPORTANT HEARING.
NOW RATES --
SO WE AS OF YET STILL DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM SO WE WILL OPERATE
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND SO WHY DON'T WE PROCEED TO
WE HAVE MISSED JUROR CHEN.
WE DO NOT HAVE MISTER SHARON WHO
WAS FIRST AND SIGNED UP.
ORDER MR BONTA.
ESTHER BONTA IS ELSE HIS SECOND
AND SIGN UP --
AND SO THIRD WE HAVE MISSED
BAKER.
THIS BAKER WAS SELECT PRESENT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO THIS IS THE ITEM NUMBER.
TWELVE ON THE REGULAR CALENDAR.
ITEM TWENTY EIGHTEEN DASH.
ONE TWENTY NINE REQUEST FOR NOT
IT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER ON
THE PLAMEN DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT.
RELATED TO PRIVACY PROTECTION
PRACTICES.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MORNING GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU MADAM UNDER A FREER
HELP TODAY I'M HERE IS A TO
REQUEST THAT OUR JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE
APPROVE AN AUDIT OF THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT DDD. TO FOCUS ON WHAT
THE DD DOES AND DOES NOT AND
SHOULD DO BETTER TO PROTECT THE
PRIVACY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS.
PARTICULARLY WITH RESPECT TO
THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS
AYE IN COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN
EDT AND WHAT OUR CONSTITUENTS
ARE JUST CUSTOMERS.
BACK IN TWENTY FIFTEEN JUST TO
PROVIDE SOME SOME CONTEXT IN
HISTORICAL BACKGROUND NEWS
REPORTS INDICATED THAT EDT WAS
MAILING DOCUMENTS TO ITS
CUSTOMERS.
AND THOSE DOCUMENTS IN PAPER
MAIL.
SNAIL MAIL CONTAINS THEIR FULL
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER WITH
THEIR HOME ADDRESS WITH THEIR
NAME AND OTHER PRIVATE
INFORMATION.
REPORTS STATED THAT PEOPLE OTHER
THAN PEOPLE'S ET DE DOCUMENTS IN
THE MAIL RECEIVED OTHER PEOPLE'S
EDT DOCUMENTS IN THE MAIL SO
SOMETIMES THERE IT YOU
ACCIDENTALLY GET SOMEBODY ELSE'S
MAILING.
WITH THEIR SO SECURITY NUMBER
THEIR NAME THEIR ADDRESS AND
PRIVATE INFORMATION ADDITIONAL
REPORTS STATED IT SO SECURITY
NUMBER WAS CLEARLY VISIBLE
THROUGH THE PLASTIC ENVELOPE --
SO YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE TO
RECEIVE THE PIECE OF MAIL IF YOU
SOMEHOW GOT A HOLD OF IT --
YOU'RE ABLE TO SEE THAT
INFORMATION AND I I THINK THIS
IS CERTAINLY UP I'M SURE IS
ALARMING TDD.
I WAS ALARMING TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND BECAUSE SO
SECURITY NUMBERS ARE ONE OF THE
SINGLE MOST VALUABLE PIECES OF
CURRENCY.
WHEN SOMEONE WANTS TO COMMIT
FRAUD AND IDENTITY THEFT I WHICH
IS RAMPANT ENOUGH AS IT IS?
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT SNAIL MAIL
IS ONE OF THE AREAS THAT IS MOST
VULNERABLE TO FRAUD AND IDENTITY
THEFT FOR CONSTITUENTS IN LIGHT
OF THIS NEWS BACK.
OF OVER THREE YEARS AGO.
A MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE IN THIS BODY INCLUDING
MYSELF.
I SENT A LETTER TO EDT IN JULY
OF TWENTY FIFTEEN BY DEMANDING
AND REQUESTING ITS POLITELY AS
WE COULD TO STOP PRINTING FULL
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS AND
COMMUNICATIONS WITH OUR
CONSTITUENTS OUR CUSTOMERS.
IN FACT THE CHAIR OF THE PRIVACY
COMMITTEE AT THAT TIME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MISTER OF MIKE DATO ALSO
SEND A SEPARATE LETTER MAKING
SIMILAR DEMANDS REQUESTS.
AND IN ADDITION I PERSONALLY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET
WITH -- THE
HEAD OF DEPARTMENT OF A FOR OF
EDT LATER THAT MONTH TO JUST
HAVE A ONE ON ONE CONVERSATION
AS YOU'VE HEARD IN THIS
COMMITTEE BEFORE IT'S OFTEN
SOMETHING I SAID IF WE CAN.
REACH OUT TO AGENCIES AND TRY TO
RESOLVE THE PROBLEM WITHOUT
LEGISLATION AUDIT WE SHOULD
CERTAINLY TRY TO DO SO.
THE RESPONSE THAT WE RECEIVED
FROM EDTA WHICH YOU I BELIEVE
HAVING YOUR BACKGROUND
INFORMATION FROM OCTOBER.
TWENTY FIFTEEN STATED THAT THEY
WOULD WORK TO BEGIN TO REMOVE
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS AND THAT
ALSO SECURITY NUMBERS WOULD BE
REMOVED FROM ALL FORMS BY
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
TWENTY FIFTEEN THE RESPONSE ALSO
STATED THAT EDTA IS PLANNING TO
ELIMINATE THE USE OF MAILED
FORMS AND TO REVAMPING UPDATE
ITS LEGACY COMPUTER SYSTEMS
RIGHTLY SO.
AND THAT THEIR CUSTOMERS COULD
OPT INTO ONLINE SERVICES THAT
WOULD PRECLUDE THE RELIANCE ON
PAPER DOCUMENTS AND IN
PARTICULAR WITH YOUR SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER.
NEWS REPORTS LATER CONFIRMED
HOWEVER THAT EDT CUSTOMERS WERE
CONTINUING TO RECEIVE.
SNAIL MAIL WHEN THEY HAD
REQUESTED NOT TO AND YEARS LATER
THAT THE FULL SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER WAS STILL IN THERE.
THIS INCLUDED CONSTITUENTS AND
OTHERS WHO WERE ON MATERNITY
LEAVE FOR EXAMPLE IN RECEIVING
THEIR DISABILITY CHECK THEY HAVE
GONE ONLINE TO OPT FOR ONLINE
COMMUNICATIONS WITH EDT.
AND CONTINUE TO RECEIVE AND
SNAIL MAIL OTHER FOR THEIR FULL
SO SECURITY NUMBER AND OTHER
PAPERS -- SO
AGAIN IN TWENTY SIXTEEN I
REACHED OUT --
TO THE DIRECTOR I WAS VERY
GRATEFUL FOR HIS ACCESSIBILITY
AND HIS CANDID CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE CHALLENGES EDT WAS
FACING.
AND FOUND --
I FOUND IT TO BE ONE OF THOSE
MEETINGS WHERE WE BOTH PROBABLY
FELT THAT BE HAD BANGED OUR
HEADS AGAINST THE WALL IN
FRUSTRATION.
WITH WHAT WAS HAPPENING --
BUT THE ANSWER I RECEIVED AND
THAT WE HAVE CONTINUED TO
RECEIVE IS THIS IS AS GOOD AS WE
CAN DO --
THAT WE WERE WRONG AND WHAT WE
SAID BEFORE WASN'T QUITE RIGHT
AND NOW IT'S GOING TO TAKE MANY
YEARS TO EVEN BEGIN TO MAKE THE
KIND OF CHANGES NECESSARY TO DO
SOMETHING THAT.
WE ARE HOLDING BUSINESSES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR DOING IF IF THEY
DO IT POORLY AND THAT IS PROTECT
THE PRIVATE INFORMATION OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS.
I'M SO I I WANNA SAY I'M VERY
THANKFUL TO THE DIRECTOR FOR FOR
YEARS NOW I'D KNOWING THAT THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE IN WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE AND MEMBERS OF
THIS LEGISLATURE.
BUT HAVE GREAT CONCERNS ABOUT
WHAT WE HAVE RECEIVED FROM EDTA
IN RESPONSE INCONSISTENT ANSWERS --
RELIANCE AT ONE POINT IN SAYING
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
REQUIRED US SO SECURITY NUMBERS
TO BE USED WE LATER FOUND THAT
THAT WAS NOT THE CASE.
AND CALIFORNIA'S OWN LAW SAYS
THAT AGENCIES ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
SEND SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS
FULL SO SECURITY NUMBERS IN THE
MAIL TO CONSTITUENTS UNLESS IT
IS REQUIRED BY LAW AND IT IS NOT
REQUIRED BY LAW --
MEMBERS I HAVE SERVED ON THIS
COMMITTEE FOR THREE AND HALF
YEARS NOW I RARELY REQUESTED ON
IT.
AND YOU OFTEN HEAR A BROKEN
RECORD FOR ME WHICH IS CAN WE
WAIT AND SEE IF WE'VE DONE
EVERYTHING WE POSSIBLY CAN FIRST
BEFORE WE TRY TO LAUNCH THE
AUDITOR INTO A DEPARTMENT --
AB DONE THAT I MEMBERS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE HAVE DONE THAT AND
NOW I THINK IT WOULD ACTUALLY BE
VERY.
IT IS IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT WE
HAVE AN END IF I DE AND EXAMINE
WHAT CAN BE DONE BETTER.
HOW IS THIS AFFECTING OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND WHAT IS WE AS A
LEGISLATURE NEED TO DO WHAT IS
IT YOU DO YOU NEED TO DO --
IN ORDER TO PROTECT THE PRIVACY
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS IN THEIR
CUSTOMERS THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
AUDIT.
THANK YOU MS BAKER IDEA --
WANT TO BEFORE WE CALL UPON THE
AUDITOR FOR HER PRESENTATION.
I JUST BRIEFLY GO OVER THE
STANDARD FORMAT FOR ALL
PRESENTATIONS TODAY FOR THE SAKE
OF THE AUDIENCE.
AND THOSE THAT ARE WATCHING THIS
ON TV -- ARE
STANDARD FORMAT WILL BE THAT --
THE REQUEST HER OF THE AUDIT
WILL FOR ME FIRST MAKE THEIR
PRESENTATION.
THEN EACH MEMBER WOULD HAVE UP
TO TWO WITNESSES TO MAKE --
STATEMENTS ARE UP TO WE ASK ALL
WITNESSES TO TRY TO LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO TWO MINUTES EACH --
YOU WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ELABORATE ON YOUR PRESENTATION
NOW THROUGH THE QUESTIONS AND
ANSWERS THAT WE FOLLOWED UP --
IT PRESENTATION FROM THE MEMBER
WILL OR THE REQUEST WILL BE
FOLLOWED UP BY THE STATE
AUDITOR'S PRESENTATION OF HER
ANALYSIS --
I WILL THEN INVITE THE AFFECTED
AGENCY. TWO RESPONDED TO MAKE
COMMENTS REGARDING THE AUDIT
REQUESTS --
AGAIN IT ASKING GOD THE
RESPONDING AGENCIES TO TRY TO
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS AT TWO
MINUTES --
WITH FURTHER OPPORTUNITY TO
ELABORATE --
FROM QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
AND THEN THE PUBLIC WILL BE
INVITED TO COMMENT ON THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO EACH I
REQUEST.
AFTER THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO ASK
QUESTIONS.
SO WELL WITH THAT --
NAME.
WELL ACTUALLY LET SEC --
COMMENTS.
YES -- STATE
AUDITOR PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
AS MS BAKER INDICATED THIS WOULD
BE AN AUDIT OF EDTA IN AND WE
WOULD START OUT BY LOOKING AT
WHAT THEIR POLICIES AND
PRACTICES ARE. FOR PROTECTING
TOM P. I I ESSENTIALLY
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION AND DO THOSE
PRACTICES COMPLY WITH STATE AND
AT STATE LAWS FEDERAL LAWS AND
REGULATIONS ARE ANY STATE
POLICIES.
AND THEN SPECIFIC TO THE THE
ITEM SHE IDENTIFIED SENSE TWENTY
FIFTEEN ARE IS EDT CONTINUING TO
MAIL DOCUMENTS.
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS ESSENTIALLY
OR CONSUMERS CUSTOMERS OF OF EDT --
THAT CONTAIN PERSONAL
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION
SPECIFICALLY SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS BUT WE WILL ALSO LOOK
FOR OTHER INFORMATION --
AND IF THEY ARE DOING THAT WHY
ARE THEY CONTINUING TO DO THAT
AND HAVE THEY CONSIDERED ANY
ALTERNATIVE METHODS OF
COMMUNICATING WITH CONSTITUENTS
[inaudible]
ET HAVE THEY COME UP WITH
ALTERNATIVE METHODS FOR ENSURING
THAT THEY PROTECT THAT
INFORMATION TO THE MAXIMUM
EXTENT POSSIBLE.
IN ADDITION --
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING AND AND
MS BAKER INDICATED THIS IN HER
LETTER THERE ARE --
CONSUMERS ARE OUR CUSTOMERS WHO
HAVE ASKED TO BE ABLE TO JUST
COMMUNICATE AND WITH THE DD
ONLINE AND NOT RECEIVE HARD COPY
DOCUMENTS IN THE MAIL SO TO THE
EXTENT POSSIBLE SHE'S ASKING US
IDENTIFY HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS.
HAVE ASKED TO JUST WORK WITH THE
DD ONLINE AND OF THOSE HOW MANY
OF THOSE ARE CONTINUING TO
RECEIVE DOCUMENTS IN THE MAIL
THAT AGAIN CONTAIN PERSONAL
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION.
OUT WITH RESPECT TO ALTERNATIVES
WATER DVDS PLANTS CLEARLY THERE
THEY HAVE A LEGACY SYSTEM WE ALL
KNOW THAT DO THEY HAVE PLANS TO
REPLACE THAT SYSTEM.
HOW LONG IS THAT GONNA TAKE HOW
COSTLY IS THAT GOING TO BE SOME
OTHER ISSUES THAT?
OF MS BAKER ASKED US TO LOOK AT
ALSO COMPLAINTS ALL THE NUMBER
OF COMPLAINTS THAT DVD HAS
RECEIVED OVER CERTAIN TIME FRAME
AND WHAT HAS THE RESPONSE BEEN
BANNED TO THOSE COMPLAINTS HAVE
HAS THE RESPONSE BEEN TIMELY.
HAVE THOSE RESPONSES BEEN
EFFECTIVE AND THEN FINALLY
REALLY LOOKING AT ARE THERE
OTHER OPTIONS THAT.
PERHAPS WE CAN IDENTIFY OR THAT
EDT HAS LOOKED AT AND THE
RATIONALE FOR NOT PERHAPS --
PURSUING SOME OF THOSE
ALTERNATIVES TO TO MITIGATE THE
RISK OF A PERSONAL IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION GETTING IN THE WRONG
HANDS THE BUDGET FOR THIS AUDIT
IS ABOUT. TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
HOURS THAT WOULD TAKE ARM AUDIT
STAFF ABOUT FIVE MONTHS TO
COMPLETE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MS BAKER DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF YOUR
REQUEST AT THIS TIME NOW JUST
BEGAN BEHALF OF A LOT OF PEOPLE
YES ARUM.
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME --
PATRICK HEADING THE DIRECTOR OF
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT --
WELCOME SIR WHICH LIKE.
TO THANK YOU --
IT AND THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF MONIES
PATRICK HAVING THEM DIRECTOR THE
BY THE DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT --
AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT I'M I'M CLEAR AND I THINK
HAVE EXPRESSED ITS THIS TO
SOMEONE BAKER AND PUTTING INNER.
A LETTER TO THIS COMMITTEE BUT I
DO SHARE THE SAME CONCERN ABOUT
PROTECTING.
FOLKS INIVIDUAL --
PERSONAL IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION PI --
IDENTITY THEFT IS COSTLY IT'S
TIME CONSUMING --
AND IT ENDS UP BEING A TERRIBLE
WASTE OF EXCUSE ME TERRIBLE
INVASION OF PEOPLE'S --
DURING MY TENURE AT EDT A SINCE
HAVE BEEN APPOINTED I THINK
WE'VE MADE TREMENDOUS PROGRESS
ON CELS COULD IN NUMBERS AND
FRANKLY --
WE CONTINUE TO DO SO --
AND REMOVING THOSE FROM OUR
SYSTEMS THAT THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE SYSTEM SEN
[inaudible]
COUNTRY --
GREW UP USING SO SECURITY NUMBER
SIT SPEND --
NUMBER THAT THE STATE HAS USED
ON THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
USED TO IDENTIFY PEOPLE.
SUCCESSFULLY FOR A LONG PERIOD
OF TIME --
AND WE HAVE REMOVED SO SECURITY
NUMBERS ON ABOUT 3240% OF ALL
DOCUMENTS THAT WE HAVE AT THE
DEPARTMENT.
OF SINCE OF MISS BAKER OF
BROUGHT HURTS CONCERNS TO US --
AND FRANKLY EVEN BEFORE THAT A
DATING BACK --
TO PRIOR DIRECTORS EMPIRE MOVES
AS OF IF SOMEONE BAKER ALLUDED
TO SOME LEGISLATION THAT WAS
PASSED IN THE STATE.
OF PRIOR TO THIS --
THOUGH BUT I WOULD ALSO SAY OF
BACKING UP I BELIEVE IT WAS --
TWENTY SIXTEEN THIS LEGISLATURE --
KNOWING THIS --
ISSUE -- AND
THE GOVERNOR TOOK AN
EXTRAORDINARY ACTION --
AND IT HAS TO DO WITH SORT OF A
LARGER CATASTROPHE THAT THE US
STATE AUDITOR BROUGHT UP.
A WHICH WAS THAT OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE COMPUTER
SYSTEM FELT --
AS SOON AS I WAS APPOINTED
ASSUME IS --
THESE ISSUES CAME UP --
FOURTH THE PATHWAY TO REPLACE
THAT COMPUTER SYSTEM.
THE LEGACY COMPUTER SYSTEM IT
HAS OVER NINE THOUSAND A
DIFFERENT COBALT PROGRAMS THAT
IT INTERSECTS WITH. TO GIVE YOU
A SENSE.
OF WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH --
IN FRANKLY WILL BE --
EXTRAORDINARILY DIFFICULT TO
MAINTAIN AND UPDATE WELL WELL
INTO THE FUTURE.
THAT IS WHY BACK IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR PUT IN ITS BUDGET.
SET ASIDE TO REPLACE A COMPUTER
SYSTEM IN THE COMPUTER SYSTEM IN
WITHIN THE DOCUMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN PROVIDED TO THIS
LEGISLATURE IN IN THEIR VOTES --
AS WELL AS THE GOVERNOR
SIGNATURE --
PROVIDED --
WE'VE STATED THAT WE HAVE FULL
INTENT OF REPLACING THAT WITHIN --
BUT THAT SYSTEM FAT THERE'S BEEN.
APPROXIMATELY I THINK IT WAS
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS OF SET
ASIDE --
FROM THE GOVERNMENT AS WELL AS
SOME MONEY REDIRECTED FROM MY
DEPARTMENT FOR THE SEPARATE SOME
OF THAT MONEY WE USED --
TO TRUNCATE REMOVE A SOURCE
COULD BE NUMBERS OR WE CAN --
BACK THEN.
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT --
THIS ISSUE CONTINUES TO BE THAT
THIS ISSUE IS SOMETHING THAT WE
WILL FRANKLY NEVER BE ABLE TO
GET RID OF SO SECURITY NUMBERS.
AND ITS USE IN THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE SYSTEM.
AND IT'S NOT A STATE.
ISSUE.
IT'S THE WAY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT GIVES US AWAY TO BUT
MOVE ABOUT MONEY WE TALK ABOUT
BEST PRACTICES FRANKLY THE STAGE
GATE SYSTEM THAT IS SET FORTH
WITHIN CDT --
SUCH ASIDE TIMES WHEN IT TALKS
ABOUT BEST PRACTICES.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE ISSUES THAT
WE WILL GET --
TO AND HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING WITH
THEM AND GOING THROUGH TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THIS BEST
PRACTICES ARE.
I'D LOVE PRESS TO GET TO ONLINE
ONLY THAT IS WHY WE HAVE SET
ASIDE MONEY IN THE BUDGET TO GET
TO THAT PLACE ALRIGHT MR HENNING
GONNA ASK YOU TO WRAP UP.
I I I WOULD JUST SIMPLY SAY --
THAT AS MUCH AS I WOULD
APPRECIATE A KNOWING IF THERE'S
ANY MORE THINGS WE CAN DO AT A
DEPARTMENT --
THAT YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE TO MEET WITH A SOMEONE
BAKER ANYBODY THAT HAS CONCERNS
ON THIS ISSUE.
UP BUT THAT WILL ALSO BECAUSE
THIS IS A BUDGET ITEM THAT'S
BEEN IN THE BUDGET FOR THE PAST
FEW YEARS.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO ANNUALLY ON
THIS TALK ABOUT WHAT WE ARE
DOING IN THE PROCESS IS THAT WE
HAVE.
A SUPPORT TO DO THIS OF THAT I
THINK WILL ACCOMPLISH THE GOAL
THAT ASSEMBLY WOMAN BAKER --
SEEKS TO CORRECT.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
MR HENNING --
I THE BUT BEFORE OPEN UP FOR
QUESTIONS --
I WANT -- TO
REMIND.
NOT ONLY YOU MISTER HEADACHE BUT
TO ALL OF OUR AFFECTED AGENCIES
AS WELL AS MEMBERS OF THE
AUDIENCE THAT WENT --
TO THE STATE AUDITOR SHARED WITH
ME IN OUR MEETING YESTERDAY
WHICH IS THAT NOT ONLY --
DOES OUR STATE AUDITOR PROVIDE
THE VALUE OF OF CONDUCTING THEIR
INDEPENDENT AUDITS OF OF THESE
AGENCIES BUT ALSO. TO SERVE AS A
A A CONSULTANT --
IN TERMS OF WAYS --
TO IMPROVE OR TO TRIED TRIED.
TO ACHIEVE THE THEM THE MISSION
AND THE GOALS THAT --
THAT -- WE
ARE SETTING FORTH --
NINE PERHAPS A PROVIDE NEW IDEAS
AND NEW SUGGESTIONS ARE PERHAPS
A FOUNDATION.
FOR FUTURE BUDGET REQUESTS FOR
UPDATES TO ET DE A COMPUTER
SYSTEMS --
ITSELF MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT THE
ONLY THING I WOULD SAY THAT THAT
IS THAT.
BECAUSE AS I SAID AND I I
BELIEVE AUDIT WOULD PROBABLY
AGREE WITH ME [inaudible]
ARE.
SISTER COMPUTER SYSTEM IS IN
SUCH A STATE.
OF WITH UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE.
THAT.
THE TIME IT WOULD TAKE.
MAY DISTRACT FROM THE MISSION OF
COMPLETING THAT COMPUTER SYSTEM.
AND THAT WOULD PUT IT IT'S JUST
IT'S A MITIGATION OF RISK.
IF YOU CAN UNDERSTAND SIR AND
I'M AND I WOULD.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE BOUNCING HERE.
AND I AND I HOPE THAT THE
COMMITTEE SEES THAT.
AND HOPEFULLY CITIES THAT OKAY
WE'RE DOING WHAT WE CAN WHAT WE
WHAT WE WILL ASK THE AUDITOR TO
IF IF THIS REQUEST IS APPROVED --
SEE THAT OR NOT AND AND TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE MS RUBIO.
BOB THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
US ASSEMBLYMEMBER BAKER
INDICATED THAT --
ONE OF THE COMMENTS THAT WAS
MADE TO HER WAS THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REQUIRED TO SUCH
SECURITIES TO BE --
PUT ON THE DOCUMENTS AND SHE
INDICATED THAT THAT WAS NOT
CORRECT AND RIGHT NOW HE DIDN'T
MADE A STATEMENT THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
I JUST HEARD AT THE PUBLIC IN
NEW ONCE BUT IT TO WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SAYS IS THAT
WE NEED TO IDENTIFY PEOPLE
[inaudible]
BECAUSE THE WAY THAT WE THE WAY
THAT THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
SYSTEM IS SET UP.
IS THAT --
AS ALL THIS IS WORKING
CALIFORNIANS --
WE IDENTIFY YOURSELF WHEN WE GO
TO OUR EMPLOYERS LOT OF YOUR
SMALL BUSINESS FOLKS --
POTENTIAL SECURITY NUMBERS WITH
IDENTIFY WAGES TO THAT THOSE
WAGES ARE IN TURN USE SO THAT WE
COULD FIGURE OUT WHETHER OR NOT
YOU QUALIFY.
FOR A VARIETY OF BENEFITS
INCLUDING UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
IN ITS DOCUMENTS REQUIRES AN
IDENTIFIER.
THE ONLY IDENTIFIER UP UNTIL.
FRANKLY RECENTLY --
HAS BEEN USEFUL SECURITY NUMBER.
SO WHILE THEY DO NOT USE THE
EXACT.
TERM SOUL SECURITY NUMBERS.
WE USE THEM THROUGHOUT OUR
SYSTEM ALLSTATE USE SOME
THROUGHOUT THEIR SYSTEM THERE'S
NOT. ONE STATE IN OUR UNION THAT
DOES NOT USE SOAP SECURITY
NUMBERS IN THE ADMINISTRATION.
OF THEIR UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
SYSTEM.
THAT'S CORRECT BUT FILE FOR
EXAMPLE WITH THE WITH THE STATE --
MY MONTHLY PAYCHECK COMES WITH
EX SAYS AND THE LAST FOUR SOCIAL
THAT DIGITS OF THE SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS OTHERS THOUGH
BEING IDENTIFIED BECAUSE OF THAT
THOSE ARE.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY.
THEN AND I AM TRYING TO GET TO
WHERE I THINK THAT YOU WANT TO
BE AND I'D LIKE TO BE THERE.
MY DEPARTMENT HAS RECEIVED. ZERO
DOLLARS WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
THE PAST --
TWO AUGMENTATIONS TO MY BUDGET
TO REPLACE THE BENEFITS SYSTEM --
VOTE FOR UNEMPLOYMENT DISABILITY
PAID FAMILY LEAVE TO DO THAT.
AT TO REPLACE ALL SECURITY
NUMBERS WHEN MISS BAKER FIRST
BROUGHT THIS ISSUE UP WE RAN THE
NUMBERS. TO WITH THE NUMBERS
BECAUSE OF THE ANTIQUITY OF OUR
SYSTEM.
ACOSTA ST ABOUT THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS --
AND IT WOULD GO BACK THROUGH THE
CDT PROCESS THE STATE'S GOOD
PROCESS WHICH IN.
MY ESTIMATION FIVE FIVE SIX
YEARS I DON'T I'M THAT'S MY
DESTINATION.
BUT WHAT I WOULD TELL YOU IS
THAT -- I'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO GET THERE I'M
TRYING TO GET THERE YOU
AUGMENTED MY BUDGET SO THAT WE
CAN GET THERE WERE ALONG THE
PROCESS [inaudible]
BEING THERE --
AND RIGHT BUT IN THE MEANTIME
WE'VE YOU SAID THAT 3240% --
YOU'VE REMOVED IT THAT
INFORMATION AND FROM 3240% OF
THE DOCUMENTS.
I'M WELL HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO
FOLKS THAT --
IDENTITY THEIR IDENTITY HAS BEEN
STOLEN --
WITH I'M SORRY WE DON'T HAVE THE
BUDGET AYE IT'S THESE THIS
POPULATION IS ALREADY VULNERABLE
IF THERE ARE GOING TO ANY
PROCESS TO EDT I'M ASSUMING THAT
THEY'RE ALREADY.
EITHER UNEMPLOYED OR THEY'RE
THEY'RE IN THAT VULNERABLE TO IT
SITUATION AND TO ADD THAT AND
THIS IS ME YOU MIGHT YOU MADE
THE COMMENT.
DIED --
IDENTITY THEFT TIME CONSUMING
THESE FOLKS ALREADY IN THE VOTE
VULNERABLE STATE.
AND FOR US TO BE ARE EXPOSING
THEIR INFORMATION JUST DOESN'T
SEEM RIGHT AND I CAN APPRECIATE
THE BUDGET QUESTIONED BY I'M
JUST A NORMAL PERSON AND COMPUTE
I MEAN I CAN.
WITH MY PHONE.
YEAH THERE'S WHOLE BUNCH OF
THINGS THAT I CAN DO AND SO IT
JUST DOESN'T FIT IN MY
COMPREHENSION HOW.
OUGHT WE CAN'T JUST CODE
SOMETHING TO REMOVE --
THE SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS ARE
GOING TO CHANGE THAT AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU.
THE BENEFIT SYSTEM THAT WE WILL
HAVE IN OUR STATE WILL BE THE
LARGEST.
IN OUR COUNTRY.
AND WHAT I WILL WHAT I WILL TELL
YOU IS THIS GOING TO COST
SOMEWHERE AROUND.
IT'S GONNA COST A WHOLE LOT OF
MONEY --
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS --
WHAT?
WHAT I'LL TELL YOU THAT WE ARE
MARCHING DOWN THE PATH TO GET
THERE?
WE HAVE ALREADY SET A COURSE TO
GET TO THAT PLACE A PLACE OF
THEIR OWN TO OUR THING INDICATE
QUICK SOLUTION IT'S BEEN IT'S
BEEN MENTIONED TO ME MADE WHICH
IS BY.
PAPER WITH HOLES PUNCHED IN IT
MAYBE WEEK THERE'S MAYBE THERE'S
A LOW TECH SOLUTION THAT WE CAN
GO THROUGH.
THEY ALL COST MONEY.
AND IF I DON'T HAVE MONEY
ALLOCATED TO ME WHICH OFTENTIMES
SUSAN EDUCATION A PRIORITY
[inaudible]
THEN.
BUT I'M FACED WITH THE DILEMMA
WITHIN MY DEPARTMENT OF OF WHAT
IS THE PRIORITY FOR RUNNING.
OUR SYSTEMS WHAT I WILL TELL YOU
IS THAT KEEPING THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE SYSTEM PAYING BENEFITS.
TO CALIFORNIANS AS YOU DESCRIBE
THAT ARE ON THOSE FRINGES IS THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY FOR ME.
WE HAVE RECEIVED THE BEST
RATINGS FOR THE SOLE SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION WHO COMES OUT AND
IT'S BY ANNUAL AUDITS OF OUR
SYSTEM.
AND THEY SAY AND THEY TELL ME
THAT WE RECEIVED THE THAT WE ARE
THE PAST OKAY SO IT THEN.
PEOPLE'S INFORMATION THAT I
QUESTION TO YOU ROADS ARE ARE
YOU OKAY WITH THE AUDIT THAN.
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT WE ARE
ALREADY GOING THROUGH A SYSTEM
THAT IT WHETHER OR NOT I'M OKAY
WITH THE AUDIT FRANKLY IS NOT.
SOMETHING THAT --
I GET TO DECIDE I'VE QUIT YOU
DECIDE WHERE WE'RE HERE TO TO
HEAR YOUR OF LEADING INTO THE
FIGHT GOT TO DECIDE AT A FRANKLY
WOULD BE SPENDING MY TIME AND I
WOULD THINK THAT.
THERE ARE OTHER THINGS THAT YOU
GUYS COULD FOCUS ON THAT A
FRANKLY MORE IMPORTANT THAN THAT
SECTION WELL IT'S A TO THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE AND IT LOOKED AT
THAT YOU'RE ASKING ME AND OF
WHAT I WOULD TELL YOU THAT YOUR
DECISION WHETHER.
YOU RIGHT NOW I UNDERSTAND THAT
BUT BUT THE HIVE YES VERY LUCKY
OF THE AUDITOR DESCRIBED IF YOU
CAN LET ME ASK CONTINUE MY
QUESTION I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATED.
WHAT MY WHAT I'M SAYING IS YOU
TO YOU IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
BOTH FOR THOSE FOLKS THAT THEIR
IDENTITY IS BEING STOLEN THAT'S
THEIR PRIORITY AND SO HOW CAN WE
COME TOGETHER? TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOUR PRIORITIES ARE THEIR
PRIORITIES AS WELL BECAUSE THIS
IT'S JUST SOUNDS AGAIN I'M JUST
A NORMAL PERSON AND TO ME IT
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE A BIG DEAL.
AND PERHAPS THERE IS THAT MONEY
PROBLEM BUT WE CAN'T KEEP
EXCUSING --
INEFFICIENCIES BASED ON ON BOND
MONEY BECAUSE THERE ARE OTHER
WAYS THAT CAN.
EITHER I DON'T KNOWSAVED SOME
MONEY SOMEWHERE YOU KNOW THAT
THERE'S AND EFFICIENCIES IN
EVERY DEPARTMENT AND SO IF WE
CAN FIGURE OUT HOW THOSE
INEFFICIENCIES CAN BE --
CORRECTED BUT THIS IS A BIG
CONCERN AND IT SHOULD BE.
YOUR NUMBER TWO PRIORITY IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS --
IDENTITIES ARE NOT BEING STOLEN
SO JUST WITH THAT I APPRECIATED
I KNOW WE'RE GONNA GO ROUND AND
ROUND AND ROUND IT DOESN'T SOUND
LIKE WE'RE GONNA COME TO A
RESOLUTION ON THAT THE AUDITOR.
ON STEPS AND THAT THEM BUT I
THINK I AGREE WITH YOU IS THAT
IT IT SHOULD BE ONE OF OUR
PRIORITIES I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
TO A BUT I WILL TELL YOU THE
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT RECEIVE THESE
BENEFITS.
IS GETTING THAT CHECK.
AND I HAVE A COMPUTER SYSTEM
THAT YES BUT IF THEIR IDENTITIES
STOLEN THOSE CHECKS ARE GONE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO BE PAYING --
OTHER --
WHEN THEIR IDENTITIES ARE STOLEN
AND SOMEBODY'S CHARGING UP FOR
EXAMPLE ON THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY
THAT TECH WILL BE GONE BECAUSE
CREDITORS WILL COME AFTER THEM
WAS ALRIGHT THANK YOU I'M GOING
TO STEP IN HERE I I THINK YOUR
POSITIONS HAVE BEEN MADE CLEAR?
ETCETERA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF MR
HEADING FIRST LET ME THANK YOU
FOR THE NICE JOB YOU.
AT YOUR DEPARTMENTS IN THE
SERVICE THAT YOU PROVIDE.
TO PROBABLY MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA.
YOU KNOW I'M PRETTY OLD --
AND I HAVE I HAVE THIS THING
CALLED MEDICARE OF CARD.
AND MEDICARE CARDS UNTIL
RECENTLY HAD A SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER ON THEM.
AND WE WERE ACCUSTOMED TO USING
THEM AND ALL OF A SUDDEN IN THE
MAIL COMES THIS ENVELOPE FROM
WHEREVER UP IN.
WASHINGTON DC OR WHEREVER IT
COMES FROM.
AND I HAVE A NEW CARD.
AND THEY I HAVE A NEW CARD
BECAUSE THEY DELETED THE SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS FROM THE
MEDICARE CARDS AND WE HAVE SOME
NEW.
MULTI DIGIT NUMBER AND HAVE BEEN
INSTRUCTED TO DESTROY THE
MEDICARE BECAUSE THE OLD ONE AND
TO USE A NEW.
SO I KNOW THIS CAN BE DONE.
WHAT I'VE BEEN UNABLE
[inaudible]
TO REALLY.
PINNED DOWN IN THE DOCUMENTS
THAT WERE.
IN OUR BINDER HAVING TO DO WITH
THE SUTTER.
FROM YOUR DEPARTMENT.
IS WHAT THAT BUT THE WHAT THE
REAL PROBLEM IS WHAT THE
TIMELINE IS AND WHAT THE DOLLARS
ARE.
I'VE SEEN I SEE SOME LETTERS
FROM TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN BUT
WE'RE NOW IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN AND I THINK WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
AND SOMETIMES YOU KNOW THE THE
STATE AUDITOR'S HERE TO HELP.
JUST LIKE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
I'D LIKE TO SEE A AT THE END OF
THIS PROCESS OF PLAN TO GET TO
THE POINT WERE ONE WE IDENTIFY
ALL OF THE SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS THAT CAN BE SCRUBBED.
AND OF AND CHANGED TO OTHER.
DIGITAL ADDENDA FIRES. TO THE
COST FOR THAT --
AND THREE A TIMELINE.
I'M SOMEWHAT BECAUSE OF MY TIME
UP HERE I CONTINUE TO SERVE ON A
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE IT HAS TO DO
WITH IT PROJECTS SO I'M SOMEWHAT
FAMILIAR WITH THOSE AND SOMEWHAT
FAMILIAR WITH THE COST AND THE
SUCCESS OR FAILURE RATE.
BUT I'D LIKE TO SEE WHAT THE
WHAT THE ESTIMATE IS THE SCOPE
OF THE PROJECT IS WHAT THE
DOLLARS INVOLVED ARE.
AND WE'LL SEE IF WE CAN'T FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO GET YOU SOME MONEY.
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS IT CAN BE
SCRUBBED OUR SCRIPT I REALIZE
THAT US SOMETIMES WITH RESPECT
TO EMPLOYER RETURNS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT YOU'RE GONNA NEED USE
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS
[inaudible]
BUT THAT.
SITUATION AND THOSE FORMS SHOULD
BE.
OF LIMITED TO THE MAXIMUM EXTENT
POSSIBLE SO.
I'M GOING TO BE SUPPORTING THE I
REQUEST TODAY I I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THAT FROM YOU AND MAYBE THE
AUDITOR CAN.
YOU TWO CAN GET TOGETHER AND PUT
THAT TOGETHER SO WE HAVE THAT TO
CONSIDER AS WE TAKE A LOOK AT
THE BUDGET FORMULATION.
FOR A 200-019-2000.
TWENTY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU --
CENTER ROTH BEFORE --
MISTER HEADING IF --
YOU MAY RESPOND TO THAT BUT TO
PROCEDURAL MATTER.
JOINT ETCETERA ALLEN I LIKE.
TO ESTABLISHED QUORUM BY NOT
CALLING FOR ALL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MERCY CHAIR.
MERCY CHIEF HERE ACOSTA
[inaudible]
HERE.
HERE BAKER HERE BAKER HEARING AS
ARYAN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
RUBIO HERE [inaudible]
WHAT [inaudible]
SENATOR ROTH [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
BELL CANNELLA [inaudible]
FULLER [inaudible]
LARA [inaudible]
ASSEMBLY SQUIRM.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU AND I'D LIKE --
TO TAKE CARE OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE --
A PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR OF
SIX ITEMS --
THE I LIMITS RENT GOOD --
TO QUICKLY THE ITEM TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THAT'S ONE TWENTY
SANSKRIT BAKER CONSERVATION AND
DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION --
I REQUEST FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN --
AMONG OTHERS --
ITEM TWENTY EIGHTEEN DASH ONE
TWENTY TWO DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES.
REGIONAL EXPANSION MODEL ON A
REQUEST FROM CENTER AND NIELSEN --
ITEM TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT'S ONE
TWENTY SIX LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES --
REQUESTS FROM SEVERAL LARA.
ITEM TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT'S ONE
TWENTY SEVEN CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY PARKING PROGRAMMING
ACCOUNTS OUTSIDE STATE TREASURY
REQUEST BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA.
ITEM TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT'S ONE
THIRTY ONE ALARM.
ALUM ROCK UNION ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND BOARD OF
TRUSTEES REQUEST FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA AMONG OTHERS.
AND ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THAT'S ONE THIRTY THREE FALLEN
LEAF LAKE COMMUNITY SERVICES
DISTRICT I REQUEST FROM SENATOR
GAINES.
THOSE SIX ITEMS ARE PROPOSE FOR
CONSENT TO DO WE HAVE ANY
REQUEST TO PULL.
MOVE IS MOTIONS MADE BY MISTER
WOOD SECOND BY MISS --
MISTER A CLOSER --
I'D SAY THERE IS ANOTHER
PROCEDURAL THING.
YES --
BEFORE WE GO FURTHER WE AGAIN AS
A PROCEDURAL MATTER WE NEED.
TO SPEND JAIL ACT RULES THIRTEEN
AND FIFTEEN ROLE THIRTEEN WILL
ALLOW THE STATE HONORS ANNOUNCES
TO BE PUBLICLY RELEASED AT THIS
TIME WILL FIFTEEN ALLOW THE
COMMITTEE TO WAY DISCUSSION AND
TAKE ACTION.
IS OUR MOTION AND SECOND TO
SUSPEND BOTH RULES MOTION BY MS
RUBIO.
SECOND BY MISTER WOOD.
ROLL CALL ON THE PROCEDURAL
MOTION OF SUSPENDING THE J. LACK
RULES.
THIRTEEN FIFTY ROLL CALL FOR
WAVING COMMITTEE RULES THIRTEEN
AND FIFTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI.
SUJI AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE BAKER AYE AYE BAKER
AYE IN THE SYRIAN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO I WOULD.
WOULD I SENATOR ROTH.
ROTH AYE ALLEN [inaudible]
NOW [inaudible]
CANNELLA.
CANNELLA AYE FULLER.
FULLER AYE LARA.
CENTRE BELL I I MEAN CENTER
ALLEN I APOLOGIZE [inaudible]
LARA [inaudible]
THAT MOTIONS.
ALRIGHT SO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
HAS BEEN.
APPROVED WELL ADD THE THAT THE
MOTION TO SUSPEND THE CHAIR
ELECT RULES.
AB BEEN APPROVED WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND TO APPROVE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MADAM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI.
WHERE SUCI AYE ACOSTA?
COST AYE BAKER AYE AYE BAKER AYE
IS ARYAN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO I WENT.
WOULD I CENTER ROTH.
ROTH AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BELL [inaudible]
CANNELLA [inaudible]
CANNELLA AYE [inaudible]
FULLER.
FULLER AYE LARA.
OKAY SO THAT MOTION.
PASSED THE APPROVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS BEEN PASSED CENTER
ROTH.
YES THEY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
WE WILL ARE ALLOWED THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A THE REST THE
COMMITTEE --
TO ADD ON TO THOSE ITEMS AND SO
THE SIX ITEMS THAT WERE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THOSE AUDIT
REQUESTS HAVE BEEN APPROVED IF
YOU'RE.
HERE FOR THOSE SIX ITEMS.
I WILL HAVE NO FURTHER HEARING
ON THOSE SIX ITEMS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS BAKER FOR
YOUR PATIENCE --
WE WILL RETURN TO YOUR HONOR I
REQUEST AND I WANNA GIVE MISTER
HANNEGAN OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND
TO CENTER ROTS QUESTION IF YOU
REMEMBER IT.
I APPRECIATE THAT OF MISTER
CHAIRMAN A I THINK THAT WHAT I
WOULD JUST.
SOME GUYS TOO MISTER OFFICE THAT
AS AS YOU KNOW.
STATE WHEN WE'RE GOING THROUGH
THE STATE DETERMINES THAT IT'S
NOT A LONE WOLF TYPE OF A
SITUATION.
THAT OFTENTIMES IS WALKING HAND
IN HAND WITH THE LEGISLATURE
THROUGH THE PROCESS.
WE'VE GONE THROUGH AN ANNUAL
BUDGET PROCESS WE WILL CONTINUE
TO DO THAT.
WHAT I WOULD ASK FOR USE TO
RECONSIDER AT TO LOOK AT THE --
STOCKINGS THAT WE HAVE WITHIN
OUR PROCESS --
THAT WE HAVE BEEN GOING THROUGH
WITH THE BENEFIT SYSTEM
MODERNIZATION PROGRAM.
BUT THAT DOES INCLUDE THAT SITS
IN OUR BUDGET DOCUMENTS --
TO REPLACE SECURITY NUMBER.
AS ENOUGH SO THAT WE CAN
COMPLETE THAT PROJECT SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE DO GET
THOSE.
CHECKS OUT TO PEOPLE AND AND I
DON'T KNOW WILL TELL YOU WE'VE
HAD THE AUDITOR WITHIN OUR
OFFICE WE HAD IT.
HOW THE AUDITOR WITH THAT'S --
FOR FOR QUITE A FEW KEY
FORTUNATELY THERE ARE.
A AND SHE WAS HELPFUL --
AT TIMES A BUT WHAT I WILL TELL
YOU IS THAT.
AT THIS POINT I I'VE I'M FEARFUL
THAT.
IF YOU WERE TO LOOK BUT IF YOU
WERE TO GO INTO THE SYSTEM IF I
HAD FAILED TO COMPLETE THE
PROJECT.
THE MAY BE THERE WOULD BE A A
TIME DID WANT TO GO LOOK AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE COMPLETED THE
BUT WE'RE AT A POINT.
WITHIN THE STAGE GATE WITHIN THE
TIMELINE THE PROJECT TIMELINE
SYSTEM.
THAT'S BEEN APPROVED BY THE
STATE THAT'S BEEN APPROVED BY
THE LEGISLATURE WITH SEVERAL
TEKKEN POINTS --
WITH LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEES --
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS AND BACK
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WE LAID OUT.
WHAT OUR PLAN WAS IN TWO STAGES
OF THAT INCLUDED ELIMINATING AS
MANY PLACES AS WE CAN SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS?
FRANKLY --
BUT SENATOR WE WE'VE DONE THAT
AND WE WILL CONTINUE OUR
CONTINUING TO DO THAT --
AND WE ARE CONTINUE TO MUCH FORD
WITH THE MODERNIZE JUSTICE YOU
HAVE -- WITH --
THIS'LL SECURITY ADMINISTRATION
AS PEOPLE KIDS HAVE WITH --
THEIR EDUCATION NUMBERS IN THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM TO REPLACE
THAT NUMBER IT DOES TAKE THE
LEVEL OF EFFORT IT DOES TAKE.
SOME MONEY TO REPLACE --
ANTIQUATED SYSTEMS WE ARE
MARCHING TOWARDS A PATH OF HOW
THE FOR THE PAST FEW YEARS WILL
WE TERRY I BEFORE YOU GO TO
PROCEED I NEED TO EXCUSE MYSELF
AND I'M GOING TO ASK THE VICE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE US SANTA
ROTH.
TO TAKE OVER THIS HEARING I I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT --
IN ADDITION TO SENATOR ROTH --
TAKEN OVER IN THE THE GAVEL --
THE STATE BRIEFLY STATE MY
POSITION THAT A WHILE I
CERTAINLY RESPECT THAT --
THAT THE EDT APPEARS TO BE
MAKING PROGRESS AND UPDATING A
SYSTEM --
THIS WELL SPEAKING FOR MYSELF
PERSONALLY I TO WANT.
TO EMPHASIZE --
AND JOINED HIS RUBIO AND AND AND
OF STRONGLY EMPHASIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROTECT PROTECTING
CALIFORNIANS SIR.
ALSO SECURITY NUMBERS AND FOR
THAT REASON I WILL BE
RECOMMENDING AND I TO THIS I
REQUEST.
SENATOR ROTH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR TAKEN OVER AND A POLICE
PERSON.
WELL I GUESS I'LL LIMIT MY
COMMENT I JUST WANTED.
TO HELLO MY TO SIR I HEARD THE A
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR FIGURE FOR
A SYSTEM MODIFICATION AND FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
THE IT PROCUREMENT BUSINESS IN
THIS STATE.
THAT'S A FLESH WOUND.
SO I'D LIKE TO PURSUE THAT AND
LIKE TO UNDERSTAND HOW MANY.
OF PRICES SEIZE REQUIRES SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER ABSOLUTELY AND
HOW MANY DO NOT AND THEN I'D
LIKE TO MOVE FORWARD THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS TO GET THAT FIXED
WE SPEND A LOT OF MONEY.
FORTUNATELY THANKS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION.
IN THE STATE AND IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS.
I AND I THINK THIS IS ONE
ELEMENT OF OF OF CYBERSECURITY
THAT WE NEED.
TO CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD ON
SO WITH THAT I WILL --
SHUT MY MOUTH AND ASK MY
COLLEAGUES IF OTHER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THE COMMENTS.
ANY OTHER --
ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE.
YES SIR STEP RUNDOWN.
PAT WAS CHAIRMAN MEMBER MIKE
MATIC A COUNSELOR CONSUMER
WATCHDOG AND SINCE THAT.
THE CHAIRMAN AND I WERE MENTORED
BY THE SAME JUDGE ADVOCATE
GENERAL I GUESS THAT MAKES ME
ALL -- TO
THE BIG FAN OF DIRECTOR HANDING
AND I THINK OF THE JUST JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE A
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT.
IS EXACTLY THE ASSISTANCE OF
THAT HE NEEDS TO DO HIS JOB
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR ANY OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT.
SEEING NONE --
WE'RE NOW AT THE POINT WHERE
THERE COULD BE A MOTION IF THERE
IS.
IT'S BEEN MOVED --
AND SECONDED --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ACT
ACTUALLY IT UP IF I COULD JUST
TAKE A BRIEF MOMENTS CLOSES ALL
I. PODEROSA.
NEVER BAKER BECAUSE I I WANT
THINK COMMITTEE I DO ONE THING
OF THE DIRECTOR WE WE ARE NOT IN
A SITUATION WHERE THERE IS AN
AGENCY THAT HAS.
BEEN HIDING THINGS FROM US WE
HAVE A DIRECTOR WHO IS.
THE ISSUE IS IMPORTANT WHERE WE
HAVE IS -- A
DIRECTOR HAS SAID TO US THERE'S
WE'RE GONNA BE A LOT OF MONEY.
AND ARE LEGISLATURE'S GONNA NEED
TO HAVE THE BEST POSSIBLE
INFORMATION WE CAN HAVE.
AND WELL YOU DD HAS TRIED IN
PRIOR YEARS TO ANSWER OUR
QUESTIONS AND HAS MADE
COMMITMENTS AND PROMISES TO WHEN
THEY'RE GOING TO MAKE PROGRESS
IN REACH MILESTONES IT HAS BEEN
SOMETHING WE'VE SEEN COME TO
FRUITION NOW WE NEED THE AUDITOR
TO GO IN.
AND BE THAT PARTNER WE NEED TO
BE A PARTNER WITH THE DIRECTOR
AS WELL.
AND THIS INCLUDES SOMETHING WE
DIDN'T HEAR TOO MUCH ABOUT THIS
HEARING BUT I I BELIEVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOCK IT WAS BUT WAS
GETTING TOO AND THAT IS.
WHAT TEMPORARY FIXES CAN WE BE
PUTTING IN PLACE WHILE THIS
LONGER MULTI YEAR REPLACEMENT OF
THE LEGACY SYSTEM AS IT'S
HAPPENING BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
THE GREATEST FRUSTRATIONS THAT
WE'VE EXPERIENCED?
WHICH IS AT EVERY TURN WERE
LOOKING FOR WHAT CAN BE DONE --
TO TO YES PUT A BANDAID ON IT
BUT TO PUT DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
NOW AND THERE'S BEEN ZERO
PROGRESS ON THAT.
AND THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT SHOULD
THE D. USEFUL SECURITY NUMBERS
IT'S ARE THEY GOING TO CONTINUE
TO SEND THEM IN THE MAIL. TO
THEIR CUSTOMERS ARE CONSTITUENTS
AND WHAT CAN WE DO TO PROTECT
THEM AND THAT SO I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WAS CLEAR AGAIN --
I THINK THE DIRECTOR OF FOR HIS
FOR HIS WORK IN THE PAST AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION OF THIS AUDIT.
THANK YOU IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE ITEM NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DASH ONCE
YOU NINE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT PRIVACY PROTECTION
PRACTICE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MERCY ITCHING.
ELK AND THE TEARS
RECOMMENDATIONS AND I THROUGH
AMERICA'S MURATSUCHI
[inaudible]
ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE BAKER AYE AYE BAKER
AYE NAZARIAN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I RUBIO.
RUBIO I WOULD.
WOULD I SENATOR ROTH I'M ROTH
AYE ALLEN [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
CANNELLA.
CANNELLA AYE FULLER.
FULLER AYE LARA [inaudible]
LETTERS UNCLE A VERY MUCH AKIN
TO HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FLORA
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THIS IS SIGN IN ORDER IN THIS
COMMITTEE SO --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN.
AND THIS ISN'T --
AUDIT REQUEST --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN DASH ONE THREE
ZERO CORRECT.
THAT IS CORRECT.
BERMAN MOTOR VEHICLES REAL ID
[inaudible]
MR [inaudible]
THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
I WILL THE SENATE TODAY WITH MY
CO AUTHOR AND COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLYMAN JIM PATTERSON ON A
REQUEST TO AUDIT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES.
RIDLEY THE WAIT TIMES HAVE
INCREASED.
AND PEOPLE ARE EXPERIENCING
AVERAGE WAYS OF UP TO FIVE HOURS
ON ROUTINE SERVICES.
EVEN IF YOU BOOK AN APPOINTMENT
MONTHS IN ADVANCE.
THROUGH THE DMP WEBSITE
CALIFORNIANS ARE STILL FACE
WAITING LONG HOURS.
IT SENDS ME THAT THE REASON FOR
THIS AUDIT BECAUSE OF THE AMOUNT
OF CONSTITUENTS THAT CONTACT MY
OFFICE IN THE LAST FEW MONTHS
ABOUT THE HORRIBLE EXPERIENCES
AT YOUR LOCAL DMV'S.
IN FACT I RECEIVED AN EMAIL FROM
A CONSTITUENT THAT OUR DAUGHTER
FAINTED WHILE WAITING IN LINE AT
THE FOUR TO DMV AND SHE'S QUITE
A DAUGHTER WITH WHITNEY OUTSIDE
FOR ABOUT THREE HOURS WHEN SHE
FAINTED.
LUCKILY THERE WAS OTHERS IN LINE
TO HELP CALL NINE ONE THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT CAME QUICKLY.
BUT DESPITE ALL THIS SHE REFUSED
TO GO TO THE HOSPITAL BECAUSE
SHE NEEDED HER REPLACEMENT
LICENSE YOU KNOW ONCE HUESO
THREE HOURS SHE OR HE SPENT IN
LINE.
DMV EMPLOYEES WATER JUST INSIDE
FOR THE REST OF HER WEIGHT WHICH
WAS AN ADDITIONAL. TWO HOURS.
WHILE INSIDE SHE SPOKE TO OTHER
PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T HAVE
APPOINTMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
THERE [inaudible] SEVEN HOURS.
THE DMV POSTSCRIPT WAIT TIMES
FROM LOCAL FIELD OFFICES THE
TIMES ARE ONLY MEASURED.
THE MOMENT YOUR ISSUE THE TICKET
NUMBER THAT TIME DOES NOT
ACCOUNT FOR THE HOURS SPENT
OUTSIDE WAITING LINE TO GET A
NUMBER.
ACCORDING TO DMV THE INCREASE WE
TYPES ARE PROBABLY DUTY
IMPLEMENTATION OF REAL LIGHTING.
WHICH STATES BUT TO CONTINUE TO
TWENTY TWENTY ABOUT THIRTY
MILLION CALIFORNIANS HAVE A
STATE ISSUED DRIVER LICENSE OR
IDENTIFICATION CARD.
NO NO LONGER BE VALID FOR AIR
TRAVEL AFTER OCTOBER FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY AND THE ONLY WAY.
OBTAIN A REAL IDEAS TO GO TO GM
OFFICE BEFORE THAT DEADLINE.
I KNOW THAT YESTERDAY THERE WAS
A ROBUST DISCUSSION REGARDING
LONG WAIT TIMES.
THE DMV WASN'T ABLE TO GIVE
CONCRETE TIMELINES ON WHEN THE
WAIT TIMES WE GET SHORTER.
WHAT PLANS THEY HAVE IN PLACE TO
FIX THIS PROBLEM?
MY CONCERN IS THAT DECISIONS
WILL CONTINUE TO FACE
UNACCEPTABLY LONG WAIT TIMES I
WAS WE PROACTIVE DO SOMETHING
NOW.
THERE'S A LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
FROM THE DEPARTMENT ON ANY PLANS.
TO HELP WITH THE WAIT TIMES AS
WELL AS A DISTRUST OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
I HOPE THAT EVERY MEMBER HERE --
HAVE STOPPED YOU LISTEN TO THE
TESTIMONY TODAY AND KNOWLEDGE
THAT THIS AUDIT IS NOT A
PARTISAN ISSUE.
IT'S NOT REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT
IMPACTS ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
THIS IS A CALIFORNIA WHITE ISSUE.
REALLY GET DOWN TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO SOLVE THE SOLUTION.
WITH US AT ALL ON REFER TO MY
COLLEAGUE HERE SO WE JIM
PATTERSON.
THANK YOU OUT MEMBERS AND THE
AND THE CHAIRS THAT I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
YESTERDAY.
I IN THE BUDGET --
ACCOUNTABILITY HEARING WE FOUND
THAT THE DMV IS REQUESTING A
ADDITIONAL.
A SIXTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
UPPER ADDED STAFFING IS ALSO
ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL.
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS THAT
IS ON TOP OF THE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT HAVE BEEN GIVEN FOR
OUR THE PURPOSES OF GETTING
THESE WAIT TIMES ARE REDUCED AND
YET THE WAIT TIMES HAVE ACTUALLY
EXPLODED.
YESTERDAY WE HEARD A LOT OF
EXCUSES --
WE DID LEARN THAT ALL OF THE
ADDED FUNDING APPROVED IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET.
HAS RESULTED IN ONLY ONE OR TWO
NEW EMPLOYEES AT EACH LOCATION.
THROWING MONEY AT THIS PROBLEM
IS NOT GOING TO FIX IT TO THE
DEPTH OF THE DIFFICULTIES THAT
WE ARE UNCOVERING.
WE DON'T WANT TO BE HERE SIX
MONTHS FROM NOW ASKING OURSELVES
WHERE THE MONEY WENT.
AND THE LINES ARE STILL OUT THE
DOOR.
THAT'S THE REASON WE'RE
REQUESTING THE AUDIT FOR A DEEP.
DIVE INTO THE DELAYS THAT ARE
CAUSED BY A NUMBER OF PROBLEM
AREAS.
REAL ID IS ONE AS WELL AS A
OUTDATED DEATH TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORM.
THERE BEEN FAILURES OF
FUNDAMENTAL PLANNING GOING BACK
A YEARS AND THE IMPACTS HAVE
BEEN UP FELT BOTH BY.
CALIFORNIA CUSTOMERS AND BY THE
DILIGENT HARD WORKING EMPLOYEES
OF THE DMP.
YESTERDAY WHEN I ASKED ALONG
WITH OTHER COLLEAGUES FOR MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE SYSTEM
OUTAGES.
THE TIMES THAT THE DMV'S FORTY
YEAR OLD SYSTEM CRASHES.
CUSTOMERS ARE LEFT SCRATCHING
THEIR HEADS.
THIS HAPPENED ON MONDAY ACROSS
THE STATE FOR ALMOST A HALF A
DAY.
IT HAPPENS FREQUENTLY BUT UPON
DIRECT --
QUESTIONING OF THE DIRECTOR.
WE COULD NOT DETERMINE THE FACTS.
OUR SHE IS EITHER DID NOT KNOW
THEM OR WERE UNWILLING TO UP.
DISCUSS THEM WITH THIS IN ORDER
TO TELL US THE SCOPE SIZE AND
FREQUENCY OF THESE OUTAGES A THE
THESE DETAILS MAY BE
EMBARRASSING BUT THEY'RE
NECESSARY FOR US TO FIND OUT AND
WE THINK THAT THE AUDIT.
HELPS US TO GET THERE WE FIND
OURSELVES IN WHAT APPEARS TO BE.
A MASSIVE FAILURE OF ONE OF THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES THAT IS UNABLE TO
FUNDAMENTALLY SERVE DRIVERS IN A
TIMELY MANNER.
WHICH IS THAT FUNDAMENTAL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR BEING IF
THERE WAS EVER A DEPARTMENT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT THE ISC BECAUSE CRYING OUT
FOR AN AUDIT IT IS THE DM DE.
WE HAVE A COURAGEOUS INDIVIDUAL
TO TESTIFY HERE TODAY.
COLIN GRANT IS A MANAGER IN THE
LOS ANGELES DMV OFFICE.
HE'S BEEN THERE FOR THIRTEEN
YEARS HE HAS ALSO FILED A REPORT
WITH THE STATE AUDITOR.
AS A QUIZZLE BLOWER.
HE KNOWS THE DMB SYSTEMS INSIDE
AND OUT HE IS A PROFESSIONAL AND
PASSIONATE LEADER WHO JUST
SIMPLY HAS RUN OUT OF OPTIONS
AND REALLY WANTS TO BE PART.
OF MAKING THE KINDS OF SYSTEMIC
WIDE RANGING CHANGES THAT THE
THE DMB EMPLOYEE SEE EVERY DAY
AND THE DM THE CUSTOMERS ARE
EXPERIENCING.
WITH LONG WAIT LINES.
MEMBERS WE NEED TO COMMEND HIM
FOR HIS BRAVERY AND I WANT.
TO JIM TO KNOW THAT HE IS NOT
ALONE THERE ARE MANY D. M. BEEP
EMPLOYEES WE HAVE HEARD FROM
THEIR MANY CUSTOMERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE HERE TODAY. TO SHARE
THEIR STORIES.
COLIN WILL BE THE SPOKESMAN FOR
THEM AND WE APPRECIATE HIM BEING
HERE THE FACTS IN TESTIMONY
TODAY WILL MAKE IT CLEAR.
THE PROBLEMS ARE HUGE MULTI
FACETED AND REQUIRE A DEEP AND
SERIOUS AUDIT OF THE DMV WITHOUT.
MISTER CULLEN GRANT [inaudible]
SERVER.
YOU STATE YOUR NAME CLEARLY FOR
THE RECORD BEFORE YOU START
AGAIN I APOLOGIZE AND ALSO.
IF YOU COULD KEEP YOUR OF
REMARKS RELATIVELY BRIEF I
REALIZE YOU HAVE A STORY TO TELL
AND I WANT YOU TO BE ABLE TO
TELL IT.
BUT WE DO HAVE AN AGENDA HERE
TODAY THAT I NEED TO MOVE SERVE
SO MISTER GRANT YOU THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY.
YOU MAY PROCEED --
MY NAME IS COLIN GRANT --
I AMA MANAGER --
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES IN THE LOS ANGELES
FIELD OFFICE FOR FIELD
OPERATIONS DIVISION.
I FOLLOWED A WHISTLE BLOWER
COMPLAINT WITH THE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE AND WAS COMPELLED TO
CONTACT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON --
TO VOICE MY CONCERNS I MET HIM
TO IMPROVE --
THE DMV FOR EVERYBODY.
I HAVE BEEN AN EMPLOYEE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THIRTEEN YEARS
AND I HOPE TO WORK.
FOR MUCH MORE YEARS TO COME.
I STARTED WITH THE DEPARTMENT AS
A MOTOR VEHICLE REPRESENTATIVE
PROCESSING A WIDE VARIETY OF
APPLICATIONS FOR THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I'VE BEEN A MANAGER NOW FOR
LITTLE BIT MORE THAN HALF OF MY
CAREER WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
IT IS MY HOPE THAT MY TESTIMONY
TODAY WEIGH HEAVILY ON THIS
COMMITTEE'S DECISION TO RULE IN
FAVOR OF AN EXTENSIVE AUDIT OF
THE DEPARTMENT'S OPERATIONS.
WHICH ULTIMATELY WILL BRING TO
LIGHT VIOLATIONS OF LAW.
GROSS INEFFICIENCY GROSS
INCOMPETENCE MISCONDUCT AND
WASTE OF STATE RESOURCES.
AS THE OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY
DATELINE APPROVED APPROACHES THE
NUMBER OF CUSTOMERS SEEKING TO
OBTAIN THE REAL ID WILL CONTINUE
TO INCREASE IN THE LONG WAIT
TIMES WILL BECOME EVEN MORE
WORSE THAN WHAT THEY ARE TODAY.
UNLESS THE ISSUES I AM GOING TO
MENTION ARE DRESSED.
THE REAL IDEA THE REAL ID IS
ANOTHER HUGE WEIGHT ON A SYSTEM
THAT IS ALREADY BUCKLING UNDER
MAJOR SYSTEMIC FAILURES.
REAL ID IS ONE OF THE BIG
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS TO THE
EXCESS OF WAIT TIMES HOWEVER.
IT WOULD BE AN EXTREME OVER
EXAGGERATION TO SAY IT IS THE
SOLE REASON AND THE BECAUSE BUT
DIEM V. AUTOMATION DIEM VIS A
WAS LAUNCHED IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY IT IS STILL IN
USE TODAY.
LITERALLY REGISTRATION
TRANSACTIONS ARE PROCESS ON A
GREEN SCREEN COMMAND LINE
INTERFACE.
DIEM VIS A IS OVERLOADED AND
FRAUGHT WITH GLITCHES
PROGRAMMING ERRORS AND
LIMITATIONS.
ALL TOO OFTEN SERVICE TO THE
PUBLIC WILL COME TO A COMPLETE
STOP BECAUSE OF DIEM VA MOST
RECENTLY THIS PAST MONDAY.
THE EVENTS THIS THESE EVENTUALLY
REQUIRE COMPUTERS TO BE REBOOTED.
AND DMV PROGRAMMING TO BE
RELOADED.
IN FACT LAST YEAR'S MASSIVE
OUTAGE OUTAGE.
WAS CAUSED BY COMPLETE SYSTEM
FAILURE OF DMV A IT IS A
LOGISTICAL NIGHTMARE TO
IMPLEMENT NEW LAWS USING DIEM VA.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS HAD TO CREATE
SEVERAL SUB SYSTEM SUCH AS THE
ENTERPRISE APPLICATION SERVICES
ENVIRONMENT E. HE'S --
DOCUMENT AUTHENTICATION DEVICES
DADS --
FILLED OFFICE DOCUMENT IMAGING
FOTI -- TH
PHOTO IMAGE RETRIEVAL.
FOREIGN DOCUMENT VERIFICATION
FINGERPRINT CAPTURE AND
ELECTRONIC DEAL FORTY FOR
RETRIEVAL AND SO ON A SINGLE
APPLICATION FOR DRIVER'S LICENSE
CAN REQUIRE A TECHNICIAN TO TALK
WILL THROUGH ALL THE SUBSYSTEMS
AND HAVE TO ENTER THEIR USER
NAME AND PASSWORD CREDENTIALS.
FOR EACH TIME.
THESE WORKAROUNDS OUR ALL TOO
OFTEN FREQUENT AND USED TO
COMPENSATE FOR IN NEARLY FORTY
YEAR OLD SYSTEM.
DIEM VA IS THE CORE DATABASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THAT HOUSES
THE CORE DATA. FOR RECORDS FOR
DRIVER'S LICENSE IDENTIFICATION
CARDS REGISTRATION FOR VEHICLES
AND VESSELS IN OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSING --
I DON'T BELIEVE IT FURTHER
EXPLANATION IS NEEDED TO COME TO
THE CONCLUSION THAT DMV IS
INADEQUATE TO HANDLE.
THE STATE'S BUSINESS NEARING THE
YEAR --
TWENTY TWENTY IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA MOTOR VEHICLE ACT
IS ALSO CAUSING SEVERE DELAYS
AND CONFUSION THE M. V. FIELD
OFFICES.
WITH THE PUSH TO IMPLEMENT
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE
WITH THE INADEQUATE SYSTEM IN
PLACE.
IT NOW THERE'S EXTREME BOTTLE
NECKING THAT IS OCCURRING FOR A
LOT OF THE CUSTOMERS.
IN APRIL TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN THE DEPARTMENT PHASED
OUT PAPER APPLICATIONS FOR
DRIVER'S LICENSE AND
IDENTIFICATION CARDS.
ONLY CUSTOMERS WITH ADDRESS
CONFIDENTIALITY ARE PARTICIPANTS
OF THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S AT
HOME SAFE AT HOME PROGRAM.
RECEIVE PAPER APPLICATIONS ALL
OTHER CUSTOMERS ARE REQUIRED TO
COMPLETE AN ELECTRONIC
APPLICATION AT A TOUCH SCREEN
TERMINAL.
OR ON THE DEPARTMENT'S WEBSITE
WHICH WAS NOT OPERATIONAL AT
ROLLOUT.
THE MOTOR --
THE MOTOR VOTER ACT HAS
SUCCESSFULLY REGISTERED NEW
VOTERS HOWEVER IT IS ONE OF THE
MAJOR CAUSES FOR THE EXCESS OF
WAIT TIMES.
MOST FILLED OFFICES DO NOT HAVE
A SUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF T. S.
TEASE TO HANDLE THE VOLUME OF
CUSTOMERS APPLYING FOR DRIVER'S
LICENSES AND IDENTIFICATION
CARDS.
APPLICATION PROCESSING TIMES
HAVE INCREASED ON CONSIDERABLY.
TECHNICIANS ARE TASKED WITH
RETRIEVING VERIFYING IN MAKING
ANY NECESSARY CHANGES TO THE
INFORMATION.
THAT WILL BE TRANSMITTED TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE USING GOOGLE
CHROME BROWSER.
THEN THE TECHNICIAN HAS TO
TOGGLE OVER TO A MONTH ZILLA
FOXFIRE BROWSER TO COMPLETE
PROCESSING OF THE APPLICATION
FOR A DRIVER'S LICENSE.
USING THE EXACT SAME INFORMATION.
MOVING ON TO THE CUSTOMER FLOW
SYSTEM.
CFS IS THE DEPARTMENT'S NEW
TICKET LISTS NUMBER SYSTEM TO
CALL CUSTOMERS TO A WINDOW.
IT WAS UNVEILED EARLIER THIS
YEAR.
CFS -- WAS
FAR FROM COMPLETION IT SHOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN ROLLED OUT.
IT WAS -- IT
WAS A MAJOR REASON WHY THERE ARE
LONG LINES OF SOMETIMES OVER A
HUNDRED CUSTOMERS SIMPLY WAITING
TO OBTAIN A TICKET.
PRIOR TO CFS A REPRESENTATIVE AT
A START HERE WINDOW ONLY HAD TO
PRESS ONE BUTTON ON THE THERMAL
PRINTER. TO ISSUE A TICKET TO A
CUSTOMER.
CFS COHEN --
REQUIRES COLLECTION OF
INFORMATION NAME PHONE NUMBER
PURPOSE OF VISIT FROM THE
CUSTOMER WHICH IS ENTERED INTO
THE CFS SYSTEM TO GENERATE A
UNIQUE NUMBER FOR THE CUSTOMER.
CUSTOMERS WERE OFTEN CONFUSE
WAITING FOR A COMBINATION OF
THEIR INITIALS IN THE LAST FOUR
DIGITS AT THEIR PHONE NUMBER TO
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN.
MISS MISTER GRANT.
MR GRANTS MAY APPEAR --
MUCH OF WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IT'S
VERY VERY IMPORTANT YOU'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE IF THE OTHER
DISAPPROVED TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO THE STATE AUDITOR.
WE'LL BE HAPPY TO ACCEPT YOUR
WRITTEN COMMENTS OF FOR THE
RECORD IF YOU'D LIKE TO SUBMIT
THEM IN THERE MAY BE SOME FOLKS
OUT -- OUT
THERE THAT MAY WANT TO COPY AS
WELL.
I'M GONNA HAVE TO ASK YOU TO TRY
TO WRAP IT UP --
WERE APPROACHING.
ABOUT THREE TIMES THE NORMAL
TIME LIMIT THE TO CHAIR ALLOWS
SO I THOUGHT I WOULD HELP HIM
BEFORE I GIVE HIM THE GAVEL BACK
HERE HOW ABOUT THAT OKAY WELL
LET ME GO AHEAD --
WAS THAT WAS SUBMIT IN WRITING
TO THE MEMBERS FOR THE RECORD --
ONE THE MV EMPLOYEES HAVE HAD TO
ACCOMPLISH MUCH WITH INADEQUATE
TOOLS FOR MANY MANY YEARS --
HIRING OF NEW EMPLOYEES WILL
HOPE I WILL HELP BUT THE
DEPARTMENT WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
HIRE THEIR WAY OUT OF THIS
PROBLEM --
IF THESE IS SYSTEMIC ISSUES ARE
NOT ADDRESSED --
THE LINES WILL CONTINUE TO GROW
IN WITH THE INFLUX OF CUSTOMERS
SEEKING THE RELY D. AS THE
OCTOBER.
TWENTY TWENTY ARE DEADLINE
APPROACHES.
I URGE ALL OF YOU TO APPROVE THE
AUDIT TODAY --
THESE CONDITIONS ARE UNBEARABLE
FOR OUR CUSTOMERS AND ALSO FOR
DIEM THE EMPLOYEES --
AN EXTENSIVE AUDIT IS THE ONLY
WAY TO BRING ALL THESE ISSUES TO
LIGHT SO THAT THEY CAN BE
APPROPRIATELY ADDRESSED --
IN THE EVENT OF AN AUDIT I AM
MORE THAN WILLING TO MAKE MYSELF
AVAILABLE TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND ALSO TO THE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE. TO ADVISE IN
AN OBJECT OF OBJECTIVELY
IDENTIFYING THE CAUSE AND VIABLE
REMEDIES TO FOR THESE EXTREME
WAIT TIMES.
WITH THANK YOU MISTER GRANT WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
TIME TO JOIN US TODAY AND
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
A MISTER CHAIR YOU'RE READY FOR
THE STATE AUDITOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH US OUT HER --
FOR SHARING VIA.
COMMITTEE HEARING IN MY ABSENCE
OF STATE AUDITOR --
WHICH PLEASE MAKE YOUR PRESENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AS A
MEMBERS INDICATED THIS WOULD BE
AN AUDIT OF DMV FIRST OBJECTIVE
IS LOOKING AT THE AVERAGE WAIT
TIMES AND THE INFORMATION THAT
D. M. V..
A PRESENTS ON ITS WEBSITE AND
THEY'RE ASKING US TO EVALUATE
THE ACCURACY AND RELIABILITY OF
THAT INFORMATION THAT'S BEING
SHARED PUBLICLY ON ITS WEBSITE.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY LOOKING AT
WHAT STEPS HAVE THEY TAKEN AS AS
EVERYTHING'S BEEN IN THE MEDIA
WE KNOW THAT THEY ARE CAN.
INTENDING TO EXTEND HOURS AT
CERTAIN OFFICES NOW HAVE
SATURDAY HOURS ON IN ADDITION TO
THOSE WHAT OTHER IT --
STEPS HAS DMB TAKE INTERTRIGO
REDUCE WAIT TIMES IN ADDITION TO
THAT WHETHER THEY INTEND TO DO
AS FAR AS EVALUATING ARE THOSE
EXTENDED HOURS WORKING ARE THEY
REDUCING WAIT TIMES BY HOW MUCH.
WHAT OTHER MEASURES DO THEY NEED
TO TAKE GOING FORWARD --
ARE THEY GOING TO ASSESS THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OF THE NEW OUR
EXTENDED WEEKDAY HOURS AND
CERTAINLY THE WEEKEND HOURS ALSO
THE MEMBERS ARE ASKING US TO
LOOK AT HAS DMV.
ARE BASICALLY DIVERTED RESOURCES
FROM OTHER FUNCTIONS AND HAS
THAT HAD AN ADVERSE IMPACT ON
INDIVIDUALS TRYING TO GET
COMMERCIAL DO.
TYPES OF SERVICES FROM DMV
BECAUSE RESOURCES HAVE BEEN
DIVERTED THEY'RE ASKING US TO
LOOK AT THAT AFFECT --
ALSO ASKING US TO SPECIFICALLY
LOOKING AT REAL ID --
WHETHER WAIT TIMES HAVE
INCREASED HAVE APPOINTMENT
AVAILABILITY HAS THAT DAY
DECREASED SINCE THEY'VE STARTED --
TO PROVIDE THIS SERVICE RELATED
TO REAL ID.
I'M TRYING TO DO SOME ANALYSIS
BASED ON LOCATION AND WHAT IS D.
M. V. DOING TO DETERMINE WHICH
OF THE LOCATIONS DID WE DID THEY
DECIDE TO EXTEND HOURS HAVE
SATURDAY HOURS.
ARE SATURDAY --
AVAILABILITY AND HOW DID THEY
MAKE THAT DETERMINATION AND HOT
WILL THEY COURSE CORRECT THAT IF
THAT IS REALLY NOT --
AFFECTING ANY CHANGE OR
IMPROVING SERVICES FOR
CONSTITUENTS --
SPECIFIC OBJECTIVES RELATED TO
REAL ID FIRST OBJECTIVE IS
REALLY WHAT WE'RE DMV'S PLANTS
KEEP IN MIND THAT REAL ID WAS
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN ON NOTICE LIKE
A LOT OF OTHER STATES.
THAT THIS HOUSE TO BE COMPLETED
BY TWENTY TWENTY IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THE STATE ASKED
FOR A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
EXTENSION SO REALLY WHAT WAS
DMV'S PLANNING PROCESS.
DETERMINING WHAT ANTICIPATING
WHAT THE WORKLOAD WOULD BE HOW
WOULD THEY ROLL OUT REAL ID HOW
WOULD THEY EDUCATE OUR CONSUMERS
IN CALIFORNIA TO DETERMINE. TO
UP WHAT THEY NEEDED TO DO WHAT
MATERIALS THEY NEED TO BRING TO
D. M. V. TO BE ABLE TO GET A
REAL IDEA NEW LICENSE.
ALSO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
REQUIRED TO CERTIFY OUR STATE AS
COMPLIANT WITH REAL ID.
THE MEMBERS WANT US TO GET AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND WHAT'S THE STATUS
OF OUR COMPLIANCE ARE WE ARE
WILL WE BE IN COMPLIANCE.
ARE WHEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
EXPECTS US TO DO WITH RESPECT TO
HIRING --
WHAT'S THE STATUS OF HIRING NEW
EMPLOYEES AS AS MISTER PATTERSON
INDICATED LEGISLATURE'S PROVIDED
FUNDING OFF HOW MANY EMPLOYEES
HAVE THEY HIRED HAVE THE
ADEQUATELY TRAIN THOSE EMPLOYEES.
HOW DID THEY DETERMINE WHERE TO
PLACE THOSE EMPLOYEES ARE IN THE
VARIOUS DISTRICT OFFICES WAS
THAT THE BEST A DECISION MADE?
AGAIN WITH RESPECT TO OUTREACH
WHAT TYPES OF OUTREACH HAVE THEY
CONDUCTED --
ARE THE MATERIALS IN A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT LANGUAGES ARE ARE
THEY EDGE ARE EVALUATING EXCUSE
ME EVALUATING HOW WELL THAT'S
WORKING AND AGAIN ARE THEY
MAKING.
ADJUSTMENTS TO THEIR OUTREACH
EFFORTS TO MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS
THAT COME TO A DMV OFFICE HAVE
THE APPROPRIATE INFORMATION
BECAUSE ONE OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED IN THE LETTER AND I THINK
YOU'VE SEEN IN THE MEDIA AS
PEOPLE WAIT IN LINE ALL DAY AND
THEN THEY GET TO THE FRONT.
DESK AND THEY GET TURNED AWAY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE WRONG
DOCUMENTS SO WHAT KIND OF
OUTREACH IN EDUCATING OUR HAS
DMV BEEN DOING AND WHAT ARE THEY
GOING TO DO IN THE FUTURE. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT DOESN'T
PRODUCT CONTINUE TO HAPPEN.
AND THEN ALSO LAST OBJECTIVE
LOOKING OUT THE FORMS AND
INSTRUCTIONS ARE THEY CLEAR ARE
THEY ACCURATE AGAIN ARE THEY AND
A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT LANGUAGES
ARE THEY MAKING IT AS EASY AS
POSSIBLE. FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
GET A NEW REAL ID OUR DRIVER'S
LICENSE OR OUR CARD --
THE BUDGET FOR THIS AUDIT IS
ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED HOURS
THAT WOULD TAKE US ABOUT SEVEN
MONTHS WHAT WE COULD DO IF WE
NEEDED TO GET IT DONE MORE
QUICKLY.
IS -- ASSIGN.
COUPLE OF TEAMS TO THIS BECAUSE
MY EXPECTATION IS WE WOULD SPEND
TIME AT HEADQUARTERS BUT
CERTAINLY GET OUT THERE STE TO
SOME DISTRICT OFFICES.
GO BACK TO THE OLD DAYS OF
AUDITING DO SOME OBSERVATION OF
PEOPLE WAITING IN LINE --
CERTAINLY WOULD DO EVERYTHING WE
COULD TO NOT GET IN THE WAY OF
PEOPLE PROVIDING SERVICES TO
CONSTITUENTS BUT CERTAINLY WOULD
NEED TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
MANAGEMENT.
BUT AS WE DO WITH ANY AUDIT WE
WOULD BE RESPECTFUL OF YOU KNOW
MANAGEMENT'S TIME ETCETERA SO
AGAIN MISTER CHAIR IT WOULD TAKE
US SEVEN MONTHS.
ARE IF THE COMMITTEE I WAS
INTERESTED IN US ETTING THIS
DONE MORE QUICKLY THAT IF IT IS
APPROVED WE CAN CERTAINLY I I
JUST ABOUT THE TEAM IN THE
STRUCTURE OF HOW WE WOULD GO
FORWARD WITH THIS AUDIT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THAT IS FROM.
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
PLEASE COME FORWARD AND PRESENT
YOUR CASE [inaudible]
AND DEATH.
LET'S SAY WE HAVE THREE
WITNESSES SO --
SIR IF YOU CAN NOW --
ACCOMMODATE THESE WITNESSES
APPRECIATED [inaudible]
GOOD FOOD.
ALRIGHT WELCOME --
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
GOOD MORNING.
US I'M DEEMED HUMOR THE DIRECTOR
OF THE PART MOTOR VEHICLES WITH
ME AS BOBBY CROCKETT HE'S THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES DIVISION.
AND A FORMER BUDGET OFFICER SO
FIRST.
I WANT TO APOLOGIZE TO OUR
CUSTOMERS AND OUR EMPLOYEES UP
IT IS UNACCEPTABLE OF THAT WE
ARE EXPERIENCING AND OFFICES I
UNDERSTAND THAT AND I GET THAT.
AND IT IS NOT WHAT WE WANT TO
HAVE TO HAPPEN TODAY AND
CONTINUE FORWARD.
UP THIS IS OUR HIGHEST PRIORITY
RESOLVES OUR CUSTOMERS AND OUR
EMPLOYEES CAN HAVE A BETTER
EXPERIENCES WITH THE DMV.
THIS IS A PROBLEM AND AS A
DIRECTOR I AM RESPONSIBLE.
AND WE ARE ACTIVELY WORKING TO
REDUCE THE WAIT TIMES.
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A COMMAND
CENTER THAT IS MARCHING OFF
FIELD OFFICES WE HAVE HAD TWO
SEMI FILLED US WE ARE ACTIVELY
MARTINE.
EACH FIELD OFFICE WERE MARTINE
THE WAIT TIMES IN EACH FIELD
OFFICE WHERE MARCHING THE NUMBER
OF CUSTOMERS IN OUR FIELD
OFFICES.
AND OUR EMPLOYEES WE'RE MAKING
ADJUSTMENTS IN REAL TIME.
THE TEAM ARE DEVELOPING NEW
STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS THESE WAIT
TIMES [inaudible]
I WE HAVE A COMMAND SIR THAT
WE'VE ESTABLISHED AND WE HAVE A
ROOM WHERE WE HAVE.
A ABOUT TWENTY PEOPLE IN THERE
AND THE TEAM IS DIVIDED INTO
MINOR TUNING OF THE QUEUING
SYSTEM DALY A AND THEN WE ALSO
HAVE ANOTHER TEAM THAT IS.
A MINOR TING OFFICE IS CALLING
TO FIND OUT IF THERE'S THAT
ABSENTEES THEM OR WE NEED TO
MAKE ADJUSTMENTS ON THE IN REAL
TIME IN TERMS OF LIVING
EMPLOYEES AROUND.
A DO WE NEED TO ADJUST THE
WINDOWS ARE OPEN FOR A DRIVER'S
LICENSE APPOINTMENT VERSUS A A
NOT APPOINTMENTS SO WE ARE
MAKING.
THOSE ADJUSTMENTS IN REAL TIME --
YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT TO REDUCE
THE WAIT TIMES TO ACCEPTABLE
LEVELS BY THE END OF THE YEAR WE
HAVE.
A A NUMBER STRATEGIES THAT WE
HAVE A WE AND OUR IT'S ME RIGHT
NOW AND WE HAVE MORE THERE WILL
BE AMPLE INDEX A COUPLE WEEKS IN
THE COMING MONTHS.
AND WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT THOSE DRAGS WAIT TIMES
DOWN BY THE END OF THE YEAR.
SO I WITH THE COMMAND CENTER WE
ARE NOT MAKING THOSE JUDGMENTS
OR FIND OUT WHAT ARE THE
CHALLENGES THAT THE OFFICES HAVE.
IT WITH THERE'S RETRAINING OF
THEIR EMPLOYEES WE DO WEDNESDAY
MORNING TRAIN FROM --
EIGHT TO NINE EVERY WEEK AND
REALLY I DO THAT WE GO OVER
PROCESS AND PROCEDURES WE
INFORMED EMPLOYEES IN THE
OFFICES OF THE THE NEW PRODUCT
OF PROCEDURES OR EVEN A DO
REFRESHER TRAINING --
WE DO LIVE EMPLOYEES BETWEEN
OFFICE IS IF THERE'S A CHEF WE
NEED TO ESTABLISH JURY ONE
OFFICES WE LIVE EMPLOYEES.
AROUND IN THE MORNING WE JUST OF
WINDOWS --
AND I KNOWLEDGE THAT THE
COMMENTS MISTER COLLINS AND WE
HAVE ADDRESS MANY OF THOSE
ALREADY AND WE ARE NOT GOING TO
ADDRESS OF THE MAIN ONES THAT HE
HAD BOUGHT FOR IT.
OUT WE WILL DO BETTER OUR
CUSTOMERS AND EMPLOYEES DESERVE
THAT -- WE
DID EXTEND THAT --
OFFICE HOURS WE OPENED ON OFFICE
OF OUR EARLY AND FOURTEEN
OFFICES AND WE HAVE SEEN
REDUCTION IN THE WAIT TIMES IN
BOTH OF THOSE OFFICES.
A WERE ABLE TO GET OUR CUSTOMERS
IN EARLIER IN THE MORNING AND
START THE DAY OF AND THEN ON
SATURDAY SERVICE WE STARTED THAT
EXTENDED UP TO SIXTY OFFICES
LAST ARITY.
WE ARE SEEING AN INCREASE IN
CUSTOMERS COMING TO OFFICE ON
SATURDAY WHICH TAKES THE
PRESSURE OFF THE OFFICES DURING
THE WEEKDAY AND THAT WE WANT TO
SEE.
OF THERE IS DATA IN REAL TIME
THAT IS BEING REPORTED
THROUGHOUT THE DAY AND OUR TEAM
IS FOCUSED ON THREE DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE OFFICE THE LINE
OUTSIDE THE OFFICE.
THE WAIT TIME INSIDE THE OFFICE
IN THE THE TRANSACTION WE'RE
LOOKING AT ALL THREE OF THOSE
SEGMENTS OF TO BREAK DOWN WITH
THE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE IS.
INSIDE THE OFFICE AND ALSO FOR
OUR EMPLOYEES INTO THE PROCESS
SEEN TRANSACTION SO --
WE ARE LOOKING AT ALL SECONDS OF
THAT SO WE I MEET WITH THE
COMMAND CENTER TEAM IN THE
MORNING AND I MEAN WITH THE MATH
AND THE DAY TO FIND OUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT HOW IDEA STARTING
OUT WITH ALL THE OFFICES IN
THEIR DAY A HOW THE DAY ENDED
WITH EACH OF OFFICES AND WHAT IT
JUST AS DO NEED TO MAKE SO WE
HAVE A TEAM THAT WE MEET.
ON THAT AND SO WE ARE FOCUSED
1100% ON OUR EFFORTS TO REDUCING
THE WAIT TIMES I HAVE THE
EXECUTIVE THAT IS WORKING ON
THIS WE HAVE A COMMAND CENTER OF
TWENTY PEOPLE MIND YOU THAT.
WE HAVE IN PLACE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WE HAVE THAT ARE GOING OUT --
AND DOING A JUST AND SO WE ARE
DOING THESE ADJUSTMENTS IN REAL
TIME WE'RE NOT WAITING AND
MAKING DECISIONS AND TALK WE ARE
EX WE SEE A PROBLEM WE SEE AND
JUST IN THE NICK MAKE.
MAKING THAT IN REAL TIME.
I WE ARE DEVELOPING THESE NEW
PROCESSES AND WERE IMPLEMENTING
THAT.
AND UP HOWEVER YOU KNOW IF IF
APPROVED BY LESTER WE WILL
COOPERATE WITH ANY ON IT BUT I I
OWE THIS PROBLEM.
WE ARE WORKING ON IT YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT THAT WE WE BY THE END
OF THE YEAR WE WOULD JUST WAIT
TIMES AND SO WE ARE WORKING.
ON DEVELOPING NEW STRATEGIES
DALY AND IF SOMETHING COMES UP
WE'RE DISCUSSING IT AND WE ARE
MOVING TO OF MANAGERS AROUND IF
WE HAVE --
TO WE ARE PUT THE BEST PEOPLE A
WHERE WE NEED TO WE I HAVE
IDENTIFIED OFFICE WITH THE
HIGHEST WAIT TIMES WE'RE
MARCHING THOSE.
AND WE'RE MAKING ADJUSTMENTS --
AS NEEDED TO BRING THOSE WAIT
TIMES DOWN YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT THAT I WILL DO THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR STATEMENT --
DID YOU HAVE A THE ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY HERE IS NOT TO OKAY
YOU'RE HERE FOR ANSWERING
QUESTIONS ALRIGHT LET ME OPEN IT
UP FOR A OF THE COMMITTEE
STARTING WITH THE VICE CHAIR
CENTER ROTH.
YOU KNOW FROM A GOOD MORNING.
IT'S IT'S THE MORNING.
YOU KNOW FROM MY PERSPECTIVE FOR
A FROM FOR GOVERNMENT CUSTOMER
SERVICE IS JOB NUMBER.
ONE AND WE'RE PROBABLY NOT GOING
TO GET A QUALITY AWARD ON THIS
[inaudible]
ONE JEFF.
LOOK BUT LET ME ASK A COUPLE
QUESTIONS FOR THOSE FOLKS WHO
ACTUALLY HAVE TO REPORT TO THE
DMV OFFICE. TO RENEW A DRIVER'S
LICENSE MY UNDERSTANDING IS
PERIODICALLY YOU HAVE TO DO THAT
IS THAT CORRECT CORRECT.
HOLE FOR AN ADVANCE DOES THE DMV
SEND OUT THE WRITTEN NOTICE TO
THE ZOOMER THE DRIVER THAT.
IN THAT PARTICULAR YEAR IN THAT
PARTICULAR CASE HERE SHE HAS TO
REPORT TO THE DMV OFFICE.
CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW THEY GET
MAILED OUT I SUCCEED WE START
THE PRICES ON NINETY DAYS IN
ADVANCE A IT'S A AUGUST TWENTY
EIGHTH WE ARE CHANGING THAT
PROCESS WHERE THERE COULD BE
MAILED OUT HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS
IN ADVANCE SO IS IT SIXTY DAYS
NOW.
WAS IT SIXTY DAYS OR NINETY YOU
KNOW HOW UGLY I RUN THE PROGRAM
PRINT THE INFORMATION MAIL IT
OUT SO.
I WE START THE PROCESS AT NIGHT
DAYS AND THE CRESSMAN WILL
PROBABLY GET IN THE MAIL UP
BETWEEN SIXTEEN THIRTY FIVE DAYS.
SO SIXTY DAYS IN ADVANCE OF THE
DAY.
THAT YOUR LICENSE EXPIRES OR
LESS YOU'LL GET A NOTICE IT SAYS
YOU HAVE TO REPORT TO THE DMV
OFFICE.
CORRECT AND SO WE ARE.
CHANGING THAT TO NINETY DAYS
WHAT'S THE AVERAGE WAIT TIME
TODAY.
IN THE SYSTEM TO GET AN
APPOINTMENT.
AT THE DMV OFFICE SO I OUT WE
LOOK AT IT JUST YESTERDAY AND WE
HAVE BEEN MONITORING IT THEIR
THEIR APPOINTMENT CENTER OUT TO
A COUPLE NIGHTS AND WE KNOW THAT
WE NEED TO DO BETTER IN TERMS OF
MAKING APPOINTMENTS AVAILABLE.
A ONE THING IS THAT WE HAVE TO
BALANCE APPOINTMENTS WOULD NOT
APPOINTMENTS IN TERMS OF HOW
MANY WE HAVE OUR WINDOWS OPEN
AND SO.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE ABOUT 2530% A
APPOINTMENT AVAILABILITY AND SO
WE HAVE TO BALANCE BETWEEN
SERVING CUSTOMERS WITH
APPOINTMENTS AND NOT
APPOINTMENTS BECAUSE WE MADE ALL
APPOINTMENTS WERE NOT BE ABLE TO
SERVE THE CUSTOMERS THAT ARE
WALKING IN AND NOT APPOINTMENTS
WE HAVE TO BALANCE THE TWO UGH.
SO WE'RE WORKING ON THAT IN
TERMS OF WE CAN REDUCE THE WAIT
TIMES UP FOR THE LONG
APPOINTMENTS WE WILL BE ABLE TO
OPEN -- MORE
APPOINTMENTS SO IS IT POSSIBLE
THAT.
A MOTORIST IN CALIFORNIA COULD
[inaudible]
A MOTORIST TO REPORT TO THE DMV.
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN STE. FIFTY AND
SIXTY DAYS PRIOR TO THE
EXPIRATION OF THE LICENSE AND
THE MOTORIST NOT BE ABLE TO
OBTAIN AN APPOINTMENT AT THE DMV
OFFICE WITHIN THAT TIME.
POSSIBLY YES SO WE ARE WORKING
TO ADDRESS THAT.
LET ME TELL YOU ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT CONCERNS ME AND I
UNDERSTAND THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS AUDIT REQUEST.
AROUND THIS BUILDING --
INSIDE AND OUTSIDE THE
LEGISLATURE.
BUT THAT WITHIN THE LAST THREE
WEEKS I WAS STOPPED ON THE
STREET IN THE CITY OF RIVERSIDE.
BY A FORMER FEDERAL JUDGE.
BUT MY PAY GRADE.
WHO PROCEEDED TO REGALE ME WITH
THE STORY ABOUT HAVING RECEIVED
ONE OF THESE LETTERS HAVING THEN
ATTEMPTED TO SECURE AN
APPOINTMENT BECAUSE HE'S SORT OF
A BUSY GUY?
ADDED AS WE ARE OF COURSE NOT NO
MATTER OF YOUR STATURE --
ATTEMPTED TO OBTAIN AN
APPOINTMENT THE DMV OFFICE WAS
AND UNABLE TO DO SO AND THEN
SPENT THE NEXT. FOUR FIVE OR SIX
I FORGET EXACTLY HOURS WAITING
AT THE DMV OFFICE TOO A OBTAIN A
RENEWAL.
OF HIS PARTICULAR DRIVER'S
LICENSE.
NOW IT REALLY DOESN'T MATTER TO
ME WHETHER HE IS OR WAS A
FEDERAL DISTRICT COURT JUDGE OR
THE CUSTODIAN AT THE STATE
BUILDING IN WHICH WE HAVE AN
OFFICE.
THAT REALLY MAKES NO DIFFERENCE
WHAT IS CONCERNING TO ME IS THE
FACT THAT WE SEND A LETTER THE
LETTER PROBABLY SAYS YOU CAN
CALL AND GET AN APPOINTMENT.
YOU CANNOT SECURE AN APPOINTMENT
YOU GO TO A D. M. V. OFFICE IN
YOU THEN PARK IN A CHAIR
ASSUMING THERE IS A CHAIR. FOR
HOURS ON END WAITING TO GET A
LICENSE THAT WE MANDATE YOU HAVE
AND IF YOU DON'T WE PENALIZE YOU.
THAT'S NOT THE WAY GOVERNMENT
SHOULD WORK AND I'M NOT FAULTING
YOU MA'AM YOU HAVE SOME VERY
DEDICATED WORKERS IN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES I KNOW THEY WORK VERY
VERY HARD.
I'M PERHAPS WAS NOT THE
EQUIPMENT THEY NEED TO HAVE THE
WE NEED TO FIX THIS PROBLEM.
WE NEED TO IDENTIFY WHAT THE
PROBLEM IS WE NEED TO TAKE TAKE
A LOOK AT HOW MUCH IT'S GOING TO
COST TO FIX IT.
IF IT'S NOT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THAT WE APPROVED WE NEED
TO HAVE A BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL.
AUGMENT THE BUDGET AND GET YOU
THE MONEY [inaudible]
ASAP.
THE PROBLEM AND I'M NOT SURE THE
END OF THE YEAR WORKS.
SO.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME MISTER
CHAIR THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS AND
ANSWER MY QUESTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I HAVE
MISTER OBERNOLTE NEXT FOLLOWED
BY MR ACOSTA IS RUBIO AND CENTER
LARA.
THAT THEY CAN MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
SO.
BUT I'M VICE CHAIR OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND I REMEMBER THAT
LAST YEAR.
WHEN WE WERE ANTICIPATING THAT
REAL ID MIGHT CAUSE INCREASED
WORKLOADS THE DMV?
THAT WE APPROPRIATE AN
ADDITIONAL SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
ASKED.
FOR PREPARE FOR THAT AND ONE OF
THE PRIMARY THINGS THAT WAS TO
BE DONE WITH THAT MONEY WAS CHIU
INSTITUTE.
SATURDAY ALL --
HOURS AT SIXTY FIELD OFFICES
[inaudible]
SIMONI A MOMENT AGO YOU SAID
SOMETHING REALLY ALARMING WHICH
IS THAT.
IT ONLY LAST WEEK DO WE ACTUALLY
GET THOSE OFFICE HOURS OPENED IS
IS THAT THE CASE BECAUSE I
REMEMBER THAT THERE WERE
SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN IN JANUARY
YES SO WHEN WE EMPLOYMENT WILL I
BE IN JANUARY WE DID OPEN ON
SATURDAY --
WE DID NOT SEE THE VOLUME OF
WILL LIKELY CUSTOMERS COMING IN
AND SO IT WASN'T NOT A VERY OUT
WITHOUT DOWN.
DATA BECAUSE THE BODIES WERE NOT
COMING IN EMPLOYEES I DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH WORK TO KEEP THEM BUSY
THROUGHOUT THE DAY.
THAT WE GET SUSPENDED BUT WE DID
READ THAT BRING BACK ON STUDIES
OUT OF SAUDI SERVICE HOURS AND
IN JUNE ON THE IN FORTY OFFICES.
ON THE FIRST AND THIRD CHARITIES
IN IN JULY INCREASE THAT TO
FORTY THREE OFFICES AND THE
FIRST AND THIRD SATURDAYS AND
THN JUST LET IN AUGUST WE'VE
CONTINUE.
OUT GOT SIXTY OFFICES OPEN EIGHT
TO FIVE UP ALL DAY OUT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND SO WE
WERE MAKING THOSE ADJUSTMENTS
AYE AND PART OF IT IS THAT WE
HAD TO GET SOME LEASES IN PLACE
TO EXPAND SORRY SERVICE AND I
LEAST OFFICES.
AND WE HAVE TO NOTIFY THE AND
FUND THE UNION THAT WE'RE GOING
TO WORK IN PLACE ON SATURDAY SO
WE HAVE TO INFORM THE UNION CHEN
FIVE EMPLOYEES SO WE HAVE TO DO
TO END IN STEPS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE WERE ABLE.
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES ON
SATURDAY.
BUT WE ARE COMMITTED TO A
KEEPING THOSE SIXTY ON SO YOU
STARTED.
FIELD OFFICE HOURS ON SATURDAY.
YOU DIDN'T SEE THE DEMAND FOR
THEM AND SO YOU CURTAIL THEM AND
THEN RECENTLY HAVE BROUGHT THEM
BACK.
YES SO WORTH THE WAIT TIMES WHEN
AT THE OFFICES WHEN YOUR COUNTRY
CURTAIL THEM.
MADE IT JUST THE IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT IF EVEN IF THE DEMAND FOR
REAL ID WASN'T THERE BUT THAT'S
NOT THE ONLY SERVICE THAT THESE
PEOPLE ARE COMING TO THE DMV.
FOR IT SO THAT WE WILL BE DEBT
RECOGNIZE THAT --
WE AND SHOULD NOT HAVE A REDUCE
THOSE HOURS OR OR STOP THOSE
HOURS WE ARE BROUGHT THEM BACK
IMMEDIATELY AND SO I WERE
WORKING TO REDUCE THOSE WAIT
TIMES WAIT AND WE ARE.
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THAT WAS A
AND WE SHOULD NOT HAVE STOPPED
THAT AND WE ARE GOING TO WORK
HIGH TO AND CONTINUE TO IMPROVE
OUR SERVICES SO IF THATTHE
LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATED MONEY
FOR THAT PURPOSE.
AND WE THERE WAS CURTAILED THE
SOME OF THAT MONEY LEFT WHAT WE
USE THAT WE WERE ALSO WORKING
ADDITIONAL OVERTIME SO --
THE MONEY THAT WAS NEEDS FOR
SELF SERVICE THAT WE WERE NOT
USING -- WAS
SPENT ON OVERTIME FOR THE
EMPLOYEES TO SERVE OUR CUSTOMERS.
SO THE MONEY'S GONE.
MONEY HAS BEEN SPENT A OKAY WELL
I I FIND THAT A LITTLE
DISTURBING I I WISH THAT IF WE
IF WE APPROPRIATE MONEY FOR
CERTAIN PURPOSE YOU KNOW THAT
THAT I FEEL LIKE USED OF OPEN
THE THE FIELD OFFICE HOURS --
THE FIELD OFFICES ON SATURDAYS
AND KEPT THEM OPEN AND MAYBE
THAT WOULD HAVE --
MADE THIS PROBLEM A LITTLE BIT
LESS SEVERE BUT IT UNITED SOME A
DISCUSSION YESTERDAY ABOUT THIS
AND I I VERY STRONGLY FEEL THAT --
OUR CONSTITUENTS REALLY DON'T
CARE ABOUT WHY THIS IS HAPPENING
YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
WHY THAT THEY CARE ABOUT THE
WHAT.
BEYOND FOR BETTER FOR WORSE.
INTERACTION WITH THE DM V. IS
ONE OF THE PRIMARY TOUCH POINTS
THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS HAVE WITH
THEIR STATE GOVERNMENT WE HAVE.
THOUSANDS OF STATE DEPARTMENTS
AND YET OUR AVERAGE CONSTITUENT
WILL PROBABLY ORDER THE
INTERACTION YOU OVER THE COURSE
OF YEAR WITH WITH ONE OR TWO AND
ONE OF THOSE IS PROBABLY A DMP
SO.
THEY ARE COLORING THEIR
PERCEPTIONS OF OUR ENTIRE STATE
GOVERNMENT BY.
THEIR EXPERIENCES AT THE
VARIANCES ARE NOT GIVING THEM A
VERY POSITIVE VIEW OF THE WAY
THAT THEIR GOVERNMENT IS SERVING
THEM SO.
BUT WE NEED TO GET THIS FIXED --
IMMEDIATELY I THINK YOU'RE GONNA
HEAR THAT OVER AND OVER AGAIN I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT ON AUDIT.
IS NOT NECESSARILY SOMETHING
THAT'S PUNITIVE IT'S NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE PUNITIVE WE'RE
TRYING TO GIVE YOU THE RESOURCES
THAT YOU NEED TO IDENTIFY WHERE
THE PROBLEMS ARE WORTH A BOTTLE
NECKS ARE.
AND GET THEM FIXED I THINK THE
AUDITOR HAS RESOURCES THAT MAYBE
THE DEPARTMENT DOES NOT HAVE IN
IDENTIFYING THOSE PROBLEMS AND I
LEADING YOU TOWARDS A SOLUTIONS
ON A SUPPORT THE AUDIT TODAY BUT
I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU THAT WERE
ON THE SAME TEAM HERE.
AND WE'RE NOT TRYING TO TO SLAP
YOUR HAND OR TELL YOU THAT THE
DEPARTMENT'S TERRIBLE AND IT'S
GOING THE WRONG DIRECTION WE'RE
TRYING TO WORK TOWARDS A
SOLUTION.
THINK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR ACOSTA.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND UP
AND AND THANK YOU TO THE TO THE
OF AUTHORS OF THIS --
I REQUEST WAS OF THIS AUDIT
AMISH YOU MOTO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE NO CAN'T BE THE SEE
TWO DAYS IN A ROW POINT
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS --
SO I I I I YOU KNOW I I HAVE
SOME SYMPATHY FOR YOU.
YOU KNOW IN THAT REGARD --
HOWEVER AND AS MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER OBERNOLTE APPOINTED OUT.
YOU KNOW ARE CONSTITUENTS SEE
THE OF THE FORWARD FACING OF
GOVERNMENT IN.
MANIFEST ITSELF PRIMARILY ONE
WAY AND I AND I BELIEVE IT'S
PRIMARILY THE ENVY --
WE REGISTER OUR CARS ANNUALLY --
WE'VE TRIED TO CHANGE THAT THE
PAST WE WE DO OUR DRIVER'S
LICENSES AND OTHER OTHER THINGS --
AND IT IT WHEN IT GOES BADLY IT
IT TENDS TO GO VERY BADLY AND
THEM AND THEY COME BACK TO US.
ARE AMONG THE TOP COMPLAINTS IN
MY DISTRICT OFFICE OUR DMV AND
ATV AND IT'S IRONIC I GUESS A
NOT SO MUCH THAT WE HAD BOTH OF
THEM HERE TODAY WITHOUT REQUESTS.
WHILE LOOKING AT VARIOUS UP
PIECES OF THOSE --
THOSE DEPARTMENTS.
AND I I DID WATCH THE MAJORITY
OF THE VERY LONG HEARING
YESTERDAY I WAS IN A MEMBER OF
THE OF THAT THOSE THOSE
COMMITTEES BUT I DID TAKE THE
TIME TO TO WATCH IT --
AND AND I I I THINK THERE WAS
SOME TROUBLING THINGS THEREIN
AND TO SAVE PEOPLE TIME --
THAT DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO
WATCH I'M GONNA ASK A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS IF THE REPEATS OF
YESTERDAY --
IF YOU'LL FORGIVE ME BUT THERE
ARE SOME SOME VERY TROUBLING
ISSUES HERE I'M THAT PIGGYBACK
OFF OF WHAT WHAT MR OBERNOLTE IT
JUST -- ASK
YOU AND THAT WAS THAT'S ABOUT
SATURDAY HOURS --
E. KNOW AYE AYE I WASN'T AWARE
THAT WE STARTED THEM IN JANUARY
AND THEN WE CURTAIL THEM --
THAT IS INFORMATION I THINK IS
IS IS ALSO VERY TROUBLING --
I DRIVING BY MY LOCAL DMV OFFICE
IN MY DISTRICT IN MY HOMETOWN.
OF THE NEW HALL OFFICE IT USED
TO BE THE OFFICE EVERYONE WENT
TO FROM THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
BECAUSE IT WAS THE QUIET SLEEPY
LITTLE OFFICE HASN'T BEEN THAT
WAY IN MANY MANY YEARS.
AND EVERY TIME I DRIVE BY THIS
OFFICE OTHERS LINES OUT THE DOOR
AROUND THE BLOCK NOW EVERYBODY
KNOWS THE LAST FEW --
WEEKS -- IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND FRANKLY THROUGHOUT
THE WEST WE'VE HAD SOME VERY
HIGH TEMPERATURES WITH
TEMPERATURES AS HIGH AS I IN A
HUNDRED AND I PROBABLY BUT
HUNDRED TWELVE HUNDRED FOURTEEN
DEGREES.
AND WE HAD PEOPLE STANDING
OUTSIDE OF A VERY SMALL THE IN
THE OFFICE THAT IS A WOEFULLY
INADEQUATE FOR THE FOR THE AREA --
JUST TO GET INSIDE AND AND THE
pTHAT --
YOU'D YOU TRACK WAIT TIMES AND
NOW YOU YESTERDAY YOU MENTIONED
AND ALSO RECORDED TODAY AND IN
THE NEWSPAPER --
THAT.
IT THE WAIT TIMES FOR AN
APPOINTMENT WITH AN APPOINTMENT
OR TWENTY THREE MINUTES IN
WITHOUT AN APPOINTMENT OR AN
HOUR TWENTY THREE MINUTES.
AND I WOULD --
AYE I TAKE EXCEPTION TO THAT
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN TO MULTIPLE
THE IN THE OFFICES ARE IN AND
OUTSIDE OF MY DISTRICT.
AND I'M NOT COUNTING THE WAIT
TIME OUTSIDE I'M TALKING ABOUT
ONCE YOU WALK IN THAT DOOR.
EITHER IT THAT'S IT THAT'S JUST
A STATISTICAL IMPOSSIBILITY SO I
DON'T KNOW WHERE YOU'RE GETTING
YOUR DATA I'M --
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE PLAYED CHANT
CHANCE TO REBUT THIS BUT BACK TO
THE SATURDAY HOURS --
HOW DID YOU CHOOSE WHICH HOURS
WHICH OFFICES TO OPEN ON
SATURDAYS I UNDERSTAND IT SIXTY
AND WE HAVE HOW MANY OFFICES TO
ORDER HADN'T SEMICHA OFFICES
227-100-7100 SEVENTY TWO OFFICES?
SO I KNOW THAT WE TOOK A QUICK
CENSUS I MISTER MISTER WOODS
MISTER ON IT SO SHE'S AN AND MY
DISTRICTS --
IN VERY POPULATED.
THESE AT ALL --
THAT THOSE ARE AREAS THAT WE
COLLECTIVELY EACH SERVE YOU KNOW
ARE ALMOST TWO MILLION A MILLION
HALF PEOPLE.
AND THERE'S NO SATURDAY OFFICE
HOURS WHATSOEVER --
HOW DID YOU COME ABOUT THE
PROCESS OF CHOOSING WHICH
OFFICES HAVE SENATE OFFICES WERE
SELECTED BASED ON THEIR WAIT
TIMES IN AND?
I ALSO THEIR HIGH VOLUME
DRIVER'S LICENSE OFFICES AND
THERE IS SOME OFFICE SO WE LOOK
AT THE PROFILE SUMMER MORE HEAVY
IN VICTORIA VEHICLE REGISTRATION
IT'S ON MORE.
HIGH PROFILE A DRIVER'S LICENSE
IN THAT'S THE CRITERIA ALSO WAS
LOOK AT JIM JUST YOU TO THINK
THE STATE.
OUT WORD OF WORD IS AND WHAT THE
STUDY SERVICE OFFICE SO THAT OUT
WE HAD THEM SPACE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
ANOTHER THING EXACT AND THE
EMPLOYEES OUT OF WORK IN THIS
ANY SERVICE IT'S VOLUNTARY
OVERTIME IN MANDATORY OVERTIME
WE PULL FROM THE SURROUNDING
OFFICES DISTAFF POLICE STAFF OF
THE OFFICE WITH EVERY WINDOW
OPENS WE PULL FROM THE OTHER
OFFICES.
PROVIDE A FULL SERVICE ON SAUDI
SERVICE AND SO WE HAVE TO
BALANCE GET ENOUGH EMPLOYEES TO
MAN IN OFFICE OF VERSES ABOUT WE
OPENED ALL THE OFFICE IS A EVERY
STUDY -- IT
BE MANDATORY OVERTIME FOR ALL
THE EMPLOYEES AND THAT WOULD
DEATHLY PUTTING ADDITIONAL
STRAIN ON THIS EMPLOYEES INTERNS
BE ABLE TO GET THEIR JOB DONE.
A EVERY DAY INCLUDE SORRY SO
THAT'S IT THERE'S A BALANCE
BETWEEN.
US YOU FOR OUR EMPLOYEES A WHOLE
LIFE IN IN BALANCING OUT WORKING
THERE OF PROVIDING SANTEE
SERVICE SURE I I UNDERSTAND THAT.
WE ALL HAVE CONSTITUENTS THAT --
IN ORDER TO BALANCE THEIR
HOMEWORK LIVES THEY THEY OFTEN
WORK YOU KNOW SIX DAYS A WEEK
SOMETIMES SEVEN DAYS A WEEK --
SO I THINK THAT'S GONNA FALL ON
DEAF EARS THE MILLIONS HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. SEVENTY
NINE TO BE SEVENTY NINE TENS BY
DOLLARS.
BUT ON ON OVERTIME SO IF YOU FOR
SATURDAY HOURS THAT YOU DIDN'T
COMPLETE YOU DIDN'T HAVE THOSE
OFFICES OPEN SO I'M I'M REALLY
TROUBLED TO HEAR THAT.
WE'VE SPENT MONEY FOR SATURDAY
OFFICE HOURS THAT WAS FOR
MANDATORY AND VOLUNTARY OVERTIME
AND YET THAT MONEY IS NOW GONE
BUT WE DIDN'T COMPLETE THE
MISSION OF HAVING SATURDAY
SERVICES AND WE ONLY HAD SAY.
OUT OF ONE SEVENTY TWO ROUGHLY --
YOU KNOW 3538% OF THE OFFICES
ARE EVEN OPEN AT THOSE TIMES AND
WE UP APPROPRIATE SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THIS
LEGISLATURE TO DO IT --
I'M I'M GONNA ASK TO MOVE THIS
AUDIT I'M AND I DO HAVE JUST
ANOTHER A QUICK QUICK QUESTION --
THE YOU KNOW.
YOU MENTIONED YESTERDAY THAT YOU
IN THE IN THE SHIFTED AND YET
TODAY'S WHILE THE SHIP TO TWO
HUNDRED FORTY EMPLOYEES AROUND
FROM HEADQUARTERS --
TO COMPLETE THESE YOU TO HELP
WITH THE DRIVER'S LICENSES I'M
ANNA AND REAL ID WHICH BY THE
WAY I'M ALL OUT OF STATE FOR THE
RECORD.
AS WELL --
WE'VE KNOWN ABOUT THIS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND THREE AND AND FRANKLY
MADAM YOU'VE BEEN YOUR POINTED
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY THIRTEEN SO
TWO THOUSAND THREE TWENTY
THIRTEEN ACTION IS JUST FIVE OF
THEM GOT A LITTLE BIT.
YET ABOUT EIGHT YEARS YOU'VE
BEEN IN THIS POSITION ALMOST
FIVE YEARS AND YET WE STILL NOT
PREPARED FOR IT --
THAT'S TROUBLING WHAT BACK TO
THE QUESTION WHAT WERE THE
EMPLOYEES THE TILTED FOR FORTY
EMPLOYEES YOU SHIFTED FROM
HEADQUARTERS.
INTO THE DISTRICT OFFICES DOING
PRIOR TO THAT MOVING IN TO HELP
WITH DRIVERS LICENSES.
BUT THEY'RE DOING OF SOMEONE WHO
ARE DOING A LITTLE WHO WORKS IN
THE WORKING ON PROJECTS AND SO
SUCH AS SUCH AS AYE NONSPECIFIC
NAM OF THE WORKING OUT.
THERE WORKING ON PROJECTS IN
TERMS OF SOME OF THE NEW
STRATEGIES THAT ONE AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO IMPLEMENT SUCH AS SUCH
AS LOOKING AT IF WE CAN AND DO
SOME OF THE TESTING.
AT HOME YOU WOULD DO IT --
TOO AT AT HOME THROUGH A
COMPUTER WE KNOW THAT TWO OTHER
STATES ARE ARE DOING THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THAT STRATEGY --
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT EMPLOYEES
THEY'RE DOING SOME PRODUCTION
WORK ACT AND HEADQUARTERS
TOUCHES ON WE DO A 100% REVIEW
OF OUR THE CAR EVERY CAR THAT IS
ISSUED WE DO A QUALITY REVIEW OF
EVERY CARD WHICH IF SOME OF
THOSE --
SOME EMPLOYEES ARE DOING SOME
KEY ENTERING REMOVING SOME OF
THOSE OVER OUT TO UP TO THE
FIELD. TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
EMPLOYEES.
THAT WERE DOING Q. SEE.
AND SOME KIND OF ANALYTICAL WORK
SO IT WAS SO WE ALSO HAVE SOME
THAT WERE --
IN OUR AND I DOING SOME CUSTOMER
SERVICE AND RESPONDING TO
CORRESPONDENCE FROM CUSTOMERS
REMOVE SOME OF THOSE EMPLOYEES
OUT.
AYE WE'VE MOVED --
SOME AND AB PEOPLE FROM MY
REGISTRATION OPERATIONS YOU THAT
DO SOME PRODUCTION WORK OF
RESPONDING TO VEHICLE
REGISTRATION PROCESS AS WE MOVE
THOSE EMPLOYEES OUT.
IT DONE AND OUT COVER ALL OUR
DIVISIONS OUT WE HAVE SOME OF
OUR INVESTIGATIVEOFFICE
ASSISTANCE A LEAVE OF THOSE THAT
THE ANSWER SOME OF THE PHONE
CALLS IN HEADQUARTERS IN MOOD
AND SOME OF THOSE OFFICE
ASSISTANTS A OUT.
TO ASSIST WITH THE NON
PRODUCTION WORK TO BRING THE
TRAIN PREDICTIONS BACK ON THE
WINDOWS TO PROCESS CUSTOMERS.
THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE A NEED.
AND THEN IDEA OF THE BALANCE
COULD RIGHT NOW IN YOUR IN YOUR
OFFICES ARE STATEWIDE.
BETWEEN THEROUTINE THAT IS THE
RE REGISTRATION OF VEHICLES
PEOPLE THAT THAT DON'T PAY TO
USE YOU KNOW --
SERVICE OR THAT ARE MEMBERS OF
AN AUTO CLUB THAT CAN DO IT
THERE --
THOSE ROUTINE SERVICES READ RE
REGISTERING YOUR CAR ETCETERA --
AND THE FACT THAT THE FOLKS THAT
ARE GETTING THEIR NEW REAL LIFE
HE'S.
WHAT KIND OF BALANCES THAT IS IT
FIFTY FIFTY IS IT 10% ARE
GETTING IDEAS IS THAT 90% WHAT
WILL COUNT NUMBER DO YOU HAVE
YOU HAVE IT TWO HUNDRED FORTY
PEOPLE THEY CRUNCHING NUMBERS?
PRIOR TO MOVING THEM ASSUME YOU
PROBABLY HAVE SOME SOME GREAT
DATA SO.
SO SO WHAT I DON'T HAVE THE
EXACT PERCENTAGE IT DEPENDS ON
THE OFFICE TO PAY AN HONOR EVERY
OFFICES YOU NEED LAST STATEWIDE
YEAH THAT'S IT SO STATEWIDE.
AND I I'M NOT SURE IF WE HAVE
THE EXACT VOLUME YOU WANNA KNOW
HOW MUCH IS A VEHICLE
REGISTRATION HOW MUCH TO DRIVE
SO SO.
ALRIGHT SO STATE WHY ON ANNUAL
BASIS HOW ME DRIVERS LICENSES
THAT WE PROCESS NO I I ASKED YOU
TO BE STAYS BETWEEN OFFICE RIGHT
NOW TODAY.
IF SOMEONE WALKS INTO THE
AVERAGE DAY IN THE OFFICE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT PERCENTAGE ARE THERE
[inaudible] FOR WE'VE HEARD
TESTIMONY RECENTLY AND THEN
ONLINE AND CONSTITUENTS CALLING
AND STOPPING ME ON THE STREET AS
SENATOR ROTH MENTION --
OF MULTIPLE MULTIPLE OUR
SOMETIMES AS LONG AS EIGHT HOURS
OF PEOPLE PASSING OUT IN THE IN
THE OPPOSITE SENATOR.
WHAT NUMBER DO YOU KNOW --
OF BUT EVEN IF IT'S SOMEONE
ANECDOTAL WHICH I MEAN I'M
SURPRISED AT THE YOU WOULDN'T
HAVE THE DATA.
THAT PEOPLE ARE WALKING INTO AN
OFFICE HALF FOR GOING THIS WAY
TO GET NEW REAL ID AND HALF FOR
GOING THIS WAY TO DO ROUTINE DMB
SERVICE SUCH AS RE REGISTER IN A
CAR WHAT'S WHAT'S ANOTHER TODAY
RIGHT NOW AND WE ARE SEEING
ABOUT 1019% OF THE CUSTOMERS.
AGAIN A REAL LIKE THE WE HAVE NO
NUMBERS ON THAT SEA OF NUMBERS
THAT 20% AND WHAT WAS IT BEFORE
TAKE PEOPLE GETTING A DRIVER'S
LICENSE PRIOR TO THIS.
BUT SO PRIOR TO THIS NUMBER SO
SO IN 19% IS CAUSING YOUR YOUR
YOUR CLAIM WAS YESTERDAY. 19%
WAS CAUSING [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
NOMINEE YOU SIX HOURS PRO IS AN
AVERAGE SIX HOUR DELAY IT THE
DMB.
WHAT WAS IT PRIOR TO THE 19%?
SO THE OFFICE PROFILE SO I IT
COULD BE WELL.
I'LL HAVE TO GET YOU EXACT
NUMBERS BUT FOR AN OFFICE JANE
ON SOME WE DON'T DO KNOW THAT
SOME OFFICERS ARE MORE HEAVY IN
SHERMAN DRIVERS LICENSES.
AND THAT COULD BE A SIXTY FORTY
SPLIT BUT STATE WHY IT COULD BE
SIXTY FOUR I I WOULD SAY.
THAT RIGHT NOW IT'S MOVED UP TO
SIXTY FORTY IN TERMS OF DRIVERS
LICENSES AND IN VEHICLE
REGISTRATION BECAUSE THE SHIP
HAS BEEN CROWNED RELY TEACHER.
SO A I AND I HAVE ONE ONE LAST
POINT IT WITH ADULTS THE CHAIR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD SOME
TROUBLING REPORTS THAT THERE IS
AN ORGANIZATION OR COMPANY
CALLED YOU GOV.
THAT'S BEEN SNAPPING UP
APPOINTMENTS --
SUCKING THEM OUT OF THE SYSTEM --
AND SELLING THEM TO PEOPLE AND
SO ONLY PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE
MONEY TO BE ABLE TO RE PURCHASE
THESE STE TIME SLOTS ARE ABLE TO
DO THAT --
SO OBVIOUSLY THERE'S SOME FLAWS
THERE I'M I I WAS SHOCKED TO
HEAR THIS AND I'M SURE THE
CONSTITUENCIES AND AND THE MEDIA
ARE GOING TO BE A LITTLE
SURPRISED IF THEY DON'T ALREADY
KNOW THIS --
WHAT IS THE DMV DOWN TO CLOSE
THIS THIS EGREGIOUS LOOPHOLE
THAT IS CAUSING OUR CONSTITUENTS
AND NOT BE ABLE TO GET THEIR
APPOINTMENTS OUT THAT THEY
DESERVE?
ONLINE SO WE EVOLVE.
INTO THAT COMPANY YOGA A WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE NOT
SCREEN SCRAPING IT OFF OUR PLATE
WITH SYSTEM AND ACTUALLY
GRABBING THOSE APPOINTMENTS AND
THEN RESELLING THEM.
SO WE DID SOME FOR EXCELLENT
FORENSIC ANALYSIS OF THAT TO IN
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE JUST
GRABBED THE POINT WASN'T
AVAILABLE FREE TO CUSTOMERS.
AND SO THEY HAVE AND THEY ARE
NOT DOING THAT WE AND HAD A
DELIBERATE DIFFICULTY CONTACTED
ORDER TO INTERVIEW THAT THE
OWNER HE WOULD NOT SHOW UP --
FOR AND MAKE CONTACT WITH US AND
WE WE DID FIND THAT AND WE ALSO
WANT TO GO IN AND REVIEW IS
OPERATIONS TO SEE HOW HE'S DOING
THAT TO FIND OUT.
AND DONE HE HAS NOT --
FALL THAT WITH THIS ALLOWS INTO
TO SEE ITS OPERATIONS --
I I I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR THAT
WOULD LIKE TO FOR THAT YOU STOP
ALL SCRAPING OF ANY THIRD PARTY
BEING ABLE TO ACCESS WE DID
THERE WAS ANOTHER COMPANY CALLED
US MAIL DOT COM THAT WAS DOING
THAT THEY'RE DOING IT SO YOU
HAVE STOPPED.
WE HAVE STOPPED OTHER COMPANIES
THAT ARE EMBRACING OKAY OKAY.
YOU KNOW THIS IS THE REASON I
CAME TO SACRAMENTO IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR TAXPAYERS AND
THEIR DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT
APPROPRIATELY AND THAT'S WHY
I'VE.
I'VE I'VE MOVED THE AUDIT I
THINK IT'S UNNECESSARY I'M.
FUNCTION OF GOVERNMENT AND TO
PUT SOME OF THE STUFF OUT IN
DAYLIGHT APPRECIATE YOU COMING
HERE AND WHAT'S CHALLENGING --
THE IN A WORK ON A WORKING IN
GOVERNMENT AND LIMITED RESOURCES
BUT WE HAVE APPROPRIATED
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF MONEY YOU
ASK FOR MORE MONEY THAT WE'VE
BEEN APPROPRIATED.
OUT FOR THESE PURPOSES --
AND I'D JUST LIKE TO SEE THAT
TAXPAYERS MONIES ARE BEING WHITE
WISELY SPENT IN THAT THEIR
VALUABLE TIME THEY'RE NOT TAKING
VACATION TIME AND TIME JUST TO
GET THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSE.
IT SHOULD BE A ROUTINE FUNCTION
OF GOVERNMENT SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED THANK YOU
MISTER.
MR ACOSTA --
NEXT IS MS RUBIO BEFORE WE GO
ANY FURTHER I WANTED TO SAY I
HAVE ON MY LIST SENATOR LARA.
MS BAKER SENATOR ALLEN SAID.
AND IT IS ALSO TEN FORTY WE HAVE --
ó WE WE WE HAVE WE THIS IS OUR
SECOND ITEM WE HAVE SIX MORE
ITEMS TO GO.
WITH THAT MISS RUBIO.
THANK YOU I KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THE TECHNICALITIES
AND MONEY AND ALL THAT FOR ME.
GIVES ME --
THIS IS A CULTURAL --
I DON'T KNOW HOW WE CAN --
I DID A CULTURAL.
I SEE IT IS A LET ME BACK UP
WE'VE OFTEN JOKED ó IT'S THE
DMT -- WE'VE
BEEN CONDITIONED OVER THE YEARS
TO ACCEPT THAT THE DMV IS.
LYING THE FOR THE HOURS BUT I
THINK ALSO THE EMPLOYEES HAVE
BEEN CONDITION THAT IT'S OKAY.
TO JUST KIND OF GET UP IN THE
MIDDLE OF A TRANSACTION AND GO
GET COFFEE IT'S HAPPENED TO ME.
AND SO IS THERE A TRAINING.
OR ANYTHING THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
DO FOR THE EMPLOYEES BECAUSE I
THINK WE ALL CAN AGREE THAT IT
IS A CULTURE IT'S A DMB CULTURE
I JUST WAS JOKING A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO.
ABOUT THE DMV AND THE WHEN THIS
CAME UP I WENT OH I'M PART OF
THAT CULTURE AS WELL.
ARE WE GONNA HAVE ANY KIND OF
TRAINING OR ANY KIND OF I DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT WE COULD DO TO
CHANGE THE CULTURE.
A OF THE EMPLOYEES IN THE DAY
THERE'S MANY THAT DON'T.
YOU NO SLACK OFF AND AND JUST GO
GET COFFEE WHEN PEOPLE IN FRONT
OF THEM HOWEVER THE OVERALL
CLERK CULTURE AT LEAST IN MY
PERCEPTION IS THAT.
WHAT'S JUST THE DMV AND PEOPLE
ARE JUST GOING TO ACCEPT THAT SO
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME KIND OF
PEOPLE KIND OF TRAINING SO THAT
WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT THAT
CULTURE IS IS IS GONE --
THE OTHER THING IS I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE CAPABLE OF OF PROCESSING
THESE THINGS QUICKLY I JUST GOT
MY DRIVER'S LICENSE.
ACTUALLY TWO WEEKS AGO AND I DID
AN ONLINE AND WITHIN THE WEEK I
HAVE MY DRIVER'S LICENSE WHICH I
WAS REALLY IMPRESSED SO IF YOU
HAVE THAT.
ABILITY ONLINE WHY DON'T WE HAVE
THE ABILITY WHEN FOLKS ARE --
THERE IN PERSON AND SO THE ONE
REQUEST I GUESS WOULD BE IS WHAT
CAN CAN YOU LOOK AND INTO KIND
OF THE CULTURE MAY BE THE THE
AYE AYE THAT SOME OF THE OUR
SURVEY SOME OF THE EMPLOYEES AS
FAR AS A CULTURE I THINK THE
GENTLEMAN THAT TESTIFIED.
EARLIER SAID THAT THAT'S PART OF
THE PROBLEM AS WELL IT'S NOT
JUST THE SYSTEMS OR THE OUTDATED
EQUIPMENT IT'S THE CULTURE OF
THE DMV.
AND WE NEED TO FIX THAT AS WELL
BECAUSE WE CAN INVEST ALL THE
MONEY WE CAN.
INTO THE DMB BUT IF THE CULTURE
THE THEY WERE JUST GOING TO BE
WAITING IN LINE AGAIN BECAUSE
IT'S JUST KIND OF IT'S ACCEPTED
THAT IT'S THE DMT.
I GUESS IN SO WE WE ALREADY HAVE
STARTED A CUSTOMER SERVICE
TRAINING WE HAVE VOTE OUT
DIFFERENT OF FOUR CATEGORIES.
OF ITS UP FOR RESOLVE INITIATIVE
AND AND WELCOME IN SO WE CAN
RESOLVE THE PROBLEM SO WE HAVE
ALREADY STARTED THAT TRAINING --
THERE MAY BE SOME EMPLOYEES ACT
OUT WE HAVE TO DO REFRESHER
TRAINING GO BACK WE DO THAT ON
WEDNESDAY MORNING WE DO
WEDNESDAY MORNING TRAINING.
WILL TAKE THAT BACK AND WE WILL
MAKE SURE THAT THAT OUR
EMPLOYEES UNDERSTAND.
OF WHAT THE CULTURE IS IS TO
SERVE THE CUSTOMERS WITH WITH
THE RESPECT AND THAT WE WILL GO
BACK AND WE WILL DO MORE
REFRESHER TRAINING AND CONTINUE --
TO BUT WORK ON THAT THAT I I DO
AGREE THAT IS NOT ACCEPTABLE
THAT WE HAVE ALREADY STARTED
BECAUSE MR RESTRAINT REGARDING
THAT BUT HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
TRACK THAT AFTER THE TRAINING IS
DONE HOW ARE YOU GOING TO TRY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE FOLKS ARE
ACTUALLY.
ME BECAUSE TRUST ME WE'VE ALL
BEEN TO TRAININGS AND WE ARE
THERE BECAUSE WE HAVE TO BE AND
SO HOW DO YOU FOLLOW UP AND AND
MAKE SURE THAT THE THE THE
TRAINING THAT YOU GAVE THEM HAS
WORKED.
SO THIS IS WHERE WE WILL WORK
WITH OFFICE MANAGERS IN THE
OFFICE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
TRAINING IS CONDUCTED.
WILL DO SOME SPOT WE WILL DO
WHAT WE MAY CALL SECRET SHOPPER
TRAINEE OUT DOES VISITS TO MAKE
SURE AND SEE.
THAT HOUSE THE CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE WE WHEN I GO AND
VISIT THE OFFICES I DON'T
ANNOUNCE ON COMEY WE KINDA HANG
I CAN HANG BACKING UP WHAT'S
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE OFFICE
IN OBSERVE.
AND I WHEN WE I DO HERE AND WE
DO HEAR CUSTOMER COMPLAINTS THAT
WE DO GET WE DO GET THOSE WE
ADDRESS THOSE IMMEDIATELY WE
REACH OUT TO THE CUSTOMER AND
THEN WE REACH OUT.
AND TALK TO THE OFFICE MANAGER
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS AT SOME
OF THE BEHAVIOR OF THE OF OUR
EMPLOYEES IN THE OFFICE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHESS
SENATOR LAURA STEPPED OUT AND SO --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST
I HAVE.
BOTH QUESTIONS FOR AGENCY
DIRECTOR AS WELL AS THE AUDITOR.
AND ALSO A SECOND THE AUDIT
MOTION I PROCEED --
THIS BEING BROUGHT FORWARD VERY
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THIS --
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO'S.
POINT ABOUT CULTURE.
AND WHAT TRAINING ARE YOU DOING
I THINK THERE'S AN UNDERLYING
CURRENT HERE AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT THE AUDIT COVERS IT.
AND THAT IS WHAT IS THE
ACCOUNTABILITY. FOR WHEN THERE
IS A PERFORMANCE.
AND I HEAR A LOT OF TERMS THAT
SOUND GOOD WHICH IS WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE --
RESOLVE TRAINING THAT RESOLVE
THIS IS VERY GOOD BUT THEN.
VERY RECENTLY LAST MONTH WE GOT
AN AUDIT.
ABOUT AN EMPLOYEE SLEEPING ON
THE JOB FOR YEARS.
AND NO ACCOUNTABILITY.
SO ALL THE TRAINING IN THE WORLD
FOR THE CULTURE MAY BE HELPFUL
BUT IF THERE'S NO ACCOUNTABILITY.
IT MEANS NOTHING AND THAT'S THE
CASE FOR ANY INSTITUTION SO.
I AS WAS TO MAKE A COMMENT
BECAUSE I HAPPEN TO HAVE THE
REPORT IN FRONT OF ME AND MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE HAS MADE A VERY
GOOD POINT THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT CANNOT BE AUDITED
HERE I DON'T GETS COVERED BY THE
AUDIT BUT IT IS.
THE CULTURE AND ACCOUNTABILITY --
TO THAT POINT I WOULD LIKE TO
ALSO FULL OF MISTER ROSS
QUESTION WHICH I DON'T BELIEVE
YOU ANSWERED HE ANSWERED YOU
HAVE.
A VERY DIRECT QUESTION.
AND THAT WAS WHAT IS THE AVERAGE
WAIT TIME.
FROM WHEN SOMEBODY GETS THE
NOTIFICATION IN THE MAIL AND I
BY THE WAY.
THE DAVEY NEVER SENT ME MINE BUT
THAT GOES TO THE AIR QUESTION
WHEN YOU NEED TO RENEW YOUR
LICENSE WHEN YOU GET A
NOTIFICATION THE MAIL.
AND WHEN YOU CAN GET AN
APPOINTMENT.
HE ASKED YOU THAT QUESTION
DIRECTLY AND THE ANSWER YOU GAVE
WAS WERE WORKING ON THIS WE HAVE
THAT NEED TO DO YOU KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION IT
DOESN'T MATCH UP.
SO WE HAVE APARTMENTS AVAILABLE
NINETY DAYS OUT.
AND WE'RE WE MAIL OUT TO RENO
KNOWS IS --
IT TODAY IT DOESN'T MATCH UP WE
GET SIXTY DAYS IN ADVANCE
APPOINTMENTS ARE AVAILABLE
NINETIES AND IF THAT'S I CANNOT
IT DOESN'T MATCH UP.
HOW WE NEED TO MAKE MORE
APPOINTMENTS AVAILABLE TO MATCH
UP WITH WHEN YOU GET TO NOTICE
AND -- THOSE
WILL START GOING OUT INTO THE
MONTH I KNOWLEDGE THAT WHAT I
THINK I'M HEARING IS YOU DON'T
KNOW THE ANSWER TO THE QUESTION
WHICH IS WHAT THE AVERAGE WAIT
TIME AS WELL AND I UNDERSTAND
THEY DON'T MATCH UP.
THAT'S WHY OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE
IN LINE WHEN THEY CAN'T GET AN
APPOINTMENT BECAUSE THE ONLY
APPOINTMENTS AVAILABLE ARE AFTER
THE EXPIRATION.
THAT TO ME UNDERSCORES ANOTHER
REASON WHY WE DESPERATELY NEED
THIS AUDIT AND I HOPE IT WILL
GET.
LAST SUPPORT FOR THE COMMITTEE
BECAUSE IF IF IT THE DIRECTOR
LEVEL WE DON'T HAVE ANSWERS TO
THOSE TYPE OF QUESTIONS.
WE NEED THE ON SO YOU'RE TALK IT
SO IF I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY --
THE PLATE WITH BILLY ABILITY BY
OFFICE IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO
GET AN APPOINTMENT SO'S YOUR ST
ACT OUT WE DID LOOK AT THE
WEBSITE.
AND TERMS THAT WE DO WE DO LOOK
AT THE POINT AVAILABILITY --
IT IS --
SOME OFFICES YOU MAY BE ABLE TO
GET WIND OF THE COUPLE WEEKS
SOME IT MAY IT IS OUT TO EIGHT
WEEKS AND SOMEONE IS OUT TO NINE
TO TWELVE WEEKS IT DOESN'T MATCH
UP WITH BEING WHETHER WE NOTICES
GO OUT. TO BE ABLE TO GET AN
APPOINTMENT THAT CARRIES.
SO I RIGHT NOW YOU KNOW IT'S IT
IS DIFFICULT TO GET A POINT
WITHIN TEN DAYS AND SO WE HAVE
FIVE MINUTES IMPOSSIBLE IT IS.
THE IT KIT AND SOMEONE PENCILS
YOU CAN WRITE HE'LL GET AN
APPOINTMENT SO WE WE NEED TO
WORK.
AND A STRATEGY TO MAKE MORE
APPOINTMENTS AVAILABLE TO TO
MATCH UP AND I YOU KNOW WE LOOK
AT THE WEBSITE YOU CAN LOOK AT
IT TODAY RIGHT NOW AND
APPOINTMENTS WHEAT I DID LOOK AT
IT --
THEY'RE GOING OUT INTO SEPTEMBER
OCTOBER NOVEMBER DEPENDING ON
THE OFFICE CONSOLE DEPARTMENT
BILL OF THE AND RIGHT NOW IS NOT
MEETING OUR DEMAND.
THANK YOU --
IN NOW YOU WERE VERY KIND
YESTERDAY TO TO ACCEPT --
AND I I GAVE YOU IT AT THE TIME
I GET A HUNDRED FIFTY THREE IT'S
A SAMPLE OF THE CONSTITUENTS
THAT HAVE CONTACTED ME.
AND JUST SAID I HAVE HAD THIS
PROBLEM WITH EXPERIENCES CAN YOU
TELL ME WHAT YOUR AND IT WAS
KIND OF TOUGH. TO TO BE HOURS TO
GO THROUGH THIS MANY THANK YOU
AYE MAGIC TAKE THAT LAST NIGHT
ON THE EVE OF THE HEARING SO I
APPRECIATE THAT WHATEVER YOU'RE
ABLE TO GET THROUGH.
WHAT WERE YOUR TAKEAWAYS WHAT
DID YOU LEARN FROM THAT?
DON'T YOU FEEL MAY BE THE AUDIT
CAN HELP YOU ADDRESS AS PROBLEMS
OR NOT.
SO I READ THROUGH ALL OF THESE
LAST NIGHT AND DEFTLY WE DEEM
NEED TO WORK ON OFFICES IN TERMS
OF THE OFFICE MANAGER BEING
RESPONSIVE FOR THE OFFICE A LOT
OF WHAT WE DID.
AND THERE WASN'T NOT PROPER
SIGNAGE THAT WAS ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH INFORMATION TO GO TO THE
RIGHT LINE STAND THE PLACEMENT
NOT EQUIPMENT LINE.
AND TRIAGE WAS NOT BEING DONE
PROPERLY IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE
THEN PUT ON IT BECAUSE WE HAVE
THE RIGHT DOCUMENTS --
THEY NEED TO RETURN AYE WE DO WE
THAT PROBABLY WAS NOT ENOUGH
THAT.
COMMENTS WERE MADE WHERE WE HAVE
TO EXPEDITE WINDOW TODAY IT WE
DID REMOVE THE HEART STOP ON
GETTING TAKING HER NAUSEOUS AT
FOUR THIRTY WE ALSO AND PRIVACY.
NOT BE ABLE TO TAKE YOUR ONLINE
UGLY TO ALL APPLICATION THAT WAS
ONE COMMENT THAT WENT INTO
EFFECT ON JULY SIXTEENTH --
WE ARE PUT IMPLEMENTED TEXT
MESSAGING OF IF YOU ARE IN THE
OFFICE AND YOU HAVE YOUR Q.
TICKET EYES TERRIFIC AT THAT IS
BEING IMPLEMENTED THE NEXT
COUPLE OF WEEKS.
AND SO THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS
THAT THAT WE NEED TO REALLY WORK
WITH EACH OFFICE EACH OFFICE IS
DIFFERENT.
AND WE WILL WORK WITH EACH
OFFICE ADDRESS OF THE CONCERNS
WE HAVE TO DO AN OVERALL LOOK AT
EVERY OFFICE TO ENSURE THEY'RE
DOING THE BEST PRACTICES THEY'RE
SERVING THE CUSTOMERS --
WITH SOME OF THESE WORDS THE
CUSTOMERS --
DID NOT WE SEE WHAT THEY ASK FOR
OF THOSE EARLY BEING BILLS
BECAUSE WE SHOULD BE I'VE BEEN
CONTACTED THIS MORNING ARI
PASSED THAT OUT IN Q. OUR
LOOKING AT THAT ONE CUSTOMER
REQUESTED A REFUND WILL FOLLOW
UP WITH THAT AND GET WHEN THEY
GOT PAID BOTH ONLINE.
AND BY CHECKING THE DAY OF THE
TO THE NINETY BOTH PARENTS GOT
IT WILL GET THAT CUSTOMER REFUND
SO -- WHEN I
GET BACK TO THE OFFICE I WILL
HAVE INFORMATION BACK AND HOW WE
RESPONDED TO EACH OF THESE
CUSTOMERS THAT THAT THAT SENT
YOU INFORMATION VERY VERY GREAT
LOOK AT ALL OF THESE?
AND I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT FOR
COLLEAGUES THERE ACTUALLY. SEVEN
HOURS SOMETIMES THREE HOURS TO
GET NUMBER THAN ONE HOUR TO GET
INTO THE ROOM AND OTHERWISE THEY
THEY HAD A POT [inaudible]
PARENTS --
IN I APPRECIATE YOU LOOKED AT
THAT WHAT WHAT I TOOK AWAY.
AND AGAIN I THINK IT UNDERSCORES
THE NEED FOR THIS AUDIT IS THAT
THE THE STATEMENTS THAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM THE DEPARTMENT ON
WAIT TIMES BEAR NO.
RESEMBLANCE TO WHAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE EXPERIENCING
AND REALITY I'VE USED I'M SURE
YOU READ THAT COMMENTARY ABOUT
HOW I'M STANDING IN LINE FOR THE
FIFTH OUR AND I LOOK ON THE
WEBSITE IT SAYS THE WAIT TIME IN
THIS PLACE IS FORTY FIVE MINUTES.
AND THAT THAT WHERE YOU ARE
DEPLOYING RESOURCES.
ADDITIONAL STAFF IS BASED ON
WAIT TIMES I'M VERY GLAD THAT
THE AUTHORS WROTE THIS SO THAT
WHEN THE WEIGHT AND WHAT THE
WAIT TIME MEASURES BECAUSE
THAT'S GONNA TELL US WHERE WHERE
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO DEPLOY
THEM.
SO APPRECIATE THAT QUICK
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUDITOR --
THERE IS NEW TECHNOLOGY THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS RECENTLY SAID
THEY'RE GOING TO DO THIS --
TEXTING TO LET YOU KNOW WHAT
YOUR NUMBER IS SIMILAR TO WHEN
YOU GO TO THE GENIUS BAR APPLE
OR SOMEWHERE ELSE SO THAT IF YOU
HAVE TO WAIT FOR A WHILE YOU
DON'T HAVE TO STAND THERE.
YOU CAN GO GET FOOD HAVE LOCKER
AND EVEN MAYBE WAIT YOUR CAR
RIVER IT IS --
WILL THIS AUDIT IN THE WAY THAT
YOU'RE READING A GIVE YOU
SUFFICIENT ABILITY TO SEE HOW
THE VERY RECENT TECHNOLOGY
CHANGES THAT.
LITERALLY JUST COME OUT SINCE
THE AUDIT WITH AUTHORED HAVE HOW
EFFECTIVE THEY ARE BEING.
A AND AND DOES IT GIVE YOU THE
FLEXIBILITY TO DO THAT YES
THERE'S A AN OBJECTIVE THAT
TALKS ABOUT WHAT STEPS DMB HAS
TAKEN TO REDUCE WAIT TIMES --
AND ALSO ASKING US TO ASSESS
WHETHER OR NOT THAT REALLY HAS
HAD A POSITIVE IMPACT ON WAIT
TIMES HELP YOU.
VERY MEDI ANSWERED YES IT AND
ONE OF THE AREAS THAT IS
IMPORTANT AND THAT WE ARE A
LITTLE BIT OF ALLUSION TO IT IS
AND THE COMMENT YOU HEARD US
FOLKS BE WAITING IN LINE.
AND SOMEONE JUST CLOSES THE
WINDOW AND SOMETIME AROUND NOON
EVERYBODY STOPS EVERYTHING STOPS
THE WIND STOPS. EIGHT YOUR HARD
WORKERS HAVE TO TAKE A BREAK --
THEY HAVE BREAKS READ THE DATES
HEALTHY IT'S GOOD BUT I WANT TO
KNOW IF THE AUDIT A GIVES YOU
THE FLEXIBILITY TO LOOK AT HOW
STAFF FOR BEING USED ON THE
FLOOR.
IN THOSE OFFICES REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER NOT TO HE OR OTHERWISE
TO BE ABLE TO DETERMINE WHY IS
IT THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT HAPPENS OR WHEN
FIVE O'CLOCK COMES AROUND THAT
HAVE HAVE FIRST HALF HOUR BEFORE
THE CLOSE SUDDENLY EVERYTHING
SPEEDS UP AND WERE ABLE TO GET
FOLKS OUT THE DOOR FOR HER
TESTIMONY.
DOES NOT PROVIDE YOU WITH THAT
ABILITY TO DO YOU NEED
ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE ON THAT.
NO I DON'T THINK WE NEED
ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE ON THAT I
THINK THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING WE
WOULD ABSOLUTELY WANT TO LOOK
FOR AND AMEND IT AND THAT WOULD
BE WOVEN THROUGH A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT OBJECTIVES MS BAKER
BECAUSE WE WOULD BE LOOKING AT
THEIR PLANTS.
AND THAT WOULD BE RELATED TO HOW
ARE YOU GOING TO MANAGE YOUR
VARIOUS OFFICES HOW DID YOU
DETERMINE WHICH OFFICES FOR
SATURDAY HOURS HOW YOU
DETERMINING HOURS DURING THE DAY
HOW MANY STAFF ARE YOU GOING TO
HAVE FOR A VARIETY OF FUNCTIONS
THAT SO YES THAT WOULD BE.
WOVEN THROUGHOUT MULTIPLE
OBJECTIVES THANK YOU IT AND AT
THE END IN ADDITION GOES TO THE
ISSUE I WANNA MAKE SURE THE AYE
COVERS THIS BECAUSE WE WANT TO
GET THIS RIGHT [inaudible]
WHOM THAT.
SOMETIMES FOLKS WAIT AS THEIR
MANY COMMENTERS HERMAN IS IT
SOMETIMES A WAIT FOR HOURS FOR
IT LIKE SIX MINUTES OF SERVICE.
SO WE TOOK A SCREENSHOT SAID IT
TOOK ME SEVEN MINUTES ONCE I GOT
UP THERE TO GET TAKE CARE OF I
HAD TO WAIT SEVEN HOURS.
IN OTHER INSTANCES --
SOMEONE WAITS FOR SEVEN HOURS
AND HAVE A VERY LONG PROCESS BUT
THAT'S LESS WAIT TIME THAT'S
MORE WHAT SERVICES BEING
PROVIDED TO YOU THAT PERHAPS
COULD HAVE BEEN PROVIDED A
DIFFERENT WAY.
AND AND THAT IS UP MORE THAT CAN
BE DONE ONLINE AND DOESN'T
REQUIRE YOU TO COME TO THE DMV
AND EVEN MORE THAT CAN BE.
ALLOWED IN THE WORLD OF OF THE
MOTOR CLUBS AND OTHERWISE I
DON'T PERSONALLY HAVE TO THINK
SHOULD HAVE TO BECOME A MOTOR
CLUB MEMBER IN ORDER TO GET SOME
OF THESE OTHER APPOINTMENTS
WE'VE HAD A CONVERSATION ABOUT A
SEPARATE HEARING.
BUT WHAT DOES THE OUGHT TO GIVE
YOU THE ABILITY TO LOOK AT WHAT
CAN BE CHANGED AND EVEN MOVED
OUTSIDE OF THE DMV OFFICE
WHETHER IT'S MORE ONLINE
TRANSACTIONS.
OR WHAT MIGHT BE A GOOD.
CANDIDATE FOR ALLOWING AT A
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP WITH SIMILAR
TO HOW THE POST OFFICE WHICH
ALSO SERVES A VERY CRITICAL
FUNCTION [inaudible]
HAS A POSTAL ANNEXES THERE OFTEN
SMALL FAMILY BUSINESSES WHERE I
DON'T HAVE TO GO THE POST OFFICE
OF I WANT TO SHIP A PACKAGE YOU
DO THINGS.
DOES THE I GIVE YOU THE ABILITY
TO DO THAT.
AGAIN I THINK THAT WOULD BE
WOVEN THROUGH VARIETY OF
OBJECTIVES BECAUSE IT'S AGAINST
LOOKING AT WHAT IS D. M. V.
DOING.
TO ANTICIPATE REAL ID BUT ALSO
MANAGE ITS OVERALL FUNCTIONS IT
WHETHER IT'S REGISTRATION AND
AND INCLUDED IN THOSE PLANS DID
THEY DETERMINE OKAY THESE ARE
THE TYPES OF FUNCTIONS THAT WE
CAN SHIFT AS YOU SUGGEST THAT TO
AN ANNEX OR WE COULD MAKE THAT
AN ONLINE FUNCTION.
PARTICULARLY SINCE REAL ID THE
REQUIREMENT IS YOU HAVE TO COME
INTO A DMV OFFICE SO WE KNOW
WE'RE GONNA HAVE FOLKS COMING IN
THE DMP.
ARE THERE OTHER FUNCTIONS THAT
WE COULD CONVERT TO JUST AN
ONLINE SITUATION OR HAVE THE
SATELLITE.
ANNEXES OR WHATEVER TO SO OKAY
THE A SHORT ANSWER IS I THINK IT
WOULD BE WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THAT THE DISCUSSION TODAY WE
WOULD WE THAT IN A VARIETY OF
OBJECTIVES AND I HOMES OUT THANK
YOU BECAUSE I THINK YOU'D BE
VERY VALUABLE IF YOU'RE GONNA BE
IN THE WEEDS.
ON ON HOW THEY'RE OPERATING
PARTICULAR WITH WILL WHAT ARE
GOOD CANDIDATES. TO TO ALLOW FOR
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS --
NOT LIMITED TO MOTOR CLUBS BUT
EVEN BEYOND BECAUSE WE'VE DONE
THAT IN AREAS WHERE WE HAVE VERY
CRITICAL TRANSACTIONS LIKE
POSTAL SERVICE WORK THAT NOW IS
IS PROVIDED IN OTHER WAYS --
I ALSO WERE AND I'M I'M DOING
THIS BECAUSE I REALLY WANNA MAKE
SURE GET IT RIGHT AGAIN.
YOU KNOW THE REGISTRAR OF VOTERS
EVERY ELECTION CYCLE THEY HAVE
TO RAMP UP WITH A LOT OF
TEMPORARY WORKERS TO PROCESS
BILL BY MAIL BALLOTS.
AND I I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S A
PRACTICE THE DMV HAS HAD IN THE
PAST [inaudible]
BUT I HOPE THAT THIS WILL ALSO
GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK
AT WHAT WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN.
UTILIZED TEMPORARY SOLUTIONS --
MOST BUSINESSES HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THAT WHEN THEY HAVE AND IF
THEY DON'T GO TO BUSINESS --
BUT IF THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY DO
THAT -- I
I'D REALLY LIKE TO SEE THIS
AUDIT INCLUDE THE ABILITY.
TO HOW WELL AND IF THE DMV IS
APPROPRIATELY RAMPING UP AND
THEN.
CAME BACK WHAT WHAT I DON'T SEE
HAPPEN IS A BUDGET THAT WE GIVE
YOU FOR ONE THING YOU END UP
SPENDING ON SOMETHING ELSE SO.
THAT WAS A BIT OF A SHOCKING
POINT HERE --
WILL YOU ALSO SPEAK I OR HER
ALIVE DISCUSSION AT SPEAKING TO
MANAGEMENT.
YESTERDAY AND THE HEARING ONE
CRITICAL PUBLIC COMMENT WE HAD
AND THEN PER INDIVIDUAL HAD TO
WAIT FOR A COUPLE HOURS IN THE
IRONY WAS NOT LOST ON ANY OF US
TO COMMENT ON THIS WAS.
A FORMER EMPLOYEE OF THE DMV AND
WHO SAID PLEASE SPEAK TO THE
EMPLOYEES DON'T JUST VISIT WITH
MANAGEMENT.
AT THESE LOCATIONS EITHER IN
SACRAMENTO ARE GOING TO THE
OFFICES AND YOU MENTIONED YOU
WOULD BE TALKING TO SUPERVISORS.
CAN YOU PLEASE BE SURE TO
INCLUDE IN YOUR WORK.
TALKING TO EMPLOYEES LONGTIME
SHORT TIME WHISTLEBLOWERS NON
WHISTLEBLOWERS AND WE THINK IT
IS I JUST DIDN'T HEAR THAT WORD
AND AND THAT IN THE PROCESS THAT
WAS GOING.
GOING TO HAPPEN AND FINALLY --
THE ABILITY.
TO DETERMINE WHAT ELSE OTHER
THAN REAL ID IS THE CAUSE OF
PROBLEMS AT THE DMV A LOT OF
WHAT WE WE HEARD A LITTLE BIT OF
IT MENTIONED AIR IN THE
DOCUMENTS THAT YOU'RE GETTING
THE DMV CAUSING.
THE HARM.
BUT THERE'S LEVEL OF SERVICE.
THAT IS NOT THE WAIT TIMES IS
NOT THE ONLY ISSUE OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE HAVING A
PROBLEM WITH IT'S THE LEVEL OF
SERVICE.
AT THE DMV I DON'T SEE THAT IN
THE SCOPE OF THE AUDIT AS IT'S
CURRENTLY WRITTEN.
WHAT DO YOU ANTICIPATE YOU WOULD
NEED EITHER GUIDANCE ON OR?
BE ABLE TO COVER WHEN IT COMES
TO IMPROVEMENTS IN THE LEVEL OF
SERVICE TO SOME US GOES TO AGAIN.
BRING A BACKGROUND FULL CIRCLE
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO IS GOOD
POINT ABOUT CULTURE.
WELL I THINK A COUPLE OF THINGS
FIRST OF ALL.
WITH RESPECT TO CULTURE AND AND
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT RAMPING UP
AND WE WE DO HAVE AN OBJECTIVE
THE MEMBERS ASKED US TO LOOK AT
YOU KNOW.
THE STATUS OF HIRING AND ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS AS I WAS SITTING
LISTENING TO THEIR TO
DISCUSSIONS AS WAS THERE A PLAN
TO HIRE LIMITED TERM BECAUSE
REAL ID IS GOING TO BE JUST THIS
INFLUX EVERY SINGLE.
LICENSE HOLDER IN CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO GET A REAL ID AND THEY
HAVE TO GOING TO A DMV OFFICE.
THERE'S GONNA BE A FLOOD OF
INDIVIDUALS WAS THEIR
ANTICIPATION AND THEY'RE
PLANNING [inaudible] TO HIRE.
PEOPLE ON A LIMITED TERM BASIS --
VERY SMALL EXAMPLE OF THAT IS UP
TO US WITH REDISTRICTING WE KNEW
WE WOULD BE.
SLAMMED WITH A LOT OF WORK A FEW
YEARS AGO WE HIRED SOME LIMITED
TERM FOLKS IN THAT AND THEY KNEW
I'M GONNA BE WORKING FOR THE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE FOR A YEAR AND
THEN I'M DONE.
SO THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING WE
WOULD BE LOOKING --
FOR THERE IS AN OBJECTIVE THAT
ASKS US TO LOOK AT THINGS BEYOND
REAL ID.
ARE AS FAR AS DETERMINING
WHETHER THERE ARE ANY OTHER
FACTORS THAT REALLY AFFECTED
DMV'S ABILITY TO PROVIDE SERVICE
TO PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WHETHER OR NOT DMV HAS
ADEQUATE PLANS TO ADDRESS THOUGH
SO I THINK THAT MIGHT TOUCH ON
WHAT YOU'RE ASKING OF HAVE AND
THEN THE LAST IS ABOUT LOOKING
AT TRAINING --
AND HEARING THAT THEY HAVE
TRAINED WE MIGHT WANT OBSERVE
THE TRAINING WE MIGHT WANT TO
SEE OKAY WHAT IS D. M. V. DITCH
DOING TO DETERMINE WE'VE BEEN
PROVIDING ALL OF THIS TRAINING
HAS RESULTED IN IMPROVED SERVICE --
AND WHAT KINDS OF THINGS OR ARE
THEY DOING TO DETERMINE THAT AND
DO THEY NEED MAKE TO MAKE
MODIFICATIONS TO THE TRAINING OR
DO THEY NEED --
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
MANAGERS TO MAKE SURE MANAGERS
ARE.
ARE MAKING IT CLEAR TO STAFF
WHAT THE EXPECTATIONS ARE SO
AGAIN IT'S KIND OF A SIMILAR
ANSWER TO YOUR OTHER QUESTIONS.
THERE ARE VARIETY OF JEFF CAN
INJECTED HERE THAT HAVE A LOT OF
THAT WOVEN IN OF THE MEMBERS
ASKED A LOT OF DIFFERENT
QUESTIONS AND WE'RE TRYING TO
WEAVE THAT INTO EACH OBJECTIVE
AYE I THINK YOU FOR THAT I
REALLY THINK THE AUTHORS. FOR
FOR TRYING TO HAVING A FOCUSED
ON IT BUT ONE THAT ALLOWS US TO
GIVE THE AUDITOR THE FLEXIBILITY
TO DO THAT.
AND IN PARTICULAR IN THIS LAST
WHAT CONSEQUENCES COME WITH
FAILURE TO DO IT BECAUSE IF
THERE ARE NO CONSEQUENCES WE'RE
GOING TO SEE ANOTHER REPORT FROM
YOU PERHAPS ABOUT SO MANY SLEPT
ON THE JOB FOR FOUR YEARS.
MEANWHILE WE'VE GOT CONSTITUENTS
PASSING OUT ONLINE AYE WHEN
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET SOMETHING
THAT THEY HAVE TO GET IN ORDER
TO FUNCTION --
I ALSO I THINK THE DIRECTOR FOR
COMING FOR TWO DAYS OF TESTIMONY
FOR PERSONALLY LOOKING AT THOSE
RESPONSES IF I CAN BE OF SERVICE
AND CLOSING THE LOOP WITH ANY OF
THOSE CONSTITUENTS ON IT --
AND A REALLY HOPE THE THAT
YOU'RE GONNA I'M SURE YOU WILL
BE IN FULL COOPERATION WITH THE
AUDITOR ALL THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS --
BECAUSE IT'S CRITICAL THANK YOU
FOR INDULGING MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
IT IS ELEVEN A. M. WE'VE BEEN
HERE FOR TWO HOURS THIS IS OUR
SECOND ITEM.
SEVERAL LARA.
THANK YOU I'LL BE BRIEF I HAVE
TWO QUESTIONS BUT I I ALSO WANNA.
ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IT'S IT'S
EASY TO BEAT UP ON THE DMV --
AND IT'S AN EASY GO --
TO ESPECIALLY WHEN IT'S IN VOGUE
AYE IN OUR COUNTRY NOW THIS
NOWADAYS TO ATTACK GOVERNMENT
AND TRY TO DISCREDIT IT.
BUT ALSO UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES THE DEPARTMENT HAS
HAD AND ACKNOWLEDGING OUR OWN
RESPONSIBILITY AS LEGISLATORS --
IN TERMS OF LACK OF FUN. TO THE
DMV -- AND
CERTAINLY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE'S THERE'S CONCERNS OF MY
QUESTION IS A COUPLE YEARS AGO
WE WERE WE ACTUALLY HAD SOMEWHAT
SIMILAR.
ON HOW WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS --
THIS ONGOING NEED TO INCREASE
SERVICES AND THERE WAS
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE FIELD
OFFICES.
AND THERE WAS A STRATEGY AS AS A
SUMMER BAKER SAID AND ALLUDED TO
IN TERMS OF HOW DO WE GET PEOPLE.
TO USE THE ONLINE SERVICES AND
GET THEM.
NOT TO NECESSARILY HAVE TO GO
INTO THE D. M. V..
AND I WANNA AND MAY BE ABLE TO
HAVE THAT DISCUSSION I WANTED A
TERRIFYING FOR ME DIRECTOR.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO THAT
STRATEGY HAS AS WE HAVE WE
INCREASED THE AMOUNT OF SERVICES
ONLINE?
I UNDERSTAND THE REAL ID ACT IS
AN ISSUE BUT HAVE.
WHERE ARE WE ON THAT STRATEGY SO
SO WE HAVE A PLAN WE ARE WORKING
TO ADD ANOTHER TRANSACTION TO
OUR CELLS ARE?
US SELF SERVICE TERMINALS WHERE
THIS IS WHERE YOU DON'T HAVE TO
A SEE A TECHNICIAN YOU ARE --
CAN GO TO I SAW CERTAIN WHICH
ARE IN OUR FIELD OFFICES IN
RETAIL LOCATIONS AND SO THAT IS
FOR IF YOU HAVE VEHICLE
REGISTRATION YOUR INSURANCE
LAPSE AND THEN YOU HAVE TO BE
REINSTATED.
IT'S A FOURTEEN DOLLAR
REINSTATEMENT FEE WE ARE --
BY THE FALL WE WILL HAVE THAT IN
PLACE SO THAT IS WHERE YOU TAKE.
THE CUSTOMER OF OUT IN THE FIELD
OFFICE IN USING ALTERNATIVE
SERVICES THAT WE DO HAVE A PLAN
TO ADD MORE TRANSACTIONS.
BUT AS THE LEGISLATURE PASSES TO
IMPLEMENT THOSE FIRST IN SO
THERE'S BEEN MANY.
OF THE STATUE SENATE IN PASSING
WEEK IMPLEMENTED THOSE AND SO WE
HAVE TO DO WE WE HAVE TO HAVE IT
FOLKS WORKING ON DO YOU HAVE
BEEN A HOW MANY BILLS WE'VE
PASSED THAT AFFECT THE DMV AND
D'AMATO FOR CLOUD THAT THAT
TAKES.
AND I I DIDN'T BRING THAT WITH
ME I DID HAVE MY LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR IDENTIFY AND THAT WE'VE
DONE -- MANY
AND AND SO THERE'S A THERE'S A
SOME THAT WERE WORKING THERE
HAVE TO OF MID JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY NINE TWO OF THOSE ARE
VERY IMPORTANT TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I'LL BE DONE THE FOR
CONNIE PILOT FOR IGNITION
INTERLOCK DEVICE YOU HAVE TO
HAVE STATEWIDE.
IMPLEMENTATION JANUARY FIRST THE
AND GENDER IDENTITY AND SO WE
HAVE TO DO THAT --
JENNIFER'S --
TWENTY NINETEEN WE'VE DONE --
AND AMNESTY AND FOR THE
SUSPENSION ON NOT FORGET YOU CAN
STILL BE ABLE TO DRIVE THAT
WE'VE DONE SOME AMNESTY ON THAT
AND SO THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
THAT WE HAVE TO DO.
TO BE ABLE TO STILL --
SERVE THE CUSTOMERS IN
CALIFORNIA STRAIGHT [inaudible]
BECAUSE OF ASSN STATUE WE HAVE
HARD IMPLEMENTATION DATES ARE
RESOURCES AND I T. ARE DEDICATED
TO MAKING SURE THAT.
WE MAKE THAT COMMITMENT AND
IMPLEMENT THOSE LEGISLATION AND
SO IN TERMS OF GETTING THE OTHER
ONLINE ACTIVITIES WE HAVE TO DO
A COMMIT FIRST OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
IF YOU CAN GIVE WILL GIVE US
LIKE THAT'S WHAT SUMMARY OF OF
THAT TO THE COMMITTEE SO THAT WE
CAN ALSO LOOK AT THE SCOPE OF
THE LIFE THAT I HAD GOTTEN A
HUMBLING WERE REQUIRING.
YOU TO DO ON ANNUAL BASIS AS
BILLS GET PAST MY THE QUESTION I
THINK IT IS FOR BOTH THE
DIRECTOR AND THE AUDITOR.
YOU KNOW I'M CONCERNED WITH OUR
AB SIXTY DRIVERS AND THE SCOPE
OF THIS BILL THIS AUDIT IN TERMS
OF HOW WOULD THAT IMPACT.
THE DATA OF THE THESE VULNERABLE
TO OUR DRIVERS ALREADY YOU KNOW
WE HAVE A CONCERN WITH --
MEAN ON ANY POTENTIAL EXPOSURE
TO OUR IMMIGRANT DRIVERS FISH
UNDER THIS FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION.
IS THIS WHAT THE SCOPE OF THIS
AUDIT IMPACT --
ANY DATA OR ANY INFORMATION AND
IN REGARDS TO OUR AB SIXTY
DRIVERS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT AB SIGH AFTER.
ITS ARE UNDOCUMENTED DRIVE OKAY --
I I DON'T IMAGINE ANY OF THE
OBJECTIVES BASED ON WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING SENATOR WOULD HAVE AN
ADVERSE IMPACT ON THOSE DRIVERS.
I'M NOT SURE.
MIGHT NEED A LITTLE BIT EXTRA
HELP AS WE ARE GOING TO MAKE
SURE THING WHERE WE'RE
PROTECTING THE DATA ADAM AS WERE
COLLECTING AND LOW ABSOLUTE FOR
INTO WELL IT AND ANY TIME MY
OFFICE CONDUCTS AN AUDIT AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT ELECTRONIC DATA
AND WE'VE ALREADY TALKED Y. T..
STAFF ABOUT THIS PROJECT WE
THINK WE WOULD USE OUR IT
AUDITOR'S WE HAVE --
INFORMATION --
SECURITY OFFICER HAVE TO PUT
TOGETHER A DATA SECURITY PLAN.
WORK WITH LEGAL MAKE SURE THAT
WERE FOLLOWING THE APPROPRIATE
STEPS TO PROTECT ANY INFORMATION
THAT WE OBTAIN FROM A DEPARTMENT.
SO WE WOULD HAVE VERY TIGHT
CONTROLS IN PLACE WITH RESPECT
TO THE DATA THAT WE GET FROM THE
ENVY IF YOU CAN JUST RESPOND TO
THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE I MEAN
YOU KNOW THE POPULATION.
THAT WORD TOWARD TALKING ABOUT
YES SO OF WE MAKE SURE THAT.
THE DOCUMENTS THAT SUBMITTED
FROM THAT BY A DOCKET WAS
SUBMITTED AND THAT WE HAVE WE
SCANNED AND WE AND STORE THOSE
THAT DATA
AND SO WE ARE VERY MINDFUL OF
PROTECTING THE INFORMATION OF A
DOCTOR IMMIGRANTS SO THAT THEY
ARE NOT IDENTIFIED ANYWAY.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ENSURE THE PROTECTION OF THE
INFORMATION OF THEIR DOCUMENTS
IS -- NOT
SHARED WITH ANYBODY.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE YOUR AYE
ANSWERS THE QUESTIONS AND AGAIN.
I REMIND US THAT YOU KNOW THE
DIEM BEEP DOES PLAY A CRITICAL
ROLE THERE ARE.
A GREAT STAFF ARE TRYING TO DO
THE MOST WITH WHAT WE HAVE THEM.
I ASK THEM TO DO EVERY YEAR NOT
ONLY TO POLICY BUT THROUGH
MANDATES THAT WE HAVE SO I
APPRECIATE WORK THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH SENATOR ALAN.
WELL THANK YOU. FOR THIS
DISCUSSION I ALSO WAS ABLE TO
NAY YESTERDAY --
TO THE DISCUSSION OF THE BUDGET
SUB IN AND YOU OF HIS FACE A LOT
OF HARD QUESTIONS I THINK
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THE THE
LEGISLATURE IS SOUND.
IS VERY --
I'M HAPPY.
ABOUT WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING IN
THE REPORTS FROM HONDA IF THE
FIELD IN ALL SORTS OF DIFFERENT.
DMV OFFICES ALL OVER THE STATE
[inaudible]
AND YOU KNOW I THINK THE
QUESTION.
I LIVE THAT LEAVES ME A LITTLE
TORN ON THIS REQUEST
[inaudible]
IS -- YOU
KNOW IF FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IF
WE WE KNEW THAT DOING THE AUDIT
WOULD SUDDENLY RESOLVE ALL THESE
PROBLEMS I WOULD OBVIOUSLY BE
VERY ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORTIVE.
I GUESS --
MY QUESTION IS --
YET IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE KEY
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE DONE.
WE KNOW WHERE YOU YOU KNOW
YOU'VE YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT.
YOU KNOW ADDITIONAL STAFF ALONE
IMPLEMENTING A TEXT NOTIFICATION
OPTION PILOTING SELF CHECK IN
KIOSKS EXPANDING.
THE NEW SELF SERVICE TERMINALS
ON THE SATURDAY SERVICE
EXPANSION EARLY OFFICE HOURS --
ALL THE NEW HIRING THAT HAS TO
HAPPEN.
I THERE'S A WHOLE SLEW OF PET
PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS AS WELL.
SO THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT --
I THINK ARE ARE GOING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE --
I ALSO THINK THAT WE AS A
LEGISLATURE INCLUDE COORDINATION
WITH YOU NEED TO VIEW LOOKING AT
WHETHER THERE ARE THERE CERTAIN
THINGS IT HOT THAT CURRENTLY
HAPPEN AT THE DMV THAT HAVE TO
HAVE A D. V. I JUST GOT MY
PASSPORT RENEWED.
BY MAIL --
SURLY THERE IS.
THE SAME [inaudible]
SECURITY AND AND YOU KNOW
INTEGRITY AND AND FRIED.
CHALLENGES A CONCERNS ASSOCIATE
WITH THE PASSPORT IS THERE IS
WITH THE DRIVER'S EYES I DON'T
KNOW WHY TO DO THAT BY MAIL BUT
PEOPLE HAVE TO GO IN PERSON. TO
THE LICENSE I LOVED IT DESERVE
REASON FOR THAT.
SO FOR THE REAL IDEA IT'S A
FEDERAL REQUIREMENT THAT WEEK
EVERY DVD HAS TO OUR CREDENTIAL
PERSON IN PERSON IN PERSON SO
WHAT ABOUT MY PASSPORT WHITE Y.
IS THAT OKAY.
DE DUM DE IN THAT BY MAIL SO AT
THE FOR A RENEWAL ALL ONCE WE
CREATE WE CREDENTIAL YOU FOR
REAL ID OR IF YOU CURRENTLY HAVE
A DRIVER'S LICENSE --
YOU CAN RENEW EVERY FIVE YEARS
FOR AT THE FIRST TWO RENEWALS
THAT IN PERSON VISIT RENO YOU
COULD DEBT BY MAIL SO IT'S ONCE
EVERY FIFTEEN YEARS AT WHICH
HAVE TO COMMIT AND RENEW IN
PERSON.
AND SO WITH REAL ID IT IS
BECAUSE FEDERAL OUT RELY DE TO
DO AN IN PERSON VISIT BUT YOU
REDUCE A ON A MAC THE CENTURY
NOVEL UNNOTICED AND IF YOU'RE
ELIGIBLE YOU CAN RENEW BY MAIL
YOU CAN RENEW ONLINE.
WHERE YOU CAN GO TO A SELF
SERVICE TERMINAL TO RENEW ONLINE
IS THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENT THAT
YOU HAVE?
TO WE HAVE TO RECRUIT RECRUIT
ANSWER YOU IN PERSON.
AND THEY DID NOT.
I IMPOSE THAT REQUIREMENT ON
PASSPORTS [inaudible]
PASSPORTS A NO I THINK WE GET
OUT BECAUSE WHEN I GOT MY
PASSPORT I GOT MY PHOTO AND SEND
THE PAPERWORK AGAIN.
I I WILL NOT REAL FAMILIAR WITH
HOW THEY VERIFY YOUR IDENTITY UP
THROUGH THE PASSPORT SYSTEM BUT
THESE ARE WHERE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REQUIRES AN IN PERSON
VISIT.
AND SO HOW THEY SET UP THE
PROCESS FOR PASSPORTS IS
DIFFERENT HOW THEY SET UP THE
PROCESS FOR A FEDERAL ID
[inaudible]
YEAH.
I GUESS MY CONCERN IS THAT OUT
WE WE HEARD FROM THE HOTTER
EARLIER THAT.
THEY'VE GOT FAR TOO MANY
REQUESTS FROM THIS COMMITTEE AND
FROM OUR MEMBERS THAN THEY CAN
HANDLE.
ON A WHOLE SLEW OF DIFFERENT
TOUGH ISSUES.
AND I JUST WONDER ARE WE GONNA
GET SO WE'RE GONNA PUT WE'RE
GONNA ASK YOU TO SPEND YOUR
BUDGET ON THIS AUDIT --
WHEN THAT BUDGET OUGHT TO BE
GOING TO DIRECTLY ADDRESSING THE
PROBLEMS [inaudible]
YOU CERTAINLY [inaudible]
I I I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
QUESTION THAT THEY DID YOU'VE
HEARD THE HEAT FROM THE
LEGISLATURE FROM CONSTITUENTS.
I WONDER WHETHER THIS IS A GOOD
INVESTMENT IF AS LONG AS THE
LEGISLATURE IF WE WERE NOT TO DO
THIS THIS AUDIT.
THE LEGISLATION WOULD HAVE TO
SET UP SOME SORT OF SYSTEM TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR REGULAR
CHECKSTHAT WE BE READY TO PULL
THE TRIGGER ON THE AUDIT IF WE
FELT AS THOUGH.
YOU WEREN'T BEING RESPONSIVE AND
YOU WARRANT MEETING THESE ARE
THESE --
COMMITMENTS THAT YOU MADE TO US
PRETTY CLEARLY YESTERDAY AND
TODAY.
SO THAT'S WHERE I'M THAT'S WHY
I'M TORN RIGHT NOW I'M I'M I'M --
I'M ALL FOR NOT IF I IT'S REALLY
GONNA MAKE A DIFFERENCE BUT IT'S
GONNA TELL US WE ARE YOU KNOW.
AND AND TAKE AWAY BOTH THE
AUDITOR'S RESOURCES IN YOUR
RESOURCES [inaudible]
FROM -- FROM
GETTING TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
PROBLEM --
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE AN EXERCISE
IN FUTILITY I'M YOU KNOW.
SO THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF MY OPEN
QUESTION RIGHT NOW.
THAT I'M THAT I'M GRAPPLING WITH
I WOULD CERTAINLY SAY THAT IF
THIS IS COMMITTEE DECIDES NOT TO
DO AN AUDIT I WOULD WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAD.
A VERY --
STRONG COMMITMENT FROM YOU TO
COME BACK TO THIS COMMITTEE ON A
REGULAR BASIS REPORT BACK ON
YOUR PROGRESS.
AND I WOULD ALSO I'D BE --
YOU KNOW.
INTERESTED IN IN IN.
GETTING TOUGH IF IF THERE WAS A
I FEELING ON THIS COMMITTEE THAT
YOU ARE MEETING THE COMMITMENTS
YOU MAY CLEARLY TO US.
BOTH YESTERDAY IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND TODAY.
HERE IN THE AUDIT COMMITTEE.
SO THAT'S MY THOUGHTS ON THIS ON
THIS ISSUE RIGHT NOW AND I GUESS
I'D LIKE THAT MAYBE I'D LIKE TO
HEAR THE AUDITOR I MEAN YOU'RE
YOU KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE
CONSTANTLY GETTING REQUESTS FROM
MEMBERS.
WHO I MEAN OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO DO THE BEST YOU
CAN AND YOU'RE YOU'RE VERY
CAPABLE AND AND AND --
IF THIS AUDIT COMES THROUGH --
ZADA REQUEST CONSIDER YOU GONNA
DO DE GOOD JOB I KNOW YOU WELL
IN YOUR YOUR VERY DILIGENT AND
YOU KNOW AS YOU KNOW.
MESSES WITH THE CHAIRS REMINDERS
OVER OVER AGAIN WE'VE GOT
FIFTEEN REQUEST TODAY ALONE AND
WHERE YOU ARE HERE TWO HOURS
INTO THE MEETING.
DURING ALSO AT THE A TALKING
ABOUT THE DETAILS WE STILL HAVE
A LOT TO REQUEST YOUR SEATS
MEMBERS WAITING TO PRESENT THEIR
REQUEST [inaudible]
ADEN.
YOU KNOW SHE'S BEEN RAKED OVER
THE COALS PRETTY THOROUGHLY
YESTERDAY AND TODAY IT'S ON THE
FRONT PAGES TODAY SACRAMENTO BEE --
YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK THAT.
NO SURPRISE I DON'T THINK ANYONE
AT THE DNC --
WOULD --
YEAH I THINK I DON'T KNOW WHY
THE HEAT THAT THEY'RE UNDER
RIGHT NOW --
IT WHERE WHERE SHOULD I
PRIORITIZE THIS REQUEST GIVEN
ALL OF THE POLITICS ALL OF THE
PUBLIC SECURITY GIVEN THE THE
CLEAR STATEMENT OF OF
RESPONSIVENESS FROM THE DMV.
VERSES ALL THE FIFTEEN OTHER
REQUESTS THAT WOULD BETTER UP
THAT ARE GONNA ALSO TAKE UP THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE ALSO GONNA AT
YOU EXPLORE IMPORTANT ASPECTS
THE GOVERNMENT FUNCTION
[inaudible]
WELL.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT WE DON'T
TAKE A POSITION ON AUDITS BUT
BUT WHAT WE TYPICALLY THIS AUDIT.
HAS STATEWIDE IMPACT.
FROM THERE ARE SOME ODD IT'S
THAT WE ARE ASKED TO DO BY THIS
COMMITTEE AND BY MEMBERS THAT
ARE VERY NARROWLY FOCUSED ON A
SPECIFIC DISTRICT OR
CONSTITUENCY --
IF I WERE TO COMPARE THIS AUDIT
TO SOME OF THE OTHERS THAT'S THE
PERSPECTIVE I WOULD HAVE HONOR
WE WOULD PUT A TEAM ON THIS
AUDIT RIGHT AWAY BECAUSE THIS IS
CLEARLY AN ISSUE THAT'S IN THE
FOREFRONT.
OF EVERYBODY'S MIND BECAUSE SO
MANY PEOPLE HAVE INTERACTIONS
WITH DMV.
BUT CERTAINLY IT'S THE
COMMITTEES DISCRETION IF THE
COMMITTEE FEELS THAT THERE ARE
EFFORTS THAT DMV IS TAKING AND
THEY DON'T YOU DON'T THINK NOW'S
THE APPROPRIATE TIME TO DO AN
AUDIT.
MEAN UP OBVIOUSLY I'M GOING TO
DEFER TO THE COMMITTEES --
DECISION MAKING WITH RESPECT TO
THAT BUT BUT WHEN WHEN WE LOOKED
AT AUDIT SENATOR WE TRY.
TO EVEN IF WE DO GET AN AUDIT
THAT'S MORE NARROWLY FOCUSED WE
TRY.
TO LOOK AT THE SCOPE AND SEE IF
THEY'RE THINGS THAT WE CAN
ANALYZE AND ASSESS THAT WILL
HAVE AN IMPACT STATEWIDE ON
CONSTITUENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THIS CLEARLY
IS AN AUDIT THAT.
ALREADY THE SCOPE OF THIS AUDIT
IS GOING.
TO ARM TOUCH ON PRETTY MUCH
EVERY MEMBER'S DISTRICT --
AS FAR AS CONSTITUENTS HAVING TO
TO DEAL WITH DMV I I I
APPRECIATE WHAT THE DIRECTOR
SAID I DIDN'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WATCH THE HEARING
YESTERDAY.
I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THEY HAVE
TAKEN STEPS BOMB BUT WHAT THE
MEMBERS ARE ASKING US TO DO IS.
TO GET IN THERE AND ASSESS OKAY
WHAT IS THE STEPS ARE THEY GOING
TO ANALYZE HEALTH EFFECTIVE
THOSE STEPS ARE DO THEY HAVE
PLANS IN PLACE TO COURSE CORRECT
IF THOSE STEPS ARE NOT EFFECTIVE.
I THINK THAT SOME OF THE
ANALYSIS THAT WE CAN DO AS FAR
AS A SYSTEM.
BOB WHAT HOW LONG WOULD IT TAKE
YOU TO FINISH THIS.
WELL AS I SAID IN A WHEN I
PRESENTED THE THE ANALYSIS THAT
THE AUDIT IS ITS BUDGET ABOUT
TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED HOURS FOR
THE AUDIT TEAM.
THAT JUST ONE AUDIT TEAM WOULD
TAKE US ABOUT SEVEN MONTHS NOW
WHAT WE COULD DO --
IF THE COMMITTEE WANTED US TO
GET THIS DONE BY A CERTAIN TIME
FRAME THE MEMBERS DIDN'T ASK FOR
A SPECIFIC TIME FRAME --
WE COULD PUT MORE THAN ONE TEAM
ON THIS JOB BECAUSE WERE
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO HAVE TO GO TO
A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT DISTRICT
OFFICES SO INSTEAD OF HAVING ONE
TEAM GOING FROM SACRAMENTO TO
LOS ANGELES TO CENTRAL VALLEY.
WE WOULD HAVE TEAMS OFGOING OUT
CONCURRENTLY AND THAT WOULD CUT
DOWN ON THE AMOUNT OF CALENDAR
TIME IT WOULD TAKE US TO GET THE
JOB DONE.
BOB CESCA CHAIR INTO IS IT WOULD
IT BE POSSIBLE YOU KNOW WE'VE
GOT SO SEVEN MONTH PROCESS I
GUESS IT COULD BE SPED UP A BIT --
YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT A LITTLE LESS
THAN A MONTH LEFT --
OF SESSION FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
ARE.
YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD BE THE
FEASIBILITY ARE OF IF YOU KNOW
IF IF THE CHAIR AND THE VICE
CHAIR WERE NOT SATISFIED WITH
THE PROGRESS MADE OVER THE
COURSE THE NEXT MONTH.
BY THE D. M. V.. TO RECONVENE
THIS COMMITTEE AT THE VERY END
OF OF SESSION --
TO TO RECONSIDER.
I THE THE THIS AUDIT REQUEST IT
IS THAT WOULD THAT BE SOMETHING
THAT WE COULD POTENTIALLY
ENTERTAIN.
WELL IF EVER COMMITTEE WORK --
TO NOT MOVE FOR TODAY.
CERTAINLY WEAKENED --
CONSIDERED THE THAT THE
POSSIBILITY OF CONVENING A
SPECIAL SESSION --
IT TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE --
WE CAN ALSO CONSIDER.
AS THE AUDITOR IS SUGGESTING --
EXPEDITING.
AND PRIORITIZE IN THIS AUDIT
REQUESTS --
I A I THINK --
WHETHER WE DO IT TODAY OR AT A
SPECIAL SESSION.
OF COURSE WE WE WOULD HAVE TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES.
AS A COMMITTEE AS A WHOLE.
YEAH ARTISTS AT IT AND IF I MAY
MISTER CHAIR WITH ARMS PICKED UP
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED SO
WE HAVE TAKE ABOUT ANYWAY YEAH I
UNDERSTAND I UNDERSTAND I'M JUST
ASKING IF WE IF.
IF IT IF WE WANT. TO MY FOR
TODAY ON I THINK PART OF WHAT'S
WHAT'S YOU KNOW OUR YEAH THIS IS
DIFFERENT THAN A TYPICAL REQUEST
BECAUSE THE STATE WIDE SCOPE BUT
IT'S ALSO DIFFERENT BECAUSE I
WE'VE GOT A YEAH WE'VE GOT THE
ATTENTION OF SOME OF THE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS WEIGHING.
IN ON THIS I THINK THAT THE
FOLKS IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
RECOGNIZE WHAT A PROBLEM THEY
HAVE ON THEIR HANDS AYE I'M
GETTING THE SENSE THAT DAY.
OUR ARE TAKING SOME OWNERSHIP IN
UNDERSTAND.
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR THEM TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS ISSUE
AND GET THESE ISSUES ADDRESSED A
SAP?
AND I THINK THAT HE'S PUTTING
SOME PERSONAL --
CREDIBILITY ON THE LINE WITH
REGARD TO THIS SO IT IN THAT
SENSE IT'S ALSO DIFFERENT RIGHT
IT'S NOT LIKE --
TYPICAL I REQUEST WHERE AND
THERE'S NOT THIS LEVEL OF
COMMITMENT AND ATTENTION FROM
THE HIGHER UPS IT WITHIN OUR
SO I AND THAT'S WHAT THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT I AM --
THAT'S ONE GRAPPLING WITH RIGHT
NOW TO MY VOTE ON THIS ON THIS
REQUEST ON THIS DAY [inaudible]
MISTER CHAIR.
THE I. O. RESPONSE TO SENATOR
ALAN [inaudible]
YES.
BUT CENTER AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ONE IN QUESTION I
THINK IT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE I
WOULD SAY THAT.
IF YOU KNOW THIS IS NOT A
PROBLEM THAT IS NEW.
IS NOT A PROBLEM THAT HAS --
BEEN GOING ON FOR A SHORT AMOUNT
OF TIME IT'S BEEN GOING ON SINCE
TWO THOUSAND FIVE I THINK IT'S A
CULTURAL ISSUE AND IT LASTS MORE
THAN JUST A REAL ID ISSUE.
I THINK HAVING THE AUDITOR WITH
THEIR EXPERTISE TO RESOURCES AND
BEING A INDEPENDENT OUTSIDE
ENTITY LISELOTTE TO SWAY AND
RESOURCES THAT WOULD HELP BUT
DMB.
YES IT'S GOING TO THE GOVERNOR'S
LEVEL IS GOING TO LEGISLATURE
OFTEN BUT I THINK THAT'S WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE THE
AUDITOR BRING THOSE RESOURCES TO
DMV AND CANDIDLY I'M NOT SURE.
THE DMV ALONE CAN HANDLE AND
REPAIRED THE SITUATION I THINK
THEY NEED RESOURCES TO HELP
ALLEVIATE SOME ISSUES THAT ARE
FACING RIGHT NOW ONE WOULD READ
THAT'S PRICEY MY CONCERN I GUESS
WE'RE GONNA ASK THEM NOW TO
SPEND ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
FUND THE AUDIT --
WHEN YOU KNOW?
WHEN THOSE RESOURCES NEED TO GO
TOWARD ADDRESSING THE ISSUES AT
HAND --
THAT'S I GUESS THAT'S THAT'S
PART OF THE THE CHALLENGE RIGHT
ON THAT WOULD COULD RELATE IT
WILL FIND IT'S FUNNY I MEAN YOU.
YOU DID NOT GIVE HIS NOTORIOUS
AGGREGATE CALIFORNIA LIVES
THERE'S OUR MOST --
FAVORITE WHIPPING BOY --
IN GOVERNMENT AYE AND YET I
THINK WE WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
IT SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE FOR
AWHILE --
OUT FROM ITS.
FROM FROM WHERE IT WAS --
BACK WHEN I WAS A KID
[inaudible]
AND SO THIS SO IT'S SO SO NOW I
THINK THE OF SOME OF THE OLD
LEGACY IS.
REARING ITS UGLY HEAD IT'S BEEN
A CAN OF AN UNFORTUNATE
CONFLUENCE OF FACTORS FOURTEEN
SIXTY ONE AND REAL ID AND UP A
BUNCH OF OF OF OF STRESSES IN
AND PER AND AND IN EXACERBATIONS
OF OF SOME EXISTING CULTURAL
PROBLEMS WITHIN THAT WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT BUT I DO THINK.
THAT THEY ARE AND I DO THINK
THAT THEY THEY'VE IMPROVED QUITE
A BIT --
SINCE SINCE I WAS YOUNGER THOUGH
THE NOW [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
THEY'VE GOT A WHOLE NEW SET OF
PROBLEMS SO IT'S IT'S AND IT'S A
IT'S A IT'S IT I THINK I JUST
BECOMES A CHALLENGE OF HOW HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE WE'RE USING OUR
MONEY EFFECTIVELY AND HOW HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE THAT --
THAT THAT.
YOU KNOW I I GUESS IT COMES DOWN
A TRUST ISSUE IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S SOME FOLKS HERE WHO.
FEEL AS THOUGH I THE DEPARTMENT
LEADERSHIP IS IS LOST THE TRUST
OF THE COMMITTEE ON THOSE OF US
WHO WE KNOW WE'RE HEARING FROM
THEM THAT THEY'VE HEARD THIS
PROBLEM LOUD AND CLEAR IN THE
DAY.
I KNOW WHAT THEY NEED TO DO AND
AND THEY'RE READY TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE BY US.
AND THAT'S THE THAT'S THE
DILEMMA THAT WE FACE RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU SENATOR FULLER --
I'M NOT GOING TO GO BACK INTO
THE DETAILS OF THE PROBLEM
ALTHOUGH I DO HAVE DOCUMENTED
FROM MY AND AT MY OWN OFFICES
THE EXACT WEIGHT --
ON CERTAIN DAYS AND CERTAIN
TIMES AND IT STE [inaudible]
IT'S TERRIBLE.
SO -- I HAVE
A FEW QUESTIONS TO ASK YOU --
TO SEE IF THIS IS INDEED A
SYSTEM WIDE PROBLEM WHICH IT
SOUNDS TO ME IT IS AND IT SOUNDS
LIKE IT'S CRASHING ON FIVE
PLATFORMS AND I JUST WANTED. TO
GET YOUR FEELINGS ON THOSE FIVE
PLATFORMS AND IF THAT'S THE CASE
THEN I WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE
AUDITOR TIM TO CONSIDER MOVING
THIS UP AND SHORTENING THE TIME
LINE.
BECAUSE IF WE ARE TRULY IN A
SYSTEMIC.
CRISIS THAT WILL EASILY MOVED TO
ASSIST THEM SYSTEMIC CRASH OF
VITAL SERVICES FOR THE STATE OF
THINK WE NEED TO PUT IT AT THE
TOP OF THE LIST.
AND STOP WORRYING ABOUT WHAT THE
BLAME IS OR WHY IT IS AND GET
SOME REAL PARAMETERS ON THE
PROBLEM.
SO A YOU STATED AND AND I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND I THANK
YOU FOR HAVING EXTENDED SATURDAY
SERVICE TO S..
THAT HELPED A THOUGH IT DIDN'T
FIX IT BUT STEPPED.
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW IN ARE AREA
THE HEAT IS A HUNDRED AND TWO
DEGREES TWO HUNDRED ELEVEN AS I
DRIVE BY THERE EVERY DAY THEIR
PEOPLE ARE STANDING OUTSIDE IN
LONG LINES AND IT'S JUST.
AWFUL.
SO.
I'M NUMBER ONE YOU STATED THAT
YOUR APPROACH CONSISTED OF
REVIEWING THE INDIVIDUAL OFFICES
I THINK YOU SAID YOU HAD SOME
AROUND A HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
OFFICES. FOR BEST PRACTICES AND
IF THEY'RE SERVICING THE
CUSTOMER.
YES WE ARE DO WE WE HAVE DONE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO DO THAT HAVE
YOU COLLECTED IN THE DATA ON THE
PARAMETERS OF THIS PROBLEM SUCH
AS WHAT OF WHAT IS THE AVERAGE
CUSTOMER SERVICE TIME YOU STATED
EARLIER EVIDENTLY THAT THE REAL
ID TOOK FIVE MINUTES.
WHICH AT BUT THE WHOLE TOTAL
SPECTRUM OF THAT RELY DE
[inaudible]
A PROBLEM WAS ONLY LIKE ABOUT
15%.
BUT SO ARE UNKNOWN.
WITH THEIR EXPLAIN WHATEVER LIKE
HE ENDED DENNIS KITCHEN IS THIS
ADDING ADDITIONAL TALK TIME
EXPLAIN TO THE BECAUSE MCGUIRE
IDEAS WHAT DOCUMENTS YOU NEED TO
BRING AND AND EXPLAIN THAT
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS NOT A
CALIFORNIA REQUIREMENTS OF ITS
EDUCATE THE CUSTOMER WE'VE DONE
A LOT IT.
MEDIA IN TERMS OF WE SO.
JUST TO BIGGEST QUICK AS WE CAN
KEEP GOING IT.
IT'S ABOUT AS YOU SAID YESTERDAY
ABOUT FIVE MINUTES EXTRA PER
CUSTOMER.
LARA RELIED OKAY SO.
IF WE DO NOT KNOW WHAT THE
AVERAGE CUSTOMER SERVICE TIME
PER VISIT IS ACROSS THE SYSTEM
WE DO KNOW AND WE DO KNOW BY
EACH OFFICE WHAT THE WAIT TIME
IS WE HAVE A SPREADSHEET NOT THE
WAIT TIME.
THE SERVICE TIME THE AVERAGE
SERVICE TIME FOR THE NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS BECAUSE WHAT I WANT
WHEN I WANT IT THE AUDITOR TO
HELP YOU DO BENCHMARK THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE PROBLEM BY
HAVING A DASHBOARD NOT BY
INDIVIDUAL OFFICES.
BUT ACROSS THE SYSTEM A MULTI
WINE A MOMENT AND THEN YOU CAN
RESPOND TO THAT.
SO FOR EXAMPLE.
IF YOU COULD POST ON YOUR
WEBSITE THIS WOULD BE A HELP
JUST TO START IF YOUR ELECTRONIC
TICKET SYSTEM.
ACTUALLY GIVES YOU FEEDBACK ON
HOW MANY CUSTOMERS ARE COMING A
WHAT THEY NEED YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO PUBLISH A YELP LIKE.
CUSTOMER FLOW CHART RIGHT ON
YOUR WEBSITE IT SAYS THESE ARE
THE BUSIEST DAYS.
AND GET YOU THROUGH THE CRISIS
INTO YOU CAN FIX THE BUSIEST
DAYS A NUMBER THE NUMBER OF DAYS
YOU CAN ALSO BETTER ESTIMATE
WHAT YOUR SERVICES INSTEAD OF
JUST SAYING OKAY I'M GONNA PUT
SOME PEOPLE OUT THERE ON
SATURDAY SOMEWHERE --
BECAUSE THEY GOT AWAY TIME AND
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW IF THE WAIT
TIMES ARE REPORTED REPORTED
ACCURATELY BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
IF THEY'RE REPORTING FROM THE
TIME THEY PICK AT THE TAKE THE
WINDOW OR IF THEY'RE REPORTING
FROM THE MINUTE THEY GET THE
LINE AT THE BACK OF THE LINE --
WE'RE GOING WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
A SYSTEM WIDE.
PICTURE AND THAT'S WHAT I THINK
THE AUDITOR CAN DO ON FIVE
LEVELS ONE IS ON JUST THE
TECHNICAL PROCESSES WHICH IS
IMMEDIATE MANAGING THE CROWD
REALISTIC ASSESSMENT OF OF THE
SERVICE TIME THAT.
THAT'S NEEDED FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT COME AND AHEAD OF TIME SO
YOU HAVE.
YOU HAVE A PREDICTIVE MODE THE
YOU CAN DISCUSS FOR THE UNIONS
OR WHATEVER PUT YOUR PEOPLE OUT
THERE -- AND
PUT SOME OF THAT ON ON THE
WEBSITE SO THAT PEOPLE CAN SEE
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO CURE THE
PROBLEM YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS IN
THESE ARE YOUR GOALS TO GET THE
WAIT TIME DOWN.
NUMBER ONE THAT'S I THINK THAT'S
NUMBER ONE THAT'S GOT TO HAPPEN
NUMBER TWO IS CUSTOMER SERVICE
JUST YOUR SAYING REAL IDEAS THE
WHOLE PROBLEM BUT IT'S BEEN
THIRTEEN YEARS OR SOMETHING
SINCE WE KNEW ABOUT REAL ID.
SAW HOW MUCH TIME IS THAT
ACTUALLY ADDED THE SYSTEM HOW
MUCH TIME HAS EVERYTHING ELSE
ADDED TO THE SYSTEM.
AND THEN YOU CAN BEGIN GETTING
THE WAIT TIMES DOWN BY DOING
SOMETHING BY JUST TRYING TO PAY
OVERTIME AND US JUST LIKE THIS
AND YOU MONEY TO PAY OVERTIME
AND EMPLOYEES TO SKILLET BURNED
OUT.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE'RE HEADED IF
THIS IF WE DON'T BENCHMARK THIS
SYSTEM.
AND I THINK THE THE WHOLE
CUSTOMER SERVICE HAS BEEN
TOUCHED ON THAT'S LIKE PLATFORM.
TO ADD TREATMENT OF PEOPLE
NEEDING SERVICE HOW DO YOU HOW
IS IT ACCEPTABLE FOR THOSE
OFFICES THAT HAVE SAT THERE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION NEVER EVEN
HEARD ABOUT IT NOBODY'S EVEN
DOING IT THAT WOULD PREFER
FEIGNING OUT THERE.
AND HUNT THEM IN THE NEWSPAPERS
FINDING OUT BUT NO ONE ELSE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION IS.
SO THE WHOLE CUSTOMER SERVICE
TREATMENT DOWN THE ROAD YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO HAVE SOME TYPE OF
QUALITY CONTROL [inaudible]
AND PERHAPS THE AUDIT CAN HELP
YOU DOCUMENT Y. BENCHMARK.
WHERE YOU CAN PUT THE MOST
RESOURCES FIRST TO MAKE THE MOST
IMMEDIATE DIFFERENCE AND THAT
WOULD BE SO THE SECONDARY?
ISSUE THAT THEY CAN HELP WITH.
I THINK AND THE NEXT THING THAT
THEY CAN HELP WITH WAS HR
IMPLEMENTATION.
SO WHAT IS YOUR AGE ARE
IMPLEMENTATION STRATEGY FOR
SURGES ONCE YOU KNOW WHAT YOUR
CUSTOMER FLOW TIME IS A MUCH
INCREASED TIMAEUS.
AND WHAT IS YOUR WHAT IS YOUR
ROLE OUT FOR ONLINE SERVICES
THAT A RETIEF.
WHAT'S ROUTINE WHAT'S EMERGENCY
AND WHAT HAS TO BE DONE BY YOU.
AND DO HAVE A DESPERATE THAT CAN
YOU SHARE THAT WITH US IF YOU
CAN THAT WOULD BE I THINK
HELPFUL WE MIGHT EVEN WANT TO
HAVE A SPECIAL SESSION AND MOVE
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES. TO HELP
YOU.
BUT COMING IN AND SAYING.
WELL WE A LOT MORE WORK FROM
EVERYBODY BECAUSE MONEY BUT WE
DON'T REALLY KNOW WHERE.
EXACTLY WENT.
WE DON'T REALLY KNOW THE
MAGNITUDE SYSTEM WIDE OF THE
PROBLEM.
AND WE'RE JUST GONNA KEEP LIKE
WORKING OUT SERVICING CUSTOMERS
AND BEST PRACTICES.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HELP ANY OF
US EVEN THOUGH IT'S WELL
INTENDED AND THAT'S PROBABLY ALL
YOU CAN DO WITHOUT WATER
RESOURCES AND WITHOUT US HAVING
A BETTER PICTURE.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST I THINK YOU
NEED -- TO
LET US KNOW WHAT THE EMERGENCY
SERVICES NEEDS ARE BECAUSE
THAT'S THAT THAT'S GONNA GET IN.
THAT'S IT IS EVERYWHERE AND
THOSE ARE PARTICULARLY
TRAVELLERS WHO LOSE THEIR
DRIVER'S LICENSE THOSE KINDS OF
PEOPLE.
WHO ABSOLUTELY ARE STRANDED
SOMEWHERE NOW THEY CANNOT GO TO
THAT DIEM THE AWAY FIVE HOURS?
SO I THINK THE AUDITOR COULD
HELP US GAIN INSIGHT INTO THAT
IF WE MOVE FORWARD QUICKLY AND
MAYBE WE COULD SOLVE THE PROBLEM
OF ROLLING OUT RESOURCES BETTER.
IF WE UNDERSTOOD THIS SYSTEM IS
OVERBURDENED IN WHAT WAYS AND
WHAT SPECIFIC.
THE CIVIC HAPPENINGS LAST BUT
NOT LEAST --
HAVE YOU A DOZEN SOUND LIKE YOU
HAVE BUT HAVE YOU CONSIDERED
CONTRACTING MORE THE SERVICES
OUT WITH PRIVATE BUSINESSES.
SUCH AS STRIP PLAYER SOMEONE
ELSE YOU ALREADY HAVE A LINK TO
THAT DID THAT DOESN'T REQUIRE
TOO MUCH MORE WORK WITH WHAT.
I HAVE YOU PUT THAT ON THE
WEBSITE OR HAVE YOU DONE AN
OUTREACH TO THE PUBLIC TO LET
PUBLIC NOW HERE'S A PLACE YOU
CAN BE DIVERTED.
TO YES SO WE WE DO HAVE A
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR AUTO CLUB
AND A WE HAVE A SELF SERVICE
TERMINALS IN A FIELD OFFICE IN
RETAIL LOCATIONS SO WE DO.
AND WE HAVE REGISTRATION
SERVICES WE DO COMMUNICATE THAT
OUT TO THE CUSTOMERS THAT THEY
HAVE ALTERNATIVE SERVICES YOU
CAN DO A TRANSACTIONS ONLINE WE
DO COMMUNICATE DATA.
HOW DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE TURNING AWAY AND THE AVERAGE
FOR NOT COMPLETE PAPERWORK?
A WEEK I DON'T HAVE ANY WILL BE
COLLECTING THAT WITH OUR TRIAGE
SO WE ARE NOT THAT'S THE DATA
THAT WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO COLLECT
OTHER OLD AUDIT INFORMATION YOU
NEED.
NEEDED UP BECAUSE BECAUSE THOSE
ARE EVEN COUNTED IN.
THE PEOPLE LIKE COMING BACK TO A
THREE AND FIVE TIMES AWAITING
FELINE.
THOSE ARE THOSE ARE EVEN
CONSIDERED ACTUALLY A DIFFERENT
PROBLEM.
WHICH IS JUST HOW TO EDUCATE THE
PUBLIC.
AND HOW TO ROLL OUT MORE ON YOUR
WEBSITE AND OUT REACHES THROUGH
WHAT LIKE AIRPORTS OR WHATEVER
YOU CAN HAVE THINGS THAT ARE
CITIES WE WHATEVER.
WE DO HAVE SIGNAGE AT AIRPORTS
WE HAVE VIDEOS PLAYING THAT DONE
SIX AIRPORTS WHERE YOU'RE IN
LINE SIX AND CAN'T YEAR IN LINE
TO GET YOUR TIAS SAY.
THAT JACK WE DO HAVE A VIDEO
THERE A WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
SOCIAL MEDIA WE'VE DONE AND
NEWSPAPER ADS WE'VE DONE WE
CONTINUE TO DO THAT WE CONTINUE
TO PUT HER ARTICLES ON IN THE
DAY.
WHEN YOU COME BACK TO US YES
DEMO OR ELSE WHY DON'T YOU WITH
A?
WE HAVE THIS MANY PLACES SOLVED
AND THIS MANY PLACES STILL
PROBLEM AT THESE TYPES OF THE
DAY AND THIS IS THE ROLL OUT
PLAN AND THAT WOULD BE WONDERFUL
BUT THAT'S A HUGE HUGE TASK
YOU'RE GOING TO NEED SOME HELP
WITH BINGE PARKING IN A I A
HURRY I THINK.
SO I'M GOING TO BE ASKING US TO
CONSIDER THIS A SYSTEM WIDE
FAILURE.
AND TRYING TO SPEED UP THE DATA
COLLECTION FOR YOU THROUGH THE
AUDIT PROCESS --
SO THAT WE CAN THEN HAVE
EVIDENCE TO ROLL OUT HELPED YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
ETCETERA DID YOU WANNA FOLLOW UP
BILL I THINK YOU OKAY CHO
[inaudible]
OKAY -- NOW
IS THE TIME FOR A PUBLIC COMMENT --
WOULD LIKE TO ASK A INDIVIDUALS
I EXPECT THERE MAY BE SOME
STRONG.
THE FEELINGS HERE BUT THAT WE
ASK COMMENTS TO BE LIMITED TO
ONE MINUTE EACH.
HELLO I'M LIST THEM KEY AND I'M
IN IRAN AND A FORTY EIGHT YEARS.
AND I CURRENTLY WORK WITH
SEVERAL ATTORNEYS IN FRESNO --
AND I CARE COORDINATE FOR THEIR
MEDICALLY COMPLEX PATIENTS OR
CLIENTS.
AND ONE SUCH CLIENT I HAVE IS A
FIFTY EIGHT YEAR OLD --
MALE WITH SCHIZOPHRENIA AND
ISN'T STAGE FOR PROSTATE CANCER --
HE CALLED ME AND WAS DESPERATE
BECAUSE HE GOT MUGGED IN THE
PARK [inaudible]
HE IS.
TEETERING BETWEEN BEING HOMELESS
AND IN A BOARDING HOME.
BOASTS A TIME.
AND A HE CALLED ME AND HE WAS
VERY VERY DESPERATE BECAUSE HE
DID GET MUGGED.
AND SWAY LOST IS ID AND HIS ATM
CARD.
AND HE COULDN'T GET HIS ATM CARD
REPLACED WITHOUT [inaudible]
AND ID SO I SAID OKAY I'LL CLEAR
MY SCHEDULE WILL I TAKE YOU TO
THE DMV TOMORROW MORNING WILL BE
THERE BRIGHT [inaudible]
LAKE.
AND WE SHOWED UP AT TEN O'CLOCK
TO A LINE OF ABOUT MOVE.
OR FORTY IT TOOK US TWO HOURS TO
GET TO THE MAIN DESK WHERE WE
GOT OUR NUMBER.
AND THEN IT TOOK US AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR HOURS BEFORE WE
GOT HIS COPY OF HIS ID.
MA'AM I'M GONNA ASK YOU TO TRY
TO WRAP.
AND THAT WILL BE THAT SAID ABOUT
IT.
IN THAT TIME WITH THE STAGE FOR
PROSTATE CANCER WE HAD MANY
BATHROOM BREAKS.
SO IT WAS UP AND DOWN AND TRIED
KEEP A SCHIZOPHRENIC.
IS LIKE KEEPING A THREE YEAR OLD
YOU KNOW IN CONTROL SO.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT IT WAS A
HUGE ISSUE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DENNIS
MONTALBANO I AM A USED CAR
DEALER.
OKAY THAT GUY THAT EVERYBODY
SAYS THE HATE --
THAT.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE A CUSTOMER
THAT NEEDS A DRIVER'S LICENSE
RENEWED OR RELY DEAR WHATEVER.
YOU GO TO THE DMV MAYBE ONCE HE
HERE.
BUT AS A CAR DEALER I HAVE TO GO
THERE MULTIPLE TIMES.
SO ALL THESE ISSUES THAT YOU
GUYS ARE HEARING.
TIMES IT BY TENER TWENTY AND
YOU'LL SEE WHAT WE ARE DEALING.
WE USED TO HAVE AN E. TICKET.
WHO IS AN INDUSTRY TICKET?
WE DON'T GET THOSE ANYMORE.
SO NOW WE HAVE TO SIGN IN.
AND NOW WE WAIT.
I CAN'T GET AN APPOINTMENT.
BECAUSE DEALER POINT MINTZER
LIKE THREE MONTHS OUT.
I HAVE TEN DAYS. TO POST FEES
ARE AND FUNNY.
WHEN YOU WALK IN THE DOOR
[inaudible]
IT'S LIKE YOU WALKED IN AS THE
RELATIVE EVERYONE HATES WHEN
YOU'RE WALKING IS A DEALER THEY
ASK YOU TO SIGN IN.
WHEN YOU SIGN IN?
YOU GO INTO THE ABYSS.
YOU MAY WAIT THERE FOR FOUR
HOURS [inaudible]
AND THEY ONLY HAVE ONE OR TWO
PEOPLE THAT TO DEALERS.
IN FRESNO WHERE I'M FROM MICROBE
FROM PRESENT TODAY BECAUSE I'M
VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS IF
YOU CAN'T TELL [inaudible]
BUT THERE'S THREE DANBY'S IN THE
FRESNO AREA.
THE NEWEST ONE ON ALL OF AB AND
YOU.
DOESN'T DO DEALERS.
THE CLOVIS ONE WAS JUST REMODEL
IT WAS CLOSED SO WE HAD ONE DMV
TO GO.
TO THEY TOOK OR EAT TICKETS AWAY
AND THEY GAVE INTO UNDOCUMENTED
DRIVER'S LICENSE APPLICATION.
AND NOW THEY'VE ADDED REAL ID.
I GOT MY REAL ID IT TOOK FIVE
MINUTES IT WAS EASY SIR AND ASK
YOU TO WRAP UP.
I THINK WE HAVEN'T ADDRESSED THE
INDUSTRY.
THE PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY BRING
YOU MONEY.
THAT THE ONLY REASON I GO THERE
IS TO BRING YOUR REGISTRATION.
AND WE'RE BEING TOTALLY
[inaudible]
ABUSED.
THANK YOU ABUSES THAT WHAT WE
SEE THE INDUSTRY WHAT DO YOU
MEAN WHAT RESENTMENT THE CAR
INDUSTRY TO PEOPLE THAT SELL
CARS WE HAPPEN TO BRING YOU THE
TRANSFER PAPERS.
BUT WE BRING YOU'VE REGISTRATION
MONEY.
ALRIGHT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
ENGAGE IN THE WEIGHT WE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME HERE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
HI.
MY NAME IS MARIAM EXAM I WORK A
DAY IN FEE FOR TWENTY YEARS.
AND I WORKING THE FIELD OFFICE
AND OPERATION AND I KNOW IT
FAIRLY WELL.
AND YOU DEFINITELY NEED AN AUDIT
FOR YOUR CONSTITUENT FOR THE
TAXPAYERS MONEY YOU NEED AND NOT.
A GOOD BUSINESS SPROUT OF TO
HAVE ANOTHER THAT YOU SAW HOW
WOULD YOU SPEND THE TAXPAYERS
MONEY.
AND NOT THE TO REVIEW IN
OVERRODE UNIT WHAT I WAS USED TO
WORK WITH US SO MANY MILLION TO
ASK.
THE TO GET STATE OF THE ART
SCANNERS OKAY.
IT'S LIKE GETTING A BRAND NEW
CADILLAC SAID OF GETTING ONE
DRIVERS TO DRIVE TO AUTOMATIC
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO HAVE 15%
PUSHING THE PROJECT WITH THE
BRICKS ON PUFF PUFF OF THE 15%
OUT HANDICAP OR CANNOT WHICH
FIFTY FIVE OTHER SITTING
CHEATING BLUES OTHER.
FIVE WAS THE CAR THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENS AT THE DE SITE AND TALK
TO US AND SEEN SIDE.
THIS IMPLEMENTATION WE HAD EIGHT
TO TEN MILLION BACKUP AND MISS
SURVIVOR DID THE DIRECTOR WHO
HIRED MISSUS YOU MORTAL WAS
BREEZY AND AND I HAVE ORDERED
THE COMMITTEES EVERYTHING IS THE
CONNECTED AND SEE.
WAS PRESENT DIFFERENT IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS SEEING HOW HOW GOOD IT
IS EXCESSIVE PLUS SO YES WE NEED
WE NEED THE AUDIT. TO COME TO
TALK TO US TO DECIDE BECAUSE
THERE ARE MANY OTHERS LIKE ME
WHO WAS THEN RESTORES YOUR HEAD
WAS STAND ON YOUR HEAD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT --
CLOSING COMMENTS FROM THE
REQUESTING [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
BUT WAS CHARMED ME MEMBERS UP
PUSH YOUR TIME YOUR PATIENCE.
I AM NOT CONVINCED THAT RIGHT
NOW WE TRULY DO KNOW WHAT THE
ANSWERS ARE TO SOLVE THIS
DILEMMA.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE DMV HAS
RIGHT NOW THE CAPABILITIES TO
SOLVE ALL THE ISSUES THAT ARE
BEFORE THEM.
WE GIVE YOU SEVENTY BILLION
DOLLARS LAST YEAR AND YET THE
WAIT TIMES ARE LONGER THAN EVER
I BELIEVE THIS AUDIT IS A DROP
IN THE BUCKET. FOR THE RIGHT
DIRECTION NO PURPOSE THE ART IS
NOT THE POINT FIGURES IS NOT TO
LAY BLAME.
IN THIS SITUATION THE PURPOSE OF
AN AUDIT IS TO BRING IT
INDEPENDENT.
OBJECTIVE OUTSIDE ENTITY. TO
BRING THEIR EXPERTISE THEIR
RESOURCES AND THEIR GUIDANCE TO
HELP SOLVE [inaudible]
THIS ISSUE.
WHEN THERE'S ONLY ONE PLACE TO
GO TO GET YOUR DRIVER'S LICENSE
AND YOUR REAL WHY DO YOU USE?
AND BOTH OF COURSE OF GOVERNMENT
MANDATES THE GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO
DO BETTER.
YOU MUST YOU BETTER.
BUT ALSO WE NEED FOR
CALIFORNIANS LIKE AVAILABLE
CUSTOMERS THAT YOU DESERVE.
WE CAN AND WE MUST DO BETTER
ARMS WITHOUT I WILL.
EFFORTS TO MIND MY COLLEAGUE FOR
HIS COMMENTS.
THANK YOU I'M MEMBERS I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE --
THE TIME A THAT YOU SPENT IN
THIS I DID JUST RISK WITH
RESPECT. TO THE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE ABOUT THE AUDIT NOT.
WHAT DO WE KNOW WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A FIRST RATE AUDITOR?
WE KNOW THE HISTORY THAT WHEN WE
HAND OFF THIS KIND OF NOT
RESPONSIBILITY IT IS DONE DONE
EXCEEDINGLY WELL AND THE FRUITS
OF THAT EFFORT WE SEE.
TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
AND WHETHER YOU CONSIDER A THE
DMV TO BE.
A COMPETENT AND CANNED SELF
CORRECT OR WHETHER YOU THINK OF
AS MANY CALIFORNIANS DO THAT
THEY'VE LOST.
CONFIDENCE IN THE D. M. V..
IT IS A TOOL THAT IS VITALLY
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO IDENTIFY
AND FIX THE PROBLEM.
ADD YOU HAVE HEARD THE UP
WILLINGNESS OF THE AUDITOR TO
CUT THE TIME TO MAKE IT VERY
VERY --
QUICKLY IN TIME RESPONSIVE AND I
ALSO THAT WOULD BE REMISS IF WE
DIDN'T SAY THERE ARE SOME.
A MUCH BIGGER AUDIENCE WATCHING.
THEN JUST US IN THIS ROOM.
THAT THESE ARE THE LITERALLY
TENS UPON THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT IT HAD THE DIFFICULTY THAT
HAS BEEN EXPRESSED HERE.
HELLO.
CAN BE ON THE WAY.
AND WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THE CONFIDENCE IN THE TRUST.
THAT THE AUDITOR KNOWS WHAT
SHE'S DOING AND WILL PROVIDE IN
A QUICK PERIOD OF TIME.
THE NECESSARY PATHWAY TO FIX
THIS.
WE DO NEED TO HAVE MORE TIME IN
THIS BECAUSE THIS HAS BEEN A
SYSTEMIC PROBLEM FOR A LONG LONG
TIME.
SO LET'S GIVE THE AUDITOR THE
GREEN LIGHT.
AND I THINK WE WILL GET TO A
GREEN LIGHT AT THE WAITING LINES
MUCH MUCH QUICKER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IDEA.
OF BEFORE I CALL FOR THE VOTE --
MOTION'S BEEN MADE BY MR COSTA
SECOND BY MS BAKER.
I WOULD LIKE SAY THAT --
YOU KNOW I RESERVED MY
RECOMMENDATION --
FOR THIS REQUEST UNTIL --
AFTER HEARING UPON HEARING FROM --
ALL OF THE STAKE HOLDERS AS WELL
AS FROM MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT TO HAVE MADE THE EFFORT.
TO COME TO THE HEARING --
I AM CONVINCED THAT --
THAT'S THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WOULD BENEFIT FROM HAVING AUDIT --
THERE'S NO STATE AGENCY THAT
TOUCHES THE LIVES OF MORE
CALIFORNIANS AND THE DMV.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS WEIGHED IN ON THIS AND THAT --
THERE ARE CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER
AN AUDIT AT THIS TIME.
WHAT HELP OR HINDER WITH IT THE?
ONGOING --
PROGRESS --
THAT THE DMV IS MAKING IN
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE.
A HOWEVER AS MISTER OBERNOLTE
INDICATED EARLIER --
AUDITS ARE NOT NECESSARILY
PUNITIVE THEY CAN BE HELPFUL.
AND I THINK.
THE DMV AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NEEDS ALL THE HELP
THAT WE CAN GET --
AND SHORTENING THEIR WAIT TIMES
[inaudible] FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND FOR THAT REASON
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS AUDIT.
THAT MADAM SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
RURAL CALM TO APPROVE AUTO
CUSTOMER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
DASH ONE THREE ZERO ALL
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLE
FAIRLIGHT DE IMPLEMENTATION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN.
CHAIRS RECOMMENDATIONS AND I
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MERE CT.
WHERE SU CHI I?
ACOSTA AYE AYE ACOSTA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I NAZARIAN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO AYE [inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
SENATOR ROTH.
ROTH AYE ALLEN.
AND WE'RE NOT VOTING BELL.
THOUGH NOT VOTING CANNELLA.
CANNELLA AYE FULLER.
FULLER AYE LARA.
ALRIGHT BILL IS ON OR THE
REQUEST HIS UNCLE.
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU MISTER.
FOR THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT MEANS THAT --
WE WILL AWAIT --
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WHO
ARE CURRENTLY NOT PRESIDENT --
TO ADD ONTO THEIR VOTES.
ALRIGHT WHO'S NEXT ETCETERA
STONE YOU'VE BEEN VERY PATIENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
.
IT'S THIS IS ITEM TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THAT'S ONE TWENTY FOUR
THE GOLD COAST [inaudible]
HEALTH PLAN.
SENATOR THANK YOU --
HONORABLE CHAIR HONORABLE
MEMBERS --
MADAME AUDITOR I SEE YOU SEE I I
JUST WANNA BEFORE I START MY
PRESENTATION JUST WANT TO
APPLAUD YOU ALL FOR THE THE VERY
HARD WORK THAT YOU DO IN DIVING
INTO THE THE WEEDS OF THESE VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUES AND I HAVE TO
SAY I'M.
I'M VERY IMPRESSED WITH THE HOW
YOU ALL WORK TOGETHER TODAY.
BUT TODAY WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF
BY MY COLLEAGUE OUR COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOP COSTA.
I ASK YOU TO APPROVE THE AUDIT
OF THE GOLD COAST HEALTHCARE
PLAN IN VENTURA COUNTY.
THE REASON I ASK FOR THIS IS
REALLY QUITE SIMPLE THIS COUNTY
RUN HEALTHCARE PLAN IS PUTTING
INDEPENDENT PHARMACIES IN VENDOR
ARE IMPOTENT MENTOR COUNTY.
AT RISK OF BANKRUPTCY AND
SEVERAL AND ALREADY BEEN FORCED
TO CLOSE DOWN.
MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES AND ENTER
A COUNTY DESERVE BETTER AND THE
ACTIONS OF THE GOLD COAST HEALTH
CARE DESERVE THE SCRUTINY.
OF AN AUDIT TO FIND OUT IF THEIR
DECISIONS HAVE BEEN.
THE BEST FOR THOSE THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE SERVING.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE THE VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
VOTED TO CREATE GC HP AS A
COUNTY ORGANIZE HEALTH.
SYSTEMS MODEL.
AFTER BEGINNING SERVICE IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THEY WERE FLAG
BY THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR SOME
FISCAL INEFFICIENCIES.
SO THEY CHOSE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN TO PUT OUT A REQUEST FOR
A NEW PHARMACY BENEFIT MANAGER
WERE AS WE COMMONLY REFER TO
THEM AS P. B. M.'S.
WHICH WAS AWARDED TO A COMPANY
CALLED OPTUM OUR ACTS.
THIS IS THE POINT THAT
PHARMACIES BEGAN TO EXPERIENCE
SERIOUS PROBLEMS WITH
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR GENERIC AND
BRAND NAME DRUGS THAT THEY WERE
PROVIDING TO THEIR MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES.
THE LARGEST PROBLEM FOR
PHARMACIES HAS BEEN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CLAW BACKS OF
THIS IS WHEN THE PBM DEMANDS
REFUNDS --
FOR REIMBURSEMENT SET OF ALREADY
BEEN PROVIDED TO PHARMACIES AT
AND THEY CLAIM IT WAS DUE TO
ALLEGE CODING ERRORS BY THE
PHARMACY BENEFIT MANAGERS.
THIS IS BECAUSE MANY INDEPENDENT
PHARMACIES TO GET BACK PAYMENTS
THAT WERE IN THEIR MINDS ARE
READY BELOW THE COST OF THE
DRUGS THAT THEY HAVE PROVIDED.
MANY OF THESE FARMERS HIS
BELIEVE THEY CANNOT SURVIVE OF
THIS PATTERN ON A UNDER
REIMBURSEMENT AND SUBSEQUENT
CLAW BACKS [inaudible]
HAWKE CONTINUES.
I RESPECTFULLY OF US ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO AUTHORIZE AN AUDIT
TO SEE IF GOAL BECAUSE HEALTH
CARE FOLLOWED PROPER PROCEDURES.
WHEN BRINGING ON THEIR NEW PBM
TO EVALUATE WHETHER GOAL COAST
POLICIES FOR ESTABLISHING
REIMBURSEMENT RATES ARE?
REASONABLE AND APPROPRIATE AND
TO ASSESS WHETHER THE STATE'S
OVERSIGHT OF THIS PROCESS.
IS ADEQUATE INAPPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
REQUEST IN AT THE APPROPRIATE%
TIME I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE SOME
MY WITNESS DANIEL MARTINEZ FROM
THE CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION WHO'S IN SUPPORT OF
THIS REQUEST.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND BEFORE YOU
GO ANY FURTHER I BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE A BIPARTISAN RECOMMENDATION
IN SUPPORT OF YOUR I REQUEST.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
ARE KEPT UP BE BRIEF UP MY NAME
IS JENNY MARTINEZ A I WORK FOR
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION.
I LIKED HIM REMIND FOLKS DE AND
TO KEEP IN MIND THAT YOU KNOW
FIRST AND FOREMOST AT THEIR REAL
PEOPLE BEING IMPACTED UP UP BY
THIS CLUB BACK TO SENATOR STONE
MANSION --
SEVERAL PHARMACISTS HAVE
INFORMED OUR SITUATION THAT
THEY'RE ON THE VERGE OF GOING
OUT OF BUSINESS OR THAT THEY ARE
ALREADY OUT OF BUSINESS ONE
PHARMACIST I SPOKE TO RECENTLY
INFORMED US THAT SHE HAD TO TAKE
OUT A FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR PERSONAL LOAN.
JUST FOR PAYROLL OVERHEAD AND
HER HER DOORS OPEN UP I'M SAD TO
REPORT SHE DID NOT SHE WAS NOT
ABLE TO KEEP OUR DOORS OPEN AND
THAT PHARMACY HAS CLOSED.
ANOTHER PHARMACISTS I'VE SPOKEN
TO A HOW TO STOP TAKES STOP
TAKING A SALARY SHE USED UPPER
SAVINGS SHE SOLD HER CAR.
SHE PER HOUSE ON THE MARKET ALL
JUST TO KEEP THE PHARMACY OPEN
RIGHT NOW I'M I'M HAPPY TO SAY
IT'S IT'S OPEN BUT IT'S ON THE
VERY LAST STRING.
BEFORE IT CLOSES --
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH LONGER
THAT PHARMACIES GOING TO LAST.
NONE OF THIS WAS REALLY A
PROBLEM PRIOR TO OP TOMORROW XP
COMING THE PBM BACK IN JUNE
FIRST.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN BOMB AND THERE
WERE SOME CONTROVERSIES
SURROUNDING A THIS THIS PBM
BEING IMPLEMENTED AND THAT TIME.
ON DURING THE HEARING WHICH
DECIDED THE NEW PBM THERE WERE
THREE FINALISTS THAT WERE SCORED
UP ACCORDING TO WHAT WHAT WAS
THE NECESSARY --
SCORING THAT THAT THAT THEY
PLANNED NEEDED AND AUTUMN ENDED
UP SCORING LOWEST UP OF THE
THREE FINALISTS AND YET WERE
SELECTED.
AND SO --
THIS DESPITE THE OBJECTIONS OF
SEVERAL INDEPENDENT PHARMACIES
AND OTHER THE OTHER FINALISTS AS
WELL.
UP IN IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WAS WHEN WE WERE FIRST
CONTACTED ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
AND DURING THAT THIS TIME WE HAD
FIRST OUR FOLKS TO GO TO THESE
COMMISSION MEETINGS THAT OVERSEE
THE PLAN. TO VOICE THEIR OF
CONCERNS BECAUSE THESE CALLBACKS
RESTORED TO TAKE PLACE ALONG
WITH THE NEGATIVE REIMBURSEMENTS.
ON THAT WERE PLUMMETING AS SOON
AS THIS PBM STARTED TAKING OVER --
I'VE BEEN GOING TO THESE
COMMISSION MEETINGS PERSONALLY
SINCE DECEMBER OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BECAUSE THE ISSUE WAS
NOT GETTING ANY BETTER.
TOM WE HAD.
COMMUNICATED TO THE PLAN AT THAT
TIME THAT THERE IS A PROBLEM
THAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED
PHARMACIES WERE IN DANGER OF
CLOSING.
AND AS YOU ALL KNOW.
UP WHEN PHARMACIES CLOSE ACCESS
TO CARE FOR PATIENTS BECOMES A
PROBLEM.
AND IT IS IMPORTANT NOTE THE
GOLD COAST ONLY SERVES MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES.
AND WHEN THEY CAN'T.
WHEN THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
MINUTES NOT ONLY DO THEY?
HAVE.
PROBLEM MEDICAL PROBLEMS BUT
COSTA COUNTY'S RISE WHICH MEANS
COST THE STATE RISES AS WELL
[inaudible]
SO -- WITH
THAT OUT OF JUST THE TRIP OVER
TO TO THE STATE ON THE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARE S.
CENTERED STONE INDICATED THIS IS
AN AUDIT ESSENTIALLY OF GOLD
COAST.
UP BUT WE WOULD BE LOOKING AT
ANY STATE AGENCIES THAT ARE
RESPONSIBLE TYPICALLY HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AND WHAT THEIR
OVERSIGHT ROLE IS WITH ESPECT
TO MANAGED CARE ENTITIES --
BUT CLEARLY TO AN IMPORTANT
OBJECTIVE THAT THE SENATOR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAVE ASKED US TO
LOOK AT IS THE WHOLE ARE OF
PEOPLE PROCESS THAT WAS USED.
IN DETERMINING AND SELECTING
OPTIM OUR ACTS AS THE AS THE PBM
ARE IN THIS PARTICULAR REGION
AND SPECIFICALLY LOOKING AT
DETERMINING WHETHER NOT GOLD
COAST EXECUTED THE CONTRACT IN
THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE
CONSTITUENTS.
ARE AND THE PHARMACIES ABOUT
BOTH THE BENEFICIARIES IN THE
PHARMACIES IN THE REGION AND
WHEN THE INFORMATION WAS
PRESENTED TO THE COMMISSION AND
VENTURA COUNTY THEIR MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE COMMISSION.
WAS IT A FULL DISCLOSURE --
OF INFORMATION OUT WHEN THEY
WERE DETERMINING HOW HOW TO VOTE
ON THAT PARTICULAR CONTRACTS
REALLY WANTING THE MEMBERS
WANTING TO UNDERSTAND WAS
ACCURATE RELEVANT ROBUST
INFORMATION PROVIDED TO THE
COMMISSION SO WE WOULD LOOK FOR
THAT.
AND THEN WITH RESPECT TO THE
OPERATIONS WHETHER NOT GOLD
COAST IS REALLY PROVIDING
SUFFICIENT OVERSIGHT OVER THE
PBM TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT PBM
IS.
FOLLOWING LAWS REGULATIONS
POLICIES KING AT REIMBURSEMENT
RATES -- AND
THEY'RE ASKING US TO DO A
COMPARISON --
FOR FOR THE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
FOR THAT GOLD CHO SIN OFF THE
MAREK'S PROVIDE --
COMPARE THAT TO SOME OTHER
MANAGED CARE AND SOME OTHER PBM
SITS IN CALIFORNIA AND SEE IF
THERE ARE DIFFERENCES AND WHY
ARE THERE THOSE DIFFERENCES.
ARM AND THEN ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT REALLY LOOKING AT GOLD
COAST PRACTICES AND OUR
PROCEDURES FOR ESTABLISHING WHAT
THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE SHOULD BE.
DETERMINING WHETHER OR NOT THOSE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES ARE
REASONABLE AND IF NOT WHAT STEPS
DO THEY TAKE TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES.
THE BUDGET FOR THE AUDITOR
AROUND TWO THOUSAND HOURS ALL
THIS WOULD TAKE ONE TEAM ABOUT
FIVE MONTHS TO COMPLETE THE
FIELD WORK.
GET THE AUDIT DONE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
A WOULD LIKE TO NOW INVITE.
TO IN REPRESENTS FROM THE GOLD
COAST AND HEALTH PLAN COMPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
TRANSMITTAL THAT'LL SINGULAR
ROPES AND SMITH WE REPRESENT THE
GOLD COAST HEALTH PLAN AND WE
HAVE WITH YOU TODAY.
A DOCTOR ANY FREEZES THE
PHARMACY MANAGER WITH GOLD COAST
THAT CAN PROVIDE SOME SOME
HISTORY OF OF THIS LONG ISSUE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS.
I AM DOCTOR IN FREEZE A
PHARMACIST AND THE DIRECTOR OF
GOLD COAST HEALTH PLAN THE STATE
FUNDED PUBLIC AGENCY.
SERVING MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES
IN VENTURA COUNTY.
THE PLAN APPRECIATES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE AND THE ON IT REQUEST.
THIS AUDIT REQUEST ADDRESSES
FIRST THE SELECTION OF THE PLANS
PHARMACY BENEFIT MANAGER OR PBM.
SECOND PHARMACY REIMBURSEMENT
RATES.
AND THIRD RECRUITMENTS DESCRIBED
AS CLAW BACKS.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE PLAN
CONDUCTED A THOROUGH PUBLIC PVM
PROCUREMENT PROCESS.
CULMINATING IN THE PLANS
GOVERNING COMMISSION SELECTION
ADOPTED MAREK'S.
SHORTLY AFTER THE INCOME IT PBM
SUED THE COMMISSION OVER AT
SELECTION PROCESS.
THE COURT DENIED THE PETITION IN
ITS ENTIRETY.
OTHER BIDDERS DID NOT SHOWING
THE LAWSUIT.
NOR WAS THE RULING APPEALED.
WE BELIEVE THAT AN AUDIT WOULD
REVIEW MATTERS PREVIOUSLY
REVIEWED BY THE BY THE COURT.
THE SECOND AREA OF FOCUS IS THE
PHARMACY REIMBURSEMENT RATES DUE
TO THE CONCERN OF INDEPENDENT
PHARMACIES ABOUT RATES.
PLAN HIRED AN INDEPENDENT
EXTERNAL CONSULTANT TO CONDUCT A
MARKET RATE ANALYSIS COMPARING
CURRENT RATES PRIOR RATES AND
INDUSTRY AVERAGES.
THE ANALYSIS SHOWED THAT THE
RATES ARE WITHIN MARKET FOR A
MEDICAID MANAGED CARE PLAN.
IN CALIFORNIA AND NATIONWIDE.
THE FINAL AREA OF FOCUS IS THE
RECRUITMENT SUPERCLUB BACKS.
IN ITS FIRST YEAR OF SERVICE OP
TAMARA ACTS MADE SEVERAL PRICING
ERRORS RESULTING IN OVERPAYMENTS
TO PHARMACIES.
A PLAN IS REQUIRED BY LAW TO
RECOUP FUNDS OVERPAID TO
PROVIDERS.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
INDEPENDENT PHARMACIES RECENTLY
FILED A LAWSUIT AGAINST NOT ONLY
UP TO MORE ACTS BUT ALSO THEIR
CONTRACTING AGENTS.
WE'RE FOLLOWING THE PROGRESS OF
THE SUIT CLOSELY AS PART OF THE
REGULAR MONITORING OF OUR
PHARMACY NETWORK.
OF UP MOST IMPORTANT.
OF UTMOST IMPORTANCE TO THE PLAN
IS OUR COMMITMENT TO OUR MEMBERS
AND ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE
ACCESS. TO PHARMACY SERVICES.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT NO
MEMBERS HAVE REPORTED ANY ACCESS
ISSUES [inaudible]
IN SUMMARY.
THE COURT UPHELD THE PLANS
PROCUREMENT PROCESS.
AN INDEPENDENT RATE ANALYSIS
CONCLUDED THAT THE RATES ARE
WITHIN MARKET.
THE OVERPAYMENTS WERE RECOUPED
AS REQUIRED.
IN LIGHT OF THESE ACTIVITIES IN
THE NEW LITIGATION BROUGHT BY
THE INDEPENDENT PHARMACIES.
OUR POSITION IS THAT THIS AUDIT
WILL REVIEW MATTERS PREVIOUSLY
INDEPENDENTLY REVIEWED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I ALSO WANTED --
TO EXTEND THE OPPORTUNITY TO REP
CENTER FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES IF THEY
WOULD LIKE.
TO PLEASED TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS
IF NOT.
IT'S UP TO YOU.
OKAY AS A OKAY.
ALL RIGHT --
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE MS
RUBIO.
YES THE THE MY BIGGEST CONCERN
IS THAT THERE IS PENDING
LITIGATION AND THAT'S WHAT IT
WAS -- THE
REASON I PULLED IT OFF CONSENT
IS I WANTED TO JUST CHECK WHAT
THE AUDITOR IN TERMS OF
LITIGATION BECAUSE I KNOW WE'VE
HAD.
OUR PREVIOUS REQUEST THAT WERE
BEING LITIGATED AND HOW DO WE
CONTINUE WITH THAT.
SO UNDER OUR STANDARDS I'M
HAVING MY CHIEF COUNSEL COME UP
AND TALK --
OFFICIAL DO A BETTER JOB THAN I
BUT UNDER OUR AUDIT STANDARDS.
WE ARE WE ARE PRECLUDED FROM
CONDUCTING ARTWORK THAT WE
DETERMINE WHAT INTERFERE WITH AN
ONGOING ONGOING LITIGATION OR
INVESTIGATION SO WE WOULD MAKE
SURE THAT WHEN WHERE.
AND WHY HAVE AN ATTORNEY
ASSIGNED EVERY AUDIT WHEN
THEY'RE WORKING WITH THE AUDIT
TEAM THAT WERE NOT STEPPING INTO
AN AREA THAT WOULD POTENTIALLY
INTERFERE WITH THE LITIGATION
THEM NOW.
STEPPING EARNERS RIDGEWAY CHIEF
COUNSEL FOR THE STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE GOOD MORNING A WE HAVE
NOT SEEN THE LITIGATION QUESTION
IT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S A SUPERIOR
COURT MATTER WHICH IS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US TO OBTAIN AT
THE EARLY PORTION OF OUR
RESEARCH ON THESE AUDIT REQUESTS.
I'M TO THE EXTENT THAT THAT WE
WOULD IDENTIFY ISSUES OF OVERLAP
BETWEEN THE AUDIT REQUEST AND
THE LITIGATION.
AS THE STATE AUDITOR HAS
INDICATED WE WOULD ENDEAVOR TO
SCOPE AROUND THOSE ISSUES IN
OTHER WORDS PERHAPS SELECT A
DIFFERENT PROVIDER SELECT
DIFFERENT BLOOM MEDICATIONS THAT
ARE THOSE THAT ARE.
AT ISSUE IN THE LITIGATION.
AND WE DO HAVE LIMITATIONS AS
THE STATE ARE INDICATED IN TERMS
OF OUR ABILITY TO REPORT ON
MATTERS AS WELL IF THEY IN FACT
WOULD INTERFERE WITH THE ONGOING
LITIGATION AND THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE WOULD WORK.
WITH THE AUDIT T. AS WE WENT
THROUGH THE COURSE OF THE AUDIT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE NOT
DOING ANYTHING TO JEOPARDIZE
EITHER PARTY'S RIGHTS IN THAT
PROCESS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MS BAKER IF YOU AYE AND I HAVE
THAT SAME QUESTION I WON SKILL
BUT MORE SPECIFIC --
THE SCOPE OF DISCOVERY.
IN THE OTHER MATTER IS DECIDED
BY A JUDGE AND HOW THE PARTIES
GO BACK AND FORTH BEFORE A JUDGE
ON WHAT CAN BE DISCLOSED TO THE
OTHER SIDE WHAT IS PRIVILEGED
WHAT ISN'T.
I I KNOW FROM PREVIOUS
EXPERIENCES COMMITTEE THAT
YOU'RE VERY SENSITIVE WHAT'S
PRIVILEGED INFORMATION.
IT'S PERFECT BUT WILL YOUR WHEN
YOU SAY WE WE ARE CAREFUL TO
MAKE SURE WE DON'T INTERFERE.
THAT THAT INCLUDES THAT WE DON'T.
AN ANALYSIS OF WHETHER OR NOT
YOUR WORK COULD COUNTER ACT
BEING CONSISTENT WITH A JUDGE'S
ORDER ON THE SCOPE OF DISCOVERY
WHAT'S DISCLOSED THE OTHER SIDE.
WE OUR REQUIRE WE WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO ABIDE BY THAT COURT
ORDERS ANY SIMILAR ORDER OUR
DUTY TO PROTECT THE INFORMATION
THAT WE OBTAIN IS THE SAME AS
THE PARTIES TO DUTY TO PROTECT
THEIR CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION
SO AGAIN.
WE WILL BE WORKING WITH THE
ODDITY TO ENSURE THAT WE WERE
NOT --
RELEASING ANY INFORMATION
APPROPRIATELY BEAR IN MIND TOO
THAT UNTIL THE AUDIT IS COMPLETE
WHERE PROHIBITED BY LAW FROM
RELEASING ANY INFORMATION
WHATSOEVER THAT WE WOULD WORK
WITH THE ODDITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR WORK PAPERS WERE
PROPERLY SORTED AT THE END OF
THE JOB.
IN THE EVENT WE GOT A SUPER
REQUEST WILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COULD I JUST
MAKE ONE COMMENT ON THE PENDING
LAWSUIT HERE.
A FLEA YEAH I THINK ONE OF THE
CONCERNS WE HAVE IS THAT THAT
THE FIRST HEARING OF THE LAWSUIT
IS SUPPOSED TO BE IN DECEMBER
AND WILL.
PROCEED ABOUT YOU KNOW THROUGH
THE NEW YEAR OF NEXT YEAR.
WERE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT AN
AUDIT REPORT COMING OUT RIGHT IN
THE MIDDLE OF OF THE LAWSUIT
THAT'S FOCUSING ON THE VERY.
ISSUES I MEAN THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE OF THE SAME ISSUES THAT
THE COURT OF LAW AND THE
PLAINTIFFS ARE LOOKING AT THAT
THE AUDIT REPORTS GOING TO COME
OUT WITH SOME SORT OF
CONCLUSIONS AND AN OVERLAP AND
SO. ONE WE ARE CONCERNED WITH
WITH HOW THIS COULD INFLUENCE
ANY PARTICULAR COURT CASE AND
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED THAT THERE
IS SOME REDUNDANCY AND OVERLAP
WITH TWO INDEPENDENT ENTITIES
LOOK AT THAT THE SAME ISSUES.
THAT'S HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND.
WELL AS AS AS MY CHIEF COUNSEL
INDICATED WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
LITIGATION SO IT'S HARD FOR US.
TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THE
SCOPE THAT CENTER STONE AND AND
MISTER COST ARE ASKING US TO
CONDUCT.
HAS OVERLAP OR NOT I MEAN IF
THERE ARE INSTANCES WHERE IT
THERE IS OVERLAP WERE SENSITIVE
TO THAT.
AND WE WOULD HAVE TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION WHAT WE CAN REPORT
OUT -- ONCE
WE COMPLETE THE AUDIT BECAUSE
OUR ATTORNEY AND AS I SAID I
HAVE AN ATTORNEY ASSIGNED EVERY
AUDIT THAT ATTORNEY WILL BE
TRACKING THAT LITIGATION.
AND INFORMING ME AND INFORMING
THE AUDIT.
GOING THERE IS OVERLAP WE'VE HAD
OTHER AUDITS WHERE THAT HAS
OCCURRED AND WHAT WE DID WE
WOULD HAVE WE'VE HAD TO BACK OFF.
AND BASICALLY DISCLOSE IN THE
FINAL REPORT.
THAT WE COULD REPORT OUT ON A
PARTICULAR ISSUE BECAUSE THERE
WAS OVERLAP AND IT WOULD IN OUR
VIEW BASED ON ADVICE FROM
COUNSEL.
WOULD HAVE INTERFERED SO WE
WOULD WE WOULD DOWN TO BE
CAREFUL ABOUT THAT.
NONE OF THAT HELPS DENNIS US TO
ME THAT NOW WOULD NOT ONLY WOULD
YOU BE CAREFUL ABOUT THAT BUT AS
A GENERAL.
POLICY YEAH YOU ARE YOU ARE
PRECLUDED FROM ADDRESSING.
THE FACTUAL ISSUES THAT ARE THE
SUBJECT MATTER OF PENDING
LITIGATION.
THAT'S CORRECT THAT'S UNDER THE
UNDER THE AUDIT STANDARDS THAT
WE FOLLOW WE ARE PRECLUDED FROM.
IT IT THE WAY A STANDARD BREEDS
AS WE HAD WE CANNOT INTERFERE
WITH AN ONGOING WE CANNOT
CONDUCT AUDIT WORK THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY INTERFERE WITH AN
ONGOING INVESTIGATION OR
LITIGATION.
SO AGAIN THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
USING OUR PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT.
AND I'M CERTAINLY SEEKING ADVICE
FROM COUNSEL AND THEN WE MAKE A
DETERMINATION WE CAN'T EVEN GO
THERE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE.
TO A AND WE WOULD HAVE TO INFORM
THE LEGISLATURE WHICH WE ISSUE
THE REPORT PUBLICLY THAT WE
DIDN'T LOOK AT THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE.
IT HAPPENED ON THE MONTEBELLO
AUDIT THAT WE DID OFFER SENATOR
I THINK SENATOR MENDOZA AND
OTHER MEMBERS REQUESTED THAT
AUDIT.
THERE WAS A THERE WAS ONGOING
LITIGATION RELATED TO
CONTRACTING PRACTICES AND WE DID
SOME WORK IN THAT AREA BUT BASED
ON COUNSEL'S ADVICE AND LOOKING
AND MEETING WITH THE TEAM.
I MADE THE DECISION WE CAN'T
REPORT OUT ON THAT BECAUSE
THERE'S ONGOING LITIGATION.
AND OUR CONCLUSIONS MAY BE.
PROBLEMATIC --
NOW WITH RESPECT TO THE
LITIGATION IT COULD INFLUENCE
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER WE WOULD
WANT TO GO THERE BECAUSE WE
CAN'T WITH STANDARDS SO WE WOULD
CONDUCT OURSELVES THE SAME WAY
IF THIS AUDITS APPROVED
[inaudible]
TARA.
ANY --
COMMENTS OR ANY MEMBER
[inaudible]
MATTER.
FOR SURE MEMBERS KATHY MUST WITH
THE LOCAL HEALTH PLANS
CALIFORNIA REPRESENT THE SIXTEEN
NONPROFIT MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE
PLANS IN THE STATE.
ON JUST WANNA GO ON RECORD IN
SORT OF ECHOING THE COMMENTS
FROM GOLD COAST HEALTH PLAN WE
THINK WHAT THEY DID IS THEY WENT
TO PROPER PROCEDURES THEY WENT
THEY DON'T HAD PROPER OVERSIGHT.
AND WE DO BELIEVE THAT THIS
AUDIT IS RUDE WILL BE REDUNDANT
APPRECIATE THE LEGAL DISCUSSION
HERE HOPEFULLY THAT'LL HOLDS
TRUE WHEN --
WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
CERTAINLY ABOUT HAVING THIS
HAPPEN WHILE THE LEGAL CASES
MOVING FORWARD BUT AGAIN PROPER
OVERSIGHT ON WE HAVE TO WE ONLY
HAVE SO MUCH DOLLAR THAT COMES
TO OUR PLANTS FROM MEDICAID
PROGRAM.
AND WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE HAS ADEQUATE --
AT A HAS UP THEIR MEDS AVAILABLE
TO THEM AND THAT IS WHAT THIS
PLAN HAS DONE SO AS THEY STATED
NO ONE WENT WITHOUT MEDICATION
SO WE THINK IT'S REDUNDANT
UNNECESSARY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND FOR THE COMMENTS SEEING NONE
I'D FOR THE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
YES SIR MISTER I JUST WANT.
TO ENJOY THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
THE LEGAL ISSUE I WOULD BE.
SOMEWHAT SURPRISED IF THE JUDGE
IN A COURT ACTION ALLOWS THE
AUDIT REPORT IN. T THE EXTENT
IT'S OF PLANTS THE ROLE OF THE
JURY IN FINDING FACTS SO.
I'M NOT OVERLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT I THINK APPROPRIATE
PROTECTIONS COULD BE.
COULD BE TAKEN BY THE STATE OF
HER AS SHE HAS CERTAINLY DONE IN
THE PAST WHEN THESE ISSUES HAVE
COME UP SO.
IT'S MY COMMENT ON THE POINT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SERVICE JONES ELECT CLOSE.
I THINK YOU MISSED CHAIRED
APPRECIATE --
REPRESENTATIVES FROM GOAL COAST
BEING HERE THAT THAT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT IN --
IN THIS AREA OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WERE SAYING
INDEPENDENT PHARMACIES ON THE
VERGE OF CLOSING OR HAVING
CLOTHES MUCH MORE THAN IN ANY
OTHER AREAS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA --
AND MAYBE EVEN AND IN CERTAIN
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY OF THE LAST
WEEK WAS TALKING ABOUT ACCESS TO
CARE OF MOVING TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE ACCESS TO CARE FOR MEDI
CAL BENEFICIARIES TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THEY GET THEIR MEDICATIONS
TIMELY --
THERE ARE SOME AREAS OF INTER
COUNTY THAT ARE ONLY SERVED BY
INDEPENDENT PHARMACIES BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE THE POPULATION
CENTERS TO HAVE CHAIN STORES
THAT ARE THERE.
SO THIS IS AN ACCESS TO HEAR
ISSUE I'VE I ISSUES I THINK THAT --
THE AUDITOR AND CHIEF COUNSEL IT
MADE IT VERY CLEAR THAT IRAQ AND
DOING IT TO JEOPARDIZE THE ON
GOING --
LITIGATION THAT IS GOING ON AND
AND FOR THAT REASON I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY --
IN CONCURRENCE WITH LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE ASK FOR YOUR
CONCURRENCE AND AND AUDITING
GOLD COAST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE APPROPRIATE ACCESS TO
CARE FOR ALL THE RESIDENTS.
OF INTERCOUNTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
DO WE I DON'T THINK WE HAVE A
MOTION OR SECOND ON THIS ITEM.
MR ACOSTA MOVES.
SECOND BY CENTER FULLER
[inaudible]
BROKAW THINKS.
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE AUDIT
REQUEST NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN TASH ONE TO FOUR OF THE
GOLD COAST HEALTH PLAN BY
SENATOR STONE.
CHAIRS RECOMMENDATIONS AND I
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MERCY ITCHY.
VERSACE AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I NAZARIAN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
RUBIO.
NOT VOTING WOULD [inaudible]
SENATOR [inaudible]
ALMOST.
THEN THERE WOULD IS NOT HERE
[inaudible]
SENATOR ROTH.
ROTH AYE ALLEN [inaudible]
BELL.
BELL AYE CANNELLA.
CANNELLA AYE FULLER [inaudible]
FULLER I LARA.
ALRIGHT THAT'S A REQUEST.
NOW I IS ON CALL.
BIGGEST FEAR MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT THE WE HAVE OUR OUR NEXT
SIGN UP -- A
MISS RUBY HOWEVER MS RUBIO YOU
KNOW IT'S THE JUDGE GENERAL
CUSTOM OF THE COMMITTEE THAT THE
THAT WE SO WITH YOUR INDULGENCE
THAT WE'D LIKE --
TO INVITES HIM REGAINS TO UP
PRESENT.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO.
SEVERAL GAY FLORA JEFF THANK YOU
CHAIR AND THIS IS --
JUST FOR THE RECORD --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT'S ONE
TWENTY FIVE TAXPAYER
TRANSPARENCY AND FAIRNESS ACT
AUDIT REQUESTS GREAT WONDERFUL
THANK YOU SO MUCH --
GOOD MORNING I'M HERE TO ASK
THAT THE COMMITTEE APPROVED AN
AUDIT TO DETERMINE THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE TAXPAYER
TRANSPARENCY IN FAIRNESS ACT.
IS INDEED MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION --
WITH LITTLE DISRUPTION TO THE
TAXPAYING PUBLIC.
THE LEGISLATURE VESTED OF THE OP
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION --
OF ITS AUTHORITY TO COLLECT MANY
OF THE TAXES AND FEES FOR WHICH
IT HAD BEEN RESPONSIBLE.
AND STRIPPED FROM AT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE APPEALS PROCESS
RELATED TO TAX AND FEE
COLLECTION.
IT SEPARATE SUBSEQUENTLY
INVESTED THOSE POWERS INTO A
NEWLY CREATED.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND
FEE ADMINISTRATION.
AND THE OFFICE OF TAX APPEALS.
IT DID SO WITH WHAT I BELIEVE TO
BE THE BEST OF INTENTIONS
COVERAGE DISRUPTED A PROCESS
THAT CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS HAVE
BECOME USED.
TO AND CHANGED INTERNAL PROCESS
HE'S.
AND CAPABILITIES THE STATED
GOALS OF THE TAXPAYER
TRANSPARENCY AND FAIRNESS ACT
WERE TO NUMBER ONE IMPROVE THE
OPERATIONAL CULTURE TO
ACCURATELY REPORT RELIABLE
INFORMATION.
NUMBER TO ENSURE THAT THE
APPEALS PROCESS IS MAINTAINED IN
AN ETHICAL MANNER.
AND NUMBER THREE TO ENSURE
BUDGETARY AND LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTIVES ARE CARRIED THROUGH.
TO ENSURE THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS NEW
PARADIGM IS SERVING CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS.
THE WAY THE LEGISLATURE INTENDED.
I CALL UPON THE COMMITTEE TO
APPROVE AN EXAMINATION OF THE
INITIAL STAGES OF IMPLEMENTATION.
OF THE ACT THE LEGISLATURE AND
CALIFORNIANS AT LARGE TO DIRT
DESERVE TO KNOW HOW WELL THIS
TRANSITION IS PROCEEDING.
AND WHETHER IS IT IS SUCCEEDING
IN ACHIEVING ITS DESIRED GOALS.
WITH -- MORE
THAN A FEW FACTORS --
HAVE LET ME. TO MAKE THIS
REQUEST INCLUDING BUDGET
CONSIDERATIONS.
LACK OF CONSUMER ABILITY ABILITY
TO INTERACT WITH THE NEW
AGENCIES AND CONFUSION AS TO
WHETHER PRIOR ADMINISTRATIVE
HOLDINGS.
WILL CONTINUE TO SHAPE FUTURE
DECISION MAKING.
AT THE NEW DEPARTMENTS.
WHEN THE BEER WE MAINTAIN HIS
RESPONSIBILITIES DURING FISCAL
YEAR? TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
ITS BUDGET ALLOCATION WAS SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR AN ENTITY THAT COLLECTED
SIXTY BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
OR ONE THIRD OF THE STATE'S
BUDGET.
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
STATE BUDGET PROVIDES FOR REDUCE
BUDGET ALLOCATION FOR THE POV.
OF THIRTY MILLION TO ACCOMPLISH
IT'S CONSTITUTIONALLY MANDATED
FUNCTIONS.
WHILE THE FORMATION OF THE CT.
CITY TFSA AN OTA HAS LED TO
ADDITIONAL BUDGET EXPENDITURES.
THEN THE AMOUNT OF SIX HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR MILLION.
WITH FOUR THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY EMPLOYEES FOR THE CD TFA.
AND TWENTY MILLION WITH EIGHTY
EMPLOYEES FOR THE OTA.
AS A RESULT THE SAME FUNCTIONS
WHICH COST SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY
MILLION LAST YEAR.
WILL COST TAXPAYERS AN
ADDITIONAL FORTY FOUR MILLION
THIS YEAR.
THE UTILITY AND EFFECTIVENESS OF
THIS ADDITIONAL ADDITIONAL
BUDGET EXPENDITURE.
SHOULD BE EXAMINED BEFORE THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE CRAFT
THE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET.
SINCE A CD TFA HAS GONE ONLINE
IN JANUARY THERE HAVE BEEN
NUMEROUS COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE
ACCESSIBILITY OF INFORMATION.
AND THE ABILITY INTERACT WITH
THE DEPARTMENT SPECIFICALLY.
TAXPAYERS WHO COMPLAINED THAT.
THE NEW WEBSITE FOR REPORTING
BUSINESS SALES TAXES.
IS TOO CONFUSING AND COMPLICATED
TO EFFECTIVELY USE.
SECONDLY THEY CANNOT COMMUNICATE
MESSAGES THROUGH THE WEBSITE.
SPECIFICALLY FOR BUSINESS OWNERS
WHO NEED TO ADD LOCATIONS --
TO THE PERMIT ASSOCIATED WITH
THEIR ACCOUNT.
THIRDLY THERE UNABLE TO CONTACT
THE CD TFA BY TELEPHONE.
STATING THAT THEY'RE CONSTANTLY
MET WITH A BUSY SIGNAL.
THE CT CDT FAA HAS REPORTEDLY
HARASSED INDIVIDUALS FOR TAXES
THEY DO NOT OWE.
AND LOST TAXPAYERS SUPPORTING
PAPERWORK WHEN THEY ATTEMPT TO
RESOLVE FALSE CLAIM ISSUES.
AND FINALLY THE APPROPRIATE TAX
FORMS ARE NOT AVAILABLE ON THE
CD TFA WEBSITE.
IN APRIL TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE LA
JOH NOTED IN A REPORT.
THAT OF THE FIRST FOURTEEN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES HIRED
BY THE OTA TO HEAR APPEALS.
THIRTEEN PREVIOUSLY WORKED FOR
THE OTHER TAXING AGENCIES.
SUCH AS THE F. T. P..
ALL THIS PRIOR WORK HISTORY
OBVIOUSLY GIVES THEM SOME
FAMILIARITY WITH TAX ISSUES IT
ALSO TENDS TO BUILD.
AN INHERENT CONFLICT OF INTEREST
AGAINST TAXPAYERS WHO ARE
APPEALING TAX DECISIONS.
THERE'S ALSO COME TO MY
ATTENTION THAT SINCE THE OTA.
HAS BEGUN TO HEAR APPEALS CASES
NOT ONE OF THOSE CASES IS BEEN
FOUNDER FAVOR THE TAXPAYER.
AND OVER FIFTY CASES HAVE BEEN
HEARD.
A FEW CASES HAVE BEEN SETTLED
OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING PROCESS.
IN ADDITION OTA CASE BACKLOG
WHICH INCLUDES ABOUT TWELVE
HUNDRED ACTIVE CASES.
THIS ACT OF BACKLOG REPRESENTS
ABOUT A YEAR OF TYPICAL CASE
WORKLOAD.
THIS BACKLOG STRAINS THE APPEALS
PROCESS BUT ALSO DID DELAYS
ADJUDICATION RIGHTS OF THE
TAXPAYER IN QUESTION.
IT APPEARS THAT THE TRANSITION
FROM THE BEER WE TO THE CD TFA
AND OJ.
IS NOT PROCEEDING SMOOTHLY.
THESE NEW AGENCIES MAY BE FACED
WITH MANY OF THE SAME ISSUES
WHICH LED TO THE CRITICISMS OF
THE BEER WAITING.
AND ULTIMATELY LED TO THE
PASSAGE OF THE TAXPAYER
TRANSPARENCY AND FAIRNESS ACT OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN GIVEN THESE
FACTORS IT WOULD SEEM THAT
REVIEWING THE TRANSITION TODAY.
MAY HELP THESE NEW DEPARTMENTS
AVOID THE PITFALLS WHICH LED TO
THEIR CREATION AS WELL AS AIDING
THE TAXPAYERS IN MEETING THEIR
OBLIGATIONS.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS AN IMPORTANT
OVERSIGHT FUNCTION TO ENSURE
THAT OUR STATE DEPARTMENTS ARE
SERVING THE STATE GOVERNMENT AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY THE TAXPAYERS
OF CALIFORNIA.
BY CONDUCTING THIS REVIEW IN THE
A WE MAY BE ABLE TO ENSURE.
THAT THE NEW DEPARTMENTS ARE
LAUNCHING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THE LEGISLATURE'S WISHES ARE
BEING MET.
AND THAT TAXPAYERS ARE BEING
SERVED.
I REQUEST THAT JACK J. LACK
WOULD --
THROUGH THE USE OF THE STATE
AUDITOR ENGAGE IN AN AUDIT
REVIEW.
OF THE NEW TAX IF YOU
ADMINISTRATIVE STRUCTURE UNDER
THE TAXPAYER TRANSPARENCY AND
FAIRNESS ACT.
THANKS SO ARE AGAINST YOU HAVE
ANY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT A
REQUEST [inaudible]
OKAY --
STATE AUDITOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AS
CENTER GAINES INDICATED THIS
WOULD BE WE'RE LOOKING AT TWO
DIFFERENT ENTITIES --
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION AND
THEN CERTAINLY THE OFFICE OF TAX
APPEALS SO FIRST LOOKING AT TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION HE'S
ASKING US TO LOOK AT WHETHER OR
NOT TAXPAYERS REALLY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO ACCESS INFORMATION
VIA THE WEBSITE.
ACCESS INFORMATION RELATED TO
THEIR ACCOUNTS --
IN MAY BE ABILITY TO MAKE
PAYMENTS PERMIT INFORMATION A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT SERVICES
THAT TAXPAYERS NEED TO BE ABLE
TO ACCESS THROUGH THE WEBSITES
WHO IS ASKING US TO LOOK AT THAT.
IS ALSO ASKING US AS HE
INDICATED IN HIS COMMENTS TO
LOOK AT HOW THAT TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT
HANDLES TELEPHONE ENQUIRIES AND
WHETHER OR NOT THERE ARE HAVING
ISSUES WITH THAT IF THEY ARE
HAVING ISSUES WHAT STEPS TO THE
INTENT TO TAKE. TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES.
WITH RESPECT TO TAX APPEALS THE
OFFICE OF TAX APPEALS R. O. T. A
WHETHER OR NOT OTA HAS
ESTABLISHED POLICIES THEY'VE
BEEN IN PLACE.
I THINK THIS THAT WELL
LEGISLATION WAS AN WAS ON JULY
OF SEVENTEEN ARE OTA STARTED
HEARING APPEALS JANUARY OF THIS
YEAR BUT RICK HE'S ASKING US TO
REALLY LOOK AT WHAT POLICIES
HAVE THEY CREATED.
WITH RESPECT TO PASS DECISIONS
ARE MADE BY BE A WE ARE IF THOSE
DECISIONS HAVE BEEN APPEALED.
ARM AND IF SO DO THEY HAVE
POLICIES IN PLACE TO DESCRIBE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THEY MAY
DEVIATE FROM A DECISION THAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY MADE BY.
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION SO
REALLY LOOKING AT ESTABLISH
THEIR STRUCTURE AND WHAT THEIR
POLICIES AND PROTOCOLS ARE --
MOVING FORWARD.
WITH RESPECT TO THE TWO ENTITIES
THERE'S AN OBJECTIVE ASKING US
TO MAKE SURE THERE IS SEPARATION
CLEARLY THERE WAS INTENT ON
HAVING A SEPARATE OFFICE OF TAX
OF FEAR APPEALS AND TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION SO.
LOOKING AT CONFLICT CONFLICT OF
INTEREST POLICIES ARM ANY
ASSOCIATED REGULATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN DRAFTED UP BY THE
RESPECTIVE ENTITIES.
YEAH CENTER GAINES MENTIONED THE
LA OWES REPORT RELATED TO
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES HE'S
ASKING US A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
WITH RESPECT TO THAT.
O. T. A.'S HIRING POLICIES FOR
HIRING A A L. JAY'S AND THEN
CERTAINLY THERE POLICY FOR
ASSIGNING A L. CHASED PARTICULAR
CASES AND DO THEY TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THAT THEY'LL JAY'S
PREVIOUS EMPLOYMENT IF IT WAS
FTP OR SOME OTHER.
I'M ENTITIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS AGAIN IS IN A CONFLICT
OF INTEREST AND THEN THE LAST
TWO OBJECTIVES ARE LOOKING AT
ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURE
SPECIFICALLY TO OTA.
OUR REVIEW AND ASSESS THEIR
ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURE OUGHT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE ALE JAY'S
IN THE FUNCTIONS WITHIN --
TEAR REALLY SEPARATE ARM FROM
THE DIRECTORATE LEVEL THEY DO
HAVE THAT INDEPENDENCE NECESSARY
AND THEN THE LAST OBJECTIVE IS
REALLY LOOKING AT BOTH ENTITIES --
WITH RESPECT TO ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS HOW COST EFFECTIVE IS THIS
NEW STRUCTURE IN COMPARISON TO
THE PRIOR STRUCTURE.
A WHEN IT WAS ALL UNDER BE A
WEEK AND WHETHER OR NOT THERE
MAY BE DIFFERENT ADMINISTRATIVE
STRUCTURES THAT WOULD BE MORE IF
AFFECT EFFECTIVE OR EFFICIENT
EXCUSE ME --
AT THE BUDGET ABOUT TWENTY FOR
ALMOST TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED HOURS
THAT'S ABOUT A SIX MONTH PROJECT
FOR AUDIT STAFF.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO INVITE THE
IN THE REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS OFFICE
OF TAX APPEALS PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
PLACER ST THANK YOU SO MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COMMITTEE OF MY
NAME'S NICK BUT TERRACE ON THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION.
OF THE DEPARTMENT AS YOU ALL
KNOWS ABOUT ONE YEAR OLD --
MS THAT CREATED LAST YEAR JAN
JULY FIRST OF LAST YEAR I
STARTED JULY TWELFTH --
IT IN RESPONSE TO AB ONE OF TWO
OF THE AIM OF WHICH WAS TO RISK
RESTORE THE PUBLIC'S TRUST IN
INCREASE FAIRNESS CONSISTENCY
AND TRANSPARENCY IN TAX
ADMINISTRATION --
I CERTAINLY TAKE THAT VERY
SERIOUSLY AS DOES THE ENTIRE
STAFF AT CTF A JUST GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND ON WHAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING --
AS WELL AS TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES REYES SPECIFICALLY IN
OUR BY SENATOR GAINES --
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING THROUGH
THOUSANDS OF TRANSITION RELATED
ITEMS IN THE PAST YEAR WE STILL
HAVE.
QUITE A FEW --
TO ADDRESS BUT YOU KNOW IT IS A
BIG TASK WE ARE ALSO WORKING ON
A YEARS WORTH OF PAST AUDITS AND
INVESTIGATIONS THEM.
THE BILL WE WILL --
CERTAINLY WAS NOT A STRANGER TO
AUDITS AND INVESTIGATIONS SO
THERE ARE QUITE A FEW --
WITH --
AUDIT FINDINGS OUTSTANDING
INCLUDING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR THE STATE
PERSONNEL BOARD DEPARTMENT
FINANCE DG ES.
AND OTHERS --
AND WE ARE --
DILIGENTLY WORKING THROUGH POD
THAT BACKLOG --
WE'RE ALSO IN THE FINAL STAGES
OF THOSE BUSINESS AND STRATEGIC
PLAN --
DRAFTING AFTER LOSING FEEDBACK
FROM ALL OF OUR STAFF THAT WILL
BE A THREE YEAR PLAN.
OF THAT WE EXPECT TO BE ISSUED
SHORTLY.
THE CENTRAL ISSUE WHICH
ADDRESSES I THINK MOST OF THE
ISSUES RAISED BY SENATOR GAINES
IS OUR CROSS SYSTEM WHICH IS OUR
CENTRALIZED REVENUE OPPORTUNITY
SYSTEM.
WHICH HAS BEEN ONLINE FOR ONLY
THREE MONTHS IT WENT ONLINE
THREE MONTHS AGO YESTERDAY MAY
SEVENTH OF THIS YEAR --
AND I'LL COME BACK TO THAT
MOMENT BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
REALLY THE CRUX OF OF ALMOST ALL
OF THESE ISSUES --
BOB MY FIRST PRIORITY OUR FIRST
PRIORITY AT THE DEPARTMENT IS
IMPROVING THE CULTURE AND ETHICS
OF THE DEPARTMENT TO THAT AND
WE'VE DONE A LOT WE'VE
INSTITUTED STRICT NEW ANTI
NEPOTISM POLICY.
WE'VE HAD TRAINED THE ENTIRE
STAFF ON MERIT BASED HIRING
PRINCIPLES WE'VE SET UP A
HOTLINE TO REPORT MISCONDUCT.
WE CONDUCTED AN EMPLOYEE
ENGAGEMENT SURVEY THE
DEPARTMENT'S FIRST TO SERVE AS A
BENCH LINE FOR AN ANNUAL PLAYING.
COMPLAIN GATE THAT SURVEY --
WE'VE BEEN WORKING AGAINST THE
OUTSTANDING AUDIT FINDINGS WE'VE
ESTABLISHMENT OF PRICE RISK
MANAGEMENT PROCESS FOR THE FIRST
TIME THE DEPARTMENT.
WE'VE RESTRUCTURED TO CREATE A
CFO ORGANIZATION TO BRING
TIGHTER FINANCIAL CONTROLS TO
DEPARTMENT --
AS WELL AS JOHNSON RESTRUCTURING
TO TRY TO BRING UNIFORMITY ARE
AROUND THE STATE SO PEOPLE DO
NOT THAT DIFFERENT TAX OUTCOMES.
DEPENDING ON WHERE THEY ARE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
WAS PREVIOUSLY A PROBLEM WITH
DEPARTMENT --
WE ARE ALSO WORKING TO IMPROVE
EFFICIENCY WHICH I TAKE VERY
SERIOUSLY THE DEPARTMENT GIVEN
THE PUBLIC FUNDS THAT WERE
EXPANDING.
ARE THAT INVOLVES BOTH PROCESS
RE ENGINEERING AND IMPROVE USE
OF TECHNOLOGY OF JUST ONE
EXAMPLE WE'VE TAKEN OUR OFFERING
COMPROMISE PROGRAM.
UP FROM A NINE MONTH PROCESS
ALREADY DOWN TO ONE MONTH
PROCESS AND AND THERE'S MORE TO
BE DONE IN VARIOUS ITEMS.
WHEN IT COMES TO TECHNOLOGY A
LET ME TURN TO THE CROSS?
ISSUE NOW WHICH IS AT THE HEART
OF BOTH THE ISSUES ABOUT THE
DIFFICULTY OF THE NEW SYSTEM IT
ALSO IS AT THE HEART OF THE CALL
CENTER ISSUES THAT THE CALL WAIT
TIMES AND BUSY SIGNALS.
AS WELL AS ITS REALLY THE HEART
OF THE THE BUDGET NUMBERS THAT
SENATOR GAINES BOTTOM.
SUGGESTED AS WELL.
ODD SO CROSS --
IS A CUSTOMIZED OFF THE SHELF
SOFTWARE WHICH WAS PROCURED BY
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION.
BACK IN TWENTY SIXTEEN CSUS THE
CONTRACT HOME RICHARD PRIOR TO
THE HIVE CREATION OF CTF A IT IS
BASED ON SOMETHING CALLED THE
CHEN TAX PLATFORM WHICH IS USED
BY.
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE OTHER STATES
AND CITIES AROUND THE UNITED
STATES INCLUDING BY EDIE DE --
THERE ARE REAL BENEFITS TO GOING --
TO A NEW MODERN PLATFORM --
THE INC ENHANCED FUNCTIONALITY
WILL LEAD TO US BEING BECOMING
MORE NIMBLE.
AND SHOULD INCREASE REVENUE OVER
TIME -- THE
SYSTEM AS I MENTIONED WENT LIVE
JUST THREE MONTHS AGO.
ARE THE SYSTEM WORKS BUT WE ARE
CERTAINLY NOT HAPPY WITH WHERE
NOT IN ENTIRELY HAPPY WITH WHERE
WE ARE AT THE MOMENT ARE.
IT'S NOT AS USER FRIENDLY AS BIO
WE WOULD LIKE AND THE TEAM IS
WORKING DILIGENTLY --
DAY IN AND DAY OUT TO MAKE
CHANGES WE'VE ALREADY MADE MANY
CHANGES --
WE ARE CONSTANTLY MONITORING
CALL VOLUMES THAT ARE CALL
CENTERS EVERY AFTERNOON WE GET A
REPORT NOT ONLY OF THE CALL
VOLUME WHICH INCLUDES WAIT TIMES
AVERAGE CALL TIME --
BUT WE ALSO GET A REPORT OF WHAT
ISSUES PEOPLE ARE HAVING AND
THEN WE WORK OVERNIGHT THE TEAM
WORKS OVERNIGHT.
A TO ADDRESS THE SPECIFIC ISSUE
THE NEXT DAY HOPEFULLY WE PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE THOSE.
SAME PROBLEMS ONLINE OKAY SIR
I'M GONNA YET LET ME LET ME JUST
SAY THE SYSTEM'S WORKING BE PAT
WE JUST HAD OUR BUSINESS FILING
SEASON OF THE YEAR IN JULY.
WE HAD MORE THAN --
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND TAX
RETURNS FILED ABOUT FIFTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS CAME IN --
SPA ALMOST THREE QUARTERS OF A
MILLION PAYMENTS.
ALL GOING TO THE RIGHT PLACES OF
THE SYSTEM IS WORKING OUT
CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE FOR IT TO
BE.
A A LITTLE MORE USER FRIENDLY
AND WORKING ON THAT OF THE CALL
CENTER ISSUES ARE DIRECTLY
RELATED TO THE CROSS SYSTEM.
THE IMPORTANTLY THE LAST TIME WE
EXPERIENCED THESE CALL VOLUMES
WAS NINE YEARS AGO WHEN WE
INSTITUTE OUR PREVIOUS --
ONLINE SERVICE IT'S NATURAL WHEN
YOU TRANSITION MILLION TAXPAYERS
TO DIFFERENT SYSTEM.
THAT THAT THEY WOULD HAVE SOME
ISSUES AND LET ME JUST ONE LAST
IMPORTANT AND CLOSE WITH.
A THE BUDGET ISSUE WHICH IS
RAISE THE FORTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE.
OF FOR THIS YEAR MORE THAN FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF THAT IS.
DOES THE PAYMENT FOR THE VENDOR
ON THE CROSS CONTRACT A WHICH
AGAIN WAS WOULD BE DO.
WHETHER OR NOT THERE WAS CDT FAA
OR NOT BECAUSE IT WAS A CONTRACT
LET.
BY BE A WE TOM I AM.
I WOULD LOVE I WOULD WELCOME ANY
SORT OF FREE ADVICE ABOUT HOW TO
OUR COLLECT TAXES MORE
EFFICIENTLY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I WELCOME ANY ADVICE.
I WOULD PREFER IT MAYBE AFTER
WE'VE HAD THE SYSTEM IN PLACE
FOR YEAR SOMETHING TO HAVE
SOMEBODY COME BACK IN.
AND GIVE US A SOME HELP THEN I
THINK IT'S WERE LITTLE EARLY AND
WERE STILL STABILIZING SYSTEM
AND AND THAT.
TRYING TO MAKE OUR OWN
IMPROVEMENTS INTERNALLY.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE MARK I'VE WON
THE DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
TAX APPEALS.
AND I WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK BEFORE YOU TODAY I WILL
TRUNCATE MY RECOUNT MY COMMENTS
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME --
BOTTOM LINE --
WE HAVE BEEN VERY I HELPED A LOT
BY INPUT FROM STAKE HOLDERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE THE TAX AGENCIES
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
PROCESS OF OUR TWO HUNDRED SOME
DAYS OF EXISTENCE WHICH ARM. FOR
A LOT OF PEOPLE AT OTA AND I
WANT TO THANK THEM IS ALSO TWO
HUNDRED WORKING TO HIS --
LET ME SAY I THINK THE AUDIT IS
GENERALLY GOOD IDEA I THINK IT'S
NOW IS NOT THE TIME IT'S RATHER
PREMATURE WE I THINK HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED A LOT --
OVER THE LAST SEVEN MONTHS AND
PUTTING INTO PLACE OFFICES A
CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM WHICH IS
CAME UNDER BUDGET I MIGHT ADD --
ELIMINATING THE BACKLOG --
WHICH THE SEVERAL HUNDRED THAT
WAS INHERITED --
INCORPORATING A SYSTEM OF SOME
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED CASES
FIFTEEN HUNDRED WATCHER ACTIVE --
HIRING MOST OF OUR STAFF.
INCLUDING WELL QUALIFIED AND
PROFESSIONAL --
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES AND WE
HAVE.
PUT FORTH OUR REGULATIONS HAD TO
IBM'S INTERESTED PARTIES
MEETINGS ON THOSE REGULATIONS
WITH THE THIRD SCHEDULED.
WE HAVE PUT IN PLACE PROCEDURES
TO SEPARATE OTA FROM THE TAX
AGENCIES WITH NO CONTACT WITH A
ATTORNEYS LEGAL STAFF BUT MERELY
FOR PROCESSING PURPOSES.
WE HAVE PUT IN PLACE POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES AND PROTOCOLS TO
GUARANTEE THE INDEPENDENCE OF
ALJ PANELS --
BECAUSE THEY A THREE MEMBER
PANEL ARE THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
MAKE THE DECISION THAT DECISION
IS FINAL --
THE DIRECTOR AND ANYONE ELSE
DOES NOT SEE THAT UNTIL IT'S
FINE -- AND
WE'VE ESTABLISH INFORMATION
SECURITY PROTOCOLS I WANTED TO
WITH YOUR INDULGENCE I'D LIKE TO
SUGGEST THAT DRESS.
VERY SPECIFICALLY SOME OF THE
POINTS THAT CENTER GAINES RAISED --
ON PRESIDENTIAL DECISIONS OBVIO
WE PRECEDENTS CONTINUE TO BE
PRESIDENTIAL --
AND LASTS A CASE COMES BEFORE
OTA WHICH SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSES
THAT POINT.
AND IT COULD BE OVERRULED IF THE
PANEL AT OTA BELIEVES IT ISN'T
NOT A MATTER OF LAW.
OR IS SIMPLY INCORRECT --
THAT'S PUT FORTH IN SECTION
THREE OF FOR A FOR REGULATIONS --
I ADDRESSED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE SEPARATION OF THE DIRECTOR
LEVEL FROM DECISION MAKING --
THE SEPARATION FROM TAXING
AUTHORITIES THE CASE BACKLOG THE
TWELVE HUNDRED CASE BACKLOG
APPEARS TO STEM FROM A LA O.
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE THIS
IS NOT A BACKLOG OR WAS NOT A
BACKLOG PER SE OF IT RATHER
CASES.
THAT WERE SIMPLY INHERITED FROM
BE IT WE AND SENT TO OTA.
ABOUT WE DON'T HAVE A BACKLOG AT
THIS POINT --
I THINK THAT --
THAT ADDRESSES SOME OF THE
SPECIFIC ARE QUESTIONS CONCERNS
ISSUES THAT WERE BROUGHT UP WE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS WERE VERY MUCH.
I WILL BE IF NOT THE FIRST ONE
OF THE FIRST TO ADMIT THAT WERE
VERY MUCH A WORK IN PROGRESS WE
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
WE NEED TO STREAMLINE THE THE
THE PROCESS WITH THE TAXING
AGENCIES AND MAKE SURE THAT WITH
THE INDEPENDENCE OF THE OFFICE
OF OTA.
WE CAN STILL MAKE THIS WE CAN
MAKE THIS WORK FOR TAXPAYERS --
WITH A MINIMUM OF OF VAN LARA
ISSUES AND PROBLEMS AND AND AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE.
ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF BEFORE I
OPEN UP TO THE COMMITTEE I I
HAVE A QUICK GOOD --
GENERAL QUESTIONS TO THE AUDITOR
WHICH IS THAT I I I I KNOW THAT --
YOU WERE --
DON'T TAKE POSITIONS ON AUDIT
REQUESTS BUT AS A GENERAL MATTER --
HOW HELPFUL IS IT TO HAVE?
A RECORD.
OF SOME PERIOD OF TIME --
OF OPERATION TO AUDIT BEFORE YOU
THINK.
THE AUTHOR THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
WORTHWHILE.
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION MISTER
CHAIRMAN AS YOU AS YOU DID
INDICATE WE DON'T TAKE A
POSITION ON AUDIT REQUESTS BUT
TYPICALLY WOULD WORK ON GOING TO
CONDUCT AN AUDIT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
OR HOPEFULLY THAT THERE'S ENOUGH
BODY OF WORK THAT WE CAN DO A
FULL --
ROBUST ASSESSMENT --
CERTAINLY THESE AGENCIES AS THEY
INDICATED HAVE RECENTLY BEEN
CREATED I KNOW THERE WAS A THAT
YOU KNOW WE SITUATION SBB WAS IN
THERE FINANCE WAS IN THERE
ETCETERA SO --
WE WOULD BE LOOKING AT SOME OF
THEIR RESPONSES --
TO THE AUDITS THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN DONE BUT CERTAINLY --
TYPICALLY WHEN WE'RE GONNA
CONDUCT AN AUDIT OF ENTITIES WE
WANT TO SEE A FAIR AMOUNT OF
TIME OR THEIR ABILITY TO PUT
REGULATIONS TOGETHER POLICIES
THAT CENTER BECAUSE IF WE WANT
TO TEST THE EFFECTIVENESS OF SEE --
TYPICALLY WANT TO SEE CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF WORKLOAD SO THAT WE
CAN ASSESS WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE COMPLYING WITH POLICIES
REGULATIONS IT CETERA --
WITH THAT SAID THERE ARE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE WE GO IN
EARLY -- IN
LOOK AT AN ENTITY AS IT'S BEING
CREATED IN ITS DEVELOPMENT--
BUT IN THIS CIRCUMSTANCE OP
PARTICULARLY SINCE THERE WAS A
LOT OF THE A CONTROVERSY WITH B.
O. WE AND AND AS I INDICATED AND
THAT REPRESENTATIVES SPV WAS IN
THEIR FINANCE WAS IN THERE KELLY
CHAR WAS IN THERE --
WE WOULD WE WOULD HAVE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT SOME OF THAT INFORMATION
TO SEE WHAT REACTION OR WHAT ON
THE TWO ENTITIES HAVE DONE WITH
RESPECT TO THOSE.
THOSE AUDITS AND HOW THAT
AFFECTS THEIR DEVELOPMENT OF
POLICIES PRACTICES THAT CENTER.
THANKS VERY MUCH SARAH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I THINK
IS MY COLLEAGUES KNOW ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE I IF PROBLEMS
FIRST LET ME SAY I HAVE THE
HIGHEST RESPECT FOR THE AUTHOR
OF THIS REQUEST.
VERY DILIGENT HARD WORKING WELL
INTENTIONED.
A SUPERB SENATOR --
DOES A GREAT JOB HERE --
I'VE PROBABLY SPENT AS MUCH TIME
ON THIS ISSUE OVER THE LAST.
TO CERTAINLY TWO YEARS IS JUST
ABOUT ANYBODY --
BUT ANYBODY I HAVE SOME
COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSEMBLY WHO
HAVE SPENT.
CERTAINLY AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME IF NOT MORE.
BUT LET ME SAY THIS I MEAN
WITHOUT REAL LITIGATING THE RE
ARGUING THE THE ENTIRE
REORGANIZATION BO WE IN THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THESE TWO
ORGANIZATIONS.
I JUST WITH RESPECT TO THE AUDIT
REQUEST ITSELF I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE WAY THE SCOPE.
CERTAIN OF THE ISSUES HAVE BEEN
DRAFTED --
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT [inaudible]
THE QUESTIONS HAVING TO DO WITH
PRESIDENTIAL DECISIONS AND IF
WE'RE SAYING YOU KICK THAT --
AN AGENCY OR THE ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGES ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
PARTICULAR OPERATION CAN'T
REEVALUATE.
CRIER DECISIONS ARE PRESIDENTIAL
DECISIONS THAT'S SIMPLY NOT THE
WAY THE LAW WORKS.
THAT IS DONE ALL THE TIME THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
PERIODICALLY REVIEWS
PRESIDENTIAL DECISIONS AND
DECIDES TO GO IN A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS.
BUT WITH RESPECT TO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES
ASSIGNED TO THE OFFICE TAX
APPEAL YOU KNOW OUR LEGISLATION
REQUIRED THESE INDIVIDUALS BE
EXPERIENCED IN THE AREA TAX.
AND UNFORTUNATELY OR FORTUNATELY
ONE OF THE WAYS THAT ATTORNEYS
GAIN EXPERIENCE IS TO WORK FOR
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES WHETHER YOU
WORK FOR THE INTERESTING NEWS
SERVICE FOR THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD OR SOME OTHER.
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES SO TO SAY
THAT IT ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE.
IS SOMEHOW BIASED OR PREJUDICED
BECAUSE THEY GAINED EXPERIENCE
IN ANOTHER AGENCY I THINK IS.
CERTAINLY MISDIRECTED AND I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THE WAY THAT
PARTICULAR AUDIT QUESTION.
IT'S PHRASED WITH RESPECT TO
CONFLICTS I'M NOT SURE HOW THE
CONFLICT WOULD ARISE ARE WE
SAYING THAT THE ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGES DUAL EMPLOYED THAT
THEY WORK AT THE SAME TIME FOR
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AS THEY
DO.
WORK FOR THE OFFICE OF TAX
APPEALS THAT WOULD CERTAINLY BE
AWAY THAT.
I COULD SEE A CONFLICT AND
BEYOND THAT I'M NOT CERTAIN
ABOUT THAT BUT HAVING SAID ALL
THAT I GUESS MY BASIC.
CONCERN HERE IS OF THE TIMING OF
THE ON IT.
NO WE ALLOWED THE FORTY OF THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEND MANY
DECADES ESTABLISHING THE BOARDS
PRACTICES AND PROCEDURES AND
METHODS OF OPERATIONS --
BEFORE WE TOOK.
THE OPPORTUNITY OUR SELVES TO
REVIEW THE BOARD'S AS SUCCESSES
IN THE BOARD'S FAILURES AND
ULTIMATELY.
DECIDE THAT A REORGANIZATION WAS
APPROPRIATE AND IN THIS CASE
WHERE THESE --
TWO ORGANIZATIONS HAVE ONLY BEEN --
IN EXISTENCE FOR TWELVE MONTHS
OR IN THE CASE OF AN OPERATION
IN THE CASE OF THE OFFICE OF TAX
APPEALS.
A SOMEWHAT LESS THAN THAT I
THINK IT'S A BIT.
PREMATURE O SEND THE STATE
AUDITOR IN THERE TOO A TAKE A
LOOK AT OPERATIONS AND SIMPLY
TELL THE INDIVIDUALS RUNNING
THESE ORGANIZATIONS.
PROBABLY WHAT THEY ALREADY KNOWS
THAT THEIR OF ORGANIZATIONAL
EFFORTS ARE NOT COMPLETE.
SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE --
I'M SURE THAT BOTH THE OFFICE OF
TAX APPEALS IN THE DEPARTMENT
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION.
HAVE --
IMPLEMENTATION STRATEGIC PLANS A
TIME LINE UP AT WHICH OR BY
WHICH THEY INTEND TO BE FULLY
OPERATIONAL IN FULLY ORGANIZED
AND HOPEFULLY HAVE THE KINKS
IRONED OUT.
AND WHETHER IT'S TWO YEARS OR
THREE YEARS I CERTAINLY THINK WE
SHOULD ALLOW THE IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN TO BE IMPLEMENTED FULLY --
IN THE ORGANIZATION TO BE FULLY.
BEFORE WE WE SEND THE STATE
AUDITOR IN THERE I WOULD BE
SUPPORTIVE OF AN AUDIT REQUEST I
BELIEVE DEPENDING ON HOW IT'S
PHRASED IN THE ISSUES THAT ARE
GOING TO BE EXAMINED.
AT THE END OF THAT STRATEGIC
PLAN THAT IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
WHETHER IT'S TWO OR THREE YEARS.
DECEPTIVE TO DO A CHECK TO SEE
HOW THE OFFICE OF TAX APPEALS IS
PROCESSING CASES TO SEE WHETHER
THERE'S A BACKLOG TO SEE WHETHER.
IT SIMMERS ARRABAL TO CONTACT
THE APPROPRIATE PEOPLE.
THE OFFICE OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION SO I'M HAVING
SAID THAT AT THIS POINT IN TIME --
I WILL NOT BE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
AUDIT -- BUT
I WOULD I COMMIT TO OF THE WORK
THE AUTHOR WHOSE REQUESTED THE
AUDIT THAT --
AT THE END OF THAT
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN I AM
CERTAINLY TO THE EXTENT I'M
STILL HERE --
WHO KNOWS IT'S POLITICS --
I WILL I WILL REVISIT THE ISSUE
IN WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE BUT I
REQUEST AT THAT TIME THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
CENTER FULLER [inaudible]
SO -- IF
YOU'VE MADE SEVERAL DECISIONS
NOW THERE'S ME IS OPINIONS OF
COME AND UP.
IS MY UNDERSTANDING CORRECT THAT
ALL OF THIS THAT APPEALS THAT
YOU HAVE CONSIDERED SO FAR HAVE
BEEN FOUND IN FAVOR OF THE HAD
TAX AGENCY RATHER THAN THE
TAXPAYER.
LET ME LET ME.
THANK YOU CENTER FOR THAT
QUESTION LET ME PUT SOME
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT OF THE CASES
THAT ARE NOW POSTED ON OUR
WEBSITE AND WE HAVE SOME.
STEVE SEVENTY I BELIEVE OUR
THERE'S A THERE'S A COUPLE CASES
THAT ARE IN FAVOR THE TAXPAYER --
THERE ARE MORE COMING LIKELY IN
THE NEXT TRUNKS BECAUSE THAT
CASES THAT WE STARTED OUT WITH --
WERE VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD BREAD
AND BUTTER CASES THEY INVOLVE
PENALTY CASES WHERE THERE'S NOT
A LOT OF GRAY AREA IN THESE
CASES OR HEAD OF HOUSEHOLD CASES
WHERE THAT THE LEGISLATURE MADE
A DECISION THAT CATEGORICALLY
YOU ARE ELIGIBLE FOR HEAD OF
HOUSEHOLD OR YOU'RE NOT --
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
THE DISCRETION SOME OF THESE
CASES ARE QUITE --
SYMPATHETIC WE DON'T BELIEVE WE
HAVE THE DISCRETION TO ACT ON
THAT WE ARE A LJ IS ACT AS A
MATTER OF LAW IN MAKING THOSE
DECISIONS --
I SUSPECT THAT --
WELL I DON'T SUSPECT I KNOW THAT
SOME OF THE CASES THEY'RE COMING
DOWN THE LINE SOME OF THE MUCH
MORE COMPLEX CASES WHERE THERE
[inaudible]
OF OF REASONABLE POINTS OF VIEW
ON ON EITHER SIDE FOR EXAMPLE A
TAX CREDITS ARE INDEED CREDITS
THINGS LIKE THAT --
WE CAN EXPECT TO SEE SOME
DIFFERENT OPINIONS AND A SENSE
AND SO FORTH I'D ALSO ADD THAT
DURING THE PROCESS OF THE
APPEALS WHEAT WE THE ALJ IS
TOGETHER WHERE OUR STAFF
ATTORNEYS HOLD PRE HEARING
CONFERENCES.
AND MANY OF THOSE CONFERENCES
ISSUES COME TO LIGHT.
BY EITHER THE TAX AGENCY OR THE
TAXPAYER AND THE TAXATION SHE
HAS WITHDRAWN --
BECAUSE THEY DON'T FEEL LIKE
THAT WAS SAID A SUITABLE.
SO I'VE SEEN I APPRECIATE IT BUT
AS WE'VE SEEN WE'VE BEEN HERE
FOR LIKE LONGTIME WAS THAT WAS
GO SO I JUST REALLY THAT WHAT'S
THE RECORD OF TAX PAYERS APPEALS
GRANTED VERSES [inaudible]
NOT GRANTED.
OF WHAT YOU'VE DONE SO FAR IS
YOUR BEST ESTIMATE --
YOU KNOW I WOULD I WOULD PREFER
TO GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT
QUESTION AND THE REASON.
I AS WELL AS SPEAKS SO THAT'S
FINE -- SO
IS IT NOT.
THAT THERE ARE NO TAX PAYER
APPEALS THAT HAVE SUCCEEDED.
IT IS TRUE THAT THERE AND
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT ARE POSTED
RIGHT NOW THERE IS A DECISION
THAT WENT IN FAVOR THE TAXPAYER
WITH RESPECT TO A PETITION FOR
REHEARING OF A CASE.
THE OTHERS I BELIEVE ARE IN
FAVOR OF THE TAX AGENTS.
I THINK THERE [inaudible]
THAT.
THAT'S NORMAL ALL I'M GOOD GALA
NEED IS A SNAPSHOT FOR ME TO
DECIDE.
AND AT THIS POINT A PROBABLY
MAKING THE MOTION TO MOVE
FORWARD BECAUSE THERE'S SOME --
POSSIBILITY THAT THAT SHOULD BE
INVESTIGATED BUT I DON'T I AGREE
THAT YOU HAVE RATIONAL ARGUMENTS
IT SOUND LIKE IT'S PROBABLY.
GOING TO CHANGE THE RECORD IN
THE FUTURE.
GIVEN THE DIFFERENT KINDS OF
CASES THAT ARE COMING BUT IT'S
JUST NOT HERE FOR US TO SEE
TODAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
THIS BAKER.
THANK YOU THAT ALSO PEAKED MY
INTEREST AS WELL AND I HEARD
THAT BUT I I WANNA GO BACK TO
YOUR TESTIMONY ABOUT.
BACKLOG IN THAT THERE ISN'T.
ONE AND I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
IS WHAT SOME CLARIFICATION YOU
MENTION THAT THE CASES THAT CAME
BACK CAME TO YOU WERE ONES THAT
EXISTED BEFORE --
IS IS THAT CORRECT THAT THAT IS
CORRECT OKAY CHAU DO YOU.
BUT REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY
CAME FROM DO YOU HAVE A BACKLOG.
MAYBE THEY WERE THE ONES YOU'VE
CAUSED OR HAPPENED WHERE YOUR
EXISTENCE BUT IS THERE THERE'S A
BACKLOG.
THERE IS NOT A BACKLOG.
A TWELVE HUNDRED CASES WHERE THE
CASES THAT WE INHERITED FROM BE
A WEEK IN THE TRANSITION THERE
WERE CASES IN PROCESS.
OTA TOOK THEM OVER.
THERE WAS A BACKLOG OF A COUPLE
OF SEVERAL.
I I DON'T KNOW THE EXACT NUMBERS
AND IT WAS A FEW --
HUNDRED THREE FOUR HUNDRED OF
CASES THAT NEEDED TO BE
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT AS THE
TAXPAYER HAD FILED AN APPEAL AND
IT HAD NOT BEEN ACKNOWLEDGED YET
I SUSPECT THAT IS BECAUSE OF
SOME CONFUSION THE TRANSITION.
ALL OF THOSE HAVE BEEN
ACKNOWLEDGED.
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE WAS
A BACKLOG IT WAS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT INITIAL RESPONSE TO THE
TAXPAYER.
THOSE A BIDDING KNOWLEDGE AND
THEY ARE IN OUR SYSTEM THEY ARE
PART OF THAT. FIFTEEN HUNDRED
CASE THAT I MENTION.
NOW HAVING SAID THAT WE ARE
ACTUALLY GETTING MORE APPEALS
THEN -- BEER
WE AT THIS POINT.
SO -- WE ARE
WE ARE KATA WE'RE CAUGHT UP BUT
INITIALLY WE EXPECTED.
APPEALS ON THE ORDER OF SAY A
HUNDRED TWENTY A MONTH WE'RE
GETTING MORE LIKE A HUNDRED
THIRTY HUNDRED FORTY SO IT'S
POSSIBLE WE NEED.
TO REASSESS OUR RESOURCES TO
MAKE SURE WE KEEP UP WITH THE
WITH THE APPEALS PROCESS AND
RESPOND IN A TIMELY MANNER.
MAY MAYBE I'M --
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT YOUR
CONSIDERING THE BACKLOG IS IT
THAT IN SEMI DIDN'T GET A
RESPONSE.
AND THAT YOU TOOK CARE OF THAT
BECAUSE I GOT A RESPONSE OR IS
IT JUST YOU HAVE YOU HAVE A CASE
LOAD WASN'T MUCH COURSE EVER.
EVER CASELOAD BUT THEN THERE
SOME THAT OURS ARE OLD.
AND I SO WHAT WOULD IT WOULD DO
WELL YOU SAY WE HAVE NO BACKLOG
WHAT I WOULD CONSIDER A BACKLOG
IF.
WE GOT A HUNDRED TWENTY CASES
AND IN A MONTH AND WE ONLY WORK
THROUGH ONE HUNDRED OF THEM.
WE GOT TWENTY CASES THAT ARE
DELAYED AND IS THAT TWENTY EACH
MONTH ACCUMULATES THAT BECOMES A
BACKLOG THAT'S NOT WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW.
OKAY AND HAVE YOU DO YOU KNOW
HOW YOUR RATE OF DEALING WITH
THOSE CASES IS COMPARED TO WHEN
BE A WE WAS THE ENTITY.
BECAUSE JUST BIT HOW YOU COMPARE
FOR ME IF THERE IS A BACKLOG AND
THEY'RE SOMETHING THAT ALREADY
AT THIS EARLY STAGE IS A CONCERN.
WE'RE WATCHING THAT VERY
CAREFULLY YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S SAM.
WE HAVE A LIMITED.
HISTORICAL RECORD AT THIS POINT --
I I THINK GIVEN OUR CURRENT
RESOURCES WE CAN KEEP ON WE CAN
KEEP ON TRACK WE'RE IN GOOD
SHAPE RIGHT NOW BUT WE NEED TO
WATCH IT VERY CAREFULLY --
IN TERMS OF ADDRESSING THAT WAS
CERTAINLY THE BILL WE HAVE A
LONG HISTORY OF HOW LONG IT
EXISTED AND SAID YOU HAVE A
SENSE OF JUST WHAT.
EVEN IN YOUR SHORT TIME PERIOD
WITH THE CASES.
BUT YOU HAVE THAT COMPARED TO
WHAT BILLY WAS DOING DO YOU KNOW
THAT THE THE LIKE THE TIME THE
TEXT OF THE CASE TAKES TO GO
THROUGH THE SYSTEM IS OR ARE HOW
HOW QUICKLY SOME RATE OF SOME
POINT OF COMPARISON BECAUSE THAT
IS ONE OF THE POINTS THAT.
WERE STRUCK OUT IN MY MIND IS
VERY INTERESTING IS THAT IF WE
ARE OF MADE THIS TRANSITION OVER.
IT HAS A LONG HISTORY OF HOW IT
ALL CAME TO BE BUT WHAT IF IF
I'M.
IF WE ARE NOW SEEN A POSSIBILITY
THAT TAXPAYERS WILL NOT BE
SERVED UP BECAUSE THERE'S A VERY
LONG BACKLOG.
DOESN'T REALLY MATTER TO ME HOW
LONG IT IS JUST AS ARE PEOPLE
DOING THEIR WORK AS DILIGENTLY
AS THEY POSSIBLY CAN AND WE WILL
YOUR EXISTENCE IS A LITTLE BIT
SHORTER.
THE DELAY WAS LONGER SO SHOULD
HAVE SOME POINT OF REFERENCE --
IF IF IF A TAXPAYER GOES THROUGH
THE THROUGH THE REGULAR PROCESS
OF THE APPEAL PROCESS THAT IS IT
DOESN'T THERE'S NO EXCEPTIONS IT
WASN'T TAKEN OUT FOR SETTLEMENT
THEN CAME BACK AND IT'S ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY DAYS WE
EXPECT THE PROCESS.
ONCE WE ARE FULLY IMPLEMENTED
WITHOUT TO BE SHORTER THAN IT
TAKES ON OF THE BE AWAY AND I
WOULD I WOULD ADD.
THAT WITH EVERY CASE THAT COMES
TO O. T. A THERE IS A WRITTEN
OPINION THAT'S POSTED THAT GOES
TO THE TAXPAYER.
SOME OF THE LENGTH OF TIME THEN
IS FOR THE JUDGES DON'T MAKE
DECISIONS OF THESE CASES ON THE
SPOT SHIRT GO BACK TO TAKE
THIRTY DAYS IN THE ISSUE THE
OPINION SOME ISN'T JUST HOW IT
COMPARES TO BE AWAY ITSELF LIKE
MAYBE NOT.
THERE IS THERE ISN'T THERE AT
DIFFERENT HOUSES THERE ARE
DIFFERENT PROCESS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING THEIR FURTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE
COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC.
ON THIS ITEM SEEING NONE --
SENATOR BEFORE I GIVING
OPPORTUNITY CLOSE I S. WANTED.
SHARE MY THOUGHTS IN AYE I THINK.
WE GENERALLY.
WELL FIRST OF ALL WE CAN
CERTAINLY RESPECT YOUR WE ARE
STRONG PERSONAL INTEREST IN --
AND THE EN IN THE SUBJECT MATTER
AND WE THE HOME.
APPRECIATE YOUR A REQUEST HERE
AYE ME BUT I I I FEEL THAT --
THAT -- IN A
WHILE WE GENERALLY SUPPORT AUDIT
REQUESTS FROM.
OUR FELLOW LEGISLATORS HERE ODD
THAT THIS.
ONE IF IF THERE'S A CASE FOR AYE
I REQUEST TO BE PREMATURE THAT
SEEMS TO BE.
ONE OF WHERE WE HAVE --
A NEW HOW NEW AGENCIES --
AS AS THE OPPOSITE TAX APPEALS
INDICATED THEY'VE ONLY HAD TWO
UNDER WORKING DAYS --
THE THE ONLINE SYSTEMS BEEN ON
ONLY FOR THREE MONTHS AND AS THE
BAD STATE AUDITOR.
AHA INDICATOR WHILE SHE'S NOT
TAKING  POSITION ON THIS
REQUEST THAT GENERALLY SPEAKING.
THEY WOULD LIKE SOMETIME SOON IN
A TO A BODY OF EVIDENCE TO TO
EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF A
OF A OF AN AGENCY AND AND AND
AND SOME.
BODY OF WORK LOW TO REVIEW AND
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT YET AND SO.
OUR I AM RECOMMENDING GO --
A DENIAL OF THIS REQUEST BUT WHY
GIVE THE LAST WORD YET GREAT
THANK YOU.
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO MAKE THIS PRESENTATION --
I HAVE TURNS --
WITH THE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGES AND ONCE YOU HAVE BEEN
APPOINTED.
SOME OF WHICH HAVE COME FROM THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD.
SOME OF WHICH HAVE WORKED ON
CASES.
REPRESENTING THE STATE AND THE
STATE HAS CERTAIN VIEW ON THOSE
CASES.
SO I'D BE INTERESTED IN KNOWING.
WHERE THEIR APPOINTEES THAT HAVE
SERVED?
AS AN ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE
WITH THE OTA.
THAT HAVE MADE DECISIONS ON
CASES THAT THEY ALREADY WORKED
ON BOB NUMBER --
TWO THE CASES THAT HAVE BEEN
HEARD BY THE OTA EVOLVE IN
INCOME TAX APPEALS.
SO WE'VE HAD HUNDREDS OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE WANTED TO
BRING THEIR SALES AND USE TAX
ISSUES FORWARD. FOR WHICH THERE
ARE PENALTIES THAT ARE RUNNING.
AND HAVEN'T BEEN HEARD. FOR
MONTHS ON END [inaudible]
SO -- AS A
RESULT OF THE PRIORITY.
OF THE OTA --
WILL THOSE PEOPLE NOT BE
ASSESSED ADDITIONAL PENALTIES
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN.
WAITING AT THE BACK OF THE LINE
AND NOT HURT THEIR CASES HER NOT
HAVE THEIR HEAD OF CASES HURTS
UP.
UNDER THE VIA E. THOSE --
DOZENS AND DOZENS OF THOSE CASES
WERE --
WOULD'VE BEEN TAKEN UP THROUGH
THE MEETING PROCESS.
SO THOSE OUR ARE REAL CONCERNS
THAT I HAVE THAT I THINK --
YOU KNOW I I THINK THAT'S
JUSTIFIED TO MOVE FORWARD --
WITHIN AUDIT THAT --
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT --
JUST I I'VE GOT CONCERNED AS TO
WHETHER.
YOU KNOW DO WE HAVE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES THAT
ARE TRULY INDEPENDENT.
AND THEN WHY THE PRIORITY FOR
INCOME TAX.
VERSES INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE A
SALES HER VALUES TAX ISSUE
[inaudible]
THAT -- FOR
WHICH PENALTIES ARE CONTINUING
ON A DAILY BASIS --
INCREASING.
AND THEN FINALLY AND SOME OF
THESE CASES YOU'VE HAD THE OUR
* -- GO
AHEAD AND GRANT --
FLEXIBILITY I WAS READING --
ONE CASE IN PARTICULAR WHERE
THERE IS ADAPT THE DEATH OF A
FAMILY MEMBER.
AND THE IRS GRANTED ADDITIONAL
TIME FOR THE DOCUMENTATION AND
THE PAYMENT TO BE MADE.
AND THAT WAS DENIED BY THE DOD.
SO -- I'M
SHE'S MAY NOT BY THE DOD THE OTA
SO MY HOPE WOULD BE.
THAT.
THERE WOULD BE --
SOME GRACE ON THE PART OF OCHIAI.
HAD THESE --
AS THESE CASES MOVE FORWARD
WE'RE DEALING WITH SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS.
BUT OFTEN ARE NOT SOPHISTICATED.
AND NOT FAMILIAR WITH --
THE LAW.
AND THEY'RE GETTING CAUGHT UP IN
THINGS AND IN SOME CASES ASIA
SHUTTING BUSINESS AND THE BEER
WE HAD THAT ABILITY --
AND I'M NOT SEEING IT --
EXPRESSED YET BY THE OTA
[inaudible]
AND SO --
MAYBE THAT WOULD CHANGE IN THE
FUTURE.
BUT I WOULD I WOULD URGE AN AYE
VOTE TO MOVE FOR WITH THE AUDIT
I THINK THERE'S ENOUGH CONCERN
HERE -- THAT
WE OUGHT TO MOVE FORWARD AND
MAKE SURE THAT.
THERE'S COMPLETE TRANSPARENCY OR
AND WE LOOK AT THE ACT IT'S
CALLED THE TAXPAYER TRANSPARENCY.
AND FAIRNESS ACCESO.
HAS BEEN TRANSPARENT.
AND OUR PEOPLE BEING TREATED
FAIRLY AND I'VE SEEN EXAMPLES
[inaudible]
OF BOTH.
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN THE CASE OF
THE TITLE OF THE ACT.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
SO.
MOTIONS DEMAND IS OUR SECOND.
SECOND --
MADAM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ROLL CALL INTO PROOF AUDIT
REQUEST NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN CASH ONCE HE FIVE THE
TAXPAYER TRANSPARENCY IN
FAIRNESS ACT FROM CENTER GAINES.
CHAIRS RECOMMENDATIONS THE NO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WERE SUCI.
PURSUE CHINO ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I NAZARIAN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO NO WAY [inaudible]
SEATOR ROBB [inaudible]
ROTH NO [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
CANNELLA ALERT [inaudible]
FULLER I LARA.
I WRITE THAT REQUEST IS ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF NO OKAY.
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY --
NON COMMITTEE MEMBERS PRESENTING
SO MS RUBIO WHICH I LIKE.
TO THIS IS ITEM TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THAT'S ONE TWENTY EIGHT
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
WORK RELATED INJURIES.
AUDIT REQUESTS FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO.
WE HAVE ONE TWO THREE FOUR ITEMS
LAGGED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT A SIMPLE
AUDIT.
WHICH SEEKS TO GAIN IMPORTANT
INFORMATION REGARDING HOW
EFFICIENT OUR WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM IS WORKING.
THIS AUDIT WILL PROVIDE
INDEPENDENTLY DEVELOPED
UNVERIFIED INFORMATION RELATED
TO WORK RELATED INJURIES
INCURRED BY BOTH EMPLOYEES AND
INMATES WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION.
I'M IT TOTALLY CONCERNS HAVE
BEEN RAISED ABOUT THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER WE DO NOT HAVE
SUFFICIENT INDEPENDENT DATA
WHICH CAN GUIDE POLICYMAKERS.
BY COMPARING THE TIME LINES OF
MEDICAL TREATMENT PROVIDED TO
CDC ARE EMPLOYEES AND INMATES.
THE ARTICLE CHAU REASONS FOR ANY
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCES WHICH
CAN GUIDE FUTURE POLICY
DISCUSSIONS.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE JASON
MARKETS PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
APPLICANT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
TO HELP ANTI ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION OF THIS REQUEST I
RESPECTFULLY ASK [inaudible]
FOR A GOOD.
I GUESS AND YOU KNOW MISTER
CHAIRMAN CAN BE MEMBERS --
AS THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID
MY NAME IS JASON MARKETS ON THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
APPLICANTS ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
OR ORGANIZATION OF LAWYERS THAT
PROBABLY REPRESENT INJURED
WORKERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AYE WE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO'S I
REQUEST.
BUT WHAT THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION REFORM BILLS THAT
HAVE BEEN SIGNED IN ENACTED BY
THE GOVERNOR BROWN OVER THE PAST
NUMBER OF YEARS HAVE RESULTED IN
INCREASED PERMANENT DISABILITY
BENEFITS FOR INJURED WORKERS.
AND IT RESULTED IN LOWER
INSURANCE COSTS TO EMPLOYEES AS
WELL AS RECORD PROFITS FOR
INSURANCE CARRIERS.
THE COST OF THESE REFORMS HAS
BEEN UNACCEPTABLE DELAYS IN
PROVIDING MEDICAL TREATMENT TO
INJURED WORKERS.
I AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID
THE LEGISLATURE WE BELIEVE NEEDS
ITS OWN SOURCE OF INFORMATION TO
ASSESS THE DELAYS IN PROVIDING
MEDICAL TREATMENT TO INJURED
WORKERS.
THE SOONER THE TREATMENTS
PROVIDED THE CENTER THE WORKER
CAN RECOVER AND RETURN TO WORK.
JUST LAST MONTH THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION RESEARCH INSTITUTE
RELEASED A REPORT THEY COMPARED
WORKERS COMPENSATION INJURIES
AND THE DELIVERY OF MEDICAL
TREATMENT --
IN EIGHTEEN STATES HERE IN THE
COUNTRY.
CALIFORNIA RANKED OF THE WORST
THAT IS THE SLOWEST OUT OF ALL
THE STATES WHEN IT COMES TO DAYS
BETWEEN AN INJURY AND WHEN
MEDICAL TREATMENT IS ACTUALLY
PROVIDED TO AN INJURED WORKER.
IN SHORT OUR EXPECTATION IS THAT
THE STATE AUDITOR WILL UNCOVER
THIS SIMPLE FACT THE
CALIFORNIA'S INJURED WORKERS ARE
FACING UNACCEPTABLE DELAYS.
IN RECEIVING MEDICAL TREATMENT
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON THE I REQUEST THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER YOU KNOW OKAY.
HAZARDS OF TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
OVER TRICKLE REPRESENTING
COMFORT UP CLINTON'S TECHNICIAN
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
STATE ARE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
INDICATED THIS THIS IS GOING TO
BE AN AUDIT DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WAS.
A DISCUSSED WHERE WE WOULD BE
LOOKING AT POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES THAT CCR HAS FOR
RESPONDING TO AN PROVIDING
TREATMENT. TO NOT ONLY INJURED
EMPLOYEES BUT INMATES WHO WORK
IN THE FACILITY SO INMATE WORK
RELATED OUR INJURIES SO LOOKING
AT POLICIES AND PROCEDURES AND
THEN.
ARE ACTUALLY DOING SOME ANALYSIS
OF THAT WE OBTAIN A AND AGAIN WE
WOULD USE OUR IT FOLKS AND
CERTAINLY NOT PARTNERING WITH
THE AUDIT STAFF.
LOOKING AT DATA THAT CCR HAS
REGARDING OUR WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS AN INMATE
WORK RELATED INJURIES ARE TO
DETERMINE VARIOUS PHASES SO.
THAT THE AMOUNT OF TIME BETWEEN
THE OCCURRENCE OF THE INJURY THE
RECOMMENDED TREATMENT WHEN THAT
TREATMENT WAS ACTUALLY EXCUSE ME
PROVIDED.
ON THE NUMBER OF DAYS BETWEEN
THE RECOMMENDATION IF IT WAS
FIRST SURGICAL INTERVENTION WHEN
DID THAT SURGICAL INTERVENTION
TAKE PLACE OR THE EARLY THE
APPROPRIATE.
A SURGICAL PROCEDURE PROVIDED TO
THE D. INJURED INDIVIDUAL
WHETHER IT'S A AN EMPLOYEE OR AN
INMATE.
WHO WAS WORKING AT A FACILITY
AND HAS BEEN INJURED?
ON THE NUMBER OF DAYS BETWEEN
FIRST RECEIVING CARE AND
ACTUALLY BEING RELEASED FROM
CARE AND THEN THE NEXT PHASE IS
REALLY LOOKING AT BEING RELEASED
FROM CARE IN BEING ABLE TO
RETURN BACK TO WORK.
AND THEN THE FINAL OBJECTIVE
DIDN'T SKEWS ME IS TO COMPARE
AND CONTRAST.
I APOLOGIZE --
TIMELINESS AND IDENTIFY ARE
THERE ANY ANY PLACES WHERE THERE
COULD BE MORE EFFICIENCIES IS
THERE A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN OUR
TREATMENT OF EMPLOYEES AND THEIR
INJURIES AN INMATE --
INMATES WHO ARE INJURED ON THE
JOB BUT ALSO JUST LOOKING AT
TIMELINESS OVERALL AND DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THERE ARE THINGS
THAT YOU SEE ARE COULD BE DOING
OR THE SYSTEM COULD BE DOING.
OUGHT TO MAKE THAT PROCESS MORE
EFFECTIVE DAY AUDIT IS BUDGETED
ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
EIGHTY HOURS THE REASON FOR THAT
IS WE WILL WE BELIEVE WE NEED TO
DO WORK BOTH THAT.
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
HEADQUARTERS.
I APOLOGIZE --
AND SOME OF THE OF FACILITIES IN
THE STATE.
A WITHOUT MISTER CHERYL
ANSWERING QUESTIONS MEMBER MAY
HAVE.
IRATE ENERGY --
O. BEFORE OPEN FOR ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IT WOULD --
THE CDC ARE LIKE.
TO GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
EMPRESS APPLEGATE WITH
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION OFFICE OF
LEGISLATION AYE WERE OBVIOUSLY
HAPPY TO COOPERATE WITH THE
AUDIT IF IT GETS IMPROVED THERE
WERE A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT WE
WANTED TO MENTION SPECIFICALLY
THAT WE HAVE GREAT WITH THE
OFFICE OFFICE AS WELL.
WILD ON IT IS SPECIFICALLY
DIRECTED AT CDC ARE MUCH OF THE
INFORMATION THAT THE AUDIT SEEKS
IS ACTUALLY NOT HOUSE WITHIN CDC
ARE.
IT'S HOUSE WITHIN THE STATE
COMPENSATION INSURANCE YEAH --
AND SO THAT DIDN'T THE
INFORMATION THAT WE WOULD HAVE
RELATED TO THIS WOULD BE
INFORMATION RELATED SPECIFICALLY
TO INMATE HEALTH CARE PROVIDED
FOR INMATE WORKERS --
DOT IS.
THAT'S INFORMATION THAT IS
CONTROLLED BY CDC ARE BUT IT IS
ALSO.
NOT NECESSARILY AN APPROPRIATE
COMPARISON BETWEEN THAT AND
EMPLOYEES UNDER TO GET YEAR
BECAUSE YOU SEE OUR IS REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE CONSTITUTIONALLY
HEALTH CARE TO ITS INMATES WHEN
THEY GET INJURED AND THAT'S
OUTSIDE OF THAT --
THE PROCESSES AND PROCEDURES
THERE'D AIR THAT ARE AT ISSUE
HERE WITH EMPLOYEES WHO GET
INJURED WHILE THEIR WORK --
WE HAVE SPOKEN WITH THE STATE
COMPENSATION INSURANCE FUND THEY
SAID THEY ARE WILLING TO PROVIDE
THIS INFORMATION OUTSIDE OF THE
AUDIT PROCESS AND THEY BELIEVE
THAT THEY'RE PUTTING IT TOGETHER
NOW THEY BELIEVE THEY COULD HAVE
A TOGETHER WITHIN A WEEK'S ALSO
JUST POINTING OUT.
GIVEN THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE
CHAIR EARLIER THAT THE
INFORMATION ITSELF IS NOT
NECESSARILY INFORMATION THAT IS
NOT IT IS REQUIRED TO TO BE
PROVIDED DEPARTMENT AND ON THE
STATE COMPENSATION INSURANCE
FUND WOULD BE WILLING TO PROVIDE
THAT OUTSIDE OF THE OUT OF THAT
AS WELL.
RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE BUTTON.
SEEING NONE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC.
PLEASE COME FORTH.
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS VICTORIA
HASSEY IT IN ON THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS WE OVERSEE
THE DIVISION OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION.
WE ALSO HOUSE THE COMMISSION ON
HEALTH SAFETY AND WORKERS
COMPENSATION WHICH IS A BODY
THAT IS CHARGED WITH STUDYING.
ALL THINGS WITHIN SYSTEM AND
COULD EASILY HANDLE THIS REQUEST --
AND WE WOULD ASK THAT THIS
REQUEST BE REDIRECTED TO THE
BODIES WE THINK IT IS THE MORE
APPROPRIATE FORUM FOR SUCH A
STUDY.
AND THINK YOU [inaudible]
ALRIGHT [inaudible]
ANNIA.
NEXT WITNESS OUR COMMENT.
YES HELLO MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WANTED MYERS AT REPRESENTING
STATE PINE JUST WANTED TO
REITERATE THAT STATEMENT WILL
HAVE THIS DATA AVAILABLE.
WITHIN A WEEK WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF THE INMATE INFORMATION AS
CHRIS MENTIONED EARLIER
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
BUT BEFORE GOING FURTHER --
DID THEY HAVE TO COMMENTS FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS.
TO AS YOU BE SUGGESTING THAT
PERHAPS THERE'S A BETTER WAY OF
SEEKING THE INFORMATION THAT FOR
THE INFORMATION THAT I RECEIVED --
OUR EARLIER THIS WEEK WAS THAT
THAT JOB IS CDC ARE WE HAVE THAT
INSTALLED THE INFORMATION BUT
THEY DIDN'T HAVE.
ALL OF IT AND SO I WOULD DEFER
TO THE AUDITOR TO SEE IF IT'S
SOMETHING THAT --
IT'S BEEN FACT CORRECT BECAUSE I
JUST LEANED OVER AND ASKED HER
IF SHE KNEW THAT THEY WERE AND
SHE DIDN'T SO.
I WOULD DEFER TO THE AUDITOR TO
SEE IF THERE'S SOMETHING
DIFFERENT THAT WE KNOW THAT OR
THAT THEY KNOW THAT WE DON'T.
WELL LIT WAS LIKE --
WELL WE CERTAINLY HAVE ACCESS TO
INFORMATION THAT STATE
COMPENSATION INSURANCE FUND OUT
WE HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO AUDIT
THEM SO WE COULD GET ACCESS AND
IT SOUNDS LIKE.
BASED ON THE PRESENTATION
THEY'RE WILLING.
TO IN WITH US NOW TO THE EXTENT
CCR HAS INFORMATION WE WOULD
LOOK AT THAT --
I'M FAMILIAR WITH THE WORKERS
COMP I THINK IT WAS THAT I'M NOT
SURE.
I'D BE ASSOCIATION THAT THE%
FIRST WITNESS WAS A PUBLIC
WITNESS WAS ASSOCIATED WITH BUT
I KNOW THERE IS A WORKERS COMP
RESEARCH BUREAU.
THAT DOES SOME ANALYSIS I DON'T
KNOW STE ALL THE SPECIFICS ABOUT
THE ANALYSES FOR THE TYPES OF
ANALYSES THAT THEY DO.
CERTAINLY WE IF THEY HAVE
INFORMATION --
THAT WOULD BE PERTINENT TO THE
AUDIT WE WOULD LOOK AT THAT
INFORMATION ALRIGHT STATE SO SHE
WAS ARE UPSET OVER THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS AND AND WHAT I HEARD
WAS THAT PERHAPS --
HER AGENCY WOULD.
BE OF MORE RELEVENT --
RESPONDING AGENCY.
THAT TO THE ISSUES BEING RAISED
THAT DID IT I HEAR YOU CORRECTLY.
YES WE OVERSEE THERE'S AN
INDEPENDENT COMMISSION OF HEALTH
SAFETY AND WORKERS COMPENSATION.
IT HAS BEEN AROUND FIRST ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE YEARS IT HAS MEMBERS
OF APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR AND
THE LEGISLATURE.
AND IT IS CHARGED WITH STUDYING
THE WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM
ISSUES AND ANY MEMBER CAN
REQUEST.
THE COMMISSION TO REVIEW TO
CONSIDER STUDY TYPICALLY THEY
THEN DISCUSS AMONGST THE
COMMISSION MEMBERS VOTE TO
APPROVE THE STUDY IN AND IS THEN --
CONDUCTED THROUGH AN OPEN
VETTING PROCESS WE'VE HAD MANY
STUDIES CONDUCTED BY BOTH
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND RAN.
WHO HAVE USE ROBUST AND PEER
REVIEWED MATH --
METHODOLOGIES AND PARTLY ANALYST
DOES MUCH AND AN ISSUE OF ACCESS
TO THE INFORMATION WE THINK IT
WOULD BE --
WHO COULD BACK WHO KNOWS THE
SYSTEM WHILE AND COULD SAY THESE
QUESTIONS AND PERHAPS RECOMMEND
OTHERS THAT WOULD BE?
HELPFUL FOR THE REQUEST HER
CURRENT BEFORE TURN OVER TO MR
ON ACOSTA MISERABLY I JUST WANNA
CONFIRM THAT YOU WANT TO PROCEED
WITH AT THE REQUEST OF HEY I IT
SOUNDS LIKE THEY'RE GOING TO BE
CONTRACTED WITH SOMEBODY ELSE TO
GET THE RESEARCH AND I WOULD BE.
MORE -- I
THINK MORE COME IN FACT THEY
HAVE THE INFORMATION THEN THE
THE AMOUNT OF HOURS AT THE
AUDITOR WOULD HAVE TO SPEND
WOULD BE --
TO LESS OBVIOUSLY SO AGAIN I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FOR
THE AUDITOR TO CONDUCT THAT AND
AGAIN IF IF THE INFORMATION IS
READILY AVAILABLE THEN --
THE AUDITOR COULD COMPLETE THAT
AND IF NOT THEN SHE WOULD
CONTINUE WITH THE REQUEST.
BUT OTHER MEMBERS CHAIRMAN
THOUGH THE ONLY OTHER THING I
WOULD ADD IS THAT THE DR WILL
RUN TO SEE PROMISE GIVE.
THEIR OF ACCIDENTALLY
INFORMATION EITHER.
HER BACK TO SCHOOL THANK YOU
MISS RUBIO I MEAN DEMONSTRATE
BUSTER AND HAVEN'T.
I SIMILAR COMMENTS I MEAN THAT
THE DEPARTMENT BUT JUST A
RELATIONS KEPT REFERRING TO A
STUDY THIS IS NOT A STUDY THIS
IS AN AUDIT RIGHT NOW.
PERFORMED BY AN OUTSIDE AGENCY
THAT THE PURPOSE OF AN AUDIT BY
THE STATE AUDITOR IS THAT.
ALL ASPECTS CAN BE LOOKED AT AND
DELVED INTO THEY HAVE STATUTORY
LEGAL AUTHORITY TO GO INTO AREAS
THAT YOU KNOW THE YOU SEE --
WHO HER RESEARCHER MAY OR MAY
NOT OF ALL RESPECT FOR YOU SEE
SYSTEMS THAT A FABULOUS JOB
LET'S BRING THEM ON YOU KNOW?
ONLINE AS WELL BUT WE HAVE A A
PROCESS BY WHICH THE LEGISLATURE
WORKS IN THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE
TO THE UP.
THROUGH THE AUDITOR'S OFFICE TO
REALLY GET INTO THESE --
THESE ISSUES AND I THINK IT'S
MUCH MORE APPROPRIATE VENUE --
FOR THE STATE AUDITOR'S DO THIS
WORK RATHER THAN THAT PART DOES
RELATIONS THANK YOU ALRIGHT BANG
AND I WOULD ALLMOVIE OUT IT JUST
MEANS.
THAT NO ONE ELSE TO DO IT LIKE
THAT GENERAL.
SECOND ALRIGHT --
WE HAVE RECEIVED PUBLIC COMMENTS --
MS RUBIO WHICH LIKE CLOTHES
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ALRIGHT TO MOST
HAS BEEN MADE AND SECONDED
CHARTS RECOMMENDATION IS AN AYE --
MADAM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THRILLCALL TO APPROVE ORDER
CUSTOMER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
CASH ONE TWO EIGHT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AND WORK RELATED
INJURIES.
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO.
CHAIRS RECOMMENDATIONS AND I
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MERCY CHI.
MERCY CHI AYE ACOSTA AYE AYE
ACOSTA AYE BAKER [inaudible]
THEREIN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE WOULD
[inaudible]
SENATOR ROTH [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
FELL [inaudible]
CANNELLA.
CANNELLA AYE FULLER [inaudible]
LARA.
ARE I REQUEST IS ON CALL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU --
WE DO NOT SEE ANY --
PRESENTERS --
IN THE ROOM --
MR GRAY AND MR BONTA IF YOU
WOULD LIKE YOUR REQUEST TO BE.
A CONSERVE PLEASE COME --
TO THE COMMITTEE HEARING --
WE WILL NOW PROCEED WITH THE
STATE AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDED HIGH
RISK LOCAL AUDIT FOR THE CITY OF
THAT WAR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS --
KNITWEAR BACK AYE AS YOU FARM
SURE RECALL WE REQUESTED.
APPROVAL OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
CONDUCT AN AUDIT OF THE CITY OF
ATWATER AFTER WE HAD IT
COMPLETED INITIAL ASSESSMENT AT
THAT HEARING IT WAS DECIDED THAT.
ATWATER WOULD PROVIDE US
ADDITIONAL AND AND THEN WE WOULD
DETERMINE WHETHER TO COME BACK
WE HAVE RECEIVED THAT
INFORMATION FROM THE CITY OF
ATWATER --
AND WE STILL HAVE SUFFICIENT
CONCERNS ARE WE I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THEY HAVE TAKEN SOME
STEPS.
OUGHT TO MOVE IN A DIRECTION
THAT WILL BE HELPFUL TO THE CITY
BUT THERE WERE A VARIETY OF
ISSUES RELATED --
TO THEY'VE RUN A GENERAL FUND
DEFICIT FOR TEN OF THE LAST
ELEVEN YEARS OTHER FISCAL YEAR
THEIR THEIR BUDGET FOR THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR DOESN'T
COMPLETELY ELIMINATE.
THE DEFICIT.
WE WOULD EXPECT THAT TO HAPPEN
IMMEDIATELY BUT CERTAINLY WE'RE
LOOKING FOR PLANS UP OVER A
LONGER TERM LONG TERM
FORECASTING AND WE DON'T REALLY
SEE A FORMAL PLAN MOVING FORWARD
TO TRY TO KEEP THEMSELVES OUT
FROM.
RUNNING A DEFICIT IN THE GENERAL
FUND. FOR THE CITY ARM AND AND
THAT HAS A AN ADDITIONAL
AFFECTED THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE IDENTIFY PROBLEMS BACK IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN WHERE THE CITY
WAS -- USING
FUNDS FROM OTHER --
UTILITY FUNDS ETCETERA TO SHORE
UP THE GENERAL FUND DEFICIT --
THEY HAVE THE STEP THEY HAVE
TAKEN THAT'S APPROPRIATE IS THEY
HAVE ESTABLISHED LOANS NOW WHERE
THESE THEY GENERAL FUND OWES
THESE UTILITY FUNDS --
LIKE SEWER FUND ETCETERA A ALONE
SO THEY'VE ACTUALLY PROPERLY
RECORDED IT FROM AN ACCOUNTING
PERSPECTIVE NOW BUT THEY STILL
HAVE THAT THAT CONCERN WITH
RESPECT TO DEFICITS.
LIKE MY A MANY MANY CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA THEY DO HAVE ISSUES
WITH RESPECT TO RISING PENSION
COSTS AND OPARE AB UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES.
WE HAD IDENTIFIED ISSUES WITH
RESPECT TO MANAGEMENT TURNOVER
AND HAVING THE APPROPRIATE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE RIGHT
CLASSIFICATIONS AS FAR AS HAVING
A PRESS CITY MANAGER.
THEY HAVE AN INTERIM CITY
MANAGER THEY DID TALK DECIDED TO
CONTINUE THAT PERSONS --
INTERIM STATUS SO AND THEY HAVE
SOME OTHER INTERIM POSITIONS --
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR --
POLICE CHIEF WAS PUT ON
ADMINISTRATIVE LEAVE THEY'RE
CONDUCTING A AN INVESTIGATION
RELATED TO THAT AND SOME OTHER
REVIEWS --
SO WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH THAT
AND LOOKING AT THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S --
REPORT THE CONCERNS THEY HAD
RELATED TO INTERNAL CONTROLS
ACCOUNTING CONTROLS --
WE HAVEN'T SEEN IN THE EVIDENCE
THAT WAS PROVIDED TO US MUCH
PROGRESS IN ADDRESSING SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES --
I DO HAVE A LIST OF SOME OF THE
ITEMS THE CITY GAVE TO US ON MY
STAFF WENT THROUGH ONE WAS WE'VE
REFERRED TO AS A PATH FOR
FINANCIAL SOLVENCY AND MYSELF
LOOKING AT IT SAID.
IT'S NOT REALLY A PLAN OR A PATH
IT IS IDEAS OF SUGGESTIONS FOR
THINGS THEY COULD DO SO WE
REALLY WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO
THE CITY WE APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT THAT THEY'VE TAKEN.
BUT WE STILL THINK IT WOULD BE
WORTHWHILE --
FOR STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE GET
IN THEIR CONDUCT SOME ANALYSIS
AND HOPEFULLY PROVIDE SOME
ASSISTANCE AS WE HAVE DONE IN
THE PAST WHEN WE AUDITED MAY
WOULDN'T AND THE CITY OF HIM IT --
AS FAR AS SOME.
FINANCIAL EXPERTISE I HAVE
FINANCIAL EXPERTS IN MY OFFICE
THAT CAN GET INTO THIS CITY AND
HOPEFULLY TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF
THESE THINGS AND REALLY --
GIVE THE CITY SOME OF FEEDBACK
ON THINGS THAT THEY INTEND TO DO
THEIR THINKING ABOUT DOING ALL
SORTS OF THINGS SO --
WITHOUT MISTER CHAIR I KNOW
WE'VE BEEN HERE A LONG LONG TIME --
THE BUDGET IS ABOUT SIXTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS NOW THAT IS FROM
START TO FINISH THAT'S OUR
PROCESSING TIME SO WE WOULD BE
OUT AT THE CITY FOR JUST A FEW
WEEKS PROBABLY TWO TO THREE
WEEKS CONDUCTING FIELDWORK --
BECAUSE I KNOW SOME OF THESE
SMALL ENTITIES ARE SENSITIVE TO
STATE AUDITOR'S COMING OUT AND
BEING ON SITE FOR MONTHS ON END
THAT IS NOT THE INTENT HERE THIS
AUDIT.
FROM START TO FINISH WILL TAKE
US.
BETWEEN THREE AND FOUR MONTHS
PUBLIC CLOSE TO FOUR MONTHS BUT
US BEING OUT IN THE FIELD IS
ONLY GONNA BE A MATTER OF WEEKS.
ARE WITH THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN I
WILL DO MY BEST TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS MEMBERS MAY HAVE THANK
OUR RIGHT --
BEFORE WE OPEN UP TO ANY
QUESTIONS LET'S GIVE A
OPPORTUNITY --
FOR THE CITY THAT WATER PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
THEY WANT TO SIT NEXT TO HOPE
THAT I WANT THINGS ARE I'M JUST
KIDDING I WANT AND I DON'T.
MANAGER NO WORRIES ME HERE NO
WORRIES.
YEAH THERE ARE YOU KNOW HOW
LAURIE WATERMAN IN FROM CITY
MANAGER FOR CITY ABOUT WATER WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE.
A AGAIN THIS AFTERNOON.
I'M GONNA MISS KENDALL FLOODS
I'M WITH REGIONAL GOVERNMENT
SERVICES WE'VE BEEN UNDER
CONTRACT WITH CITY ABOUT WATER
SINCE JANUARY --
IN REVIEWING V. OF AUDITOR'S A
REQUEST FOR AN ON AND LOOKING AT
THE SIX PROJECT AREAS WE'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
CITY IN TERMS OF PRODUCING A
RESPONSE.
OF THE AUDITOR'S OFFICE ASKED
THE CITY TO RISK HER PROVIDE
THOSE DOCUMENTS BACK IN JULY
WHICH WE DID.
AND THAT WAS OVER SIXTEEN
DIFFERENT TARGET AREAS OVER SIX
HUNDRED PAGES OF DOCUMENTS AND
AS BEST WE CAN TELL I BELIEVE
THAT THE THE AUDITOR'S ACTUALLY.
TRYING TO DO THE BEST HOPE IN
JUST BELIEVE THAT THE PERHAPS
COULD BE MORE TIME SPENT.
IN A DIALOGUE WITH THE CITY TO
DETERMINE DOCUMENTS WHEN THEY
WERE SUBMITTED WERE NOT EITHER
UP TO SNUFF MORE WERE LACKING IN
CLARITY FOR ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT MIGHT BE USEFUL.
OF THE CITY HAS DONE A GREAT JOB
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS OF
REALLY DOING A HUGE TURNAROUND
THEY'VE ADOPTED THEIR FIRST
BALLOTS BUDGET BY UNANIMOUS A
THREE HE HAD HIS RESOLUTION.
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS THEY'VE
OVERHAULED THEIR MASTER FEE
SCHEDULE THEY'VE NOW MOVE FOR
WITH TO EIGHTEEN COMPLIANCE FOR
WATER AND SEWER THEY PUT IN
PLACE POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
THAT WOULD PREVENT.
THE ERRORS OF THE PAST WHICH
FRANKLY WERE BAD ACCOUNTING
PROCEDURES THEY WERE UTILIZING
OR ACCESSING SOME OF THEIR
ENTERPRISE FUNDS AND MOVING THEM
INTO GENERAL FUND THOSE HAVE ALL
BEEN RECTIFIED.
OUR TEAM HAS BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSE WIH THEM TO COME UP THE
BEST PRACTICES AND THEN COURSE
IMPLEMENTING THOSE PRACTICES
THROUGH A POLICY ADOPTION AT THE
COUNCIL LEVEL.
WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THE CITY AND THE
TAXPAYERS TO MOVE FOR WITH A
MONITORING PROGRAM AS OPPOSED TO
A FULL AUDIT.
VERY SIMILAR TO THE OTHER
AGENCIES THAT THE AUDITOR HAS
REVIEWED SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN
THERE BEEN THIRTEEN CITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN TARGETED FOR HIGH RISK
AUDIT. NINE IF OF HAVE MOVED
OVER TO THE MONITORING PORTION
THE PROGRAM WITH FOR MOVING TO A
FULL ON IT.
AT THIS POINT THE CITY HAS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE IN
SOME MEANINGFUL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND ALSO TO ATTRACT
SOME NEW EMPLOYEES TO FILL SOME
OF THE VACANCIES THAT THE
AUDITOR HAS IDENTIFIED.
WE BELIEVE THAT AN AUDIT AT THIS
TIME COULD NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE
CITY'S ABILITY TO IMPLEMENT ITS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
AND ALSO BE ABLE TO ATTRACT AND
RETAIN QUALITY EMPLOYEES.
SO WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR A PASS
HERE WOULD MAKE SURE THAT'S VERY
CLEAR WHAT WE ARE SAYING IS THAT
WE WOULD VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUDITOR IN A
MORE OF A COLLABORATIVE MANNER
AS OPPOSED TO THE AUDIT.
AND WORK WITH HER AND HER STAFF
TO IDENTIFY THOSE DOCUMENTS ARE
THOSE PROCEDURES WHERE WE COULD
YOU HAVE IMPROVEMENT OR
ENHANCEMENT.
IN ORDER --
TO SATISFY THE CONCERNS OF THE
SIX TOPIC AREAS AS AN EXAMPLE
ONE OF THEM WAS POLICE A
SERVICES OUR ABILITY TO DO THAT.
THE CITY ACTUALLY IS HAD A
REDUCTION IN VIOLENT CRIME AND
IN OVERALL CRIME 20% REDUCTION
SINCE.
TWENTY FOURTEEN ALL OF THE FEE
STUDIES FROM PLANNING BUILDING
UP.
RECREATION EVEN USER FEES
REVIEWED THEY'VE ALSO MOVE
FORWARD TO ADOPT THE UP
PREFERRED OR IT'S IT'S A
SUGGESTED A LIGHTING LANDSCAPE
DISTRICT FEES ALL THESE OTHER
THINGS THAT FRANKLY LIKE MANY
JURISDICTIONS THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
PERHAPS ELECTED OFFICIALS PUT
THEM OFF FOR A LITTLE TOO LONG
BECAUSE THEY DID NOT WANT TO A
BECAUSE THEIR CONSTITUENTS PAIN
AND I THINK WE ALL RECOGNIZE
THAT AT SOME POINT.
EVERY JURISDICTION IN ESPECIALLY
THOSE IN FISCAL --
CHALLENGED TIMES NEED TO HAVE A
PLAN IN PLACE WHERE THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE THE DEFENSE WILL
COST RECOVERY FOR THE DELIVERY
OF THOSE SERVICES WHETHER THEY
ARE FOR UTILITY SERVICES OR FOR
THOSE TYPE OF THINGS THAT HAPPEN
AT THE CITY LEVEL.
I'M IN TERMS OF THE OVERALL
APPROACH I BELIEVE THAT WORKING
CLOSELY WITH RGS OUR TEAM AND
WITH THE FOLKS ON ON ON THE
CITY'S A STAFF AT THIS TIME WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO COME BACK WITH
A NO SIX TO NINE MONTHS WORKING
WITH THE AUDITOR.
AND PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE WITH A
MORE UPDATED INFORMATION ABOUT
HOW WERE FARING WHAT WE'RE DOING
IT AGAIN BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO
THOSE CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
SEVER CANNELLA I KNOW THAT YOU
HAVE --
REPRESENTED --
THE THE CITY THAT WATER --
WELL IN IN IN AND WE HAD SOME
CONVERSATIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
SURE SURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UP FIRST OF I WANT TO SAY THAT
YOU KNOW THE IMPACT ON THE
COUNCIL OR THE CITY I DON'T
REALLY CARE ABOUT QUITE FRANKLY
AT MY COMMITMENTS TO THE
RESIDENTS ABOUT WATER AND
WHATEVER THE CITYHAS TO DO TO
MEET THOSE COMMITMENTS ME.
COULD DURING THE LAST MINUTE I
ASK THAT WE HOLD ON THIS AUDIT
BECAUSE I FELT THAT WATER WAS
TRYING TO MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND I BELIEVE THAT
THEY THEY ARE MOVING THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
THEY CALLED ME A FEW WEEKS AGO
AND SAID LOOK WE'D LIKE YOUR
OFFICIAL OPPOSITION OF THE SAGA
SO WE NEED TO COME IN TO EXPLAIN
TO ME WHY I SHOULD OPPOSE IT.
AND IF YOU HAVE A GOOD ARGUMENT
BUT I WILL IF YOU DON'T THAT
UNDERSCORED OUT JUST LIKE I TOLD
MY COLLEAGUES THAT WOULD DO A
FEW MONTHS AGO.
NOW WE WENT THROUGH ALL THE
VARIOUS THINGS THAT THEY'RE
DOING IT AND I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE THERE YET QUITE FRANKLY
BUT I THINK THEY ARE MAKING
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS.
WHO ARE OWN AUDITOR SAID THAT?
OF THE FOURTEEN REQUESTS MADE
WERE DOWN THE THIRTEEN NOW WE'LL
SEE HOW MISTER GAINES TURNS OUT.
THAT SHE COULD GET TWELVE OF
THEM DONE BY NEXT FEBRUARY THAT
BILLY J. LACK RECONVENES NEXT
FEBRUARY.
SO I WOULD ASK THAT
UNDERSTANDING THAT OTHER CITIES
THAT WERE LOOKED AT FOR A HIGH
RISK OF BUTTON BEEN PUT INTO.
THE MONITORING PROGRAM I THINK
THERE WERE NINE OF THEM OF THE
FOURTEEN I THINK OUT WATER --
IS ELIGIBLE FOR THAT AS WELL
JUST BECAUSE OF ALL THE WORK I
DON'T THINK THERE'S IMPENDING
DISASTER WITHOUT WATER I THINK
THEY ARE MAKING SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS.
AND OBVIOUSLY WE CAN'T DIRECT
THE AUDITOR TO PUT THEM ON A
LARGER PROGRAM BUT I WOULD ASK
THAT WE DO THAT IF THIS AUDIT
DOES NOT MOVE FORWARD TODAY.
BECAUSE AGAIN MY BEST MY
INTEREST.
BEST INTEREST OF OF THE
RESIDENTS ABOUT WATER SO I THINK
THERE'S PRECEDENT FOR THIS I
THINK THEY HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS.
AND THEN AND THERE STRUGGLING OF
COURSE JUST LIKE ALL UP AND DOWN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WE HAVE A LOT
OF STRUGGLES THAT OTHER PARTS OF
THE STATE DO NOT HAVE.
BUT WE PUT THEM IN A HIGH RISK
AUDIT.
ROOM THEN IF THEY HAVE TO GO OUT
TO BOND FOR VARIOUS IMPROVEMENTS
SOFT PAIR A HIGHER INTEREST RATE.
THEY'RE TRYING TO ATTRACT A
QUALIFIED EMPLOYEES.
I KNOW THAT IF I WERE APPLYING
FOR A JOB I WOULD LOOK AT A CITY
IF THEY WERE HIGH RISK I WOULD
HAVE SECOND THOUGHTS ABOUT IT SO.
UNDERSTANDING ALL THE WORK THAT
THEY'VE DONE --
THE FACT THAT WE PROBABLY
COULDN'T GET TO THE AUDIT UNTIL
FEBRUARY OF NEXT YEAR ANYWAY.
AT THAT TIME --
J. LACK IF IF THERE'S THEY SO
DESIRE THEY CAN GO AHEAD AND
AUDIT CITY THAT WATER.
I JUST DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
HARM IN IN DELAYING THIS TOLD US
THAT WE DO NOT MOVE FOR WITH THE
AUDIT AND I WOULD ASK THAT THE
AUDITOR I WOULD HUMBLY ASK THE
AUDITOR TO PUT THEM ON A
MONITORING PROGRAM.
MILITIA SEE HOW WE DO IN THE IF
IN FEBRUARY --
THEY DO NOT MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT THE AUTHOR IS
LAID OUT THEN AUDIT THEM AND AND
LET'S GET.
GET THINGS ON TRACK BUT I STILL
THINK THAT WE'RE THERE YET SO
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU --
AGES -- TO
WANTING ASK THE COMMITTEE KEEP
IN MIND AS THE AUDITOR IT'D
REMIND ME THAT ORIGINALLY THIS
REQUEST FROM THE AUDITOR DID
COME IN JANUARY.
OF OF AT THIS YEAR --
AND SO -- WE
WE WE HAVE TO GET A GIVEN THE
CITY OF ATWATER SOMETIME BUT
JUST FOR CONSIDERATION ANY OTHER
AYE AYE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MS BAKER.
STUFF I UNDERSTAND CREWS SOME IN.
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION THE
AUDITOR'S QUESTIONS OF HAPPEN OR
MATERIALS BEEN PROVIDED --
HAVE YOU.
HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO GO THROUGH.
WHAT HAS BEEN PROVIDED SO FAR
THIS TO MADAME MONITOR --
AND I WELCOME.
I APOLOGIZE AT STEP OUT BRIEFLY
BUT YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE IDEA.
OF HAVING THEM ON A MONITOR --
PAST AT THIS TIME.
M. IF YOU CAN COMMENT ON BOTH OF
THOSE PLEASE.
WELL WE HAVE RE REFER EXCUSE ME
A LITTLE TIRED WE RECEIVED
MATERIALS FROM THE CITY ARE APT
AT PRIOR TO THE LAST HEARING
WHEN IT WAS HER IT WAS HEARD IN
MAY.
WE HAD SUBMIT A REQUEST EARLIER
IN THE YEAR --
BUT WAS PUT OFF UNTIL THE MAY
HEARING SO AT THE MAY HEARING
WHEN THE CITY APPEARED THEY HAD
SENT US SOME MATERIALS ABOUT A
WEEK BEFORE THE HEARING AND I
TOLD STAFF.
WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
INFORMATION MY STAFF DID GO
THROUGH THE MATERIALS.
IT WASN'T AS VOLUMINOUS AT BASED
ON WHAT THEY TOLD ME AS AS WHAT
WAS REPRESENTED A FEW MINUTES
AGO BUT THEY WENT THROUGH ALL OF
THOSE MATERIALS AND I TOLD THEM
I'D YOU NEED TO ADVISE ME.
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT TO GO
FORWARD WITH THIS REQUEST OR
WHETHER WE DECIDE TO PULL IT
MONITOR.
BASED ON THE ANALYSIS THAT STAFF
DID.
AND AND I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THEY HAVE TAKEN SOME STEPS.
BUT WITH ALL DUE RESPECT THEIR
BABY STEPS AND QUITE FRANKLY I
THINK SOME OF THOSE STEPS ARE
HAVE BEEN TAKEN BECAUSE WE HAVE
BEEN LOOKING AT THE CITY OF
ATWATER WE WENT OUT THERE AND
CONDUCTED.
AN ASSESSMENT BEFORE WHICH IS
PART OF THE PROCESS BEFORE WE
EVEN COME TO THE COMMITTEE.
WE ABSOLUTELY CAN CONTINUE TO
MONITOR THEM.
BOMB IF THE AUDIT IS NOT
APPROVED WE WILL DEFINITELY DO
THAT AS WE MONITOR A LOT OF
DIFFERENT CITIES WERE CONSTANTLY
LOOKING AT NON FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS THAT ARE COMING OUT
WERE ACTUALLY DEVELOPING A
PROGRAM THAT --
HOPEFULLY WILL BE COME EVEN MORE
AND MORE ROBUST.
AS FAR AS MONITORING MY CONCERN
AND OUR CONCERN IS WE'VE.
LOOKED AT A INFORMATION BY
CONDUCTING THE INITIAL
ASSESSMENT.
CAME TO J. LACK IN JANUARY WAS
PUT OFF TILL MAY AS MR MATTEUCCI
INDICATED AT THE MAY HEARING
AGAIN WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
SENATOR.
WE TOOK THE INFORMATION THAT THE
CITY GAVE TO US AND WE'RE STILL
NOT CONVINCED.
ACOSTA WE THINK IT WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL OFF FOR US TO GET OUT
THERE AND TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF
THE THE THINGS THAT THEY INTEND
TO PUT INTO PLACE.
THE OTHER ISSUE IS.
THIS APPROVING AN AUDIT REQUEST
DOES NOT MAKE THE CITY OF
ATWATER A HIGH RISK CITY.
CONDUCTING AN AUDIT WILL WILL
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT WE
DECIDE TO PUT THEM OUT THERE AS
A HIGH RISK CITY.
THE OTHER --
RESULT OF THE AUDIT COULD BE.
THE CITY HAS PUT CERTAIN
POLICIES IN PLACE WE THINK
THEY'RE LONG STE LONG TERM
FISCAL FORECAST IS APPROPRIATE
THEY'VE TAKEN CERTAIN STEPS TO
DEAL WITH THEIR GENERAL FUND
DEFICIT THERE THEY HAVE STRONGER
BUDGETING PRACTICES IT CETERA.
SO THE AUDIT THAT WE CONDUCT MAY
RESULT IN.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
CATEGORIZED AS A HIGH RISK CITY
THEY HAVE ISSUES BUT THEY HAVE
GOOD PLANS IN PLACE AND THEY'VE
ADDRESSED A LOT OF THE PROBLEMS
THE CONTROLLER IDENTIFIED FOUR
YEARS AGO.
AND BASED ON OUR PROFESSIONAL
THEY ARE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THAT COULD BE A
POSITIVE OUTCOME OF AN AUDIT
THAT THIS COMMITTEE APPROVES AT
MY OFFICE WOULD CONDUCT AND
MONITORING IS AN ADEQUATE FOR
WHAT REASON.
MONITORING WE WOULD NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO ACCESS CERTAIN
MATERIALS IT WOULD BE LIMITED TO
WHAT THE CITY WOULD BE WILLING
TO SHARE WITH US.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE THE STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO GET OUT TO THE CITY
AND WE COULD HOPEFULLY GO OUT
AND VISIT THE CITY AND TALK TO
THEM ABOUT.
ANY PUBLICLY AND FOR PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE INFORMATION THEY WOULD
BE WILLING TO SHARE WITH US.
THE AUTHORITY --
ONCE THIS AUDIT IS APPROVED IF
IT IS OUR STATUTORY AUTHORITY AS
FAR AS ACCESS TO INFORMATION.
ARE WOULD BE MUCH MUCH STRONGER
MEN ARE STATUTORY AUTHORITY FOR
STRONG THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE YES AND WHATEVER KICK
AND WE GET THIS REAL SPECIFIC
HAS A MINUTE.
WE'RE GONNA HOLD YOU TO YOUR
WORD.
WHAT WHAT THE AUDITOR WOULD
OTHERWISE BE ABLE WANT
STATUTORILY IF IF THE AUDITOR
HAS QUESTIONS FOR YOU IF WE WERE
THAT GO WITH THE MONITORING
PROPOSAL AND I'M I'M INCLINED TO
DEFERRED OUR COLLEAGUE AND I
THINK IT'S MADE RISK MARKET BUT
I'M?
AMONG THE EDGE.
IF IF THERE'S A REQUEST WILL YOU
PROVIDE ALL THAT IS REQUESTED
NOW REALIZE FROM EXPERIENCE THIS
COMMITTEE HOW WILL SHE KNOW IF
IT'S ALL WITHOUT HAVING TO GO
BACK AND FORTH IF THERE'S ANY
MONKEY BUSINESS ABOUT THAT.
IT'S GONNA BE TEN TIMES WORSE
FOR YOU SO WILL YOU COMMIT IF
THERE IF THE COMMITTEE SO
CHOOSES TO GO FOR WITH THE
MONITORING INSTEAD OF A FULL
AUDIT.
HERE THE YOU'LL GIVE THE AUDITOR
WHATEVER SHE ASKS.
FOR SYSTEM AND HOW ELSE WAS I
RESPOND.
I DON'T EVEN THE FOR YEARS
BECAUSE I DO WANT TO JUST
HEARING LAWYER I'M JUST COMMUTER
LIAR I DON'T HAVE.
THAT AND HE WILL RESPOND I DO A
QUICK ONE THING --
AND I WANT TO ASK YOUR
FLIRTATION I'M OF THE CITY
PROVIDED IN MATERIALS BACK IN
MAY THAT I AM I WOULD I WOULD
HAVE AUDIT US THEN.
TO NOT BECAUSE IT WAS NOT
ADEQUATE BUT THE MATERIALS
PROVIDED IN JULY WERE
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE DETAIL AHEAD
WHEN INTO GREATER DETAIL BOTH
FROM THE BUDGETING STANDPOINT
FROM A POLICY STANDPOINT.
AND FROM A BASE THE RESOLUTIONS
THAT WERE PUT FORTH SO THERE WAS
A TREMENDOUS THE ALMOST SIX
HUNDRED PAGES WORTH OF DATA THAT
THEY ONLY HAD FIVE DAYS TO
REVIEW FIVE WORKING DAYS TO
REVIEW.
UNTIL SUCH TIME AS THE AUDITOR'S
SAID WE WANT TO MOVE FORWARD AND
AUDIT I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT IT WAS ACTUALLY THE
DATA I WAS REFERRING TO AYE I
THOUGHT THERE WAS SOMETHING IN
JULY.
NOT JUST A INDIAN IN MAY RIGHT
SO I MAY COME BACK TO MADAM
AUDITOR ON THAT BUT I AM HAPPY
HERE FROM HER ATTORNEY.
BUT GOOD THAT WHITEWATER TORTURE.
THAT WHITE CHURCH WILL WHITE AND
CITY ATTORNEY FOR THE CITY OF
ATWATER.
I WANNA BE VERY CLEAR.
I'M I'M I'M BOTH MYSELF AND THE
CITY MANAGER OUR TIME AS THE TO
APPOINTED OFFICIALS.
UP FOR THE CITY ARE PREPARED TO
FULLY TO REPRESENT ON THE CITY'S
BEHALF THAT WE WILL FULLY
COOPERATE.
I'M WITH THE AUDITOR WE WILL
PROVIDE THEM ANY INFORMATION
THAT THEY NEED THIS IS NOT AN
INTENT TO KIND OF HIDE OR
PALATIAL GAMES.
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT --
TO NOT BE IN A SITUATION WHERE
WE CAN'T ATTRACT TALENT TO BE IN
A SITUATION WHERE BOND RATINGS
ARE GO GOING UP.
AND WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
AUDITOR I TALKED TO BOND COUNSEL
EVERYDAY DO PROJECTS ACROSS THE
STATE A WHEN YOU GO THROUGHTHIS
AUDIT -- IT
HAS IMPACTS YOU DO IT BECAUSE IT
HAS AN IMPACT --
IN THE IMPACT IS IS AND WILL
HOPEFULLY BE POSITIVE FOR THE
FOR THE THE RESIDENTS BUT THERE
ARE BETTER WAYS TO ACCOMPLISH
THE THE SAME RESULT.
WITH A JURISDICTION THAT WILLING
TO KIND OF COOPERATE SO.
I'M HERE TO TO SAY AS A AND THEY
HAVE THE CITY ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
YOU DO HAVE THE CITY'S
COMMITMENT AND AS THE ENGINE
CITY MANAGER I WILL MAKE SURE
THAT.
ALL DOCUMENTS REQUESTED ARE
AVAILABLE AND IT'S EVERYTHING AT
THE OUTER ASKS YOU CORRECT CLEAR
REPRESENTING TWO YES TEN AND I
ACTUALLY HAD SOME DOCUMENTS THAT
WE THAT THEY HAD BREAK REQUESTED
ADDITIONAL AND WE WERE
FORTHCOMING AND THOSE AS SOON AS
THEY ASK.
BUT I THINK THAT IF IT'S NOT ON
THAT WAS BECAUSE THERE WAS A
REQUEST FOR FOR SIXTEEN SEPARATE
DOCUMENTS AND WE RESPONDED TO
ALL OF THEM IN A TIMELY MANNER
AND ACTUALLY THE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE AND IS BACK NOTES
APPRECIATING THE CONSISTENCY IN
THE CLARITY OF THE DOCUMENTS
THAT WERE.
SENT AND IF I COULD ONE OF THE
PORTENTS WE BELIEVE SOME OF THE
THE PRESUMPTIONS.
IN THIS AUDIT REQUEST ARE
ACTUALLY IN ACCURATE I THINK WE
TALKED ABOUT SOME OF THE THINGS
IN IN IN THE POLICE.
THERE HAS NOT BEEN THE ABILITY
ON AT LEAST SINCE THIS TEAM HAS
BEEN PUT IN PLACE WE WERE GIVEN
A TIME FRAME BY THE AUDITOR TO
TO RESPOND.
THAT THAT RESPONSE TIMELINE WAS
AFTER WHICH THEY HAD THE KIND OF
GET BACK TO THIS COMMITTEE AND
SAY.
HEY WE WANNA WE WANT.
TO WE WANT THIS TO BE ON THE
AGENDA THERE HAS NOT BEEN THE
SUFFICIENT TIME TO HAVE THE
DIALOGUE BETWEEN ON UNDER OKAY
YOU DON'T HAVE YOU HEARD THE
AUDITOR SAY WE DON'T THINK THIS
IS SUFFICIENT.
OKAY WELL WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
RUN WITH IT WHAT YOU NEED IS TO
IMPROVE MY MINUTES GOT YOU THERE
BECAUSE YOU DON'T I I'M I'M
ALMOST WITH YET BUT IF YOU START
SAYING THAT BUT THE AUDITOR'S.
MAKING PRESUMPTIONS IT'S NOT
GONNA HELP YOUR ARGUMENT.
SO -- IT MAY
IF I MAY THE FINAL ONE JUST TO
GO BACK THEN THE ORIGINAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT DOCUMENTS THAT
ARE.
MORE RECENTLY THE JULY DOCUMENTS
DO YOU MADAM AUDITOR FEEL THAT
YOUR TEAM HAS HAD SUFFICIENT
TIME TO ANALYZE THOSE IN MAKING
A RECOMMENDATION THAT A FULL
AUDIT B..
RIGHT I THINK THE TIMING I WANNA
MAKE SURE BECAUSE I I EXPLAIN
THIS TO MR MERCHANT YESTERDAY SO
I KNOW THERE WAS CONCERNED WITH
THERE WAS A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
THAT.
THE JAIL LIKE HEARING IN MAY WAS
MIDDLEMAN.
AND THEN WE THAT THAT THE
DECISION WAS LET THE CITY
PROVIDE INFORMATION TO US THE
DEADLINE TO SUBMIT A REQUEST
LETTER TO THIS COMMITTEE YES WAS
JULY SECOND.
SO I HAD TO SUBMIT A LETTER TO
MISTER MERCHANT COMMITTEE WHICH
I DID WITH THE WITH THE
AGREEMENT THAT IF WE CONTINUE TO
GET INFORMATION FROM THE CITY WE
WOULD CONTINUE TO ASSESS THAT
INFORMATION.
I MET WITH MY STAFF A WEEK AND A
HALF AGO WHEN.
STILL ON BECAUSE IF WE'RE NOT ON
IF WE DON'T THINK AN AUDIT IS
NECESSARY I NEED TO NOTIFY THE
CHAIRMAN AND THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT I'M NOT GOING TO
SUBMIT A FORMAL PROPOSAL OKAY
AND MEETING WITH MY STAFF.
I HAVEN'T LOOKED AT MATERIALS
MEETING WITH MY STAFF THEY SAID
YEAH WE'VE GONE THROUGH ALL
THOSE MATERIALS.
AND IN FAIRNESS TO THE CITY THEY
HAVE MADE SOME PROGRESS IS IT
SUFFICIENT FOR US TO SAY WE
DON'T THINK IT OUGHT IT IS
NECESSARY OUR CONCLUSION WAS NOW
THAT IS WHY WE CAME FORWARD WITH
A PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN YES SO.
AS YOU MENTIONED EARLIER
SOMETIMES ARTISTS JUST PREMATURE.
AND IN THIS MAY BE ONE I THINK
THAT WATER HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS.
AGAIN THIS IS A THIS IS THE
SECOND TIME I'VE ASKED FOR A
HOLD ON IT ON IT.
AND THERE WILL NOT BE A THIRD
TIME NUMBER ONE I WILL NOT BE IN
THE LEGISLATURE I WILL NOT BE ON
THIS COMMITTEE.
SO COME NEXT FEBRUARY IF THE
CITY OF ATWATER HAS NOT.
MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS YOU
WILL AUDIT THEM AND SO I'M JUST
SAYING BASED ON THE WORKLOAD OF
THE AUDITOR --
SHE'S INDICATED THAT THERE'S NO
POSSIBLE WAY TO FORTY DOLLARS
BETWEEN NOW AND JUNE ARE A
FEBRUARY RATHER.
SO THE NEXT MEETING OF THE JAIL
I COMMITTEES IN FEBRUARY WE HAVE
A CHANCE TO WORK WITH THE
AUDITOR ON THE MONITORING.
IF THEY DON'T HIT IT --
I WILL CO APPEAR AND TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FROM THE AUDIENCE IN
SUPPORT OF THE AUDIT BUT AT THIS
POINT I THINK THEY'VE MADE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS SO DOUBTS
THAT WE HOLD.
NOTHING HEALTH OKAY I'LL STAY
HOME.
NOW ARE INNOCENT --
ANY -- ONE
FROM THE GUTYES CENTER FULLER
CELL AND I THINK THE SCHEDULE
SENSE GOOD BECAUSE I'M BACK TO
THE DMV AND I WANT YOU TO DOUBLE
UP SO.
SO I'M I WILL BE SUPPORTING --
CINDER AT CANDELAS THAT IF THIS
IS A MOTION OR WHATEVER IT IS
WHEN WE VOTE ON IT THANK YOU.
ARE RIGHT --
BUT BEFORE I COMMENT TO ANYONE
FROM THE PUBLIC LIKE COMMENT ON
THIS MATTER.
SEEING NONE --
YEAH THANK THE AUDITOR FOR A
YEAR.
DOING YOUR DUTY --
YOU KNOW NORMALLY I'M INCLINED
TO OF TO TO SUPPORT THE OTTERS
RECOMMENDATION.
AND BUT IF ANYONE COMES TO ME IN
THE* Y. SUPPORTED A THE
MOTION TO LEAD TO DELAY I'M
GOING TO SAY IT'S BECAUSE THE
SENATE CANNELLA [inaudible]
AND SO [inaudible]
THAT'S RIGHT.
I WILL FIND YOU.
SO CENTER CANNELLA WOULD YOU
LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION.
SO I FORGET THE RULES OF OF
MOTIONS THIS CAN A WHAT EXACTLY
WILL A MOTION --
I WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION --
TO TWO WHERE POSTPONED THIS --
MOTION FOR A LOCAL HIGH RISK
AUDIT TO OUR NEXT YEAR LIKE HERE
OKAY SO THAT WOULD MEAN IT WOULD
AUTOMATICALLY COME UP SOCAL
WOULD MOVE THAT WE WE POSTPONE
THIS SIDE UNTIL THE NEXT.
J. LIKE MEETING I BELIEVE IN
FEBRUARY.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN OUR SO
CORRECT.
DAY SIR.
KERN I JUST DID SUB SOMETIME IN
THE FUTURE.
I'D HATE TO MISS HAS DECIDED BY
THE CHAIR [inaudible]
NOW [inaudible]
YEAH OKAY [inaudible]
THEY ARE [inaudible]
ALRIGHT --
MS HOW WOULD YOU LIKE THAT.
I DEFER TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MOTIONS MADE A SECOND IT --
MADAM SECOND PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WHICH MY RESTATING THE MOTION
JUST JUST TO SUPER YET AS BEST
YOU CAN SO THE THE MOTION --
IS IS TO POSTPONE THE AUDITOR'S --
LOCAL HIGH RISK --
AUDIT REQUEST LED TO THE NEXT A
REGULARLY SCHEDULED [inaudible]
ARE.
J. LACK HEARING TO BEATRIZ TO BE
DETERMINED AND IS THAT.
SORT OF CODIFY FOR US THAT
MONITORING WILL CONTINUE.
BECAUSE THAT WAS PART OF IT
AUTOMATICALLY GOES ON JUST.
SO IF THEY DON'T DO IT IT'S ON
THE AGENDA.
AS HELL WHICH LIKE.
TO WE WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR
AND AND WE'VE HEARD AND I'M SURE
IT'S ON THE RECORD WILL HAVE THE
TAPE THAT THE CITY WILL
COOPERATE WITH THAT'S MY BIGGEST
CONCERN IS.
WE DON'T HAVE THE STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO GET IN THERE BUT IF
THEY ARE COMMITTED TO PROVIDING
US AT MATERIALS --
PERIODICALLY AND MY STAFF CAN
LOOK AT IT BECAUSE WE WILL NEED
THAT INFORMATION TO DETERMINE
WHETHER WE'RE GONNA COME BACK.
A AND REQUESTED AUDIT BECAUSE I
WOULD WANT TO GIVE THE COMMITTEE
AN UPDATED ASSESSMENT OF THE
FISCAL STRENGTH OF THE CITY.
THINK YOU.
IF I CAN SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AGAIN I'LL REPEAT THAT WE
WILL WORK WITH THE AUDITOR ON
ITEMS REQUEST.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU SO WITH THAT
CLARIFICATION MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ROLL CALL TO RETAIN THE AUDIT
REQUESTS --
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ATTACHED --
EIGHT OH FOR CITY ABOUT WATER
AND A LOCAL PROGRAM BY THE STATE
AUDITOR --
UNTIL THE NEXT HEARING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MERCY TEAM I
PURSUE T. AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE NAZARIAN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
SENATOR ROTH [inaudible]
ALLEN BELL.
WELL I CANNELLA.
CANNELLA AYE FULLER.
FULLER AYE LARA.
OKAY THIS MOTION IS ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY [inaudible]
YOU.
ALRIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY --
SURE YOU ARE NEXT UP THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN
DEATHS ONE NINETEEN DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
PARTICIPATION IN THE CALIFORNIA
BERMAN EQUALITY ACT.
AUDIT REQUESTS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAY --
PLEASE.
KEEP IN MIND THAT --
WE HAVE TWO ITEMS LEFT IN THAT
SOME OF US INCLUDING MYSELF IS
NOT HAVE LUNCH AND IN THE STATE
AUDITOR'S BEEN.
WORKING HARD AND NEED YOU ALSO
HAVE A THE CHAIRS AYE
RECOMMENDATION I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE --
BRIEFLY MR SHARE ALL --
GIVE SOME BACKGROUND --
THANK YOU MEMBERS LEARN BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE.
AND THE CONSOLES FOR THEIR WORK --
AS YOU NOTE PART FISH WILDLIFE
IS ONE OF A PLACE IMPORTANT ROLE
AS IT RELATES TO OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL SPACE --
MANAGING CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE --
WILDLIFE RIGHT RESOURCES.
AND THE DEPARTMENT WHICH IS
PATIENT IN THE CALIFORNIA
GRAMMAR QUALITY ACT WHICH IS
ARGUABLY CALIFORNIA'S MOST
IMPORTANT IN DRIVE UP TO
ACTUALIZE CRITICAL --
TO THAT DEPARTMENT MEETING ITS
MISSION.
THIS OUT ROBUST PROCESS HAS
ESTABLISHED BY SEQUEL A HAS BEEN
IN PLACE MORE THAN FORTY YEARS
AND IT REQUIRES ALL RESPONSIBLE
AGENCIES TO BE NOTIFIED OF THE
PROPOSED PROJECT.
IT REQUIRES RESPONSIBLE AGENCIES
TO RESPOND --
CONSULTATION BY THE LEAD AGENCY
IN ORDER SAYS THAT LEAD AGENCY
AND PREPARING ADEQUATE VITAMIN A
DOCUMENTS.
I IT'S CRUCIAL FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IS ASSIST THEM
DETERMINE NECESSARY MEDICATIONS
FOR PROPOSED PROJECTS.
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BENEFIT
FROM THE PUBLIC INVOLVEMENT
PROCESS FROM THE EXPERTISE OF
CALIFORNIA'S AND THE STATE
AGENCIES IN MAKING A FINAL
DECISION ON PROJECTS.
EARLY THIS YEAR AND IS
LEGISLATION TO REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT COMPLY WITH THAT
STATUTORILY MANDATED
REQUIREMENTS NOW THAT MAY SEEM
ODD THAT YOU WOULD INTRODUCE A
BILL TO TELL FOLKS TO DO WHAT
THE READY STATUTORILY REQUIRED
TO DO.
BUT IN THIS CASE --
BECAUSE OF SOME CIRCUMSTANCES IN
OUR HOME AREA THAT WHICH IS.
NECESSARY.
IN RESPONSE THAT LEGISLATION
DEPARTMENT A KID THAT IT WOULD
BE UNABLE TO COMPLY WITH THE
LEGISLATION BECAUSE IT ONLY HAD
THE RESOURCES TO ENGAGE IN 50%.
OF THE PROJECTS THAT FALL WITHIN
ITS JURISDICTION.
CORD TO COMMITTEE HOUSES THE
PROPOSED LEGISLATION DEPARTMENT
INDICATED THAT THE CONSTRAINTS
ON FUNDS FORCES DEPARTMENT USE
JUDGMENT AS TO WHICH SECRET
PROCEEDINGS ARE MOST LIKELY TO
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT --
APPROVAL OR PERMITS.
THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU TODAY I
REQUEST THE STATE AUDITOR
EXAMINE THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE'S RESOURCE
ALLOCATION SPENDING PRIORITIES
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW IT
COMPLIES OR DOES NOT COMPLY.
WITH ITS STATUTORY ROLE AS A
RESPONSIBLE AGENCY UNDER
SEQUENCE.
ALL RIGHT DO YOU HAVE.
ANY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
I DON'T --
MISTER CHAIR AND I HAVE
ADDITIONAL BACKGROUND I CAN
PROVIDE THAT ALL WAIT FOR
MEMBERS. TO ASK QUESTIONS IF
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE THAT
BACKGROUND ALRIGHT PARA --
AT MS HOW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY INDICATED
WE WOULD BE LOOKING AT THE
DEPARTMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE
HE'S ASKED US TO LOOK AT A FIVE
YEAR WINDOW AND LOOK AT REQUESTS
THAT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE HAS
RECEIVED WHERE THEY WOULD BE THE
RESPONSIBLE AGENCY. FOR A SEQUEL
REVIEW AND THEIR ACTIONS IN
RESPONSE TO THOSE COOL THOSE
REQUESTS --
AND AGAIN AS AS MISTER GRAY
INDICATED.
HE REALLY WANTS TO UNDERSTAND --
WHETHER OR NOT FISH AND WILDLIFE
IS MEETING ITS STATUTORY
RESPONSIBILITIES WHEN IT IS
DEEMED A RESPONSIBLE AGENCY
UNDER SEAQUEST SO WE WOULD LOOK
AT SOME SICK OR REQUESTS AND
LOOK AT PROCESS.
IN ADDITION AS HE INDICATED WE
WOULD LOOK AT THE ALLOCATION OF
RESOURCES HOW WAS FISH AND GAME.
ALLOCATING RESOURCES TO THESE
TYPES OF RESPONSIBILITIES AS
OPPOSED TO SOME OF THE OTHER
FUNCTIONS THAT FISH FISH AND
WILDLIFE IS RESPONSIBLE --
FOR AND I'D A ASSESS THE JUST OF
SOME OF THOSE ALLOCATIONS AND
AND DETERMINATIONS AS FAR AS
STAFFING AND EXPENDITURES --
HE'S ALSO ASKED US TO LOOK AT
THE VARIOUS FUNCTIONS THAT ARE
FUNDED INCLUDING THE SEQUEL
PROCESS OUT ALSO HABITAT
MANAGEMENT WANTING TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND HOW MANY STAFF --
PERCENTAGES OF STAFF IN AND
DOLLARS ASSOCIATED STAFF
DEDICATED TO HAVE A TAPE HABITAT
MANAGEMENT FIRST SEQUEL VERSUS
OTHER FUNCTIONS.
DIDN'T TEARS ME --
AND THEN ASKING US ABOUT EARLY
PARTICIPATION IS THERE ARE AWAY
THAT FISH AND WILDLIFE CAN BE
INVOLVED EARLIER IN THE PROCESS
THAT WOULD BE BENEFICIAL.
ONTO THEIR SECRET PROCESS AND
CERTAINLY POTENTIALLY BENEFICIAL
TO OTHER PROGRAMS AND THEN THE
FINAL OBJECTIVE HE ASKED ASTUTE
TO ACCOMPLISH WAS REALLY LOOKING
AT THE FUNDING.
SO HOW IS FISH AND WILDLIFE
MANAGING THE FUNDS THEY RECEIVE
FROM C. COFFEES AND WHETHER OR
NOT IT SPENDING THOSE FUNDS OR
OR RE FUNDING AND SOME CASES.
ARE THOSE THOSE FEES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE LAW --
THE AUDIT IS BUDGETED AT TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED HOURS IT BUT
AROUND A SIX MONTH WINDOW OUGHT
TO COMPLETE THE WORK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
I'D LIKE TO INVITE A REP CENTER
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE IF.
YES IN THE AUDIENCE HERE.
HOW WE ALREADY HEARD ATTRACT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ACT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHUCK BOTTOM ON THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
I WAS HERE THIS MORNING WHEN YOU
STARTED.
YOU ASKED FOR A STATEMENT OF
POSITION IN UNDER TWO MINUTES
THEREFORE --
WITH RESPECT TO MISTER GRAY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU DENY
THIS REQUEST FOR AN AUDIT
[inaudible] TWO REASONS.
FIRST THIS BAKER.
I RECALL WHAT YOU SAID ALMOST
FOUR HOURS AGO.
THAT YOU HAVE A PREFERENCE
[inaudible]
FOR RESOLUTION. FOR REACHING OUT
TO AFFECTED DEPARTMENTS. TO
RESOLVE THE ITEM.
WITHOUT LEGISLATION OR NEED FOR
AUDIT.
I HAVE GOOD RELATIONS WITH
MISTER GREGG.
I BELIEVE I HAVE AN OPEN DOOR
FOR HIM AND ANY MEMBER.
ON ANY ISSUE.
MR GRAY REFERENCED A BILL WHICH
I BELIEVE IS AB THIRTY ONE NO.
TO I HAVE NOT SPOKEN IN THIS
GREAT ABOUT MISTER GRAY ABOUT
THE BILL WHICH I BELIEVE IS
WITHDRAWN.
UNTIL THIS MORNING RIGHT NOW I
HAVE NOT SPOKEN TO HIM ABOUT
THIS AUDIT REQUEST.
I THINK MY DOOR WOULD BE OPEN
AND I'M GOING TO WORK WITH HIM
ON THE CONCERNS HIS RACE IN THIS
LETTER [inaudible]
SECOND REASON.
WITH ALL RESPECT TO THE STATE
AUDITOR.
I BELIEVE IN AUDIT ON THIS
NARROW SCOPE [inaudible]
AGAINST.
ALL THE MANY AUDITS THAT ARE PUT
TO THE STATE AUDITOR.
WOULD NOT BE A STRATEGIC USE OF
FUNDS AND TIME RIGHT NOW
[inaudible]
BECAUSE JUST SEVERAL WEEKS AGO
YOU THE LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATED
TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS.
AND GAVE US A STATUTORY
DIRECTIVE. TO IMPLEMENT A
SERVICE BASED BUDGET REVIEW.
THERE ARE STRICT TIMELINES AND
YOUR DIRECTIVE TO US.
THERE ARE AT LEAST FOUR
REPORTING IN HEARING OVERSIGHT
OPPORTUNITIES YOU GAVE US IN
STATUTE.
AND THE INSTRUCTIONS BROADLY ARE
A TO TO IDENTIFY OUR GOALS ARE
CORPS PROGRAM SERVICE STANDARDS
ESSENTIAL ACTIVITIES.
DEVELOP COST ESTIMATES STAFFING
REQUIREMENTS.
ANALYZING CURRENT SERVICE LEVELS
ACTIVITIES COST COMPARISONS
ANALYZING EXISTING REVENUE
STRUCTURE.
I WELCOME THAT ASSIGNMENT YOU
GIVE US UNDER THE BUDGET PATHWAY.
I WANNA MEET AND EXCEED ALL
EXPECTATIONS THROUGH THAT PATH
WHERE.
I WANT TO USE THAT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS WIDELY WISELY.
AND BECAUSE SEQUEL IS A CORE
FUNCTION OF OUR DEPARTMENT OF
MAPS LEE CERTAIN IT'S GOING TO
BE SCRUBBED.
REVIEWED DISCUSSED AND PRESENTED
TO YOU IN A MULTIPLE KIND OF
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS IN THE NEXT
YEAR AND A HALF.
SO FOR THOSE TWO REASONS I
RECOMMEND YOU NOT APPROVE THIS
AUDIT.
HI I'VE BEEN HERE ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE AS THE DISCUSSION
AS WELL.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU FOR A YEAR
CONCISE --
PRESENTATION QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
CENTER ABOUT --
IS SO INNOCENT REMEMBER ROME AND
THE AUDITOR --
BECAUSE I DWELLED ON THE SUBJECT
A LOT.
AS CHAIRMAN OF THE
TRANSPORTATION --
HOUSING COMMITTEE --
DOES THIS INCLUDE THE PROCESSING
OF OF OF HER MINUTES IN ADDITION
TO SEE COR.
AND DOES IT INCLUDE --
THE IDEA THAT.
IF SOMEBODY HAS A PERMIT THE
REQUESTING.
THAT THEY CAN PAY EXTRA FUNDS.
TO THE DEPARTMENT TO EXPEDITE.
TWO IN OTHER WORDS TO PAY FOR
YOU KNOW HE'S SAYING THAT.
HE DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH.
STAFF RESOURCES.
TO DO THE JOB TO PROCESS ALL THE
PERMITS THAT ARE OUT THERE DOING
STUFF.
SO.
A RESPONSE TO THAT OBVIOUS WOULD
BE OKAY IF SOMEBODY HAS A PERMIT
LIKE -- SAY
A WATER AGENCY.
FLOOD CONTROL AGENCY OR WHATEVER
THE SIMPLY GIVE THE DEPARTMENT
SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDS. TO COVER
THE COST OF DOING TO PERMIT.
IS THAT IS THAT SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE LOOKED AT IN THIS IN
THIS AUDIT.
ALL DOT ORG IT AUTOMATICALLY
AUDITOR'S ARE IS A SINGER ASKING
DOES THE AUDIT LETTER REQUEST
COVER YEAH BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS HE'S GOT HE'S GOT.
SEIZE GOT A HUNDRED HUNDRED TO A
PERMITS HE'S GOT A LOOK AT BUT
HE'S ONLY GOT ENOUGH MONEY FOR
SEVENTY FIVE OHMS THAT MEANS
THAT.
TWENTY FIVE WE'RE GOING TO BE --
MAYBE NOT.
PROCEEDED WITH EXPEDITIOUSLY.
YOU KNOW THAT'S KIND OF WHAT.
WHAT I GOT OUT OF PRISON TO JUST
TWO PRESENTERS?
SO DISSIDENT CLUED LIKE THE IDEA
THAT.
SE --
AGENCIES THAT WANT TO GET
PERMITS PROCESS EXPEDITIOUSLY.
IN A NORMAL FASHION --
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO PAY.
FOR THERE IS AN OBJECTIVE IN THE
THE AUDIT ANALYSIS AND BASED ON
SPA ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAZE REQUEST
THAT ASKS US NOT ONLY TO LOOK AT
SEQUEL BUT TO LOOK AT OTHER
FUNCTIONS.
THAT FISHING GAME IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR AND THE DECISION MAKING AS
FAR AS STAFFING FOR THOSE
PARTICULAR FUNCTIONS WHAT WHERE
THE PRIORITIES AND THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY SPENT ON UP SUPPORTING
THOSE FUNCTIONS.
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT SOMEBODY CAN.
I THINK WE WOULD ASK THAT
QUESTION AS FAR AS THE
DEPARTMENT'S JUSTIFICATION
BECAUSE WHAT MR GRAY'S ASKING US
IS. TO LOOK AT EXPENDITURE
STAFFING LEVELS FOR OTHER
FUNCTIONS WITHIN FISH AND GAME
AND THEN THE DEPARTMENT'S
JUSTIFICATION FOR THAT DECISION
MAKING SO I THINK WE MAY GET OUT
WHAT YOU WERE.
ASKING ABOUT A LOT OF LOVE THESE
AGENCIES THAT HAVE BUT PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THEY THE THEY SEE THIS IS A
BOTTLENECK FOR GETTING THAT JUST.
JUST THE TIME IT TAKES BECAUSE
TIME IS MONEY SO THEY'RE NOT
ABLE -- TO
IN EFFECT GO OUT TO BID UNTIL
THEY HAVE ALL THESE CLEARANCES
HE'S PERMITS [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
THE I DID WOULD BE --
SOMETHING THE WE WE'VE DONE IN
THE PAST WITH SO WHEN I CHAIRED
THE TRAFFIC AUTHORITY BUILDING
FREEWAYS IN [inaudible]
SOUNDS AYE.
WE JUST SIMPLY PAID CALTRANS AND
THESE AGENCIES SOME ADDITIONAL
MONEY.
TO COVER THE COST OF PROCESSING
OF PERMITS WE HAVE.
SENATOR FROM AND AND THEY GOT
THE MONEY AND THEN THEY THEY
HIRE WHATEVER STAFF THEY NEED
AND THEN THEY GO.
PROCESS THE PERMITS IT I MAKE IT
A SIMPLE STATEMENT HERE WAS MORE
COMPLICATED LIKE TALKING ABOUT
BUT OKAY BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
RESPOND YES SENATOR.
BUT THREE THOUGHTS FIRST.
AS I MENTIONED YOU TIP OF BEFORE
I AM THE FIRST DIRECTOR OF THIS
DEPARTMENT.
FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR YOU KNOW
WHO'S TRIED TO GET A PERMIT FROM
THE VERY DEPARTMENT I NOW I'M
DIRECTOR OF SO I UNDERSTAND THIS
CONUNDRUM.
SECOND THE WAY I READ THE AUDIT
INSTRUCTIONS OR REQUEST IT'S
MORE ABOUT [inaudible]
THE DEPARTMENT'S --
REQUIREMENTS TO COMMENT ON
DOCUMENTS.
IN THE SEQUEL PROCESS.
ALTHOUGH I CONFESS [inaudible]
A FULL.
INSPECTION EXAM MORE SURVEY OR
ASSESSMENT.
MAY TOUCH OTHER ITEMS ABOUT
EFFICIENCIES AND IMPROVEMENTS.
AND THE HAPPENED SEVERAL BILLS
SOME AUTHORED BY YOU OVER THE
LAST FOUR FIVE YEARS WHICH HAVE
BECOME LAW THAT ARE MOVING US IN
THAT DIRECTION.
IF YOU LOOK BACK IN THE LAST
FIVE YEARS WE GOT ABOUT.
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
NEGATIVE DECLARATIONS MITIGATE
MITIGATED NEGATIVE DECLARATIONS
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORTS
THAT'S THE VOLUME COMING IN TO
US THAT WE HAVE SOME.
NEED TO REVIEW PRIORITIZE AND
RESPOND.
TO I'M NOT AWARE OF MY STAFF
HAVING SAID ANYTHING.
DURING THE COURSE OF AB THIRTY
ONE OR TWO ABOUT DOING 50% OR
NOT.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT'S A
REFERENCE TO COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
BUT I CAN CONFIRM WHEN I LOOKED
INTO THIS.
THAT IN THE MID NINETIES MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE DEPARTMENT
GOT THE FIRST ABILITY TO
INCREASE FILING FEES FOR SECRET
DOCUMENT REVIEW.
WE CONVENE STAKEHOLDERS AND WE
TALKED ABOUT WORK LOAD.
AND THAT PROCESS PRODUCED A FEE.
WHICH ALLOWS US A DO ABOUT 50%
OF THIS WORKLOAD ANNUAL.
THE NEXT THING THE LEGISLATURE
DID MY UNDERSTANDING IS AND TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN THEY GAVE US.
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX INFLATION
ABILITY RELATED TO THAT FEE THAT
WAS SET IN THE MID NINETIES.
SO ALL WE'VE BEEN DOING SINCE
THEN IS INCREASING BASED ON CPR.
I WOULD ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IF
SOMEONE DOES THIS REVIEW WILL
LIKELY OUTCOME IS THE VERY
COMMUNITIES WHICH ARE STRUGGLING.
PRIOR TO PROCESS PAPERWORK ARE
GOING TO BE FACING A FEE
INCREASE.
I WOULD WELCOME MISTER GRAY'S
CHO PARTNERSHIP WITH ME ON GOING
TO THE DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY TO
PROPOSE A FEE INCREASE ON SEQUEL
REVIEW.
SOME PEOPLE WOULD PREFER
MATTERED MISTER CHAIRMAN PAIN UP.
A SMALL FEE THEN.
THE TIME AND COST OF A DELAY OF
THE PROJECT.
THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S SO THE
POINT I'M MAKING SO IT'S IT'S
ACTUALLY MORE COST EFFECTIVE TO
JUST.
OKAY -- FOR
THE PROCESSING RATHER THAN --
TAKEN -- A
HIT ON A SIX MONTH DELAY ON A
PROJECT BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
PROCESS [inaudible]
THE PAPERWORK --
EXPEDITIOUSLY AND FOR LIKE SAY A
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PROJECT
THAT'S SIX MONTH DELAY COULD BE
LIKE. THREE OR FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS AND COST INCREASES GETS
AYE AYE HERE TO SING SENATOR AYE.
BUT I GUY I WANT TO FOCUS.
ON THE SCOPE OF THE AUDIT
REQUEST AND THAT'S WHERE THE
PUBLIC RESEARCHER FROM MY
CHINAMEN.
OUR TO THIS DISCUSSION THANK YOU
CENTER FOR THE QUESTION THANK
YOU TO SAVE MONEY.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR INTEREST
BOTH IN SAVING MONEY AND
IMPROVING THE PROCESS --
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT THE
DIRECTOR AND AND YOU KNOW THE
DIRECTOR MADE SOME COMMENTS THAT
HE AND I HAVE A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP IN AN OPEN DOOR AND
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY TRUE AND WE'VE
HAD MANY INTERACTIONS.
ON MANY ISSUES --
THERE WAS REFERENCE TO TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE IN THERE WAS IN
FACT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE BY
DEALING WITH ARE THE FISCAL
ISSUES AROUND THE DEPARTMENT
[inaudible]
AND THE GOAL OF THAT PARTICULAR
ARE REVIEW --
IS FOR THE PARCHMENT.
TO GET GUIDANCE ON HOW DEVELOPER
SERVER SPACE BUDGET TRACKING
SYSTEM.
I'M IN MY MIND AND IN RESPECT TO
SENATORS QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
THAT'S VERY DIFFERENT THAN THE
GOAL THE AUDIT.
IN THE SENSE THAT --
IN THE REVIEWS NOT DESIGNED TO
ADDRESS COMPLIANCE ISSUES BUT
YOU'RE KIND RATHER STRICTLY
FISCAL ISSUES AND THE DIRECTOR
RAISES THE QUESTION OF FEES ARE
INCREASED FEES AND AS STAFFING
LEVELS AND SO ON AND SO FORTH --
A THAT REVIEWS THAT CAN BE
COMPLETED IT'S NOT REQUIRED
STATUTORY BECOME CLEAN TELL.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BONTA BUT BE I
DON'T THINK THAT IT ADDRESSES
PERHAPS INADEQUACIES THAT LIE
ELSEWHERE THAT PERHAPS IN THE
STRUCTURE OF THE LAW ITSELF
RIGHT.
THIS AUDIT I'M NOT BRINGING
FORWARD IS MUCH TO BE FISCAL
AUDIT OF THE DIRECTORS
DEPARTMENT AS IT IS LET'S TAKE A
REVIEW OF OF THE PROCESS AND THE
STATUES ON THE BOOK.
ARE AND HOW THOSE ARE WORKING
AND THAT.
WILL LEND ITSELF TO BETTER
INFORMING --
OUR BODY AYE IF WE NEED TO DO
SOME ADDITIONAL LEGISLATIVE WORK
IN THIS AREA TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS --
AT ALL LEAVES THE DEVELOPER FEES
TO THE DIRECTOR WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO HIM.
UP FOR GOOD FOR THE TIME BEING --
BY I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE
UNDERSTOOD THAT THE STAKES
THERE'S THE FISCAL ISSUES AND
UNDERSUPPLY IT'S ISSUES THAT'S
WHERE THE ART IS DIRECTED --
CERTAINLY NOT --
SAYING THAT THE DEPARTMENT
[inaudible]
I ISN'T ABLE TO WEAR HASN'T BEEN
ABLE TO OUR LANE THAT AT THEIR
DOORSTEP AS MUCH AS I'M LAYING
AT THE DOORSTEP OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND WHAT STEPS WE
NEED TO TAKE TO HAVE A BETTER
PROCESS.
IF THAT MAKES SENSE MISTER CHAIR
YES AND SO --
NOT WITHSTANDING.
IT IS MISTER BOTTOM RIGHT
CORRECT YES --
AT NO RISK AND THAT WAS THAT MR
BOTTOMS --
INDICATIONS THAT HE WANTS TO
WORK WITH YOU YOU --
WE WANT TO CONTINUE WITH YOUR I
REQUEST ITS ACT I DO WANT TO
CONTINUE IT I I WELCOME THE
DIRECTOR BONHAM'S --
ARE TRYING TO WORK WITH THEM AS
WELL BUT I THINK THE AUDIT WILL
BE IN.
FOR IT'S A GOOD TOOL FOR US HERE
AT THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS GOING FORWARD
A ON THE SECRET PROCESS AND THE
STATUE AS IT RELATES TO
DEPARTMENT WOULD.
WITH RESPECT THOUGH.
IF THE LIMITATION IS A SEQUEL
THAT I WOULD POSE THE QUESTION
WHY IN THE AUDIT LETTER IS
QUESTION.
SIX WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE
DEPARTMENT STAFF IS DEVOTED TO
HABITAT MANAGEMENT HOUSE THE
HABITAT MANAGEMENT PROGRAM
FUNDED.
SO I AM CONFUSED IN THE SCOPE
AND WOULD WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP DISCUSSING
WITH THE FOR QUESTOR.
A POSSIBLE SCHOOL.
ALRIGHT WELL --
THE REQUESTED IS AS STATED IN
THE WRITTEN LETTER AND THAT IS
WHAT WE ARE DELIBERATING WITH
THIS COMMITTEE --
AND BEGIN CERTAINLY.
I I DON'T THINK THAT THE AUDITOR
HAS ANY QUESTIONS AS TO WHAT THE
INTENT OF THE ITEM NUMBER SIX
CITIZENS SO THAT HIS.
WHAT IS RELEVANT AT THIS POINT
CENTER FULLER?
SO I JUST US WOULD LIKE TO ADD
THAT -- THE
DIRECTORIES --
CORRECTIVE BOWED HIS OPEN DOOR
AND I'VE USED IT MANY TIMES AND
I'VE APPRECIATED AT HOWEVER.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT I AM JUST SO
KNOWS YOU HAVE ALWAYS WANTED TO
KNOW THE ANSWER TO THESE
QUESTIONS.
AND I CANNOT HELP MYSELF BUT
MAKE THE MOTION --
TO GO FORWARD WITH THE AUDIT
BECAUSE I WILL ENJOY READING
MYSELF TO SLEEP EVERY NIGHT
THANKING HIM.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
MOTION'S BEEN MADE SECONDED BY
MISTER COAST --
BELIEVE --
AND I'D SAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE --
PUBLIC COMMENT.
XENA.
WAS GREAT WHICH ELECT CLOSE I
SUSPECT WE ASK DR VOTE IN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU --
MOTIONS BEEN MADE AND SECONDED --
MADAM SECOND PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ROLL CALL TO APPROVE OTTER
CUSTOMER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
CASH ONE ONE NINE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
ITS PARTICIPATION IN THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
ACT WHO ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY.
THE TEARS RECOMMENDATIONS AND I
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MERCY CHII
VERSACE AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I IN THIS AREA
[inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO I WOULD [inaudible]
SENATOR ROTH [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
BELL.
BELL AYE CANNELLA [inaudible]
FULLER.
FULLER AYE LARA.
THIS REQUEST IS ON CALL.
YOU VERY MUCH TAKE RESEARCHER
THANK YOU ARE SENATORS ALRIGHT.
THE LAST ITEM ON THE AGENDA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THAT'S ONE THIRTY TO
CALIFORNIA GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION AND DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AGAIN THE CONTROL FUND A
REQUEST BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BONTA AND CHIU.
BOTTOM MISTER BONTA THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
REQUEST.
THAT CALIFORNIA GAMING CONTROL
COMMISSION AND THE BUREAU OF
GAMBLING CONTROL ¢HIN
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OVERSEE
THE LICENSING AND THE APPROVAL.
PROCESS HE'S. FOR THE CARD ROOM
INDUSTRY THAT GAMBLING CONTROL
FUND WAS CREATED EXCLUSIVELY FOR
THE BUREAU.
AND COMMISSION TO CARRY OUT
THEIR DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES IN REGULATING
THE SEVENTY FOUR ACTIVE CARD
ROOMS.
IN CALIFORNIA THIS IS IN THE
PROCESS FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
AND IN THOSE TWENTY YEARS.
NEITHER THE COMMISSION THE
BUREAU OR THE GAMBLING CONTROL
FUND HAVE BEEN INDEPENDENTLY
REVIEWED. TO ENSURE THAT THE
REGULATORY SYSTEM IS MEETING ITS
STATUTORILY MANDATED
[inaudible]
GOALS THAT.
FUND WHICH CONSIST OF FEES
COLLECTED FROM CARBON INDUSTRY
IS PROJECTED TO BE AT
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY FOUR NINE
MILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS.
BY TWENTY NINETEEN WHILE THE FUN
CONTINUES TO GROW BY SEVERAL
SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS EVERY
YEAR APPROXIMATELY TWO TO THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
OVER ITS ONGOING EXPENDITURES
THERE STILL SEEMS TO BE AN
EXTENSIVE BACKLOG.
OF APPLICATIONS FOR LICENSING A
GAME APPROVAL.
AND NOT IT IS NEEDED IN MY VIEW
AND THE VIEW OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHU TO HELP DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT FEES ARE BEING USED
APPROPRIATELY.
AND WHETHER OR NOT THEY MAY NEED
TO BE ADJUSTED UNDER CURRENT LAW
A GAMING LICENSE REVIEW IS
REQUIRED TO BE COMPLETED WITHIN
A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS IT'S
BEEN BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION.
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN MANY CASES
THAT HAVE TAKEN WELL OVER A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS WITH
SOME CASES TAKING.
UP TO FOUR YEARS [inaudible] TO
REVIEW. TO ADDRESS THIS BACKLOG
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY EMPLOYEES
WERE TRANSFERRED FROM THE
COMMISSION TO THE BUREAU IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THE LEGISLATURE
AUGMENTED.
THE BUREAU'S BUDGET TO ALLOW FOR
AN ADDITIONAL TWELVE POSITIONS
TO ADDRESS THE SAME ISSUE.
IT WAS ASSUMED THAT ADDITIONAL
STAFF WOULD HELP THE BUREAU
RESOLVED THE BACKLOG IN THREE
YEARS BUT IT DIDN'T.
THAT BACKLOG STILL EXIST TODAY
AT ABOUT AS WE UNDERSTAND IT
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED CASES.
THE SIGNIFICANT DELAYS IN THE
SERVICES PROVIDED BY THE BUREAU
ARE NOT LIMITED TO LICENSING
APPLICATIONS THE BUREAU GAME
UNIT HAS ALSO.
NOT ISSUED ANY DECISIONS ON NEW
GAME SINCE FEBRUARY TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND AUDIT WOULD HELP
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT PLEASE
ARE BEEN PROPERLY TRAINED IN
OPERATING EFFICIENTLY TO
COMPLETE THE LICENSING.
REVIEW PROCESS IN THE REQUIRED
ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAY TIME
FRAME.
LASTLY THERE BEEN BUSINESSES
SPECIFICALLY WITHIN THE API
COMMUNITY.
THAT HAVE COME FORWARD AND AND
SPOKEN TO ME IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JUN AND OTHERS IN THE API ACT
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
THAT I FELT DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST JOIN THE PROCESS OF
APPLYING FOR A LICENSE FOR
EXAMPLE.
NEARLY ALL THE APPLICANTS THAT
ARE SENT TO AN ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARING FOR FOR THE REVIEW COME
FROM.
A RACIAL ETHNIC MINORITY
BACKGROUND IN NEARLY 40% ARE OF
AN API BACKGROUND NOT IT WOULD
ENSURE THAT ALL APPLICANTS ARE
BEING TREATED THE SAME
REGARDLESS OF THE RACE NATIONAL
ORIGIN OR GENDER --
AND WE'RE HOPING.
TO DETERMINE WHETHER NOT THERE
IS ANY DESPERATE IMPACT ON
CERTAIN OUT RACIAL OR ETHNIC
GROUPS.
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS AUDIT IS JERRY
BROWN WITH BLONDIE IN BOYD AND
CONDIT PUBLIC AFFAIRS AS WELL AS
JACQUELINE FOO.
WITH LUCKY CHANCES.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER BHAKTA.
EVEN THE BEST DESIGN REGULATORY
SYSTEMS CAN FAIL IF STRUCTURES
CHECKS AND BALANCES DO NOT
PREVENT IMPROPER INFLUENCE OVER
DECISION MAKING.
IN GAMING REGULATORY SYSTEMS
BRITAIN --
REGULATORS HAVE BROAD DISCRETION
OVER MAKING DECISIONS AND
THERE'S OF FEELING WITHIN THE
INDUSTRY THAT THAT THE
REGULATORY SYSTEM.
IS NOT IN A CONDUCTING THINGS IN
A FAIR AND BALANCED MATTER.
AND NOT IT IS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE IS GOING
THROUGH THE SAME PROCESS AND
DECISIONS ARE MADE BEING MADE
AND A FAIR AND CONSISTENT MANNER.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE JOINT.
LEGISLATIVE I'VE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JACQUELINE BILL AND I'M
WITH THE BUCKLED HER LAW FIRM.
I'M HERE THIS AFTERNOON ON
BEHALF OF LUCKY CHEN.
SUPPORT FOR THE REQUESTED AUDIT.
LUCKY CHANCES IS A LICENSED
GAMBLING ESTABLISHMENT THAT'S
LOCATED IN THE CITY A COMMA
CALIFORNIA.
IT WAS DEVELOPED IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT BY AMANDA RENEE
MEDINA WHO CAME TO THE U. S.
WITH A HUNDRED DOLLARS IS POCKET.
SELECT THE CASINO ITSELF NOW
CURRENTLY EMPLOYS OVER IN. FIVE
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE.
IN MAY TWO AND MAY TWENTY
SEVENTEEN LUCKY CHANCES
SUBMITTED A COMPARTMENT YUSHIN
TO RENEW ITS LICENSE TO THE
BUREAU.
AND IT IS AN INDISPUTABLY
COMPLIED WITH ALL REQUIRED
CONDITIONS FOR THE RENEWAL.
DESPITE THIS THE BUREAU
RECOMMENDED THAT THE COMMISSION
DENY LUCKY CHANCES --
APPLICATION FOR RENEWAL BASED ON
A TWO THOUSAND SIX IRIS REPORTS.
FEDERAL LAW INCLUDING THE BANK
SECRECY ACT MANDATES THAT EVERY
CASINO THAT GENERATES OVER
MILLION DOLLARS OF REVENUE IN
THE YEAR IMPLEMENTS POLICIES TO
ENSURE THAT MONTH TO MONTH MONEY
LAUNDERING DOES NOT HAPPEN.
SO IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
DURING A ROUTINE AUDITS.
LUCKY CHANCES RECEIVED A LETTER
FROM THE IRS OUTLINING SOME
MINOR BUT TECHNICAL DEFEAT
DEFICIENCIES IN THEIR INTERNAL
MY ANTI MONEY LAUNDERING SO --
POLICIES.
AS A RESULT OF THAT --
THE BECAUSE THOSE ARE
DEFICIENCIES WERE MINOR THEY
WERE NOT FIND AND THE IRIS
DIDN'T SEEM NECESSARY TO REFER
THEM TO THE FENCE AND DEPARTMENT
UP THE IRS.
FOLLOWING THAT AUDIT.
BUT YOUR CHANCES IN TOOK
IMMEDIATE MEASURES THROUGH THAT
FIX THESE EFFICIENCIES INCLUDING
HIRING ATTORNEY.
WHO WAS SPECIALIZED IN THE BSA
AND SHE OVER LEX NOW THE
COMPLIANCE DEPARTMENTS?
THEY IMPLEMENTED A COMPUTER I
SYSTEM TO KEEP TRACK OF CASH
DEPOSITS [inaudible]
AND PREPARED NEW ANTI MONEY
LAUNDERING POLICIES WIKISPECIES.
NO VIOLATIONS OR IN ADDITION THE
BUREAU THE BUREAU AUDITOR'S
REVIEW THESE POLICIES DURING AND
AUDIT TO THE AUDIT IN JUNE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND NO
VIOLATIONS.
A WERE FOUND.
DESPITE THIS THE BUREAU HAS USED
THIS REPORT AS A BASIS FOR THE
REST IN PEACE FOR THEIR
RECOMMENDATION TO THE COMMISSION.
TO DENY LUCKY CHANCES THEIR
RIGHT TO RENEW THEIR LICENSE.
ALTERNATIVELY THE BUREAU HAS
STATED HAS RECOMMENDED TO THE
COMMISSION THAT INSTEAD OF
DENYING THEIR GREEN MEAN STATE
FOR DENYING THE RENEWAL.
THE BEER HAS STATED THAT.
COMMISSION ALLOW THEM TO RENEW
THEIR LICENSE ON THE CONDITION
THAT THE CASINO TERMINATE THESE
CONTRACTS WITH THIRD PARTIES
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT THERE
ARE THE MILIEU RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THESE THIRD PARTY
BUSINESS ENTITIES AND THAT THE
CHANCES --
NAM AND I'M GONNA ASK YOU NOT TO
FOCUS TOO MUCH ON THE DETAILS OF
THIS PARTICULAR --
CASE BUT OF PERHAPS IN TO THE
EXTENT THAT IT HIGHLIGHTS.
THE AND SUPPORTS THIRD THE AUDIT
REQUEST UNDERSTOOD DO WE WE WE
HAVE NO FACTUAL BASIS.
TO YOU KNOW TO DETERMINE THIS IS
NOT THE FACT FINDING BODY FOR
THIS PARTICULAR [inaudible]
UNDERSTOOD SO OUR POSITION IS --
CHAIRMAN THAT LUCKY CHANCE IT
HAS BEEN TREATED UNFAIRLY AND
THIS IS JUST SORT OF A SMALL.
OF A SAMPLE OF THE THE LARGER
PICTURE --
THERE HAS BEEN X. WE HAVE BEEN
EXPECT THE CASINO ITSELF HAS
EXPERIENCE SOME BIAS.
FROM THE CASINO I MEAN FROM THE
BUREAU AND THE COMMISSION FOR
EXAMPLE --
THE OWNER OF THE CASINO MISS.
IT'S A MEDINA THE FILIPINO
IMMIGRANTS --
THE CASINO EMPLOYEES ABOUT SIX
AND A FIFTY PEOPLE THE MAJORITY
OF WHICH ARE OF FILIPINO DESCENT.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN COMMENTS
MADE ON THE RECORD BY THE BUREAU.
THAT HAVE.
INSINUATED THAT THE CASINOS
INVOLVED IN MUNCIE --
MONEY LAUNDERING BECAUSE CASINOS
OWNERS ALSO OWN A CASHED CASH
DEPOSITING BUSINESS THAT HAPPENS.
TO YOU KNOW --
CATER TO THE FILIPINO COMMUNITY.
WHO WOULD SEND MONEY BACK TO THE
PHILIPPINES --
SO SO BASED ON THAT.
AGAIN THIS IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE
OF THE THE LARGER PICTURE OF YOU
KNOW THE UNFAIR TREATMENT FROM
THE BUREAU AND SO OUR REQUEST IS
THAT.
IF YOU DO YOU APPROVE THE AUDIT
YOU KNOW.
OUR GOAL IS HERE TO INCREASE THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
BUREAU INFORMATION WHICH WILL NO
DOUBT HELPED IMPROVE THE
CONDITIONS ARE THE RESULTS.
WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
REQUEST ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH [inaudible]
THAT'S HOW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA INDICATED
THIS WOULD BE AN AUDIT WE WILL
BE LOOKING AT THE M..
GAMBLING CAN CONTROL COMMISSION
BUT PRIMARILY LOOKING AT BEER OF
CAMPBELL IN CONTROL AND A
VARIETY OF OBJECTIVES RELATED TO
THEIR EFFICIENCY AND
EFFECTIVENESS AND PROCESSING
BACKGROUND CHECKS OF BOTH GANTT
GAMBLING ESTABLISHMENTS AND
LICENSEES.
BOMB MAKING SURE THAT THEIR
PROCESSING APPLICATIONS AND
FOLLOWING STATUTORY
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE
REQUIREMENTS AS FAR AS TIME
FRAMES IDENTIFY IF THERE IS ANY
BACKLOG --
THE BECAUSE OF THE BACKLOG AND
ANY --
STRATEGIES THAT THE BUREAU HAS
FOR ADDRESSING THE BACKLOG A AS
MISTER BONTA INDICATED HE'S
ASKING US TO LOOK AT THE PROCESS
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE THE BUREAU OF GAMBLER.
TEACHERS AND TREATING ALL
APPLICANTS THE SAME OFF.
AND CONSISTENTLY --
ALSO ASKING US TO LOOK AT IT
WHETHER OR NOT TRY TO DETERMINE
IF THERE'S ANY IMPROPER USE OF
OF FUNDS OUT SO WE WOULD BE
DOING AN ASSESSMENT OF THAT.
ALSO LOOKING AT THERE'S A
SECTION WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE INDIAN OUR GAMING LAW
SECTION THAT LOOKS AT CONTRACTS
IS ASKING US TO LOOK AT THEIR
PROCESS FOR EVALUATING IN
REVIEWING THOSE CONTRACTS.
AND AGAIN ARE THEY FOLLOWING
APPROPRIATE PROTOCOLS IN
TREATING.
ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS
ASSOCIATED THOSE CONTRACTS FAIR
IN A FAIR MANNER WITH RESPECT TO
THE COMMISSION.
HE'S INTERESTED IN ARE US
LOOKING AT THE A SELECTION OF
COMMISSION MEETINGS MAKING SURE
THAT THEY'RE COMPLYING WITH THE
BAGLEY KEENE ACT.
OUGHT SELECT SOME OF THE MATTERS
AND DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE FOLLOWING APPROPRIATE
PROTOCOLS AS FAR AS ANY
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST ARE ANY
ANY OTHER PARTICULAR.
STATUTORY RESPONSIBILITIES THAT
FALL WITHIN THE COMMISSION AND
THEN THE FINAL OBJECTIVE IS
RELATED.
TO IS THERE A SURPLUS BALANCE IN
THE GAMBLING FUND OUGHT
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT --
THAT SURPLUS IS TOO HIGH IS IT
REASONABLE ARE AND AND BASED ON
THAT ANALYSIS DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT THERE NEED TO BE
ADJUSTMENTS TO FEES THAT
APPLICANTS AND LICENSEES ARE PAY.
THE BUDGET FOR THE AUDIT TWENTY
FOUR HUNDRED HOURS --
SIX MONTHS WORTH OF STAFF TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'D LIKE TO NOW INVITE
[inaudible]
TO THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE AND
THE BUREAU OF GAMBLING CONTROL --
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
GAMBLING CONTROL COMMISSION TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON IT'S ALWAYS FUN
TO GO LAST THANK YOU FOR
STICKING IN THERE WITH US.
THE STATE THE WINNER BAXTER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY CONTROL
COMMISSION.
LOWER RESPECT THE AUTHORITY OF
THIS PROCESS AND CERTAINLY THE
STATE AUDITOR THE REQUEST CAUGHT
COVERS AN EXTREMELY BROAD SCOPE
OF ISSUES SUCH AS THE AUDITOR
JUST LAID OUT.
ISSUES WE BELIEVE CAN BE
RESOLVED AT MUCH LESS EXPENSE TO
THE STATE WITH OPEN
COMMUNICATION AND THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE BEER ON THE
COMMISSION TO KNOW THE ACTUAL
ALLEGATIONS THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME WERE ACTUALLY HEARING
ALLEGATIONS MADE.
AND THE ABILITY TO FOR US TO
PROVIDE FACTUAL COMPLETE AND
ACCURATE INFORMATION TO
ALLEVIATE THOSE CONCERNS.
THE COMMISSION HAS ALREADY
PROVIDED INFORMATION TO THE
MEMBERS RESPOND TO EACH ISSUE
OUTLINES SO I WILL LIMIT MY
COMMENTS TO ONE PARTICULAR ISSUE
OUTLINED WHICH IS THE DISPARITY
TREATMENT THAT'S BEEN ALLEGED.
THE COMMISSION FOLLOWS THE LAWS
OUTLINED IN THE GAMING CONTROL
ACT IN SUBSEQUENT REGULATIONS
ADOPTED WHEN CONDUCTING ITS
ROLES RESPONSIBILITY.
THE COMMISSION IS TRANSPARENT
EIGHT IS A TRANSPARENT AGENCY
THAT FALLS ABOUT BREAKING OPEN
MEETING ACT CONDUCTS ALL MEANS
PUBLICLY.
PROVIDES RECORDS OF ALL ME ALL
MEETINGS ONLINE.
AND ALONG WITH COPIES OF THE
DECISIONS EVEN THE ONE WITH
REGARDS TO LUCKY CHANCES ONLINE
THROUGH ITS WEBSITE.
THE COMMISSION IS CHARGED WITH
ENSURING INTEGRITY IN THE
CONTROL GAMBLING INDUSTRY
COUPLED WITH THE STATUTES THAT
ARE OUTGOING CERTAIN MANDATORY
DISQUALIFIER STE.
SUCH AS FELONY CONVICTIONS FOR
CRIMES OF DISHONESTY THE
CONDITIONS THE COMMISSION
MAINTAINS INTEGRITY WITHIN THE
INDUSTRY PINE SHARING ONLY
PEOPLE OF GOOD CHARACTER.
HONESTY AND INTEGRITY MAKE UP OR
ARE INVOLVED IN THE GAMBLING
CONTROL WITH A CARTON INDUSTRY.
THE COMMISSIONER'S DECISIONS ON
WHETHER THE APPLICANT IS
SUITABLE FOR LICENSE OR SOLELY
BASED ON A REPORT THAT IS
PROVIDED TO US BY THE BUREAU OF
GAMBLING CONTROL.
AFTER THEY HAVE COMPLETED THEIR
BACKGROUND INVESTIGATION.
AND ANY ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
THAT IS PROVIDED TO US THROUGH
THE APPLICANTS.
THE REPORT IS LIMITED TO
INFORMATION SUCH AS CRIMINAL
HISTORY EMPLOYMENT HISTORY
FINANCIAL HISTORY IN ANY
LITIGATION HISTORY OR ANY OTHER --
DEROGATORY INFORMATION THAT WAS
FOUND OUT THROUGH THE
INVESTIGATION.
THE COMMISSIONERS TYPICALLY DO
NOT KNOW FIND INFORMATION OF
THOSE APPLICANTS.
SUCH AS ETHNICITY OR ANY TYPE OF
PROTECT.
THE SUGGESTION THAT AN
APPLICANT'S ETHNICITY HAS ANY
ROLE IN THIS PROCESS IS NOT ONLY
DISTURBING BUT UNFOUNDED.
ALL APPLICANTS MUST UNDERGO THE
SAME PROCESS ARE AFFORDED THE
SAME RIGHTS.
SAME DUE PROCESS RIGHTS AND ARE
TREATED FAIRLY REGARDLESS OF THE
BACKGROUND FINDINGS.
WITH RESPECT TO THE LUCKY
CHANCES WHAT THEY DID NOT.
PROVIDE YOU WITH INFORMATION ON
IS THE DECISION WAS BASED SOLELY
ON THE FACT AYE A CONVICTED
FELON WAS OPERATING WITHIN THE
CARTER.
OKAY I AM GONNA GIVE THE SAME --
ADMONITION AS I GAVE TO DIG INTO
THE TURNED REPRESENT LIKE
AGAINST BUT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
TO MUCH OF THE DETAILS OF ONE
PARTICULAR CASE THAT'S ALL I
WANT TO SAY ABOUT THAT NUMBER
[inaudible]
WITH RESPECT.
WE REQUEST THAT THIS BE DENIED
INLAND BE ALLOWED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY PROVIDE
INFORMATION FACTUAL AND COMPLETE
INFORMATION WITH REGARDS TO
THESE CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SAY GOOD MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON.
THAT MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
SCHMEISER AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF THE BUREAU OF GALLON CONTROL
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
ALSO HERE WITH ME AS CHRIS RYAN
WHO IS OUR CHIEF OF OPERATIONS
AT THE OJ.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
REGARDING THEIR QUEST FOR AN
AUDIT OF THE BUREAU AS WELL AS
THE COMMISSION --
IN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
ANYTHING GAME LAW SECTION.
WE HAD DISTRIBUTED LETTER --
THAT RESPONSE TO MANY OF THE
STATEMENTS NOW ENGAGES IN THE
AUTUMN REQUEST AND HOPE THAT
YOU'RE ABLE TO REVIEW IT
APOLOGIZED CONSENT IN LATE IN
THE GAME.
I GENERALLY THOUGHT THAT REQUEST
CONTAIN SOME INACCURATE
STATEMENTS CONCLUSIONS AND A
BASIC MISUNDERSTANDING OF THE
BUREAU'S AN IDEALIST IS
RESPONSIBILITIES AND PROCESSES.
ADDITIONALLY AND AS HIS BACK
JUST BAXTER STATED.
THAT MOST CONCERNING THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE TAKES GREAT
ISSUE WITH THE REQUESTS
UNFOUNDED ALLEGATION THAT
APPLICANTS AND LICENSEES FROM
CERTAIN RACIAL BACKGROUNDS.
NATIONAL ORIGINS MAY BE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY SPECIFICALLY THE
ASIA PACIFIC ISLAND ISLANDER
COMMUNITY --
THE CLAIM THAT ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS MAY BE THE FOCUS OF
UNNECESSARY INVESTIGATIONS IN
DESPAIR TREATMENT IS NOT
ACCOMPANIED BY ANY EXAMPLES
STATISTICS OR OTHER INFORMATION
FROM WHICH WE COULD UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE CLAIM IS COMING FROM.
I AM NEITHER THE BUREAU NOR THE
IDEALIST TREAT APPLICANTS
LICENSEES DIFFERENTLY BASED ON
RACE OR NATIONAL ORIGIN.
I CAN SURE YOU THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND I PERSONALLY WOULD
NOT TOLERATE SUCH ACTION.
SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES
OUTLINED THE LETTER DID NOT
SURPRISE US WE'VE HEARD SOME OF
THE CONCERNS FROM INDUSTRY
BEFORE.
WE'VE ATTEMPTED TO TAKE
PROACTIVE STEPS TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS.
SO FOR EXAMPLE.
WHEN CARBON REPRESENTATIVES
NOTIFIED THE BUREAU THAT I'M
USED INVESTIGATION DEPOSITS PAID
BY CARD ROOMS WEREN'T BEING
RETURNED PROBABLY --
STEP WAS IMMEDIATELY DIRECTED TO
INITIATE THE PROCESS TO RETURN
THOSE UNUSED DEPOSITS WITHIN TWO
WEEKS OF THE FINAL DECISION ON
AN APPLICATION.
I'M AN EFFORT TO ADDRESS DELAYS
EITHER REAL OR PERCEIVED
REGARDING THE STATEMENTS OF
ISSUES --
FILING AND APPROVAL TRANSACTIONS
THE BEER ALSO TO HAS TAKEN SOME
ACTION.
A NEW PROCESS WAS INSTITUTED TO
EXPLOIT THE FILING OF STATEMENTS
OF ISSUES --
BY MEDIALLY REFERRING CASES TO
AYE JLS INSTEAD OF WAITING FOR
AND KNOWS THAT DEFENSE TO COME
IN FROM AN APPLICANT --
HEROES ALSO IN THE PROCESS OF
HIRING IT FIRST IN HOUSE
ATTORNEY TO REVIEW TRANSACTIONS.
AND ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE
WORKLOAD ON AYE GLS.
THERE'S A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT BACKLOGS TO WANT TO
COMMENT ON THAT.
BUT RESPECT TO THE BACKLOG OF
THE LICENSING APPLICATIONS THE
BUREAU HAS DRAMATICALLY
DECREASED THAT BACKLOG OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS --
FOR SOME NUMBERS IN MAY TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE NUMBER OF
PENDING APPLICATIONS BEFORE US
WAS.
THREE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
ELEVEN AT THE END OF JUNE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE NUMBER OF
PENDING APPLICATIONS WAS.
ONE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
NINETY SEVEN ASH EXPLAINED THAT
NUMBER OF BACKLOGGED
APPLICATIONS BASICALLY CHANGES
ON A DAILY BASES AS NEW
APPLICATIONS ARE RECEIVED.
AND WE ROUTINELY RECEIVE ON THE
AVERAGE ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
APPLICATIONS EVERY MONTH WITH --
I'LL BUT HAVE WITH THE DIS
CREASE IT WAS DUE TO AN INCREASE
IN STAFF.
OTHER ARISTIDE TO FUNDING FOR
TWELVE POSITIONS AND FISCAL YEAR
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AND THEN TWENTY
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS THE
FOLLOWING YEAR --
ALL THIRTY TWO POSITIONS ARE
CURRENTLY FILLED BUT THEY DO
HAVE LIMITED TIME FUNDING THAT
WILL EXPIRE AT THE END OF THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR.
SO THAT IS A CONCERN ABOUT.
IF FUNDING IS NOT PROVIDED THE
BUREAU MAY LOSE STAFF NEXT YEAR
IN THE BACK WHILE WILL THEN ONCE
AGAIN INCREASED.
RIGHT IN THE MIDST OF ARE MAKING
PROGRESS.
AND EVEN WITH LIMITED TERM
FUNDING.
DEBILITY TO RETAIN STAFF MAY BE
DIFFICULT --
AND JUST SAY NO THE THE
EXPERIENCING TRAINED STAFF
USUALLY WORK ON THE MORE
COMPLICATED MARK TIME CONSUMING
INVESTIGATIONS.
SO WHEN STAFF GO OUT IT'S A
PROCESS OF HIRING RETRAINING
GETTING THEM EXPERIENCE SO THEY
CAN HANDLE THEM [inaudible]
ONCE -- BUT
WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS FOR THE FOR
THE FISCAL YEAR.
NINETEEN TWENTY ADDITIONALLY WE
WOULD LIKE TO ASSURE THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CARBON
INDUSTRY WE UNDERSTAND AND WE'RE
ALWAYS MINDFUL ABOUT
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER THE
GAMBLING CONTROL FUN.
AND HOW WE SPENT THAT MONEY AS
WELL AS A SPECIAL DISTRIBUTION
FUND WHICH IS --
MONEY THAT TRIBES PAY INTO --
ONE OF THE ALLEGATIONS IN THE
AUDITOR CLASSES THAT THE DOJ
MAYBE USING EMPLOYEES FROM THAT
FROM THE GALA CONTROL FUND FOR
OTHER PURPOSES OKAY LET ME LET
ME AGAIN NOW.
YOU KNOW I I WANT TO GIVE YOU
AYE AYE A CHANCE TO RESPOND TO
THE AUDIT REQUESTS BUT WERE NOT
THE FACT FINDING BODY THIS IS
NOT.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE ALLEGATION
WHAT IS THE RESPONSE SOARED --
DEFENSE BUT IF YOU CAN TRY TO
KEEP IN MIND HOW THIS IS
RELEVANT AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THIS COMMITTEE SHOULD APPROVED
PROVE THIS AUDIT REQUEST YOU'RE
NOT SURE AND I WAS THEM.
I APOLOGIZE I WAS JUST THERE ARE
SOME THAT STATEMENT CENTER THAT
I FELT LIKE WE HAD TO ADDRESS
BECAUSE WE FELT THERE AN
INACCURATE OR GET PROVIDE THE
FULL.
ON INFORMATION AND AND PERHAPS I
MEAN IF THIS --
WHO WHAT WHEN THE POINTS HAVE
BEEN MADE IN THE COURSE OF
TODAY'S HEARING IS AT?
AN AUDIT IS IS YOU KNOW MAY NOT
BE PUNITIVE BUT A MAY --
ESTABLISH THAT ONCE AND FOR ALL
THAT THAT THERE ARE. FOR EXAMPLE
IF THE AUDITOR DOES NOT FIND ANY
EVIDENCE OF A DISPARATE
TREATMENT OR DISCRIMINATORY
TREATMENT THAN THAT WOULD BE
EVIDENCE THAT AT LEAST ACCORDING
TO THE STATE AUDITOR'S REVIEW
RIGHT NOW WE KNOW THAT THE
AUDITOR DOES CAMPBELL AT IT DOES.
COVER A WHOLE A NUMBER OF ISSUES
SO THAT WAS KINDA CONCERNING
THING THAT IN A PRIOR TO THIS WE
HAD THE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY SIT
DOWN.
AND COME TO DISCUSS SOME OTHER
THINGS --
PROVIDE SOME FACTUAL INFORMATION
SO THAT WAS SOMETHING WE HAD A
GOOD MEETING WITH THE REQUEST
YEARS BOTH THEM SILLY MEMBERS
BONTA CHIU WHERE.
THEY'RE OPEN TO DISCUSSING SO --
* THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
REQUESTING THAT BECAUSE IT'S A
LOT OF INFORMATION WE'VE JUST
HEARD --
HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
THROUGH SOME OF THE BEEN
CLARIFIED MAYBE NARROW THE SCOPE.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT SOME OF THE
THINGS PROBABLY.
IT.
IT'S JUST BASED ON THE PERSON IN
ACCURATE INFORMATION --
SO BUT YOU KNOW WELL WE DISPUTE
THE NEED FOR THE AUDIT OBVIOUSLY
IF -- IF NOT
IS APPROVED WE WILL COOPERATE
FULLY WITH THE AUDITOR'S OFFICE
MAKE SURE THAT HER STAFF HAS
EVERYTHING THEY NEED TO COMPLETE
THE AUDIT.
ARAFAT GIVEN QUESTIONS THANK YOU
OF BEFORE GOING FOR THEIR AN AND
OPEN UP TO THE COMMITTEE --
MISTER BONTA AYE I KNOW IS MY TO
TO MEET WITH THE SPAWNING
AGENCIES --
IS IS IT STILL YOUR POSITION
THAT TO YOU LIKE PROCEED WITH
THE REQUEST AS STATED IN OUR AND
YOUR WRITTEN REQUEST HIDEOUS AND
THANK YOU FOR THAT WE HAD A GOOD
MEETING AS AS WAS DESCRIBED --
AS ALWAYS WE WE ARE OPEN TO AND
NOT JUST PASSIVELY OPEN TO WE
WANT TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS.
I TO HELP RESOLVE THE THE ISSUE
I INVITED AT A SORT OF A TWO
TRACK APPROACH WEEK YOU
CONVERSATION IF WE CAN MAKE
PROGRESS FANTASTIC.
BUT HE GOT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT --
THAT THERE WERE SOME OF THESE
ISSUES HAVE BEEN RAISED IN THE
PAST IN TERMS OF REQUESTS FOR
DOCUMENTS SOME OF IN.
THURMOND FORMAL COMPLAINTS MADE
ON SOME OF THESE ISSUES --
FOR IT FOR OTHERS AYE I
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHERE TO BE
ON THE COMMISSION COMING FROM
[inaudible]
BECAUSE THE SOME OF THE FOLKS
THAT HAVE MADE THE ALLEGATIONS
FEAR RETALIATION.
AND SO WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
SHARE -- AT
A COMPLETE SET OF OF ALLEGATIONS
BUT I THINK THAT'S THAT WOULD
HAPPEN THAT VETTING WHAT
HAPPENED DURING THAT THE AUDIT
WHERE IF THE CONFIDENTIALITY TO
BE PROTECTED IT COULD BE.
AYE WEATHER CAN BE FULL VETTING
AND THE FACTS AND I'M AND I
AGREE WITH YOU OF EVERYTHING.
AYE THAT'S BEEN SAID --
BY SOME THE OPPOSITION IS TRUE
THEN AND THAT WOULD BE
DEFINITIVELY STATED IN THE AUDIT
BUT NOW THAT THE ALLEGATIONS
THAT BEEN RAISED ARE DISTURBING
IN CONCERNING --
IN A NUMBER OF WAYS --
IT WOULD ALSO THE FINDINGS THAT
ALSO HELP GUIDE WHAT WE CAN DO
IS THE LEGISLATURE TO ASSIST
WITH THE ONGOING REDUCTION OF
THE BACKLOG WHICH IS SOMEWHAT
HELP WITH --
BUT TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION YES.
I WE ARE STILL --
SEEKING TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS AUDIT TODAY MISTER CHAIR
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MS BAKER.
THINK YEAH IT DOES THIS POINT IS
I I REALLY DO.
I HEAR FROM YOU THAT AND AND
ALSO FROM THE OTHER SIDE THAT
THE MEETING THIS HAPPENS BUT
WHAT.
WELL DID DID THE OF DEPARTMENTS.
REFUSE TO PROVIDE INFORMATION --
THIS IS FOR THE REQUESTER AT
MISRATA IT DEBATE TODAY SAID
THEY WOULD NOT PROVIDE
INFORMATION WAS THEIR REQUEST.
USUALLY IT'S IT'S IDEAL IF THAT
OPTION HAS BEEN EXHAUSTED AND
SOMETIMES IT TAKES A YEAR.
OF BACK AND FORTH YOU GET THE
INFORMATION I'M IF YOU CAN
PROVIDE A BETTER SENSE OF JUST
HOW MUCH THAT OPTION IT'S BEEN
EXHAUSTED AND WHAT THEY WERE NOT
WILLING TO PROVIDE YOU WITH.
THAT CAN ONLY COME FROM THE
AUDIT BEFORE RESCIND THE AUDITOR
WHO'S TESTIFIED TO US THAT.
SHE HAS ROOM FOR A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF AUDITSBETWEEN NOW AND
AND SEVERAL MONTHS OUT.
INCLUDING ONE THAT COULD TAKE
QUITE A LOT OF PEOPLE SO I'M CAN
YOU SHARE THE BUT MORE
INFORMATION OUT THAT YES I DO MY
BEST.
THIS AND AND SOME OF THIS IS NOT
PERSONAL KNOWLEDGE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU AND I GOT
INVOLVED WHEN A NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SUBJECT TO
THE OVERSIGHT OF THE BEER ON THE
COMMISSION CAME TO US WITH WITH
CONCERNS AND WE SHARED WITH US.
THAT THERE HAD BEEN MULTIPLE
REQUESTS FOR DOCUMENTS AYE WHICH
WOULD OR NOT RESPONDED.
TO THERE WERE MEETINGS THAT
DIDN'T LEAD TO SOLUTIONS.
I THOUGHT THERE WERE ACTUAL
FORMAL FORMAL --
COMPLAINTS THAT WERE MADE
INCLUDING TO THE INTERNAL
AFFAIRS WITH WITH THAT IDEA J.
THAT DID NOT LEAD TO A SOLUTION.
SO IT WAS SHARED WITH US THAT
THAT INTERIM STEPS OUT TO WORK
DIRECTLY.
WITH THE COMMISSION WITH THE
BUREAU HAD BEEN TAKEN THAT
DIDN'T LEAD TO A AT ADEQUATE
SOLUTIONS OR RESOLUTION OF THE
PROBLEM IN FACT IN SOME CASES IT
GOT WORSE --
WAS SHARED WITH US THAT
RETALIATION ENSUED AND
ADDITIONAL SCRUTINY THAT WASN'T
THERE AND IN THE BEGINNING
OCCURRED AFTER --
CONCERNS WERE RAISED AND ALL
THAT WAS A RED FLAG FOR US WHERE
WE SAID LET'S HAVE AN
INDEPENDENT ASSESSMENT LET'S GET
ALL THE FACTS OUT THERE.
AND AND AND SEE SO I DON'T HAVE
FOR EXAMPLE THAT PIERRE A
REQUEST FOR THE RECORD REQUEST
EVER MADE WAS SHARED WITH US
THAT THEY WERE MADE AND THEY
WEREN'T RESPONDED.
TO I THINK WHAT YOU'RE GETTING
AT IS WHAT IN FROM STEPS WERE
TAKEN.
BEFORE I WE GOT TO THIS AUDIT
AND FOR IT IS A MEMBER CHIU AND
I WE THOUGHT THE AUDIT WAS WAS
THE TOOL THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
TOOLBOX TO ASSIST.
WITH A SET OF ISSUES THAT
WEREN'T BEING RESOLVED THROUGH
OTHER INTROVERTS GOT I THINK YOU
GUYS HAVE THE NIGHT AND IT
WASN'T CLEAR ON THAT FROM BEFORE.
WHICH I WAS I WAS REFER LIB
ORDER WHAT YOUR OFFICES DOWN TO
REQUEST INFORMATION BECAUSE
SOMETIMES WHAT WE SAY TO FOLKS
COME WITHIN WITH A REQUEST IS.
HAVE YOU AS A AS YOUR OFFICE
BEEN ABLE TO EXHAUST THAT OPTION.
AND HAVE HAVE THEY NOT PROVIDED
YOU WITH THE SAME MATERIAL THAT
YOU'RE OUR INFORMATION TO YOUR
SATISFACTION --
WHAT I'M JUST GETTING
CLARIFICATION ON AND THANK YOU
IS THAT?
CONSTITUENTS CAME FORWARD TO YOU
AND SAID THEY WERE UNABLE TO GET
THE INFORMATION --
BUT BEFORE WE SEND THE AUDITOR
USUALLY HAVE I JUST AM CURIOUS
HOW MUCH THE INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS
HAVE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE TO WORKING
TOGETHER [inaudible]
GET THAT BEFORE WE SEND THE
AUDITOR --
PACKAGE HAS YOUR OFFICE HAD IT
NOT HAVE THEY SAID NO TO REQUEST
OF YOUR OFFICE FOR INFORMATION.
TO RESOLVE THE ISSUES THAT WERE
BROUGHT FORWARD YOU.
AS A MEMBER CHIU AND I MADE AN
AUDIT REQUEST WE DIDN'T.
PROPOUND THAT REQUEST FOR
PRODUCTION OF DOCUMENTS OR MAKE
ANY REQUESTS FOR DOCUMENTS OR
INFORMATION THE OPPONENTS.
WITH THEM THIS IS NOT CONSENT
UNTIL RECENTLY --
THE PARENTS ASKED ME WITH US AND
OF COURSE WE WANT TO BE WITH
THEM SO WE GET.
OUR BUT THERE WAS NO REPORT
REQUEST FOR FOR DOCUMENTS THAT
WERE MADE.
THANK YOU ANSWERS IT THINKING.
MANY OF THE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC AND ONE
OF THE PUBLIC LIKE [inaudible]
TO ADDRESSES MATTER.
ARE WE ABLE TO RESPOND
[inaudible]
TO THE QUESTIONER --
YES THANK YOU.
WE FOUND OUT ABOUT THIS AUDIT
EIGHT DAYS AGO WE'VE DONE
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO FIND
OUT MORE ABOUT THE DETAILS
BEHIND THIS REQUEST --
AND WE DID AUS FOR MEETING WHICH
WAS GRANTED YESTERDAY --
SO THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THAT
WE'RE HEARING A LOT OF THE
ISSUES THAT ARE STEMMING FROM
THIS INITIAL REQUEST TODAY
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT --
SEEING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE --
TELL WE HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE HIM.
FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
A GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS BRIAN GERINGER NAM
SOLO PRACTITIONER FROM SANTA
ROSA.
I CURRENTLY REPRESENT RENEE
MEDINA IN A CIVIL RIGHTS LAWSUIT
AGAINST THE BUREAU OF GAMBLING
CONTROL.
IN THE GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION.
MR MEDINA AS A SEVENTY THREE
YEAR OLD FILIPINO IMMIGRANT.
AN AMERICAN SUCCESS STORY.
MR MEDINA FOUNDED LUCKY CHANCES
AMONG OTHER.
BUSINESSES IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT IS CURRENTLY OWNED BY HIS
TWO SONS.
PRIOR REPRESENTING MR MEDINA
REPRESENTED FORTUNE PLAYERS
GROUP WHICH IS A LICENSE LICENSE
BY THE BUREAU.
CAN WE CONTROL IN THE COMMISSION.
A LICENSE THIRD PARTY
PROPOSITIONAL PLAYER SERVICES.
FOURTEEN PLAYERS IS OWNED BY
THREE RELATIVES OF MR MEDINA.
EACH YOU'RE EACH OF WHOM WERE OF
FILIPINO ANCESTRY.
ON OCTOBER FIFTEENTH. TWENTY
FIFTEEN SIX ARMED SPECIAL AGENTS
OF THE BUREAU GAMBLING CONTROL
CARRIED OUT AN UNANNOUNCED RAID
OF THE DALY CITY OFFICES.
A FORTUNE PLAYERS.
INSIDE THEY FOUND TO FILIPINA
EMPLOYEES ONE OF WHOM IS HERE
TODAY.
AND DETAIN THEM IN THE LUNCH
ROOM.
THE AGENTS THEN CARRIED OUT AN
ILLEGAL SEARCH.
OF THE OFFICE COMPUTERS AND THE
PERSONAL CELLPHONESOF FEMALE
EMPLOYEES.
I CSU THOSE SIX SPECIAL AGENTS.
FEDERAL COURT FOR VIOLATING
THEIR FOURTH AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
PROTECTIONS AGAINST UNREASONABLE
SEARCHES AND SEIZURES.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SETTLE
THIS LAWSUIT.
AND PAID FOURTEEN PLAYERS TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN EACH OF THE TWO
FEMALE EMPLOYEES FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. TWO MONTHS LATER AND
ASK YOU DO TRY TO LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TRIP OR THANK YOU.
I'M JUST THE PATTERN ON TRYING
TO DROUGHT HIT TWO MONTHS LATER
AFTER THE SETTLEMENT.
THE COMMISSION IMPOSE CONDITIONS
ON WEAR NAME AND ON THE LICENSE
OF LUCKY CHANCES CASINO
[inaudible]
ACQUIRING THEM [inaudible]
A IMPOSE CONDITIONS ON RENEE
MEDINA. ONE OF THE CONDITIONS
WAS HE COULDN'T SPEAK TO ANY OF
THE SEVERAL HUNDRED EMPLOYEES.
OF THE YEAR LUCKY CHANCES CASINO.
I SUIT AGAIN ALRIGHT.
PLEASE IF YOUR POINT OKAY
[inaudible]
I WANT.
THE COMMON THREAD THROUGH THESE
TWO CASES IS THERE'S THERE'S A
SYSTEMIC BIAS AGAINST FILIPINO
IT AT FILIPINO IMMIGRANT.
AND HIS RELATIVES AND I URGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO EXERCISE ITS
AUDIT AUTHORITY.
AND DEMAND AN EXPLANATION AS TO
WHY THE BUREAU AND THE
COMMISSION.
IS WASTING PUBLIC FUNDS IN THE
PURSUIT OF DISCRIMINATORY
POLICIES AGAINST MY CLIENT IN
HIS RELATIVES [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALRIGHT --
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
PUBLIC PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HI MY NAME IS TRICIA CASTELLANOS
I AM A AND OWNER OF FORTUNE
PLAYERS GROUP --
I HAVE BEEN LICENSE WITH THAT
SPECIFIC PARTY PROPOSITION FROM
THE GAMUT CONTROL --
FOR MANY BUSINESS FOR EIGHT
YEARS AND I'M HERE TO TELL YOU
THAT -- YOU
KNOW I HAVE NO ISSUES WITH --
HOW THE THAT THE BACKGROUND
CHECK BUT ISSUING A LICENSE TO
ME I THINK THERE OF --
AGAINST.
I ISSUING THE A LICENSE --
FIRST OFF I HAVE NO CRIMINAL
RECORD AND ALSO --
ALL THE QUESTIONS THAT THE HAVE
AGAINST MY COMPANY --
WE HAVE ADDRESSED THEM AND
CORRECTED THAT IS GOING ON AND
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT --
YOU KNOW THE APPROVED THE
LICENSE FOR MY EMPLOYEES SOME OF
THEM HAVE GONE TO JAIL AND YOU
KNOW THE APPROVED THEIR LICENSE
AND FOR ME I HAVE NO CRIMINAL
RECORD.
AND I'M I YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW
WHY THEY'RE NOT APPROVING MY
LICENSE.
AND THAT'S ALL I THINK JUST
BECAUSE YOU KNOW I AM A FILIPINA
I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY'RE
STOPPING FROM GETTING MY LICENSE
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY FURTHER WHAT --
COMMENTS WAS FROM FORT.
AN A. F. IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE
IF YOU CAN NOW LINE UP --
SO THAT WE CAN NO.
TRY TO WRAP THIS HEARING UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ROBERT
THE MASAKI I WORKED FOR FOR TWO
PLAYERS FOR FOR FOR EACH YOURS.
AND I AM HERE BECAUSE I THOUGHT
THAT I'M BEING HARASSED.
I DON'T ABUSE OF ABOUT MY RACE --
BECAUSE I'D THEY KEEP DENYING MY
AYE LIES MY LICENSE REPEATEDLY.
OFF FOR EIGHT YEARS I MEAN IN
THE UNITED STATES FOR FORTY
EIGHT YEARS AND THEIR JOB.
A GIVEN ISSUE ABOUT MY MAYBE
I'LL YOU A UNITED STATES CITIZEN.
I ACQUIRED MY CITIZENSHIP SO MY
MOTHER WAS BORN IN HAWAII.
AND WE WERE GIVEN I YOU ARE YOU
ARE YOU SHOULD THE UNITED STATES
PASSPORT --
IN MANILA THROUGH THE UNITED
STATES EMBASSY.
SO I WAS --
I FELT LIKE YOU KNOW I'M BEING
DISCRIMINATED.
AND THE SECOND IS --
THEY KEEP ASKING OVER AND OVER
MY BANK STATESMEN WAY BACK IN.
THIRTY FIVE YEARS AGO SOUL IT'S
KIND IMPOSSIBLE FOR ME TO
PRODUCE THOSE STATEMENTS YOU
KNOW SOME OF THE BANKS CLOSE.
AND THIRTIES LIKE DAY ASK.
A OTHERS ARE RECEIPTS OF MY A
JEWELRY STORE I BOUGHT TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AGO.
THEY WERE ASKING ME HOW MUCH IT
COSTS ARE WHICH AGAIN IS
IMPOSSIBLE ARIZONA'S IF TRY TO
WRAP UP.
IF YOU GOT SOMETHING TO ALRIGHT
THANK YOU.
FOR RIGHT ANY FURTHER WITNESSES
OR ANY FURTHER COMMENTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND THE COMMITTEE.
UP I WAS HERE JUST TO ALL.
SHARE MY HORRIBLE EXPERIENCE
WITH DAD DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
OF WE BATTLE COULD YOU STATE
YOUR NAME WELL I'M SORRY MY NAME
EAST AND JELLY THAT ILLUSORY YES
I'M WORKING.
WITH FORTUNE PLAYERS FOR A
FIERCE AS AN OFFICE MANAGER.
AND I HAVE A HORRIBLE EXPERIENCE
WITH THE BUREAU AND DEPARTMENT
ALL FWA JUST FEES.
WE BACK OCTOBER FIFTH BEATLE
OCTOBER FIFTEEN OF TWENTY
FIFTEEN BECAUSE THEY WHERE ALL.
UP GO TO THE OFFICE WITHOUT ANY
WATER AND AND I AM A VICTIM I
MEAN I'M THE ONE WHO WHERE THERE
WENDY.
DUDE DE ALL.
GO TO THE OFFICE AND THEY ARE
ALL ALMOST AS SIX PEOPLE THAT
THAT COME TO THE OFFICE GO TO
THE COMPUTER AND GET SOME OF THE
DOCUMENTS AND THE DIPPING ME IN
ONE ROOM AND THE WAY THEY
INTERROGATED ME IS.
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S SUCH A
HORRIBLE EXPERIENCE THAT THE I
AM SO AFRAID THAT TIME.
BUT DOES THIS CASE I MEAN OUT
WHEN THAT WE FILE A LAWSUIT WE'D
THEY SETTLED THE LAWSUIT AND I
WAS AWARDED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR DEBT THAT BUT IT'S A
IT'S AN EXPERIENCE THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE OKAY THANK
YOU FAMILIES.
I'LL BE BRIEF MY NAME'S ROBERT
MCCORD I'M WITH THE POP CULTURE
LAW FIRM I'M ACTUALLY HERE AS A
PRACTITIONER WHO APPEAR
REGULARLY APPEARS IN FROM THE
COMMISSION.
AND I'M HERE REALLY TO ADDRESS
REALLY INEFFICIENCY ISSUE.
THE COMMISSION ON BUREAU HAVE A
HARD JOB.
THEY'VE GOT A REGULATE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES.
I'M A PRACTICE NOT IMPACTS IN
MINISTRY OF LAW FOR FINAL
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN YEARS SINCE
TWO THOUSAND THREE WHERE THAT IS
FIFTEEN YEARS.
AND I PEERED LOT OF AGENCIES
BEFORE I PURE FROM AGAIN THE
CONTROL COMMISSION AND IN A IN
INEFFICIENCY STRUCK ME ABOUT HOW
THE COMMISSION THE BUREAU ACTS
THAT OTHER AGENCIES DON'T HAVE.
THEY USE.
IT MOST AGENCIES THE RENEWAL
PROCESS IS A MINISTERIAL IS LONG
AS YOU HAVEN'T GONE OUT
COMMITTED A CRIME.
YOUR LICENSE IS AUTOMATIC
RENEWED.
BUT NOT WITH THE COMMISSION AND
NOW WITH THE BUREAU TWO YEAR
RENEWAL PROCESS AND INSTEAD OF
FALLING ACCUSATIONS I SEE THE
COMMISSION'S ENTIRE AGENDA IS
FILLED WITH.
HANDLING RENEWALS THESE RENEWALS
IF THERE'S A VIOLATION OF THE
GAMBLING CONTROL COMMISSION IT
WOULD BE MUCH MORE EFFICIENT FOR
THE BUREAU OF FOR THE COMMISSION
THE BUREAU. TO HAVE TO FILE AN
ACCUSATION AND HAVE IT GO TO THE
AIDS HAVE IT WAY TO HANDLE IT.
INHABITED JUDICATA IT BUT
INSTEAD WE GO TO RENEWAL PROCESS
AND THE COMMISSION SPENDS ITS
TIME IN THE BUREAU'S MIGHT THIS
TIME DEALING WITH RENEWALS.
PARROTBILLS REGULATIONS ISSUES
AND THAT ALSO DO MOUTH TO DO
PROCESS ISSUE BECAUSE YOU DON'T
GET THE APA RIGHTS THAT ARE
GUARANTEED UNDER THERE.
TARA THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SEEING.
SIR IS YOU PLEASE GO
[inaudible]
FOR GOOD AFTERNOON --
MY NAME IS RUBEN MARCUS.
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN MAY PURSE --
WE CAME FROM MEXICO BI POLAR NOT
A YEAR BEFORE.
AND I DECIDED TO BUY A CAR ROOM
AND LUNCH CORDOVA.
SMALL CLUB VERY SMALL.
BUT WITH THE HELP OF MY WIFE AND
MY KIDS.
WE MAKE IT WORK.
PUT THIRTY ONE YEARS
[inaudible]
ARE.
MY HEALTH IS PRETTY BAD.
AND I WANT TO RETIRE
[inaudible]
I ASK.
FINALLY I WANT A PERSON A VERY
NICE PERSON.
BY DESTROYING. TO BUY MY LICENSE.
AND I AM KEEPING 10%.
IN ORDER TO LEAVE SOMETHING FOR
THE KIDS --
I'M VERY PROUD.
THAT I DID IT [inaudible]
NICHOLAS [inaudible]
MONTEREY SEPARATELY.
AND NOT PUT INTO FOR MY KIDS
MAKE IT TO SCHOOL.
THAT WAS NICE.
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING WRONG SAY.
THEY'RE VERY NICE TO ME.
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE
DOJ.
BY CITY COUNCIL OR MY POLICE IN
THIRTY ONE YEARS SERENATA ASKING
WRAP UP.
OKAY [inaudible]
I I HAVE.
MY LICENSE APPROVED. TO MOVE.
RELOCATION NAY QUOTE --
FROM THE CITY.
THE OJ.
AND PROBABLY LICENSING BUT FOR
SOME REASON.
WE CANNOT MOVE. TO THE CLUB EVEN
THOUGH HE'S READY.
OKAY THAT THIS IS NOT THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY.
TO P. OLE ANY [inaudible]
COMMISSION.
DECISIONS I THINK WE GET THE
GIST OF YOUR TESTIMONY SIR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OKAY.
THANK YOU ALRIGHT ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES IN IN THAT ARE A ANY
OF THE PUBLIC COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE --
MR BUT THAT WAS LIKE THOSE YES
THAT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO PRESENT TODAY
AND TO MAKE THIS --
AUDIT REQUEST A I KNOW THAT IS
AT A DIFFERENT OPINION OF
OPINION BETWEEN THE BUREAU THE
COMMISSION ASKED AS TO WHAT
HAPPENED OR DIDN'T HAPPEN AND
AND AS YOU HAVE SAID MR SURE
THIS IS NOT THE PLACE --
TO DO FACT FINDING PROCESS AFTER
THE AUDITS FOR SO THEY'LL BE
FULL OPPORTUNITY TO VET ALL
THESE ISSUES.
AND FOR ALL SIDES --
TO BE FULLY HEARD AND THAT THE
PROCESS WILL OCCUR THERE BUT I
THINK.
SUFFICIENT CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED INVALID QUESTIONS AROUND
A EFFICIENCIES AND BACKLOGS AND
APPROPRIATE PROTOCOLS BEEN
FOLLOWED AND THE BEST USE OF THE
SURPLUS.
I AS WELL AS THE POTENTIAL --
FOR SKINNER DISCRIMINATORY
IMPACT AND THE MOVIE CLIP WE WE
WE ASSUME --
GOOD INTENTIONS AND AND AND
NOTICED AMERICA DISCRIMINATORY
INTENT BUT THE FACTS WILL SHOW
WHETHER OR NOT --
INTENDED OR NOT THERE IS ANY
DISCRIMINATORY IMPACT AND I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
IDIOTIC CAN CAN REVEAL THAT.
AS WITH THAT I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY IN
A RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH I I
APPRECIATE MISTER BONTA YOUR AT
YOUR REQUEST --
THERE.
I'M SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS BEING
MADE AND SO I THINK IT WARRANTS
A THE STATE AUDITOR AS A
INDEPENDENT TO REVIEWER TO
REVIEW --
WHAT IS GOING ON ESPECIALLY?
ACCORDING TO MISTER BONTA THIS
IS THE VERY FIRST AUDIT OF THE
COMMISSION AND THE BUREAU AND
IT'S A ENTIRE HISTORY OF THE
AGENCY AND SO I I I THINK.
PERHAPS THE IT COULD BE
BENEFICIAL --
TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC AS WELL AS
THE TO THE LEGISLATURE TO HAVE
INDEPENDENT REVIEW OF THE
COMMISSION AND THE THE BUREAU
AND SO FOR THAT REASON I WILL BE --
RECOMMENDING --
SUPPORT FOR THE AUDIT REQUEST
AND DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
MOTION MADE BY MISS SHIRA IN
THIS AREA AND SECOND BY MISTER
OBERNOLTE MADAM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE I HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND SECOND OKAY.
ROLL CALL SEPARATE.
ROLL CALL TO PROVE AUDIT REQUEST
NUMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
DASH ONE THREE TWO OF THE
GAMBLING CONTROL COMMISSION AND
THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE BUREAU OF
CAMPING CONTROL OVER THE CAMERA
CONTROL FINE.
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA.
THE CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION
TONIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER MERCY
CHAI WHERE SUCI AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I NAZARIN.
NAZARIAN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
WADE [inaudible]
WOULD I SENATOR ROTH.
ROTH AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN I KNOW.
CANNELLA CANNELLA AYE FULLER
[inaudible]
LARA.
NO WE ARE SHORT ONE SENATE VOTE
IN SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO WE WILL.
NOW OPEN IT UP AND INVITES ALL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO COME
FORWARD THINKERS TO CHAIR THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF
THANK YOU IT SO THIS ITEM.
IS ON CALL [inaudible]
THE AND WE'LL SEE IF IT GETS OUT.
LIKE.
TO INVITE ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
TO PLEASE COME --
PERHAPS BY. TEN MINUTES --
Y. BY --
THREE FORTY FIVE LITTLE LET'S
LET THE CALL AND SO THAT PEOPLE --
TIED TO FORTIFY THE EXPECTED --
SO MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU CAN
CALL GO THROUGH EACH ITEM.
THERE IS ON CALL.
LIFTING THE CALL I AND AUDIT
REQUEST NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN TASH ONE TWO NINE OF
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT PRIVACY PROTECTION
PRACTICES FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BAKER.
THE CHAIRS RECOMMENDATIONS THAN
I I WILL ONLY CALLED ABSENTEE
MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER MERCY CHI
[inaudible]
WELL I SIR SU CHI I NO THERRIEN.
MISS THEREIN I ALLEN
[inaudible]
ALLEN I NO.
THAT MUCH OF REQUEST PASSES.
LIFTING THE CALL ON AUDIT
REQUEST NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN DASH ONE THREE ZERO OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
RAIL AYE THE IMPLEMENTATION.
REQUESTING UP FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHEN BEACH CHAIRS
RECOMMENDATIONS AND I I WOULD
ONLY BE I'M CALLING THE MEMBER
AND THAT WERE ABSENT.
A SALINAS ARYAN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE I SENATOR LARA.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ANNA THEREIN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
[inaudible]
WOULD I SENATOR LARA THIS IS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLE.
BUT NOT VOTING
.
I'LL GO BACK ON THAT.
THE THE IF THE ITEM IS STILL ON
CALL.
LIFTING THE CALL ON ARAFAT'S
NUMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
DASH ONCE YOU.
FOR AND LOCAL CLOSE HEALTH PLAN
FROM SENATORS STONE.
THE CHAIRS RECOMMENDATIONS AND I
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND IS THERE AND
THIS AREA AND I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE [inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
WOULD I SENATOR ALLEN.
ALLEN I CENTER LARA [inaudible]
LARA I THAT REQUEST PASSES.
LIFTING WILL CALL ON AUDIT
REQUEST NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN CASH ONCE YOU FIVE OF
THE TAXPAYER TRANSPARENCY IN
FAIRNESS ACT BY SENATOR GAINES
THE CHAIRS RECOMMENDATIONS THE
NO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AS ARYAN.
THEREIN NO OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE [inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
NOT VOTING [inaudible]
SENATOR ALLEN.
ALLEN NO BELL [inaudible]
CANNELLA [inaudible]
LARA.
THAT REQUEST FAILS.
LIFTING THE VOTE ON AUTO
CUSTOMER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
CASH ONCE YOU EIGHT FROM
DEPARTMENT CORRECTION UP BY OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION WORK RELATED
INJURIES FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO.
IT SHARES RECOMMENDATIONS AND I
ASSUMING THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAKER.
BAKER I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I WOULD [inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
I SENATOR ROTH.
ROTH AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN I KNOW [inaudible]
FULLER [inaudible]
LARA [inaudible]
LARA I BUT THAT REQUEST PASSES.
LIFTING THE CALL AN ITEM REQUEST
NUMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
CASH ITO FOR OF THE CITY OF OUT
WATER LOCAL GOVERNMENT HIGH RISK
PROGRAM FROM THE STATE AUDITOR.
THIS IS --
TO THE MOTION IS TO RETAIN THE
AUDIT REQUEST UNTIL THE NEXT
HEARING.
THE CHAIR HAD A NINE
RECOMMENDATION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ANTENNAS ARYAN
[inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I RUBIO [inaudible]
WADE [inaudible]
WOULD I SENATOR ROTH.
ROTH AYE ALLEN [inaudible]
ALLEN I LARA [inaudible]
LARA KNOW.
THAT THE MOTION PASSES.
LIFTING THE CALL AN AUDIT
REPLACE THE MATERIALS AND
EIGHTEEN DASH ONE ONE NINE OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE PARTICIPATION IN THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
ACT BY FAMILY MEMBER GRAY.
THE CHAIRS RECOMMENDATIONS AND I
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AS ARYAN.
NAZARIAN AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I WOULD [inaudible]
WOULD I SENATOR ROTH.
ROTH AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE CANNELLA.
CANNELLA AYE LARA [inaudible]
LARA I THAT REQUEST PASSES.
LIFTING THE CALL ON AUDIT
REQUEST NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN DASH ONE THREE TWO OF
THE CAMERA CONTROL COMMISSION
THAT A PART OF JUSTICE BUREAU OF
GAMBLING CONTROL CAMERA CONTROL
FINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA.
THE CHAIR RECOMMENDATIONS AND I
SELLING OVER RUBIO [inaudible]
SENATOR ABOUT [inaudible]
CENTER FULLER [inaudible]
CENTER LARA [inaudible]
LARA I THAT REQUEST PASSES
[inaudible]
IN THAT.
ALRIGHT SO WE HAVE TAKEN CARE OF
ALL MATTERS EXCEPT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
AUDIT REQUEST --
WE YES LET'S ADD ON FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
STUMBLING [inaudible] FORTY FOR
SO I THINK YOU HAVE ON TOKYO.
SO JUST ADD ON TO THE CONSENT
[inaudible]
WHAT?
NOT THAT.
YOU CAN [inaudible]
OKAY.
ADDING LAUNCHED THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AS AARON
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THERE AND I CENTER ABOUT.
BELL I FULLER LARA.
LARA AYE [inaudible]
THE BILL [inaudible]
ADDING ON UNTO UNDER A CUSTOMER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DASH ONE
THIRTY TWO OF THE CAMERA CONTROL
COMMISSION DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
CAN WE CONTROL FINE [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO
[inaudible]
CENTER ABOUT [inaudible]
BELL I FULLER.
AUDIT RICK ADDING ON TO AUNT WHO
PLACED NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN TAX ONE TWENTY NINE OF
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENTS.
ASSEMBLY AYE BY FAMILY MEMBER
BAKER THE CHAIRS FOR CONDITIONS
AND I CENTER BAO.
BELL AYE LARA [inaudible]
LARA I ADDING ONTO AUDIT REQUEST
NUMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
DASH.
ONE ONE NINE FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAY THE CHAIRS
RECOMMENDATIONS AND I THERE'S NO
ADD ON A ROOM.
VOTED ON THAT.
ADDING ON TO AUDIT REQUEST
NUMBER TWO THOUSAND EACH TEAM
TAX ITO FOR REQUESTED BY THE SEA
OTTERS OFFICE THE MOTIONS TO
RETAIN THE AUDIT REQUESTS UNTIL
THE NEXT HEARING [inaudible]
SIMILAR RUBIO [inaudible]
SENATOR LARA [inaudible]
SORRY [inaudible]
THAT WHEN CERTAINLY.
ADDING ONTO AUDIT REQUEST NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DASH ONE
TWENTY EIGHT FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RUBIO THE CHAIR AFRICAN NATIONS
AND I CENTER PAU [inaudible]
NOW I FULLER.
ADDING ONTO AUDIT REQUEST NUMBER
TELLS AND EIGHTEEN DASH ONCE YOU.
FIVE FROM CENTER GAINES THE
CHAIRS ARE CONDITIONS AND NO
[inaudible]
SENATOR PELL [inaudible]
NO NO.
LOOKS LIKE WE GOT EVERYONE.
DO WE HAVE TO THIS AREA AND
RECALL HANDY.
YES SIR WE HAVE NOT ANNOUNCED
SUNDAY AND BE AYE.
SO SEND ALSO GONNA KEEP IT UP
UNTIL TWO FORTY FIVE I'LL KEEP
MY WORD --
WELL [inaudible]
BUDGET [inaudible]
TO SURE.
CONSIDERATION ME SO OKAY.
OKAY OKAY LIKE I CONTROL NUMBER
THAT'S VERY.
THAT WAS ONLY [inaudible]
ONE I THINK [inaudible] SIX BUT
IN THIS
[inaudible]
ONE DOES EVERYBODY [inaudible]
YEAH
.
ONE AND THE OCEAN WAVES
[inaudible]
PHOTOS ABOUT
YEAH [inaudible]
PLATFORM [inaudible]
YEAH
GO CALL THE ROLL FROM ONE
LAST TIME FOR THE I REQUEST FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
REAL ID --
MADAM SECRETARY.
I DID ON THE ON THE MIKE.
LIFTING THE CALL.
LIFTING THE CALL DURING THE
HELLO.
TO LIFTING THE CALL ON I REQUEST
NUMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
DASH ONE THREE ZERO OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
REAL IT ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN.
THE CHURCH EQUATIONS AND I
ASSEMBLYMAN IS ARYAN.
THAT MOTIONS FELL [inaudible]
REQUEST RECONSIDERATION.
RECONSIDERATION GRANTED UNLESS
THERE'S ANY OBJECTION.
ALRIGHT RICK CONSIDERATIONS.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED